learn how to create a fully functional
Reddit clone with react Firebase nexjs
and chakra UI Shadi originally created
this as a playlist and he has combined
everything into one course for our
channel here are a few of the things
people have said about the course
get ready for what may be the best and
most comprehensive Reddit clone course
anywhere what is up everyone my name is
Shady and today we're going to be
building a Reddit clone with nexjs
Firebase v9 recoil which is a state
management library for react that I love
and Shopper UI which is an amazing react
UI Library that's going to help us out a
lot with our CSS I'm going to do a demo
in about 30 seconds of what it is
exactly that we're going to be building
and I'm super excited about this project
because we are going to get to cover so
many things in depth and we're going to
build a ton of full stack features front
to back that are going to really allow
us to explore all the technologies that
we're using for this build so on the
front end with Nexus and react we want
to look at things like server-side
rendering using the nexjs router for
client-side routing building our own
custom react hooks using pretty much all
of the hooks that react has to offer and
overall just front-end architecture with
react and then more on the back end with
Firebase we're going to get you covered
pretty much the entire Firebase v9
landscape everything from authentication
to the firestore database we're going to
look at how to to use real-time data to
implement real-time features with the
cloud firestore database we're going to
look at Cloud functions Firebase storage
we're going to store images security
rules database transactions and batch
rights which if you don't know what that
is don't worry I'll explain it when we
get to it and overall modeling data with
a nosql database which is what cloud
firestore is and this entire thing is
going to be written in typescript as
well which I think is super worth it for
you to learn and it's going to make your
code a lot more robust as we're going to
see so there is lots to learn here my
aim with this project was to include
enough things and go in depth into
enough things for you to actually take
all the stuff and apply it into your own
project so you can build pretty much
whatever you want with react next year
as Firebase or whatever all right so
here is exactly what we're going to
build for those of you that are familiar
with redis you can tell that this looks
pretty much exactly the same as the real
product I spent a lot of time trying to
make it look pretty much identical and
so pretty much everything from the
layout of all of the pages to the drop
down menus to the font sizes and
everything everything is designed to
look and feel exactly like the real
product and I'm super excited to show
you how to build this so here is the
home page as you can see we have this
feed that's showing a bunch of posts
from a bunch of different communities
this user that I have logged in right
now for the demo has not joined any
communities yet so it's just post from a
bunch of random communities and then on
the right hand side we have some other
UI elements and we have like things of
community recommendations so right now
it's showing the top communities which
are just ranked by a number of members
within those communities and this design
is completely responsive as well so it
works beautifully on mobile so you're
going to learn a lot about responsive
design and just overall how to build up
pretty much any UI you would like in
both desktop and mobile I'm just going
to log out because I want to log back in
in a second so if I wanted to join one
of these communities I would of course
have to be signed in and this modal is
accessible through the navbar as well so
let's talk about authentication we're
going to cover the entire authentication
flow offered by Firebase v9 we're going
to learn how to authenticate users with
third-party oauth providers like Google
and any other ones you might wish like
Twitter Facebook GitHub anything you'd
like anything that's offered by Firebase
and also looking at how to sign in and
sign up with email or password or also
going to look at password resetting as
well so the entire authentication flow
is going to be covered for you so you
can apply it in your own projects all
right cool so I'm just going to sign
back in to that user account that I
created for myself so now that I'm
signed in I can actually join any
communities that I may find interesting
so I can join as many as I would like
and then they would show up actually
inside of this little drop down here
which represents my communities and I
can access them directly from here I
want to talk about this Korea Community
thing in a little bit and this drop down
is the exact same as Reddit has it
and then I can also leave communities
right from within the side panel if I
didn't actually want to join them and
then I can actually view the communities
directly from here as well so let's go
into Tesla Motors and I can view all of
the posts inside of this community I can
see the number of members in here when
it was created and all of this stuff
related to the community and I can
actually join and leave the community
right from inside of here as well which
is pretty cool and I'm going to touch on
the creation of posts in just a short
while
all right so looking more closely at the
post now I can see the vote status so
how many upvotes or downloads this thing
has how many comments it has the user
who created this post when it was posted
what community is posted in I can like
this post or upload it I can download it
I'm going to upload this one and then we
can also view posts in a single page
view all right so this post is from Elon
Musk and he somehow has found a time
between Tesla and SpaceX to pick up
baking and he's posted about it here and
they look pretty unreal to be honest and
then I can scroll down to the comment
section and I can see all of the
comments on this post who commented on
it when it was commented and I can also
leave a comment myself so let's leave a
comment for Elon because he is clearly
really good at baking I'm gonna say hey
Elon nice
cupcakes
smiley face click comment and I can
leave a comment their form and I can
delete it and do whatever I want with it
alright cool let's now talk about the
actual creation of posts because that's
probably the most critical part of
reddit's functionality so let's just go
into a random Community we can go into
Tesla and we can just go into create
post and we can just create a post
that's called my first post in all caps
and if you will say
hey everyone this is my first post with
a bunch of exclamation points to show
how excited we are and then we can
actually post an image along with it as
well so let's just select this one here
and this has absolutely nothing to do
with Tesla but maybe I'm on the Tesla
engineering team and I'm working on the
latest full self-driving software so
then I can go back to the text inputs of
the post and I can click post and then
it will take me back to the Tesla
Community page where I can actually see
my post which is pretty cool
and I can view it in that same single
page view as well and there are no
comments yet
uh so I'm gonna give myself an upvote
because why not and I can actually
delete the post as well so let's delete
this because it's not really related to
Tesla and I'm actually just going to
rejoin this community because I did
leave before so yeah on Reddit you don't
actually have to join a community to
post in it so I built ours the exact
same way all right cool so let's go talk
about how we can actually create our own
communities now so if I go to the drop
down menu uh we saw this before we can
see that our communities are in here but
then I said that there was an option to
create our own communities so if I click
on this this model pops up that will ask
us for the name of our community and
also the community types of public
restricted or private this is the exact
same flow as Reddit so let's create a
community called chatties
community
Credit Community it will be created and
we are automatically joined into that
Community because we created it so that
kind of makes sense and we're also added
as a moderator of that Community uh so
which basically just means we're an
admin so now inside of this community I
can pretty much do everything the same
as I can in other communities and create
posts comment on posts Etc and I can
also change the image of this community
because I am an admin so let's let's
test that out let's see what that looks
like so click on this Google logo
because it has this nice circular shape
to it which fits the shape of this so if
I click save changes that image is
actually going to be uploaded to our
cloud firestore storage database and
that's going to update our community
image which is super cool all right cool
so let's actually get into the build now
obviously we cannot build every single
feature that Reddit has because this
tutorial would be insanely long so I
want to focus a lot on the core
functionality of Reddit if there are any
specific features of Reddit that you
would like to see please let me know in
the comments and I can potentially cover
that in a future video as I mentioned
before we're going to cover a lot of
Concepts there is so much to learn I'm
super excited to build this with you and
I'm going to be building it completely
from scratch so if you have any concerns
at any point throughout the video just
leave a comment with like the timestamp
and I will 100 reply to the comments
other than that I think we are good to
go I hope you really enjoy this tutorial
let's get going all right everybody
Welcome to the tutorial we're going to
get going with the build now so on the
left I just have a terminal open to the
folder that I'm going to place our new
project in feel free to place it yours
wherever you would like and once you
have my code open on the left once we
create the new project in just a second
and during the early stages of this
build and especially for this first part
our Pace might be a tad bit slower than
for most of the projects since we are
going to come across a lot of new things
for the very first time such as working
with chakra recoil and also typescript
and I want to make sure that you all
have a really strong fundamental
understanding of all of these tools so
that the entire build makes complete
sense and you can get as much out of it
as possible so I will spend a bit more
time explaining things in more detail
the first time around but do know that
after getting our first few reps in with
each of these things the pace will be
quite a bit faster in future Parts okay
so what we're going to do is start off
by just creating a brand new Next genius
application we're going to Google create
next app and go to the next shift docs
and grab this command here which is the
command for creating a brand new texture
project with this TS flag
so I'm going to paste this in my
terminal and I'm also going to add the
folder name that I'm going to place this
project into and I'm just going to let
that install and once it's done I will
open it up in vs code
it may take a few seconds for you
perfect now once that's done what we can
do is just CD into that directory and
then I'm just going to open it up in vs
code
and I'm going to spin up the development
server so we can see the newly created
app that we just made
so get this set up on the left
and let's now run the development server
by just running npm run Dev
that's going to spin our app up on
localhost 3000 so let's go to that
and here is our brand new app I'll open
up the console as well I just put it on
the bottom so we can see any errors in
our console logs that we may add in the
future cool so this is a Bare Bones
next.js project the files that we're
going to be interested in right now are
going to be this app.tsx and
index.tsx so app.tsx essentially
represents our entire application and
every page and every component that we
create is going to be a child of this
component and index.tsx is everything
that's being rendered on the screen here
it represents our index route or home
page and the way client-side routing
Works in xjs is that every file added
inside of this Pages folder is going to
be added to our routes so for example if
I have a file named blog.tsx I would be
able to go to a route localhost 3000
slash blog and we can create nested
routes as well with folders and this
will make a lot more sense when we start
building out some of our Pages all right
so we're not going to need any of this
so I'm just going to remove this entire
div here and I'm going to just add an
empty div that says hello and we can see
that on the right
so now let's go install chakra UI and
get it set up with our app so I'm going
to go just search for our chakra UI and
if I just go to the very first thing
chocolatey.com and go to get started
they have a bunch of choices for
Frameworks that you can use so we're
just going to click on next.js because
that's what we're using and there are a
few packages that we're going to need to
install so the chakra and a few
dependencies that they have so I'm just
going to copy this command here come
over to our terminal
throw that in there and I'm also going
to at the same time install Firebase as
well as recoil because these sort of
represent our core packages that we're
going to be using so let's go ahead and
install these it might take a few
seconds for you awesome so when that's
done what we can do is come over to our
app.tsx and we're going to need to wrap
our application in what's called a
chakra provider if you just scroll down
a bit on this installation page you can
see that that's exactly what they're
doing here so this is pretty much
exactly the same thing that we're going
to do so we're going to come over here
and I'm going to take this component
and wrap it in that chakra provider
which should just automatically import
for me if it does not just import it
from Chakra UI react and just paste the
component in there and this just ensures
that we have access to chakra throughout
our entire application all right so one
quick note is something that you might
notice depending on the time that you
watch this is that you might see this
error in your console and this is
basically just saying that chakra UI has
not yet released updates to be
completely up to date with react 18
react 18 was just released I think a few
weeks ago it's super brand new and so
depending on when you watch this you may
or may not see this I did do some
research on this and I found that there
is an open issue in the shock or UI
GitHub and there's a whole conversation
thread in here regarding this but
basically one of the core maintainers
said that they are working on a solution
to react 18 however it will take a few
days and this was just posted four days
ago so again depending on when you watch
this you may or may not see this if you
do see it do not worry it can just be
ignored it's not a huge deal I just want
you briefly mention it in case you were
concerned alright so what I'm going to
do is just make some brief adjustments
to our folder structure here in the root
of our project I'm just going to create
a folder called source and I'm going to
put Pages as well as Styles into that
Source folder
and this is a common practice to do it's
just a preference of mine I prefer to
keep everything that we're going to
write inside of a folder called Source
it just makes sense to me and this is a
common practice A lot of people do this
and nexjs even has an entire page on
their docs explaining how to use a
source folder it will break initially
but all we need to do is just recompile
our development server
and next.js knows to look for that
Source folder and it will just rebuild
itself to work with that folder all
right perfect so now we are ready to
create our chakra UI theme and pass that
to our shortcut provider as a prop and
since chakra is going to be handling all
of our styling for this build we
actually don't even need this Styles
folder so we can just completely delete
it
and our app should function exactly the
same we we are not going to have any
Styles provided by CSS everything's
going to be handled by chakra all right
so let's create our chakra theme so I'm
just going to go to the chakra UI theme
docs if you go to customize theme here
we're basically going to do exactly this
create a theme which is just represented
by a JavaScript object with the help of
this extend theme Hook from Chakra UI
and we're going to pass it as a prop to
our provider and we are going to have
access to all of these Styles throughout
our app so themes basically contain
styles that are going to be present
throughout our entire application like
brand colors and fonts and also styling
for common components like buttons and
this just ensures that your app looks
nice and consistent from a UI and
styling perspective okay so inside of
our source folder I'm going to create a
new folder called chakra and inside of
that folder I'm going to create a file
called theme dot typescript now I'm
going to come over here and copy this
from the chakra docs and I'm also going
to add an export
to the theme variable here because
you're going to need to import it in
app.tsx so let's go and do that
so import
ant theme
from Chakra theme and then let's pass
that theme
to our chakra provider
just exactly what they're doing over
here
okay so let's go to our theme and inside
of here I'm going to make our main color
the actual Reddit orange and that's
going to be represented by brand 100 so
every time we want to access the Reddit
color throughout our app which is going
to be a decent amount we can just access
it by using brand.100 and that will make
more sense once we start using it it's
very very simple though so the actual
hex code for the real Reddit orange is
ff3c00 so that is the actual hex code
for the Reddit brand color all right I'm
inside of this theme we're going to also
add the font that we're going to be
using and our entire body is going to be
using the font Open Sands with a
fallback of sans serif and what we need
to do in order to use open Sans is to
actually install it chakra makes that
extremely easy if you just search for
shocker UI fonts
you can go to using fonts and the
example in their docs actually uses open
sense so that is perfect and they use a
package called font source so let's just
grab that and go to our app and install
it so once that's done all we need to do
is import it into our theme file just
like they're doing over here so we're
going to come over here and we're going
to do import at font source
and open sand and we should see our app
change to that font it might not be
noticeable right now and this font is
extremely close to the real readathon
and we're just going to actually import
a few different weights of this font so
that we have light regular and heavy so
that we can bold things so I'm going to
have
300. CSS I think that they have to use
the CSS extension yep and we are going
to also grab 400 and 700.
all right once that is done you'll
notice that if you go to reddit.com
they have the sort of gray background
throughout the entire app it's present
everywhere so what we're going to do is
add that as well and the way to do that
in our app is to change the global
styling of our entire body so the way to
do that we're going to pass in a key
called Styles and inside of here we're
going to pass a key called global
and we're going to give this a callback
function which is going to contain the
key body which is going to have BG for
background and we're going to say gray
200 perfect and if you're wondering what
this gray.200 thing is if you just go to
shocker UI
theme
inside of the default theme you can see
all of the colors that they have
available there are so many of them
there's a lot of really nice colors in
here and uh yeah this this library is
honestly amazing you're going to see as
we get more and more into the build why
I love chakra so much and why I probably
never use anything else and it makes it
styling and making things look really
good super easy all right so one last
thing that we're going to just add in
here that we're going to come back to in
a bit is this key called components and
a component is basically any UI
component offered by chakra so for
example buttons and inputs and Etc
everything that's in here you can add
Global styling tubes but it appears very
consistent throughout your app so for
example a button we can add styles for
the button that single time and just
reuse them throughout our app and we can
even create variants and stuff for our
buttons and we're going to see this when
we create our nav bar buttons here you
can see that there's an outline variant
and a filled variant we're going to
create those in a bit but how that would
look would you be basically just pass in
the button component and I will come
back to this very shortly when we get to
the buttons in the nav bar I think we
can now start actually working on the
layout of the page so we're going to do
is create a nexjs layout
and if you go to the layout Docs
basically we're going to create the
exact same thing as this and this
represents the literal layout of our
entire app and we can put components in
here that we want present on every
single page like the navbar without this
layout component we would have to add
the nav bar to every single one of our
Pages that's just how nexjs works and we
are going to wrap our entire application
in this layout component and that is
where the children prop is going to come
from all right so I just took a little
break and I also briefly added a remote
GitHub repository to my projects so that
I can put it in the description for you
guys so if you do need to reference the
code at all it is available on GitHub
link is in the description all right so
now let's actually build this layer
component and get into building the nav
bar and actually get into the fun UI
stuff so I'm going to create a folder
inside of source called components and
this is where all of our react
components are going to go and inside of
components I'm going to create a folder
called the layout because we're going to
have several different layout components
that we created throughout our project
now and then inside of layout I'm going
to create a file called layout.dsx
and before we actually create a command
I just briefly want to mention this
react typescript snippet vs code
extension I highly recommend you to
download this it's going to be really
useful I'm going to use it a lot and
basically we can use little keyboards
shortcuts to create skeleton typescript
react components and it just makes
developing a lot faster so you don't
have to write all of this out from
scratch and we get all the typescript
stuff here just hand it to us out of the
box so when we work in typescript with
react we create types for each component
and these types specify what prompts
need to be passed to this component and
this ensures that we're passing
everything that this component needs to
prevent bugs and crashes and this is
something that JavaScript does not do so
typescript basically just points out
these errors to us before we even
compile the app to make sure that
everything works smoothly and react FC
is just the type of a functional
component and this just indicates that
that is what we are returning out of
this function and if this looks foreign
to you because your new typescript you
do not worry we're going to use this a
Time throughout this build and you're
going to know it like second major once
we're done but yeah highly recommend
this extension if you do not have it
okay so we're not actually going to need
props inside of our layout we're not
going to take anything so when we don't
need props we can just get rid of it
like that and this just basically
indicates that we're returning a react
functional component that's what we're
returning out of this layout function
and we're going to do this a lot so we
can get rid of this div and instead
we're going to return just a react
fragment it's going to be very similar
to what you see on the right and we're
going to take in our children argument
which basically represents our entire
application in this case and we're going
to have a navbar component which we're
going to create in just a second and
then we're going to put our children
inside of our main tag and we're not
going to have a footer for this
application if you want to create one
feel free to do that okay so now let's
create a another folder inside of our
component folder called navbar because
we're going to have a bunch of
components inside of our navbar it's
going to have a ton of children and
inside of navbar let's create our room
navbar file I'm going to call it navbar
dot TSX now in react it is common
practice to name the root file of a
folder just index.tsx for this project
I'm not going to do that just because it
would kind of get confusing if you're
looking at my tabs you would just see a
bunch of files named index index index
index and just to avoid that I'm just
going to name the root files the name of
their folder I just want to make a quick
note on that not a huge deal or anything
okay so what I'm going to do is use that
snippet again to create our skeleton
component and I'm going to remove the
props type because we're not going to
take in any props to our navbar and I'm
going to change this text briefly to
just app bar and now that we actually
have a navbar defined let's go back to
our layout component and just quickly
re-enable this and a quick keyboard
shortcut if you have a component in your
file that has not yet been imported you
can go to this thing and press command
period and this will pop up a little
menu and you can automatically import it
on Windows I think it would be control
period cool so now if we go to our
application file
and we import that
their component and we wrap
our application in that component we
should then see that navbar actually
being displayed there which is pretty
cool so we are completely done with this
layer file we can just close it we are
not going to touch it again for the rest
of this build so we can actually start
building out navbar now and this is
where we're going to get into the
nitty-gritty of chakra UI all right so
we can get rid of this div here and
we're actually going to build a
meaningful navbar and we're going to use
this UI component called Flex from
Chakra now what Flex is is it's
essentially just a div with CSS flexbox
already applied to it out of the box and
we're going to use this a lot throughout
our application so it's super handy and
um chakra UI saves us a lot of time
writing out flexbox Styles over and over
again so let's say I wrote the text in
that bar in here you'll see that it
appears exactly the same as when it was
just a regular div however now the div
has CSS Flex blocks applied to it which
we're going to need once we start adding
more components so now let's talk about
styling shock our UI component so the
way to do that is we can pass any CSS
argument as a prop to any of our chakra
UI components so for example let's say I
wanted to add a background color of
white to our nav bar I can simply do
that by just typing BG so let's say I do
VG is equal to White and I want to add a
border of one pixel solid red
that's how easy it is to style things
all right cool so now that we actually
know how to apply styles to our shortcut
UI components let's move forward so I'm
going to give this nav bar a height of
44 pixels and a and padding six pixels
in 12 pixels if you have not seen this
notation for padding before this when
you give it two arguments this basically
means top bottom right left
and what I'm going to do now is create
the component for the logos and our
logos are going to be
um in the top left cool okay so I'm
going to actually create these logos now
and it's going to consist of two images
the reason there is two is because I
could not find a single SVG file online
that had both this Reddit text and this
icon in a single file I was able to find
both of them separately though and the
way to use external assets and image
assets like that is in our public folder
we can create a another folder called
images and it does actually need to be
inside of the public folder that is
required by next.js what I'm going to do
is I'm going to paste in a bunch of
image files and pngs and svgs that we're
going to use throughout this build
there's only about six of them and I'm
just going to paste them in here for you
I would recommend just go to the link on
GitHub and grab these assets so you
don't have to go online and find them
and these are just SVG icons that I
found online and they all work very well
what that's going to look like the way
we're going to use these is we're going
to have two images and these are chakra
UI images not next images
and the first one is going to be we're
going to go into that images folder I
just created and I call this thing
Reddit face dot SVG let's go back to our
app so that showed up there and the
second one is going to be
images
Reddit text.svg
perfect and let's give these let's give
this one a height of 30 pixels
and this one a height of 46 pixels now
you can see that they are a little bit
misaligned there and that is where
flexbox is going to start to come in
handy so if I go to this logo container
and uh I give it the Align
prop which is short for Align items and
I do Center it will Center those items
for me cool and we're actually going to
add a media query to this second image
text or the logo text because you'll see
on the real Reddit when we get to a
certain screen size like on mobile that
Reddit text is not actually visible it's
not until we get to the medium screen
size is that it's actually visible so
I'm going to show you how to write a
media query in Chakra so we're pretty
much covering all these chakra
fundamentals so that everything makes
sense throughout the entire app so once
we cover this stuff once it'll just go a
lot quicker when we get to it again so
basically we're going to add a media
query to the display CSS property and
the way media queries work in Chakra is
we apply them to single CSS properties
rather than writing a single media query
with a bunch of CSS properties like you
would in raw CSS we're going to do it
property by property and that may sound
a little bit like it's more work at
first but it's actually not and it's
actually really clean and easy we're not
going to write that many media queries
it's actually quite simple so for our
display for our text we're going to make
base to be none and base represents
Mobile screen sizes because chakra is a
mobile first UI Library so mobile
screens we do not want this thing to be
displayed and then at medium sized
screens and up we're going to make it
unset and unset is basically just the
opposite of display none at Mobile
screen sizes it is not visible and once
we get to medium it is then visible
because we apply it unset and we're
going to write a quite a few mini
particularly for the navbar it is pretty
responsive as you'll see there's a lot
going on here in terms of responsiveness
so the nav bar is going to have quite a
bit of media phrase so we're doing it
really good at this cool so I'm going to
add the other components that we're
going to create in just a second I'm
going to comment them out but we're
basically going to have the directory
which is a drop down menu item a search
input and write content cool and write
content is basically represented by if I
log in quickly it's going to contain
those authentication buttons that we are
looking at but it's also going to
contain all of these icons and stuff and
this drop down menu
there's a lot going on on the right hand
side on the nav bar so I wanted to give
it its own parent component hence the
write content component all right so now
let's start working on our search input
so I'm going to go to our app and I'm
going to inside of the navbar folder I'm
going to create another component called
search input
dot TSX and I'm going to use our snippet
once again and we are eventually going
to take in a user here as a prop once we
get to authentication I'm going to leave
this empty for now all right so let's
start developing this component so I'm
going to get rid of this div I'm going
to instead use our
famous Flex component and we're going to
use this so many times all right so I'm
going to leave The Styling for this
blank right now we're going to come back
and add some stuff later once we have
some more of this input built and the
first component we're going to add in
here is called an input group so if you
want to go to the chakra UI input Docs
foreign
we're basically going to have a
something similar to this here we're
going to have an input with an icon and
chakra makes that super easy they have I
believe what's called at elements inside
the input so this is exactly what we're
going to do so I'm just going to copy
this input group here and I'm going to
paste it over here and again I'm going
to use that Auto Import thing that I
used before command period And this is
this is amazing watch this so I before I
showed you how to do it with a single
component but now look I can do it with
add all missing Imports
and that is just unreal so you'll notice
that these did not import and you may be
wondering why and that is because they
are coming from a different library that
we're going to have to install which is
chakra UI icons so what we're going to
do is it's going to go to the browser
and I'm going to search chakra UI icons
I'm going to go into here
and I'm literally just going to copy the
installation command and paste it
in our project and install that there
cool so now that we have that installed
I can back go back and try that Auto
Import thing and it should pick it up
now because we have installed the
library okay and we
we do not need this second input group
sorry I did not mean to copy the second
one we will get rid of that and when we
save that I have Auto formatting on
that's why everything moves when I see
the file if you do not I recommend you
to install prettier and turn on Save on
format
um you can do that by going into your vs
code settings just do a quick Google
search on how to do that it's it's
pretty simple and it's very very handy
cool so uh we actually will not be in
this app file for a little bit so I'm
just going to close that and now that we
have a search input defined I'm going to
come back here and re-enable this
I'm just going to comment that out I'm
gonna go up here I'm gonna
comment those out and I'm going to
import it
from search input I'm going to save this
and for some reason we are not seeing
anything
you need to refresh oh there we go okay
so we can see that something is there
but it looks kind of not great it does
not look anything like the Reddit thing
so let's do some work on that all right
first off the icon is completely wrong
um so let's make it the proper icon
we're going to make it the
search icon
from Chakra UI
icons and another keyword shortcut
that's really really cool is if you do
command shift p it'll open up the
command line in vs code and we have a
bunch of settings that we can count
these code to do and you can search for
organized Imports mine's at the top
because I used it recently but if you
just search for organizing ports and you
press enter it's going to automatically
get rid of all of the unused Imports and
sort them alphabetically I like to have
react at the top so now we have the
search icon there and phone number is
definitely not what we want to put in
there I believe on Reddit it says
search Reddit
and now we're going to add a bunch of
styles to our input and change the color
and we're going to make it look
identical to Reddit so let's go over
here we don't want the type equals
telephone here so let's add
a font size of
10 points and let's change the color of
the placeholder and the way to access
pseudo classes in Chakra is to do it
with a underscore because placeholder
we're accessing The Styling of it it's
actually a pseudo class if you were to
write it in regular CSS so to do that
read it so we do need to include the
underscore so we're going to give the
placeholder text a color of gray 500 and
we're going to add the hover pseudo
class
and we're going to make it uncover we're
going to make the background white we're
going to make the Border
one pixel solid and we're going to make
the Border color
blue 500. cool so now you can see uh
it's looking a bit more like Reddit
whereas Reddit and the length of it and
everything is going to be handled in a
bit now let's do another pseudo class
called Focus
and we're going to make the outline
none the order again one pixel solid and
the Border color not work labs border
color not border collapse for the second
time
watercolor blue 500 and we're going to
give it a height of
34 pixels
and a background of gray 50. cool I'm
going to make this a bit darker
to match more of the color of the text
all right now let's go back up to our
parent Flex container and we're going to
add some properties here now we're going
to say Flex grow is equal to one and
that means it's just going to basically
take up the remaining width of its
parent container and a lot of these
Styles will make a lot more sense once
we actually have all of the navbar
components in place but essentially
flexgro means uh basically just take up
the remaining room available we're gonna
add another property margin right and in
Chakra UI you can just say hamr I'm
going to say two and that is just I
think pixels that are going to say a
line is going to be equal to Center cool
so now you can see that we actually have
an average and the styles are exactly
the same as Reddit this icon you can see
is a little bit misaligned and when I
was doing the build I wasn't able to use
flexbox on the input it was being kind
of weird so I'm going to do is just add
a bottom margin of one
and that should make it look a bit more
centered that's pretty much it for the
search input for right now we're going
to come back to this in a bit once we
have the user because some of the
styling is going to change but um yeah
pretty simple component all right you
guys you're now going to start working
on the right content of the navbar and
write content is basically the parent of
everything going on over here we have
the authentication buttons and this drop
down menu and then all of those icons
that we saw when we were logged in that
is going to be a child of right content
all right I just wanted to mention that
When developing this application I tried
my very best to keep the components as
clean and as modular as possible and I
avoided writing extremely long
components because it can be really easy
to do that in react and I wanted to get
as close to a production react
application as possible to show you guys
how to write really clean and extendable
react applications so you kind of see
how it is done in the industry and
hopefully this will help you out with
your job search if your goal is to land
a developer job all right so inside of
our navbar folder I'm going to create a
folder called Write content inside of
right content I'm going to create the
root write content file write content
dot CSX I'm going to use our snippet and
we are going to take in a user in this
component as well like the search bar
but we don't have a user yet so I'm just
going to comment that out and we will
come back to that in a bit and we're
going to return a react fragment and
this react fragment is going to have a
component called authmodal which we're
going to create shortly that is going to
be the modal that pops up when you click
one of these buttons that's what that's
going to be
um but we're going to get to that
shortly and I'm going to create a flex
component here and inside of flex we're
going to have a component called auth
buttons which we want to create right
now and just before we do that I'm going
to give this the properties of justify
to be Center justify is short for
justify content I'm going to give a line
to the center align items to be centered
so this is basically how we Center a div
this is the CSS equivalent of display
Flex justify content is equal to Center
and align items is equal to Center for
those of you who might be wondering so
let's go create the auth buttons
component and the auth buttons are going
to be the login and sign up buttons that
we see over here on reddit.com
so let's go into write content and
create a
file called off buttons dot TSX
again with the snippet and we're not
going to take any props into these
component so I can just get rid of this
and we're going to again return a react
fragment and we're actually going to
start using
button component from Chakra UI so I'm
going to add a button called login
and another one with the text sign DOT
sign in sorry sine thousand cool and
let's go back to our right content
and enable this and do our Auto Import
all right so that's not
oh it's because we're not actually even
rendering this right now so let's go
let's go back to navbar and re-enable
this we're going to put directory up
here to comment this out and let's put
our import right content okay so you can
see those buttons popped up on the right
however they look absolutely nothing
like the Reddit buttons so we have some
work to do all right so since buttons
are going to appear in our application
several times and we want to apply
consistent styling to them we're going
to go back to our chakra theme and just
quickly create the global styling for
our buttons so that we don't have to
repeat a bunch of component styling
every single time we create a button so
inside of our chakra folder I'm going to
create another file called button.ts
This is how you would style your
components globally so that you have
consistent styling for all of your
components all right so let's see how we
can create Global component styling for
our button so I'm going to import
something from
from at Chakra UI
not icons theme I'm going to import the
type component style config
and this is a typescript things that we
get out of completion when we're
creating our button we're going to
create a button of type component style
config
so another keyboard shortcut that's
super handy in the typescript is if you
press Ctrl spacebar you will see a list
of all of the properties that this
particular type or interface is
expecting and this is really a first
glance at the power of typescript if you
have not used typescript before you're
going to be amazed when we write some
more advanced type script at how robust
and readable and Bug proof it makes the
code so I'm going to create this thing
called base style so let's do the Border
radius and look at this Auto completion
this is all thanks to typescript without
this type we would actually not have
this Auto completion right it would have
no idea like what this thing is so it
typescript at its finest okay let's
bring that type back
okay and inside a base style we're going
to give a border radius of 60 pixels and
I'm going to show you how to just apply
like a global color let's just make it
like let's make it our brand 100 color
the red color we created
and now in order to actually use this in
our chakra theme what we need to do is
go into our theme.ts file and remember
how when I was creating this theme I
mentioned that we're going to add the
button in here eventually so that's what
we're going to do now we're going to
import
back button
from that button file
and then we're going to enable it here
and then you should see that those
global Styles have been applied to our
button so if you go back to our button
if you say add a border of 2 pixel
solid red you'll see that those are
applied to every single button we create
so this is global now so what we want to
do is because our buttons have slightly
varied Styles we want to put everything
that applies to all of them inside of
this file and then anything that is
specific we will just add the same way
we have been adding other shortcut UI
Styles so I'm just going to paste in the
remaining styles for our Global buttons
because I just don't want to spend a
bunch of time writing out a bunch of CSS
once you kind of understand this the
rest will make total sense so I'm going
to go and just grab that from my other
code base and paste it in here so this
looks like a lot but it's actually not
we just have some base styling being
applied to all of our buttons and then
we have sizes which basically just
indicate any styling we want to apply to
this component at certain screen sizes
the most important thing to pay
attention to in here is the variance we
have our solid variant which has a blue
background and then we just have our
outline variant which is a white
background with a blue border which
looks like this red button here
okay so we're going to close this
because we're not really going to need
it anymore and our login button actually
is going to have the variant outline and
look at this typescript gives us this
nice Auto completion we can see all of
the options so I click outline you can
see on the right that that's actually
being applied now and like I said before
all of these styles that are specific to
these buttons only we're going to write
the same way we've been writing other
chakra UI Styles so for example the
height not every button is going to have
the same height so I'd not put it in the
global Styles I'm going to add it to
each button specifically so this button
is going to have a hit of 20 pixels and
we're going to see some more media Crews
here we're going to have on display
at mobile screens we're not going to
want to see this thing
and small we're going to make it display
is equal to flex
the width we're also going to have a
media query on
base Mobile sizes is going to be 70
pixels and at medium screen sizes it's
going to be 110 pixels margin right
of two and then I'm going to add a on
click function which I'm just going to
leave empty for now because it's not
going to do anything but we are going to
have on clicks on both of these buttons
that are going to trigger that modal at
f1g prompt us to log in and I'm going to
basically do a lot of the similar stuff
to the sign up button so I'm going to
make the variant of this solid but by
default it is solid so I don't really
have to specify that I'm going to make
the height of this equal to
28 pixels and I'm going to go grab all
of these things from this button because
it's going to apply to this button as
well so now we can see that those
buttons are looking pretty good on the
right and we can look at the
responsiveness here they disappear on
mobile and they get slightly smaller at
smaller screen sizes and this behavior
is identical to Reddit all right you
guys we are now ready to start working
on that model that I previously
mentioned before the authentication
model that's actually going to pop up
when we click one of these buttons
that's going to allow us to create user
accounts and log users in so we're going
to get a first glance at building a
modal as well as we're going to start
implementing recoil and we're going to
see how to work with global State using
recoil so super exciting stuff so what
I'm going to do is inside of components
I'm going to create another folder
called Model because we're going to have
a few different models throughout the
app I think there's two of them there's
the authentication model and then the
creation of community modal so we're
going to have a folder that houses all
of those components and inside of modal
I'm going to create another folder
called auth to house all of the
authentication modal components and
inside of here I'm going to create a
component called authmodel.tsx which
represents the sort of root component of
the authentication model so I'm going to
use our snippet and our authentication
model is actually not going to take in
any props
so we'll get rid of this
and what we're going to do now is we're
just going to get rid of this div and
right now I'm just going to return a
fragment that's completely empty I will
go back over here and implement this
Auto Import
and let's go grab the model component
from Chakra UI so if you go to if you
just Google chakra UI modal
modal dialogue we're just going to grab
a sort of basic modal that's basically
like this so what I'm going to do is
we're not going to use this use
disclosure hook but I'll grab the disc
for now we're going to sort of write our
own custom implementation of um opening
and closing the modal and I'm going to
go use the import all add all missing
Imports
okay so I'm going to get rid of this
lorem thing that's just like text and
I'm just going to write here is the
modal body cool now if I go to our
application now we should see this
button and if I click this we should
actually have a functioning modal now
which is pretty cool that's how easy it
is to implement modos with these UI
libraries however this is not the
behavior we want we wanted these buttons
to trigger that so we don't want this
button to be actually inside of the
modal itself because these buttons live
in our auth buttons component these both
of these unclick functions are going to
trigger the opening of that modal so we
need to modify just the opening and
closing of the logic a bit here and
that's what we're going to do now all
right so this is where we're actually
going to start working with recoil and
Global State the reason we need to
implement Global State here is because
with the opening and closing of this
modal does not actually live inside the
model itself it is being triggered by
other components and this calls for
moving our state upward and we're
actually going to see as we build this
application that the the authentication
model is going to be opened by a series
of components like when you try to vote
on a post that you're and you're not
logged in it will just open the modal if
you try to join a community and you're
not looking it'll open the model so
we're going to need that opening and
closing of modal State logic everywhere
in our application hence the need to
apply a recoil here so on that thought
let's go back to our app.tsx file and we
are now going to wrap our entire
application in The Recoil provider and
this is going to be the last time we
touch app.tsx so all we need to do is
just come over here
and import this component called recoil
root and that should just automatically
import from recoil
and we are just going to wrap
the app in the root now we have access
to global State everywhere in our app it
is that easy with recoil and I'm going
to show you now how to write a atom in
Recoil and an atom is similar to I guess
if you've worked with Redux before it
represents almost like a slice of state
and then we have just have access to
these atoms everywhere in our app recoil
is a lot simpler than Redux and it's so
much quicker to get set up and going so
that's why I'm super pumped to be using
it and I'm super pumped to show you all
right so what we're going to do now is
inside of our source folder we're going
to create a another folder called atoms
this is the convention we create a
folder called atoms and inside of our
atoms folder we're going to create all
of the pieces of global state that we're
going to be using so for example I'm
going to create a file in here called
auth modal
atom.ts and I highly recommend you to
check out The Recoil docs and just go
through sort of the home page of its
explanation of atoms and I'm going to
try my best to explain everything that's
sort of outlined here but if you want
further clarification just feel free to
go to The Recoil documentation it is
really great and recoil for your
information is created by Facebook as
well I think it is fantastic and I hope
you do as well so inside of our
Automotive file I'm going to import Adam
from recoil just like this this is going
to be our first glance at writing our
own typescript we're going to create an
interface called auth modal State and
this interface is going to represent the
properties that our auth modal atom is
going to have this is purely a
typescript thing you do not have to do
this with JavaScript but you will
shortly see why this is so handy and the
power of using types and interfaces with
typescript so our auth modal is going to
have two properties it's going to have
an open property which is going to
represent whether it's open or not and
that's going to be true or false a
Boolean and it's also going to have a
view and we're going to have basically
three views for our auth model we're
going to have a login view or a sign or
a sign up view or a reset password view
those are the three views that are
possible inside of our modal and it is a
vertical line that you see here
essentially means or it is called the
pipe operator in typescript and it
basically just means that we can have
this thing or this thing or this thing
and also the reason that we didn't just
make this up type string
which would also work too we decided to
be a bit more specific than just simply
saying string because we know that our
modal is only going to have a predefined
set of strings and this is a common
typescript thing and again if this makes
no sense to you we're going to write so
much typescript and interfaces and
you're going to see this so much that
it's going to make a lot more sense as
we get some more repetition with it it
is a little bit weird at first but just
try to accept it right now and as we
build it will make more and more sense I
promise we need this to be part of our
odd model state so that we so that the
model knows which component to render
because we're going to create components
for logging in signing up and resetting
password and this will make more sense
once we actually start building out the
modal component itself so I'm going to
create another variable called the
default modal State this is going to be
of type auth modal State and so now this
thing it knows what parameters to expect
because we specify that up here and so
this is again the beauty of typescript
so our default State we're going to
initialize our state as false because we
don't want it just to be open as soon as
the application spins up our view is
going to be default to log in and look
at this it's again beautiful typescript
because we specified the three possible
views up here so we're going to use
login here so now we're actually going
to create the atom itself so we're going
to say export const
modal State it's going to be equal to an
atom and this atom is going to be of
type of modal state
and the key
is the it's going to be auth model State
and the key is a parameter required by
recoil and it's basically just a unique
identifier for this specific atom and
this does need to be unique for all your
atoms this is just so you don't have
conflicting State and the default value
is going to be default modal statement
and this default value this represents
our initial value of State for this
particular atom and this is extremely
similar to the U State hook where you
just pass it a default initial value as
an argument and also one thing to note
here with typescript is because I
specified that this atom is of type of
modal state if I were to give this thing
anything other than that type for
example a number this is going to
complain and it's going to say that type
number is not assignable to type osmodal
stage so we are seeing more and more
evidence of why typescript makes your
code so much more bug free over a
JavaScript you would not get this type
validation with JavaScript and you
wouldn't realize that this is an error
until you're after education breaks and
crashes whereas in typescript it tells
you right away so that's why we're able
to use default model State because we
told it that this atom is of type of
modal State and we are passing it a
default value of the same type it's
expecting and that's why it is happy
right now awesome so now we're going to
see how to actually use this Global
state that we just defined inside of our
off model
so let's go to our auth model so we're
going to get rid of this use disclosure
hook provided by chakra and we're
instead going to do something extremely
similar to Native react state but
instead of using the use statehook we're
going to use a hook called the use
recoil state so we're going to say const
modal state
and set modal state is going to be equal
to use recoil State and then we just
need to pass it that auth modal State
atom that we created over here that's
all we need to do and this is and this
is how easy it is to get recoil set up
and this is literally all you need to do
to set up Global state so we basically
have our state value and then our
setting State function same exact thing
as you state with react however it is
global which is amazing and a lot
simpler than react so now for this modal
it is no longer going to use that is
open variable that we got rid of before
it is now going to be modal State when I
go into this it knows what properties
are defined on that thing thanks to our
interface so modal state DOT open and
we're going to remove this on closed
function we're instead going to define a
function called cons to handle close and
this function is going to use the set
modal State function and we're going to
take the previous state value and spread
it because we only want to modify a
single part of that piece of state and
that piece is going to be open and we're
going to set it to false now we're going
to get rid of this button and then
inside of our modal on close this
navigation can be handle closed and
we're not actually going to even have a
modal footer so I'm just going to get
rid of this okay so if we go back to our
model we'll see that this actually
doesn't do anything the model is not
appearing because we have not told these
buttons to trigger the model to be open
so this is the reason why we needed this
to be Global because now in our auth
buttons component we can call that set
authmodal State function that is going
to modify that specific atom and set it
to be open which the modal is listening
to and so multiple components are able
to read and write from the same atom and
Trigger Global State updates and so
that's we're going to do right here so
I'm going to enable these on click
things right here and inside of auth
buttons at the very top I'm going to
grab that set off modal State function
and there's another hook provided by
recoil called the use set recoil State
and we're using this because inside of
this component we only need access to
the setting State function for this
particular atom we do not need the value
of that state we don't care inside of
our buttons If the model is open or what
view it's in right
um if I go back to authmodal we did need
the value because we needed to tell this
model to be open or closed and that's
why we use just the generic use recall
State whereas over here we're only going
to use set recoil State and there's a
similar how to use only the value and
it's I think just use use recoil value
we're going to be seeing this a lot by
the end of this you're going to
understand this completely so now in our
on click function for logging in we want
to call that set off modal State and
what we want to do is we want to set the
openness of it to be true and we also
want to set the view to be login
right and we're going to do the exact
same thing
down here except we're just going to
make this sign up so this is basically
just when we click login it's going to
open the modal and it's also going to
show the login View and when we click
sign up it's going to open the model
annotation with the sign up view so
let's see if this works so now if I
click on login we can see that the modal
is actually being opened by both of
these buttons The View thing we have not
created the components for those yet so
don't worry but now we can actually see
how these components are modifying the
openness of this modal and that's super
cool we have just experienced Global
State we now know how to modify any
application state from any component
using recoil all right you guys so with
the recoil setup and with the modal
structure put in place we are now at a
good place to actually start building
out the structure of this model and
create the login with Google button and
the inputs that the user can put their
username and password to sign in or sign
up so let's get going on that all right
so the first thing we're going to do is
make the modal title change depending
what modal view we're in and that comes
from the value of modal State Dot View
so if I'm in the login view I want to
say login and if I'm signing up I want
to sign up and that's super easy to do
so all we need to do is make this text
Dynamic using JavaScript so inside of
our header we can say modal state
dot view is equal to login if this is
true
then let's show the text log in and this
is if you have not seen this before just
the react way of saying that show this
text if this is true this is basically
an if statement in react you do the
exact same thing for our view if it's
equal to sign up
and we can say sign up okay so now
you'll see that this has changed to
login because our default view was
logged in if I click sign up it's sign
up so it's pretty cool we can see that
the second piece of state of our modal
is now in action which is that view and
we're going to add the third one which
was reset password
so we can see that being built
dynamically okay
now we're going to work on the body so
we can get rid of this text here and our
body is going to have some CSS
properties so we're going to say display
flex and we have to manually specify
this because this is not the flex
component so by default it does not have
this so we just have to manually type it
in deflects Direction
is going to be column
we're going to say align items is going
to be equal to Center and justify
content
I don't know why I'm not getting auto
complete it's going to also be equal to
Center
this is basically centering everything
inside of this container inside of our
mortal body we're going to have the flex
component
we're going to make the direction of
this
column the Align is going to be Center
and the justify
is also going to be equal to Center
we're going to make the width of this
equal to
70 percent
awesome let's scroll up a bit you can
see and I'll put a border on this just
to make it clear on
the right what we are looking at it has
nothing in it right now so it just looks
like a line
now what's actually going to go in here
this is going to be our oauth buttons so
the sign in with Google button and it's
also going to consist of those inputs to
put in your email and password and if
you look at the Reddit modal you can see
that we have the this is what's going to
be represented by our oauth buttons and
then we're going to have these inputs as
well so basically we're going to have a
component called oauth buttons which
we're going to create very soon and
we're also going to have a component
called auth inputs which is going to be
those text inputs and we're also going
to have a component called reset
password which we will create at the
very end we'll do this after we have
Firebase setup and everything and we're
actually able to create users this will
be the very last step of Firebase
authentication so we won't revisit this
for a little bit okay cool and that is
pretty much it we just have to go and
create these components and our model
will be completely done
okay so inside of our auth modal folder
I'm going to create another file called
auth inputs
and I'm going to use our snippet so in
this component we are going to take in
some props eventually but for now we're
not going to take anything so I'm just
going to leave it blank for now and I'm
going to return
our famous Flex component
import that the flex direction is going
to be column
we're going to say a line is equal to
Center and our width
is going to be a hundred percent of our
parent we're going to give this a margin
top four okay and now we're going to
create more child components and this
one's going to be our login component
as well as our sign
up component and we also don't want to
show both of these at the same time
right we only want to show the login
component when our model view is log in
and we only want to show this when our
modal view is signed up so what we can
do is grab that modal State value and
we're going to use that use recoil value
hook that I mentioned earlier because in
this file we only care about the value
of that state we do not care about
setting that state so now in here we can
control which one we're seeing by
tapping in to that modal State Dot View
if the motorstate.view is equal to login
then show
our login component
and if this is equal to sign up
then show our
sign up component which we have not
created and that is it for this
component and the reason we are keeping
this component so small is because if we
put everything from login and sign up in
here it would be a super giant mess and
we're going to keep it this way and it
keeps it very clean and readable so that
if someone else were to read this they
would know exactly what's going on and
it's common practice in industry and it
makes refactoring the code a lot easier
and it makes the component overall more
extendable in the future all right so
what we're going to do now is I'm going
to comment these out and we're actually
going to go create the login component
now so inside of our modal auth folder
I'm going to create another component
called the login.tsx use our snippet all
right and this component is going to be
our first component that is going to
take in user inputs in the form of a
form so we're going to have two inputs
that we're going to create here and
one's going to be for the email and Y is
going to be for the password and we're
going to need to create some state in
order for our user to be able to type
these values in and for us to submit it
to Firebase all right so to do that
we're going to use the use statehawk and
I'm going to create a state variable
called login form and the setter
function is going to be called set login
form and we're going to be say we're
going to say use State and the initial
value of our login form is going to have
an email that is going to be empty and a
password
that is going to be empty as well okay
so now we can actually build the two
inputs that are going to use and update
that form state so inside of our form
let's create a input and that is going
to come from Chakra UI we're going to
create two of them just like this okay
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go back to our auth inputs component and
just enable that login component so that
we can actually see what we're building
on the right since we have something
defined now we should be able to do that
and in order to see anything I just need
to go back to authmodal because that is
the parent of auth inputs and enable
auth inputs
and that should automatically import
just make sure it's imported at the top
okay so nothing's showing let me try to
refreshing the page
oh there are inputs now the reason I
have to refresh sometimes is because I
take breaks between recording sessions
and I think the development server just
like goes to sleep so the hot reloading
kind of is uh disabled for a quick
second there until I refresh okay so
let's go back to our login form and
we're going to give some properties to
our input so this one is going to have a
name of email and we're going to give it
a placeholder of email as well
and it's also going to have a type and
the type is going to be email and we're
going to give a margin bottom of 2 so
there's some space between these two
things and we're also going to pass an
on change function which we're going to
create in just a second save that with
auto formats and we're going to do
basically the exact same thing to this
one down here so I'm going to say name
is equal to password
the placeholder is going to be the
password
our type is going to be password
and that's so that we get these uh if I
save that that's so that we get these
secretive Dots here and our on change is
going to be just an empty function for
now and so we're going to come up here
and Define two functions and those two
functions are going to be that on change
function and the submit function for
when we actually submit this form so
let's also create the button that we're
going to use to submit this form and
we're going to import a button from
sharper UI and this is going to say log
in all right so now we have pretty much
everything in place we have two inputs
and we have a login button to submit our
form and in order to make this so this
button actually triggers a submittal of
the form you have to say type equals
submit and since this is wrapped in a
form it knows to call the onsubmit
function that we're going to create in a
second when this button is clicked so
what we're going to do is create that on
submit function
it's going to be empty for now and we're
also going to create the on change
function for our inputs which are going
to be triggered every time a user types
into the input it's going to update our
state
so now let's come down here and I'm
going to change both of these two things
to be on change so they're both going to
call the same on change function and I'm
going to show you how you can have
multiple inputs use a single on change
function in your forms rather than
having to create separate stage for the
email and the password you can just have
a single state in our case login form
and a single on change Handler will
handle those updates and before we do
that I'm just going to quickly add the
on submit to the on
submit perfect so our on change function
implicitly takes in an event this event
is a change event that is emitted by
these inputs so every time the inputs
change it emits an event and it is going
to be captured by this function so the
type of this event we can say is react
dot change event and the type of HTML
element that's emitting this event is an
HTML input element and this is all
purely typescript the reason we do this
is so that when we're using our event
inside of our function we have Auto
completion and we can see all the
properties on our event so petstrip at
its finest once again so enter on change
function we are going to update form
state so we're going to say set login
form and we're going to take the
previous value of state and we're going
to spread it because we only want to
update a single piece of our form State
and that piece depends on which input is
emitting this event and how do we know
that well luckily on our event we have
event.target
dot name
and where's that name coming from that's
because we gave these inputs a name so
every time this is a particular input e
makes an event that event contains the
name of the Target that he made at the
event and so that's how we're able to
know which piece of state to actually
set so we can say event.target dot value
and that's just going to be the value
that is inside of the input so now if I
go to my browser I'm going to go to my
react Chrome extension if you do not
have the react Chrome extension I highly
highly highly recommend you to get it it
is extremely useful and it's much more
accurate in debugging react applications
than doing console logs so highly
recommend that and I'm just going to use
the react selector to inspect our login
form and you can see that it has a piece
of state with our form that has email
and password and so thanks to our on
change function that we just wrote when
I type into here you can see that state
is updating in the reaction extension
and same with the password and it knows
which input specifically we're typing
into all right so now that that's
handled let's actually style this form
because right now it looks like garbage
okay
okay so what we're going to do is on our
button let's add a width of a hundred
percent and a height of 36 pixels
and on our button I'm also going to add
a margin top of 2 and a margin bottom of
2 to give it some space around it and
now let's add all of the styling to our
input to make it look as closely as
possible to these Reddit inputs and also
our model is going to vary slightly in
how it looks just because I didn't like
this massive white space on the Reddit
form so ours is just going to be more of
uh this without the white space and
there's going to be little things that
very like I'm not going to add like this
text I don't think that's very useful
but everything else is going to be very
much similar let's go back to our app
and I'm just going to go quickly Center
this text because it is supposed to be
over here so I'm just going to go
quickly back to the authmodal to our
header I'm just going to say text align
is going to be equal to Center and
that's going to Center that for us and
I'm also just going to get rid of this
red border all right I'm also just going
to quickly add some bottom padding to
our modal body just to give it some more
room at the bottom there and let's go
back to our login and get going on these
inputs okay so the first thing I'm going
to do is add the required property to
both of these inputs
just so that we're not able to submit
our form if one of these things is empty
so let's go down here and I'm going to
add a font size of 10 point make it a
bit smaller than it is right now and I'm
going to style the placeholder by using
the placeholder sudo class and I'm going
to make the color of this gray 500
and I'm going to add some upper styling
as well you're going to make the
background white the Border one pixel
solid
and the Border color is going to be
blue 500. Perfect all right and let's
also add some Focus styling for when
this thing is clicked on and in focus
we want to make the outline none and the
three remaining things are going to be
the exact same as these so I'm just
going to copy these and paste them down
here and we are going to make the
background color gray 50 which is a
really light gray so the exact same
styles are going to apply to our
password input so I'm just going to grab
all of these we started at font size
come down here paste them down here and
I think we're just also missing the
margin on our password input so I'll
throw that in there as well to get more
spacing between that and the button
alright so this is looking really good
you can see that we have hover styling
Focus styling it's all extremely similar
to Reddit so I'm really happy with how
this turned out all right so now the
only thing we need to add to login is
that text at the bottom that says new to
Reddit sign up and that's going to
switch to view to actually be the sign
up view so let's go quickly and do that
that'll be that won't take very long at
all
all right so beneath our login button
I'm going to create a flex container and
this Flex container is going to have the
property font size nine point so all the
fonts inside of here are going to be
size 9 and we're going to make Justified
content equal to Center and inside of
here we're going to have text and text
is pretty much just a P tag with zero
margin that is a chakra component and
this is going to say new here and also a
quick keyword shortcut
um if you want to duplicate lines which
is something we do a lot you can press
option shift and then the up or down
arrows depending on which direction you
want it to show up in so for example if
I want the same line to show up beneath
it I can do option shift down arrow and
I'll duplicate the line below it which
is super handy all right so this one is
going to say in all caps sign up and
that's
and that looks like this so we're just
going to add some margin right
up one to our new here text and then
we're also going to give this
a color of blue 500 and we're going to
make it a little bit heavier if we find
we're going to say fond grid is going to
be equal to 700 we're going to make the
cursor
equal to pointer so that when we hover
over it it has the pointer of cursor
because it's something that we can click
on and when we click on this thing all
we need to do is modify our auth model
State and change the view from login to
sign up which is something we've already
kind of seen how to do so what I'm going
to do is go up to our component and I'm
going to grab the set odd model State
function using that set use set recoil
State hook that we saw before pass it
our auth mortal State atom and we only
need the setting about model State we
don't care about the Automotive State
itself and we come down here and on this
sign up text which is the thing we're
going to click to toggle that view I'm
going to add an on click function here
I should save this for their Auto
formats so we can see it
and this is going to call that set auth
model State function it's going to take
the previous state and we're only going
to modify the view we're going to change
the view to sign up so now if we click
on that text let's move that blue
Highlight if we click on that text it
actually modifies the view and we'll add
the reverse in the sign up component
we'll make it so we go back to login
just like you would see in any regular
authentication form
perfect so that's super easy with recoil
all right so the structure of this
component is pretty much done all that
we need to add in here is the Firebase
logic which is going to be handled by
this on submit function the modal is
getting very close to being done we just
need to create our signup component
which is going to be very very similar
to this component it's the pretty much
the exact same thing it just has a third
input to confirm the password and then
all we need to do is create the oauth
button or the login with Google button
that will not take very long at all
because it's just a single button and
then we will be ready to hook up our
application to a Firebase backend and
start creating users with Firebase
authentication so we're getting super
close to that we're just a few minutes
away all right so let's go quickly build
that signup component so inside of our
auth folder the same place where login
is I'm just going to create another file
called
signup.tsx instead of here then use our
snippet I'm going to get rid of the type
because we are not going to take any
props into this component and we are
going to go and copy pretty much
everything from login into here because
it's essentially the exact same thing
with just a few minor changes so let's
grab everything inside of here
up to this bracket copy that and bring
it over here so just paste that in there
and we're going to get a bunch of angry
stuff because we have not imported
anything so let's go to this input and
try doing this add all missing Imports
thing with command period and see if
that solves all that stuff so it does um
what is going on here
oh I think text for some reason with
chakra it just like doesn't Auto Import
for some reason it's kind of weird all
the other ones do but we sometimes have
to go manually import text from Chakra
no idea why but that is just how it
works okay so
um that is not showing I'm just gonna
quickly do oh it's not showing because
um if I go to auth inputs we are not
even rendering it right now so let's go
and do that inside of auth input the
same way we did log in okay so now if I
open up sign up I should see these two
inputs it's the exact same component as
login so there is no difference so let's
make those minor modifications to that
now
okay so our signup form is going to have
pretty much the exact same state as our
login form except it's going to be I'm
just going to call it sign up form and
set
sign up form and in addition to having
an email and password it's going to have
a confirm password thing
as a third argument we just need to
change this to set sign up form and the
odd change is going to behave the exact
same way even with our third input you
could technically have 100 inputs if you
want which could be handled bias on
change as long as they have that name
you are good to go and let's come down
here and graph this input and duplicate
it underneath and yeah you know how much
would you know you can duplicate single
lines
with that keyboard shortcut option shift
down arrow or up Arrow you can also do
that with multiple lines as well so
good to know that's basically what I
just did with that input so we now have
the third input there we're just going
to change the properties of this so the
name of this is going to be confirm
password
the placeholder is going to be confirmed
the type is still going to be password
and everything else is going to be the
same down here we're going to change
this to sign up because this is the sign
up form not the login form and our text
at the bottom is going to change it a
little bit as well I forget exactly what
it says on Reddit new to Reddit sign up
in the sign up form it says already a
redditor log in so let's type that in
here
already uh redditor
if you are a redditor already let's log
in
with a space
cool and we're going to change the view
we are in the signup view we want to
modify the view to be log in
awesome I think we're pretty much done
this component now that's how easy it
was to create this signup component it's
literally the exact same thing just with
a slightly different form and the text
changes that is all all right so the
only thing left to put inside of our
signup component is going to be that
Firebase logic which we are so close to
all we need to do is go and create that
oauth buttons component with our login
with Google button so let's go and do
that now it's going to be very short
it's a very simple component so let's go
into our auth folder and create another
component called oauth buttons dot TSX
even though for this tutorial we're only
going to be able to log in with Google
you could in the same component at as
many third-party oauth provider buttons
as you would want to log in with GitHub
Twitter Facebook I'm only going to use
Google but if this is where you would
add any button for a third-party oauth
provider hence the name a lot and
buttons all right so I'm going to use
our snippet and I'm going to get rid of
our prop type because we do not need it
and we can get rid of it here as well
and inside of this component we you're
going to return
our chakra Flex component and also a
button from Chakra and this button is
going to say continue with Google all
right and let's go make it so we can
actually see this component show up on
our browser so inside of authmodal we
can now go enable this component because
it exists let's import it
cool and so now we actually have a
button that says continue with Google
that is pretty hyped okay so let's go
back to our oauth buttons component
where did it go here and just to
illustrate what I was saying earlier
about being able to add any other
provider you'd want in here I'm just
going to say some other provider so you
know that this is where you would put
those buttons okay and this Flex we're
just going to give a direction of column
and that should fix that and also going
to give a width of 100
and a margin bottom
of four
Perfect all right and this Google button
does not look anything like a login with
Google button so let's make that happen
so inside of our uh Google button we're
going to just remove this text for a sec
and we are going to add an image from
Chakra and the source of that image is
going to be that is going to be one of
those images that I had you guys insert
into the project earlier or is it now
it's in the public images it is the
Google logo dot PNG so that is the
reason why this is in the project it is
for this button so if I say Images slash
Google logo dot PNG
you can see that show off on the button
there it looks really big so let's give
it a height of 20 pixels awesome and
that's our text back in there continue
with Google and I'm not sure if you
remember but if we go back and look at
this button.ts file in our chakra for
our Global button styling uh I had this
variant called oauth that I created for
all of the lock buttons that you could
potentially create and so we are going
to use this for our Google button but if
you add any more third-party oauth
provider buttons then you can use the
same variant as well so let's go over
here and let's add that variant to be oh
I
cool cool cool and let's just add a
bottom margin of two and this button
here on the bottom I'm also going to
give it a variant of glauth so that it
looks the same and what I'm going to do
is just add a bit of red margin to our
Google logo so there's some space there
and our login model is really the only
component we're going to build that
varies at all from the original red
design just because I didn't really like
this white space but our model is still
super super clean okay so all that's
missing now is just that text in between
the oauth buttons and these inputs that
says or so it's like log in with this or
this where that's going to be is inside
of our auth model root
and that's going to go right in here so
I'm just going to add text that says or
and because text doesn't want to seem to
automatically import from shortcut for
some reason we just have to go manually
add it to our Imports
up top and we can make the color of this
gray uh 400 and let's make the font
weight
700. let's actually change this to 500.
and you will notice that you see the a
lot buttons in both the login and the
signup View and the reason we do that is
because when you're logging in with
Google it doesn't matter if you're a new
or a returning user logging in is the
exact same thing and we structure our
components that way so we have the oauth
buttons here and that lives as a sibling
as often puts and auth inputs is the
parent of login and sign up so they will
appear in both of those views all right
so we are now done the UI structure of
our modal other than the resetting of
the password which we're going to do
after we set up Firebase and we're able
to create users if we are now ready to
move into Firebase and start creating
users we left off last time just
finishing power login and signup forms
and we are now ready to start working on
implementing Firebase getting it all set
up uh just one note I wanted to mention
that I did create a Discord server after
creating last video because I thought
it'd be useful for people to get help in
so if you are wanting direct access to
me and you want to sort of ask on-demand
questions on on the project or really
anything feel free to join that server I
would love to see you in there the link
is in the description let's get back to
work all right so what we're going to do
is go to
firebase.google.com and this is where
we're going to create our Firebase
project and get some configuration
variables to connect our app to Firebase
if this is your first time to the
console it may ask you to log in so just
log in with your Gmail account or create
a new Gmail account and then we're going
to do is go to the console I'm just
going to click add project and the name
I'm going to get this project is just
Reddit clone tutorial feel free to name
use whatever you'd like and then you're
going to be asked if you want to enable
Google analytics for this project
because it is a demo I'm just going to
disable this
and then we're going to click create
project and this may take a few minutes
so once this is all done let's click
continue and it'll take us to our
project so we're creating a web app so
we're going to click on web and then
we're going to give this a nickname I'm
just going to give it the same name as
our project name and then I'm going to
click Register App perfect now once
that's done it's going to ask you to
install Firebase but we already did that
when we installed chakra if you did not
install Firebase now would be the time
to do that so go ahead and do that if
you do not we're going to basically do
exactly this in our app and that is how
easy it is to connect Firebase to our
app so what we're going to do is I'm
going to come over to our repo and I'm
just going to close some folders to
clean this up a bit so it's a bit more
visible and inside of source I'm going
to create a new folder called Firebase
and then inside of Firebase I'm going to
create a file called Client app Dot
typescript
and this is where we're going to put our
initialize app you will have your own
unique configuration variables do not
put the ones that are displayed in this
video because it will not work all right
so what I'm going to do is just quickly
copy this over
all right so now we're going to do is
just in the root of our project I'm just
going to create a new file called Dot
env.local and this is where we're going
to put all of our environment variables
for our Firebase project so what I'm
going to do is on the repo I believe
there should be a DOT env.example file
that looks something like this and this
basically just contains all of the keys
that we're going to put in our end file
if you don't want to manually type all
this out because it's kind of annoying
to do that feel free to go to the repo
on GitHub and grab these keys I'm going
to paste these in here and now we're
going to copy these variables over to
put them into here all right so once
that is done all we need to do now is
just go back to our client app file and
remove these hard-coded strings and just
access our environment variables so what
I'm going to do is just temporarily move
this down here for a second just so I
can copy the things over the first one
is going to be process.env dot that
thing and we're going to do this for all
of them so once that's done and all
these names match the variables inside
of your EMB file we can close this
because we're not going to use it ever
again for this build all right so now
our app is set up to connect to our
Firebase project that we created and
we're going to access it through this
app instance that we created here we're
going to make a few changes down here
though because uh we're using max.js and
we need to handle the case of server
side rendering which introduces some
complications with creating the app but
it's just a few lines of code and I'll
explain them as we go so I'm just going
to remove these comments at the top and
what we're going to do is in addition to
this initialize app function we're also
going to grab a function called get app
as well as get apps and we're also going
to import a function from Firebase auth
and that function is going to be get
auth
foreign
we're also going to import a function
from Firebase
firestore and that is going to allow us
to actually access our database when we
uh when we create it soon
and that is going to be the function get
firestore all right and the last thing
we're going to import is going to be
from Firebase storage and that function
is going to be get storage and this is
going to be used when we get into the
creation of posts and users can upload
images we're going to store those images
in Firebase storage and Firebase storage
is it is different than firestore
database storage is used to store files
and media things like video and photos
whereas the database just stores
JavaScript object Json type data all
right now down here what we're going to
do is we're going to initialize Firebase
and I'm just going to add a comment for
clarity that's going to say for server
side rendering
okay so since our application is going
to use server side rendering in some
areas we need to avoid attempting to
initialize an app on both the next JS
server as well as on the client side
because the way next.js works when you
use server-side rendering is that it
renders the app on the server and then
that is sent to the client and then
client-side rendering will occur and we
will get an error if we try to call this
initialize app function both on the
server and the client and that will make
a bit more sense once I write this
function out so basically how this is
going to look is we're going to write it
as a ternary operator and this is going
to call that function get apps and this
is going to get all the apps that we
have created with our Firebase config
object above and it's going to say if
this app does not exist meaning that
there is no length then we're going to
initialize it
however if it does exist we're going to
go get that out and whatever the result
of this ternary operator is is going to
be stored in our app instance and then
we will have access to it on the client
side when we need it
I hope that makes sense so now we're
going to actually create our firestore
instance and this is basically how we're
going to access our firestore database
we're going to pass it our app and then
we're going to create our auth instance
which is how we're going to use Firebase
authentication also going to pass our
app and we will while we're here create
our storage instance same thing pass it
our app and now we just need to export
all of these things
so we have access to them throughout our
application we can just simply import
them in any other client-side file and
we can use their functionalities so we
are completely done with this file we
have created all of the necessary
variables and we are now ready to
actually start using these things in our
app to start creating users and data and
images and whatever so we can close this
client app file and move forward all
right so now that our app is actually
able to communicate with our Firebase
project we can now Implement
authentication and actually start
creating users so for authentication we
are going to use this Library called
react Firebase Hooks and these are hooks
that are developed specifically for
usage of Firebase inside of react and
they enable us to leverage all of the
amazing powers of a Firebase with just a
few simple Hooks and a few lines of code
and they're honestly unreal so if you
just search for this package on npm and
then you click on their GitHub
repository link this is where all of
their documentation is and if you come
to the bottom here you can see they have
documentation for all of their available
hooks so we're going to Focus right now
on these authentication Hooks and if you
come into here you will see that they
have hooks for essentially every single
authentication method so we're going to
be using you sign in with Google you
sign in with email and password and use
create email or password but once you
know how to use one of these you can use
them all and you can Implement these in
just a few lines of code so we're going
to start off with use create user with
email and password kind of a mouthful
and they have really good examples for
each one of their Hooks and they look
long but they're honestly very very
straightforward and maybe I'll zoom in a
bit hopefully you can see that so what
I'm going to do is just come over here
and grab the installation from npm and
come to our project and paste that in
there
perfect once that's done I will just
come back to this documentation here and
I'm just going to grab this and paste it
in our code base because we're going to
have it written the exact same way so
when we use any of the authentication
hooks from that Library we need to pass
it our Firebase auth instance which is
what we created in that client app file
right here and that is basically how we
link our specific app to the hooks so
we're going to need to import both of
these so I'm going to try to Auto Import
this
um okay for some reason it's not wanting
to Auto Import which I don't understand
but sometimes that happens import from
react
Firebase hooks slash odd
use create user with email and password
and underneath that I'm going to import
our clock instance from
it's going to be all the way up in
Firebase
Client app
grab that auth object and now it should
be happy so this hook returns to us four
different variables the first one is the
actual function that's going to be used
to create the users we're going to pass
this our email and password then once
this successfully completes it returns
to us a user and then there is loading
and error state which helps track the
progress of this function so if this
thing is in progress this will be true
if it errors out then this will happen
and we can use these two things to
modify our UI to make it clear to the
user what is going on so this is where
we're actually going to call that
function so I'm going to type out create
user with email and password and the
arguments we're going to pass are going
to be our signup form dot email and our
signup form dot password so let's
quickly add form validation to check
that a valid email hasn't entered and
that the password that the user enters
in the password and confirm password
Fields match and actually
um because we put the type of email on
this input HTML by default should handle
the case of an event on email and is
once you check that the email actually
contains the at sign which is what we're
going to consider a valid email I think
there's some libraries that exist that
will check that it's like a valid domain
and stuff but for the purpose of this
tutorial I think that's simply checking
for the ad signed is completely fine so
the only thing we need to handle them is
if those passwords match so we're going
to say if signupform dot password is not
equal to signupform dot confirm password
let's set an error and how are we going
to set that error well we're going to
need to create another state variable so
we're going to create a state variable
called form error we can't use the
keyword error because this is being
taken by that there
actually what we're going to do is
change the name of this to user
error it doesn't have to be specifically
error because the hook is just going to
return four parameters it doesn't care
what the name is the fourth one though
is going to be the error so I'm just
going to give it a name of user error
that way up here I can use the more
general term error I'm going to say set
error
up here
and this is going to be use State and
we're going to set it as an empty string
to start off
and then we can come and actually remove
this comment here and actually set error
to be passwords do not match
and I'm just going to return out of the
function because we do not want to
proceed with this if they and if their
passwords do not match all right and
let's open up our modal and what I'm
going to quickly do is just add that
error text here if it exists so I'm
going to add some text in here that's
going to say here is here
just so we can see what it looks like
and I'm going to make the text align to
be Center and the color
red because red means error usually and
then I'm going to change the font size
to just be a bit smaller
10. perfect and we do not want to
actually say here's the error let's
actually put in here our form
not former we actually need to be there
perfect and then uh to make this even a
bit cleaner I'm going to say error and
depth text and basically that's just
saying don't display this text unless
this exists so now let's try to submit
our form
and you can see that those required
things on our inputs are doing their job
they're making sure that text actually
exists and I believe that if I enter a
thing that does not have the at 10 in it
it should give us that that thing yeah
so it's saying uh it's saying it's not a
valid email address so this this
component handles that for us which is
super nice but let's make sure if we do
enter a value email like shady shady.com
and I enter passwords that do not match
do we get that error and yes we do now
you'll notice that when I submitted that
the page refreshed and that is what
happens by default on form submittal uh
in order to prevent that we need to take
the submit event and call the method
prevent default so what we're going to
need to do is take in the event as an
argument the same way is kind of what we
did down here how the function
implicitly took in an event and then
we'll have access to all of the methods
on that event so I'm going to create
that argument here and the type of this
is going to be react dot form event
because it is a form event it's no
longer a change event and the type of
HTML element that is producing this
event is the HTML form element and now
since we have that typescript type there
we get intellisense with all of the
methods that exist for that specific
event and I can call event dot prevent
default and now if I try that again
it's about email
passwords that do not match sign up
passwords do not match perfect and what
I'm going to do also is that when the
form is submitted I'm going to check if
there is an error and if there is then
I'm going to set it to an empty string
because we kind of want to reset the
error every time we try to submit the
form and you could add some other stuff
as well to make sure that the password
length is like six characters and
doesn't contain these characters and
contains blah blah blah but uh again
that's kind of not necessary for this
project but feel free to add whatever
you'd like in terms of validation all
right and one last thing that we're
going to quickly do before trying to
submit a user is I'm just going to use
this loading State quickly on our button
and I can't remember if I explained this
when we were creating the button but a
beautiful thing with chakra UI is that
with their buttons and I think with all
of their components we can add an is
loading prop to the component and we can
pass it a Boolean which will show a
loading state if Boolean is true so for
example if I say true it will show
orthologic state so in this case our
Boolean is going to be that loading
Boolean provided by that hook because
the status of this is going to be
toggling from true and false depending
on what the hook is up to
so let's give this a go and see what
happens so I'm going to go over to our
Firebase project and go to
authentication because that's where our
users are going to show up if they are
successful and actually I'll just click
get started here because I didn't do
that before all right so okay so I'm
glad I checked this before because what
we need to do is actually enable the
specific authentication methods that
we're going to be using so in this case
email and password and then later in
just a few minutes we're going to do
Google so let's click on email and
password and let's click enable and then
mobile save that and that Firebase is
actually going to allow us to create
users with email and password so let's
go ahead and give that a spin and if it
works we should see that user show up
inside of our users column here so let's
go back to our app we will refresh to
sort of reset everything let's open up
our modal and let's enter Shady
shady.com I'm going to make the password
chatty
and let's see what happens we can see
that loading State you see how it
toggled there that was the hook changing
status uh we don't get anything on the
UI because we haven't done anything if
it worked I'm assuming it did let's go
check our Firebase authentication so I
will need to refresh
and look at that we do have a user in
there with the email shabby chatty and
that is how easy it is to create users
with these Hooks and Google securely
stores these users and encrypts our
passwords so we don't have to worry
about any of that on our own we can just
focus on actually the fun parts of our
app so thank you to anyone who has
contributed to these amazing libraries
all right you guys now I briefly want to
show you how to do error handling with
Firebase in the rare event that an error
occurs I know it's not the most exciting
thing error handling is never that fun
but it is really good to know how to do
it to make your app more robust so let's
quickly do that so the first error that
you might think of is what happens if we
try to sign up a user that already
exists in the case of shady here we
already have a user that has been
authenticated with shady.com what
happens if you try to sign up again
uh let's take a look
we get some sort of error here and if we
look more closely at it we can figure
out maybe what's going on
okay so let's
bring that open I'm going to zoom in uh
it might be a bit small for you wow this
is painful to get this thing to expand
why won't this expand
I look like a tool right now trying to
get this thing open
okay what I'm going to do okay this is
all we really need to see we can see
that we got a 400 error which means bad
request so Firebase just said that you
tried to create a new user but a user
with that email already has been created
so we somehow need to just update our UI
to indicate that to the user so the way
we're going to do that is actually
through this user error variable given
to us by the hook so the way I'm going
to illustrate what this error actually
looks like is if I come down here to
where we're actually rendering the error
which was right here I'm going to what
I'm going to do is just add an or
statement that says or user error and an
error in this case is
the error we are setting with that state
variable uh if there's a contained valid
password and user error is going to be
the actual error returned from Firebase
authentication so what we're going to do
is we're going to say okay if error or
user error let's show some text that
shows that error I can also add an or
statement here and I'm going to type
user error and I'll notice that it has a
property called message and this is the
thing we want to access on the error
okay so uh let's try to log in with
shadyashady.com
and see what happens so we successfully
show the error on the UI Firebase error
off email already in use but that's kind
of like weird to show to the user maybe
we want to show like more meaningful
text and I want to show you how to do
that with Firebase if you are totally
fine with this then like feel free to
leave it I just want to show you how to
potentially display a more meaningful
message so inside of Firebase I'm going
to create a new file called errors
Dot TS and in here we're going to put
pretty much all the Firebase errors
we're going to come across which is not
going to be that many there's only like
a few but basically what we're going to
do is create an object
called Firebase errors and that's going
to contain
these these messages as keys
we're going to take this key and map it
to a more useful error message so for
example if the Firebase error is that
hot email already in use thing we can
return a text that says a user with that
email already exists that's much more
meaningful to the user and now what
we're going to do is inside of that
signup form I'm just going to go and
import those Firebase errors I'm going
to copy this line down here because it's
going to come from slash Firebase errors
then we're going to grab that Firebase
errors object
and then what we're going to do is where
we were rendering this user error
message that is now going to be a key of
the object Firebase errors and this is
how we can actually access that more
meaningful error message right because
and I'll address this uh red underline
in a second but if we just go back to
errors we can see that if we try to
access the object at that error.message
it's going to give us this in return
which is a very useful message okay so
I'm just going to briefly attempt to
address what is going on here it's kind
of a weird texture thing and we need to
be more specific of what type it is that
we're trying to use to index that
particular object basically all we're
going to do is take the user Dot message
and Typecast it to a valid index of that
object and all type casting is is just
taking a variable and changing its type
to a new type so the way to Typecast in
typescript is to take that variable and
then write the word as and then write
the new type this is kind of confusing
because there's key of and type of here
and if this does not really make sense
to you right now do not worry we're
going to see this a few times throughout
the project so just kind of accept this
for now I really really dislike telling
people to just accept things when I'm
teaching but in this case I just don't
think this is something to get caught up
on and this will become a lot more clear
when we start defining our own types and
interfaces with like posts and
communities and stuff so now we can do
is we see that we're getting a more
meaningful message there which is great
let's try to trigger the other one yeah
passwords do not match but the styling
changes but I think there's just
something going on with the logic here
okay so the formatting kind of messed up
my logic here
and
so I'm going to remove these brackets
and I think to prevent that from
reformatting improperly I just need to
add brackets around that so this is a
single Boolean here okay and now we can
see that we are getting the proper error
there awesome and if I just try one more
time
we can see that we get the other error
so now errors are handling both of our
cases which is great all right and one
thing I actually decided that I want to
do to make this a bit more readable
because this is kind of confusing I'm
just going to get rid of this outer
logic here and I'm going to just
simplify it to
this and this is just going to do the
exact same thing as it was before it
just is a bit more readable okay so that
is enough about errors I've had it with
errors for now let's go do something
more exciting all right so now that we
have been able to successfully create
users with email and password via back
use create user with email and password
hook let's go now Implement oauth and
log our users in with Google using the
similar hook uh use assignment with
Google and now that we've been able to
use one of these hooks we can use them
all they're all so similar in terms of
functionality and that is what I love
about this Library so we're going to go
to our oauth buttons which if you recall
is a section here and we are going to
implement the pretty much same structure
in this file so at the top we're going
to import
from react Firebase hooks off this time
though we're going to grab that use
sign in with Google function and again
we're going to need to import our
Firebase auth instance from The Client
app file Firebase slash Client app grab
off
and inside of this file we're going to
do pretty much the exact same thing as
we did in the other file we're going to
call that hook and say use sign in with
Google and we're going to path it pass
it our auth object and before arguments
this time are going to be sign in with
Google
user loading and error
awesome
so a very similar structure as before
and now all we need to do is add an on
click event handler to our button and
that will be it I'm going to add the is
loading property to our button and then
I'm going to add that on click
and we're going to give it a callback
function and all this is going to do is
call sign in with Google that is it
let's also actually quickly add some
text from Chakra that is going to
display that error if it exists we will
say error and error if it exists
awesome so what is going to happen when
we click on this button let's find out
so if I click sign in with Google this
pop-up is going to pop up
and we get some error what is going on
here I think the reason that this failed
is because we hadn't we have not yet
implemented Google authentication in our
app and this is something I always
forget to do if we come over to sign in
method we need to click on add new
provider remember we added email and
password and let's click on Google and
let's click enable
and
I'm just going to select the email
address that I have that I am currently
logged in as we can ignore the stuff
down here this is for reusing an
existing client ID from an already
existing Google project and we will
click on Save
perfect okay so now Google is
successfully enabled in our project we
should be able to refresh our app and
try again but actually let's fix this
first this is a react error and
basically what's happening is error is
an object and we cannot render an object
in the Dom we need to render only text
so I'm going to just do error Dot
message
so let's try this again let's refresh
all right
um what is this
um I honestly don't know what's going on
here at render element
hmm he's gonna have to do this error
let's do localhost 3000
okay I'm gonna just try re-compiling the
development server sometimes I'm not
sure why there's Sometimes some errors
with like hot reloading and um just
simply re-compiling the server can fix
it and that seemed to do it also this
error right here you might see in here
is saying that there's a duplicate atom
key auth modal State
um this also has to do with the hot
reloading it says that um if it is it is
safe to ignore this if it occurred
because of a hot module of replacement
and that is why it's occurring in this
case basically it just thinks that
there's uh two of the same atoms but
there is not so just kind of ignore this
for now so we can probably re-enable
this
and let's go to sign up click sign in
with Google
this should pop up over here and if your
Gmail account isn't showing up by
default there like mine is just click on
the use another account and it might ask
you to enter your email and password and
authenticate that way and I'm going to
click Shad Mary gmail.com
and we should be authenticated now again
we're going to do some stuff on the UI
that's going to handle the successful
case but let's go look at our
authentication users and you can see
that I am in there and it says that I
have used the Google provider so that's
pretty cool and this is it this is it
guys for this entire file a lot buttons
this is how easy it is to sign in with
Google and if you want to add more
providers and more buttons like apple
Facebook whatever you want you know how
to do it now with a single line of code
so pretty cool if you ask me and the
nice thing about continuing with Google
or any oauth provider is that it handles
both the case of a new user and a
returning user with authenticating with
email and password we have to handle the
signing up case as well as the logging
in case so now let's go Implement our
login method so that users who did sign
up with email and password can log in
with those credentials the login logic
is going to be very very similar to the
sign up logic we're going to have this
on submit function and we're going to
bring in that use sign in with email and
password I'm going to copy this over
bring it into our app
the only thing that's going to be
different here is we're going to pass it
the email and password in the login form
so let's go to the top and grab those
two imports from react
Firebase hooks slash auth we're going to
grab sign in with email and password and
we're also going to grab
our Firebase auth instance from
Firebase Client app
grab off and that will be happy there
again same thing with the four arguments
except this time we have sign in with
email and password so inside of our on
submit function we're going to take in
the exact same event as we had in our
sign up form and I'm just going to go
copy and paste that over the react form
event I'm going to grab this entire
thing right here
bring it into login
inside of this function I'm going to
call event dot prevent default to
prevent that refresh of page on
submittal and all we're going to do
inside of this function is call sign in
within our password and pass it the
login form whoops the login form
dot email and login form dot password
and this function is going to go check
if a user with that email exists and if
the password is correct and in our login
form we actually do not need to create
another error State variable like we did
in sign up and sign up we had to check
to make sure that the password is
matched and in this case we do not need
to do that and our HTML input element is
going to verify that the email is valid
so we do not need our own custom errors
here the only error that could exist in
the login form is going to come from
Firebase so we're just going to be okay
with using a single error object here
all right and let's go down and add the
error text that could possibly occur I'm
going to open up our app here so it's
going to appear over here very similarly
to sign up just about the button here so
we're going to have some text so inside
of our text we're going to access that
Firebase errors object and I'm just
going to automatically import it here
and inside of here we're going to need
to index it the exact same way we did in
sign up using that complicated
typescript indexing stuff so we're going
to say error Dot message
as key of type of
Firebase errors that should compile
nicely and actually I can't remember if
I added the login errors to this object
let's go look I think I might have but
then I deleted it yeah okay so I think I
added these
um at some point during sign up but then
I removed them because I wanted to wait
until I got to this point of the
tutorial I I can't remember if
if I showed you that I put these in here
these are coming from my existing
repository you can grab them off of
GitHub so Firebase has two types of
Errors for logging in the first one is
if the user is not found meaning that a
user with an email does not exist and
the second one is if the wrong password
has been entered for an existing email
you're technically not supposed to tell
the user which one it is because it
could be a malicious user you're
supposed to be kind of vague
um what I did here was for both of those
types of Errors we're going to just show
the same error invalid email or password
so that we can cancel that off and we
can test this out by trying to log in
with an unexisting email so for example
I know that the email Doug at doug.com
is not a user so if I enter a password
and I try to submit I do get an error
invalid email or password I do need to
style it here quickly so I'm just going
to do the text align
is equal to Center and the color is
going to be red
perfect and font size is going to be 10
10 points 10 point yeah just like that
perfect and also uh before I forget I'm
just going to add the is a loading state
to our button because I noticed it
didn't
um it didn't work there we did get the
correct error there though which is
perfect let's try logging in with Shady
shady.com now we're going to get the
other error because I'm going to enter
the wrong password the password for this
is Shady I'm going to enter giant string
we should get the same error so now we
know both errors are working let me try
if I log in as
Shady but I put the correct password
what happens cool we didn't get an error
we haven't done these stuff to handle
what happens when you successfully
logged in yet but we now know that error
handling is working and now it looks
like we can actually log in to existing
accounts so this is perfect we can
create users with email and password we
can log those users in and we can also
log in with Google so we've covered all
of these sign in sign up methods of
Firebase authentication and now we just
need to actually do something useful
with that user once they have logged in
to tell them that they have logged in so
let's handle that next all right you
guys so now that we are able to
successfully log users in let's look at
how we can actually obtain the logged in
user and do something useful with it so
if we go take a look at those
authentication hooks from react Firebase
hooks we can see that the very first one
is called use auth State and this is
actually how we're going to obtain the
currently logged in user and so this
hook looks like this it's implemented
like it is here and it returns three
arguments the user loading and error so
it's initialized as null and once a user
is authenticated we will then actually
have access to it through this same
object here so let's go take a look at
how that's going to work when we log in
first thing we're going to need to do is
close the modal right because once you
log in you're kind of done with the
modal so let's go look at how we're
going to do that what we're going to do
is inside of the file auth model we're
going to call that hook use odd state so
I'm going to write it like this use auth
State and I'm going to import it from
react Firebase Hooks and we are going to
need to pass it our auth instance again
from Firebase client tab so import both
of those things and then we're going to
grab those three arguments so the user
loading and error
perfect so again this is going to be
null initially and this will be true
because it's going to go check if there
isn't currently authenticated user uh
and then once this is done loading we're
either going to have a user or not
depending on if they're authenticated so
how are we going to actually close the
model if there is a valid user well what
we can do is we can bring in the use
effect hook which is a hook that runs
when the component mounts as well as
when any of the dependencies change and
we can add a dependency
of user and so basically what's going to
happen is this code is going to trigger
every single time the user object
changes and what we want to do if the
user changes from null to a valid user
if you look up here we have a function
that closes the modal so if the user
object is not null we can just simply
call that function
and now Watch What Happens the model
just closed once they refresh because
there is a valid user because I logged
in already you need to wait we're going
to need a way to sign out
um but yeah this is essentially how we
can actually close the modal
and let's actually just add a console
log of what the user actually looks like
so we can see
ourselves you can see that it's being
logged in the console it is a valid user
it has the email
shady.com and all this other data that's
not really relevant so even though we
have a user that is logged in we are
still showing the login and sign up
buttons it'd probably be more useful to
show something else because on Reddit
that's when all those icons appear and
that's when you actually have the option
to log out so let's go to the parent of
those buttons so what is rendering auth
buttons I believe it is write content
okay so inside of here you're basically
going to check if there is a user and if
there is a user so we're going to add a
ternary operator here we're going to say
if there is a user
we're going to show some component
that says there is a user
um and if there's not we're going to
want to show the authentication buttons
right because you need to because the
user does not exist so where is this
user going to come from
well what I'm going to do is I'm going
to go to our nav bar and I'm going to
again use that use odd State hook
because we can use it wherever we want
it's a hook that we have access to
throughout our entire application so we
can get access to our currently logged
in user wherever we want right so that's
what makes this hook so useful if you
want to say use auth State again we're
going to need to import those two things
uh I'll use auth State and or auth
object grab the user loading
and error
now we're going to pass our user to
multiple components that's why I'm using
it in the nav bar because I'm going to
pass it to our search input and our
right content you could technically call
this Hook from both with inside of
search input and with inside of the
right content but since we're going to
pass it to both I feel like it's better
to just call the hook once and then pass
it as a prop to these two things so
we're going to pass our user to the
right content component so let's add it
as a prop user is equal to user and
we're going to see this red underline
here and that is because we need to go
into our write content component and
actually Define an interface for our
prompt and that is a typescript thing so
that's where we're actually going to use
this I don't know if you remember I said
we're eventually going to take in a user
so if I if I comment that back in what I
need to do now is because this component
is a functional component that takes
input of type right content props how
I'm going to actually get that value
into my component is if I open it up
here and say user and basically just
destructuring the props I could also
write it like this if I wanted to and
then I would just access props
dot user but I prefer to write it in a
destructured method I think it's just a
bit cleaner okay so let's save this
let's go back to here and we'll notice
that that redundant line is gone because
because typescript knows this component
is expecting a prop called user so we
can save this and check that out we now
know that there is a user because we
pass it in and we added that term every
operator uh we're going to make we're
going to make this its own component
eventually but right now let's just add
a button that will log the user out just
so we can test this functionality that
I'm talking about so let's just add
let's just make this a button from
Chakra and it's going to say log out
and on click I'm going to call
the sign out method
from Firebase and if you go to your Auto
Imports you're going to import this from
Firebase slash auth and this is how easy
it's going to be to sign out why is this
oh I think we also need to pass in our
auth object to this thing from Client
app
okay now we have a button that's going
to hopefully log us out so let's click
on that and you'll see that that is
going to sign us out it's going to clear
that auth state so that when so that now
user is going to be null if I sign back
in
as uh Shady shady.com
with the password Shetty and again the
model closes and we can see that it is
detecting that user and we're going to
change this logout button to an actual
like drop down menu if you go to
reddit.com you'll see that it's your
logged in there's a drop down menu and
that's what we're going to add shortly
and we're going to be able to log out by
actually adding the logout option there
we go that is uh that is literally how
we access the user we're going to use
this hook a lot because we're going to
need access to our user in a lot of
places and this hook makes that super
easy and what's nice about this use auth
Hook is that it persists the user login
on refresh as well as if the user were
to come back to your website in a few
days if I refresh the page here for
example
we can see that initially for a brief
second there it uh there was a null user
and you can see that in the logs here so
state is initially null but then it goes
and context the Firebase servers and it
finds that oh there actually is someone
authenticated so we will be logged into
our application automatically all right
so the only part of the authentication
flow that we have left to cover is
resetting of the password and what
that's going to look like is this so I
just spun up the localhost on my
completed project and just to show you
what it's going to look like and what
I've actually decided to do for this
section of the tutorial is just make the
minor architectural changes to our model
to actually show this component and then
I'm just going to paste in my already
written reset password component and I
will explain the critical parts of it
pretty much the exact same thing as what
we've already seen so I just didn't
think it was worth covering the entire
thing and then what you can do is just
grab the code for this component off of
my GitHub and paste it into your
component all right so we're just going
to quickly add some text beneath this
login button that allows you user to go
to the reset password form if they did
forget their password so I'm just going
to again grab that from my other repo
and paste it into our login component
and I will explain everything it's just
very very similar to what we've already
seen paste that in there it's a very
small section we added to login and
basically this is just some text beneath
the login button there and on click
we're going to do same thing that we're
doing here except with the reset
password view so I'll paste that in
there and I'm going to make this reset
password and thanks to typescript we did
autocomplete perfect okay so now let's
go to our modal because we need to make
some changes to this logic in here and
actually render our reset password
component all right so what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to come up here and
write some JavaScript that's going to
allow us to conditionally display these
form components and what that's going to
look like is it's going to say
modelstate.view
is if this is equal to login or the
motostate.view
is equal to sign up let's show something
and if none of those are true then let's
show something else and that's something
else is going to be this reset password
like right because our model only has
three views if we're not logging in or
signing up we are going to be resetting
our password
and I'm going to move all of this up
here and then I think I just need to
wrap this in a fragment because we
because it needs a parent component of
some kind and we have not yet created
reset password so let's go and do that
inside of our auth folder I'm going to
create that component reset
password
all right and this is where I'm going to
paste in my already written component
from my completed project and explain
the important parts a lot of it is just
styling a UI component so I just didn't
think it was worth the time to do that
hey guys I am just editing this part of
the video and I noticed that I did not
mention to install react icons as you
see online for there this is the main
package we're going to be using for
icons so just install this with the
command here and this should work
smoothly and let's make sure we can
actually successfully see this so I'm
going to click on my Auto Import and add
that import click save and if I just go
to my UI reset password we do see that
form in there now so the most important
part is right here we're using that use
send password reset email Hook from
react Firebase Hooks and we're again
passing it that auth object that we
created and then we're just calling that
function when we actually click on that
reset password button and we're just
passing it the email that the user
enters and this is going to actually
send an email to that email and once
that successfully sends it's going to
set success to be true and the success
State variable basically just is
something that so that on the UI we can
say oh go and like the email was
successfully sent go and check your
email and in order to demo this I do
need access to an email that is real and
that I actually have access to and I'm
signed in so in order to do that I'm
just going to go and delete my shadmare
hey gmail.com because I authenticated
with Google there and in order to show
this password resetting process I need
to create an account with my Shad Mary
email by using email and password
authentication not a lot shout out is
not a real email all right so now that
there is no account with Chad Mary
gmail.com I'm going to go and create one
with email and password authentication
and make the password chatty
and I'm going to create that account now
I'm going to log out and then I'm going
to try to log in but oh I already forgot
my password so I better reset it so I
click reset and if I enter Shadowmere
gmail.com click reset password this is
its functionality so it's going to say
check your email I'm going to go to my
email and I'm just going to show you how
this works so that if you get this going
on your app you know how it should
option and this is what the email
actually looks like zoom in a bit it
sends me a link from our Firebase app if
I click on this link
it brings me into a form and it's saying
reset your password so if I reset my
password to say Shady Mary my full name
I click enter it says password change
and Firebase handles all the heavy
lifting of changing your password and
now if you go back to the app I should
be able to log in with that new password
so I'm going to try logging in with my
old password to show you that it's
already updated Shady did not work but
if I use my new password chatty Mary it
works
so my password has been reset I'm going
to leave it there for password resetting
again it's super similar to the other
processes in terms of using the hooks
and building up the UI component and I
really do want to and I'm sure you do
too want to move on to more interesting
things all right everybody now that we
have completed our authentication
workflow and we are able to access the
currently logged in user let's make
those changes to our navbar to reflect
what it's supposed to look like when a
user is actually logged in which is how
it looks right here in the completed
project here so if I log out this is
sort of what we currently have and then
when we log in
we will make it up here as this so we're
going to have this drop down menu we're
going to have these icons and then this
other dropping menu over here which is
pretty much identical to Reddit so let's
get going on that
all right so if we recall
inside of the nav bar we're already
grabbing that user and so now we can
conditionally display things if that
user exists so let's start off with
write content so write content just as a
reminder represents sort of all this
stuff over here as well as those
authentication buttons log in and sign
up so if I go into write content
we are going to replace this logout
button with a component called icons
which is going to be the parent of all
of those icons and then down here we're
going to have that menu which we're
going to bring in from Chakra it's going
to be a drop down menu just like we saw
over here
okay so let's get going on those icons
it's pretty straightforward we're going
to just import a bunch of icons from
react icons also one last thing the type
of this I just want to change to user
which is the actual proper type and we
can import that from Firebase auth and
that way we will get autocomplete
intellisense when we're trying to access
our user and you'll notice that we now
have some compiler issue with typescript
because this is saying that it says that
type user null undefined is not
assignable to type user so we indicated
that we're passing a user in here
because we said that here but it's
saying that this could be undefined and
it also could be null and so this type
of user null undefined is not assignable
to the type we gave it so we basically
just need to go adjust for that and the
way to do that in typescript is for
undefined we can just make it optional
with a question mark and for null we can
use the pipe operator to say this is
either going to be a user or null so
this whole thing says user
or null or undefined indicated by its
optional and now this thing is happy
okay so let's go into our write content
directory and create our icons component
icons dot TSX use our snippet and what
I'm going to do is paste in all of the
icon Imports because there's about six
of them I think these are all the icons
that we're going to put in there these
are all from react icons so we are not
going to take in any props to this
component so we can remove these
and inside of here we're going to
basically just return a giant Flex box
and this flexbox is going to have two
children the first one is going to be
another flexbox and then the second one
is going to be a react fragment I'm
going to explain why we're using a flex
here and just a fragment here in just a
second so now that we actually have
icons here which I'm just going to put
some icons text so we can see it let's
go to our right content and change the
logic here so we're going to replace
this logout button with our new icons
component
import that and so basically this is
just saying that if a user is logged in
show those icons and if they are not
show the login and sign up button
perfect so let's go into icons and
actually start building that out so the
reason I am using a flexbox here and
just a fragment here is because if you
look at our demo which is based off the
real Reddit you can see that the left
container of icons
right here disappear uh or are not
visible on Mobile screen sizes they
don't appear until medium screen sizes
and so basically we need a flex box here
or we need some sort of component to be
able to toggle that display whereas
these ones are always visible so it
doesn't really matter so that's why we
need to have a flexbox here and the way
to do that is by just adding a media
query on the display and that big screen
sensor is going to make it none and then
at medium screen sizes we're just going
to make the display Flex which is going
to make it visible
so let's actually start building out
these icons and this is going to have
some other properties as well we're
going to make a line to be Center and
we're going to make the border right to
be one pixel solid and the Border color
is going to be Gray 200. all right so
each icon individually is going to be
its own Flex box with the icon component
from Chakra inside of it and the way
we're going to use these icons from
react icons is by passing in a prop as
to our chakra icon component and inside
of as we're going to give it one of
these icons so this first one is going
to be our BS Arrow
I don't know why I'm not getting
autocomplete Circle and each of these
icons is going to have a margin right
1.5 a margin left of 1.5 a padding of
one
a cursor
equal to pointer because they are
clickable in order radius of 4 and then
when we hover them we're going to add
some hover styling and we're going to
make the background Gray 200. and this
is what that hover effect looks like the
reason we applied this Flex container to
our icon is so that we can apply this
hover effect as well as the Border
radius and the display Flex ensures that
it is centered in the container perfect
so once we've done one icon we can do
them all they're all very very pretty
much the same so we can just take this
and duplicate it we'll start with the
three left ones and this one is going to
be our i o filter Circle icon which is
supposed to represent like creating a
poll on Reddit and then this third one
is going to be our uh video cam IO video
cam outline and now one downside to
react icons is they don't have
standardized sizes they're not all the
same size so sometimes you have to play
around with the font sizes to make them
appear the same so uh for this first one
we're going to give it a font size
of 20 and these other two we're going to
give a font size of 22.
22 and the way to add multiple cursors
is to basically just do
um option click you can add as many as
you want and type in multiple places
which is super cool and now we can work
on the right side icons
so similar thing these are always going
to be visible which is why again they're
just in a fragment and I'm going to grab
one of these
paste it in there
and this first one is going to be our
chat
icon our chat dots and we are going to
duplicate this again three times or
twice I guess and then the second one is
going to be our notifications
notifications and the third one is going
to be add icon grad for like creating a
post perfect and we're going to make the
font size of these last three to be 20
just because they do appear a bit larger
and the way to select duplicate
instances of something in this case a
repeated 20 is to do um you highlight
the first one and then you press command
B and that'll highlight all of the next
occurrences of that thing I have a I
have a video on my top five vs code
shortcuts do check that out I think
everything I've mentioned so far is in
that video so
um yeah maybe you go stop and watch that
by now and that'll help you with this
project and uh just to show you the
responsiveness in Mobile screen sizes
those left icons are not visible also
we're going to make this plus icon not
visible at small screen sizes as well so
we're going to again add the media query
on our display and we're going to say
base none and then add medium between
sizes we won't make it Flex so that's
only the chat and the notification one
are visible in Mobile which is the same
as Reddit awesome so we are completely
done with icons now we can close this we
are not going to look at them again and
we can start working on that little
directory menu in the top right corner
here
all right so let's create our new menu
component so inside I've read content
I'm going to create a component called
usermenu.tsx and I'm going to use our
snippet
and what I'm going to do is come over to
the chakra docs if you just search for
chakra menu and you come to this page
here
we're basically just going to grab the
code for this component here and modify
it to look how we need it to look so I'm
going to grab this and that's what we're
going to return inside of our component
here
and then we can just automatically
import everything command period add all
missing Imports perfect so basically the
menu button represents the actual thing
that you see that is going to trigger
the menu opening and then there is a
menu item for each thing that you see
inside of the menu okay so let's make
some modifications to make it look like
this our menu button is going to have
that little Reddit icon with the Chevron
down thing and then when we're logged
out it's going to appear as just that
regular sort of Avatar icon and that's
the same behavior as Reddit they have
this Reddit icon with the Chevron and
then if you log out they have just this
Avatar looking thing and I tried to find
Icons that were most similar to the real
Reddit but of course sometimes you can't
find the exact ones you have to sort of
just use something that's similar okay
so let's actually implement this let's
go comment this in and import that and
actually named it user menu
and let's go to our app and we can see
that we have this drop-in menu now so
let's come back and make those
modifications so since our menu button
does change depending if a user is
logged in let's go actually pass our
user to our user menu so that we can
make those um adjustments when we do
need to make them so we're going to say
user is equal to user and then we're
just going to forward that as a prop
to our component and we can do the exact
same thing as we did before with making
it null undefined for user okay so now
we have access to the user and we can do
some conditional rendering so I'm going
to grab the user from our props and I'm
going to remove this actions text and
replace it with a ternary operator
that's going to say if there is a user
meaning we are logged in show something
and if there is not a user show with
something else and that's something else
for right now this is going to be a div
that says no user and if we are logged
in
let's show user
perfect so we are currently logged in so
we can see that it says user so we can
remove this as button thing we can also
remove this right icon
let's work on now what this did is going
to be if we do have a user so if a user
exists we're going to add a fragment
here and then we're going to have an
icon
and I'm just going to paste in all of
the icons that we're going to use here
which are just going to be three
different icons
and then this icon is going to be
the fa Reddit Square
and then let's make some minor CSS
adjustments to it we'll say font size is
going to be 24.
we're given a margin right of one and
then we're going to write the color gray
300 and we're actually going to wrap
this fragment in a flex box there's
going to be two Flex boxes actually but
for now we'll just use one and then I
just need to import that from Shopper UI
awesome and that just centers the icon
without the flexbox you'll notice that
the icon kind of is not centered there
so that is why we have a flexbox there
and then we can also add that this is
where we can move that Chevron down icon
in there and we're also going to add
another Flex box so there's going to be
two
which might seem a bit unclear right now
but it will make sense in a bit as we
build this up and then we're going to
make both of the Align on these
to be Center
just like that and that centered that
Chevron there cool so now this opens up
the menu we just need to style it a bit
now let's come up to our menu button and
add just a few Styles we're going to
make the cursor pointer our padding is
going to be
your pixel is six pixels and then our
border radius is going to be four four
is going to be sort of our standard
order it is for everything in our app
and we're going to give it hover State
styling of an outline of one pixel solid
and our outline color is going to be
Gray 200.
awesome and that looks like this
nice which is very very much the same as
Reddit awesome so let's come back here
and let's just quickly replace this
because it's going to be super easy
we're going to have an icon and that
icon is going to be vs C account that's
one of the icons we imported from react
icons and this one have a font size of
24 color
of grade 400 and a margin right of one
now let's actually build out the proper
menu items here so right now we have as
a bunch of random ones that would come
with the default component so let's just
get rid of all of these keep one of them
and then inside of our first one this is
what we're going to have so our menu
items are going to look like this we're
going to have a flex box and then inside
of the flexbox there's we're going to
have an icon and this first one is going
to be an icon called CG profile
and I guess I did not import that and
that is coming from react icons it's c g
so let's go quickly do that
c g profile here
awesome
and then we're going to have the text
profile
perfect so let's go back to our app and
see what that looks like
okay so that is there but it looks kind
of terrible so let's fix that up okay so
the Align on this is going to be Center
and then our icon is going to have a
font size of 20 and a margin right of
two
perfect that's looking a bit better and
then let's come up to our menu item make
our font size equal to 10 point
our font weight
equal to 700
and our hover state is going to be have
a background of blue
and the text color is going to be white
so this is what that looks like let me
hover over it it has that blue and it
makes the icon and the text white
perfect now our second one is going to
be pretty much the exact same thing we
can copy this paste it down here except
this is going to be actually log out say
log out and we just need to import one
more icon from react icon so I've got to
import these last two it's going to be
react icons
slash MD and it's going to be MD outline
login
perfect now let's go change it there MD
outline login
and that looks like this and you'll
notice on Reddit
that they have this divider I don't know
if you can see it there it's a very
subtle Gray Line Between all of these
and the logout one so let's quickly add
that chakra makes that super easy with
their component menu divider make sure
that's imported and now we have that
nice divider there okay and all we need
to do now is add our Firebase logout
function to our logout menu item the
exact same way we're doing it before
with that logo button so we can just add
an unclick to that menu item and this on
click is going to call our sign out
method from Firebase auth make sure it
Imports and then we're going to pass
this our auth object from Client app
so now if I actually click on this thing
I should be able to log out and we'll
see the display has changed there and
then if I log back in as
chattahoo we can see that the navbar
updates and we are now signed in and I
think we have to make some minor changes
to our flexbox up here I think I might
have done something wrong
um so we just need to move these Flex
containers outside of our ternary
operator so this might be kind of weird
to change I'm going to move these
outside like this
move these two up top
and we can move this icon out here
between those two flexbox containers my
apology for that that is kind of
confusing to restructure but basically
we just have to move the two Flex boxes
outside so that this was centered and we
get that Chevron there and then we can
log in
and then it appears the same way we have
the Chevron icon in both the logged in
and logged out state so something else
we have to do in here is the contents of
the menu changes when we are logged out
when we're logged out we should just
only see the option to sign in if you go
to our demo if I log out
we just have this thing log in and sign
up and on Reddit they have a menu with a
bunch of more options but these are
features we're not going to build so
we're just going to have the login sign
up thing which is just going to open the
model so it's going to be very very easy
to add so let's go back to our app so
basically our menu list content is just
going to change depending on if there is
a user so right inside of our menu list
we can add another Turner operator
that's going to check for the existence
of the user and then our first thing we
can have is a fragment our second thing
can be a fragment as well our first
fragment if there is a user is going to
be everything we've already written all
these menu items up here
just like that and if we're logged out
we just need to show a menu item that
prompts the user to log in
we want this to say login slash sign up
just like that and so then we just need
to make this actually open that login
signup model the way to do that is we
can import our recall State Setter
function on set auth modal state is
equal to use it's set recoil State pass
our auth model State atom come down here
and do what we've already done a few
times now on this menu item we do not
want to sign out we want to add it on
click
that is going to call that set off modal
State and the state we want to set it to
is going to be open
true and our view is going to be log in
by default so now if they actually click
on this login signup thing it opens the
model which is exactly what happens on
reddit.com and we can sign in directly
from here
and that seems to be working completely
fine and also you'll notice on larger
screen sizes that this text appears with
our username and the karma so let's
quickly add that all right so for that
Karma text I'm just going to paste it in
here from my other repo because it's
only about 10 lines and then I can just
explain what's going on so I'll paste it
right here beneath our Reddit icon and
what that looks like is like this you
can see that my name is there as well as
the user Karma and that little orange
icon thing so basically this is just a
flexbox with some additional styling
applied to it the most important part is
here and the reason we have both of
these is because if a user authenticates
with Google they will have a property on
their user object called display name
which is coming from their Google
account and then if they authenticate
with email and password they will only
have an email they will not have a
display name so basically this just
checks for the existence of the display
name and if it does not exist it will
show this so what's happening here is
that when we split a string at a certain
character it's going to give us an array
and by accessing the first index of that
array we're taking all of the text to
the left of the at sign in the email
which in my case is shad merhi and so
one of these two things are acting as
the user's username and you'll also
notice down here that I have hard-coded
the karma of the user and I'm going to
show you in a bit how to add custom
properties to this user object and that
is what's going to lead us into our
discussion of cloud functions because
right now with Firebase we cannot add
additional properties and this is
something that is written in the
Firebase docs they do not allow you to
modify this particular object if you
want to add custom properties things
like Karma or username or anything that
is not on this base user object we do
need to store it in another database
table and then we can make those
modifications but we will see more of
this when we get into Cloud functions
and it'll make a lot more sense then
alright so we are now completely done
with this user drop down menu component
it is fully functional for both logged
in and logged out users and we can now
work on this community drop down menu
and start to get into more of the
community-based logic of the app all
right you guys we are so close to being
done at this nav bar all we have to do
is add this community drop down menu and
make it a little bit responsive and it's
going to be extremely similar to our
user menu that we've already created so
let's go ahead and do that all right so
I'm actually just going to copy
everything from inside of this file user
menu and then I'm going to come to my
directory and inside of my nav bar I'm
going to create a new directory called
directory because we're going to have a
few child components inside of here and
inside of here I'm going to make a new
file called directory which is going to
be sort of the root of the directory I
feel like I said directory about eight
times now directory.tsx
use our snippet actually we don't even
need the snippet I'm just going to paste
in everything that we have and then I
will save that and the parent of this
directory was navbar we defined it here
before but we just never used it and now
I'm actually going to import it from
that directory import directory from
directory I called it directory because
it's kind of a community directory a
sort of the naming behind it you can see
that in our app we have this icon thing
and then there is a drop-in menu but it
does not look like we need it to look
like ours it needs to look like this
with the icon as well as the different
content okay so let's come back to here
and let's get working on that so inside
of directory we can get rid of all of
the user-based stuff because we're not
even going to show this component at all
unless a user is logged in we're going
to get rid of all of this this entire
ternary operator let's get rid of that
so that we have an empty menu list
perfect and then also can get rid of
this user ternary operator as well
so now we just have the foundations laid
out for our component
just so we don't have to write it
completely from scratch and we're not
going to need this and we are actually
not going to take in any proxy here
there is no conditional rendering at all
no problems
and then we can clean up all the Imports
because there is a ton of not used stuff
in here so we can just use that organize
Imports command from vs code reminder if
you forgot how to do that command shift
p and then search for organize Imports
and you can do that
perfect so now we have this very simple
drop down that is empty so let's work on
our menu button and we basically just
have these two Flex boxes to Center
everything that we're going to put
inside of here and make it all look nice
and aligned so I'm just going to quickly
import this home icon into here and I'm
going to be from react icons it's going
to be from react icons slash TI
and this is going to be the ti Home and
these subdirectories in case you're
wondering I can't remember if I
explained this if you go to react
icons.com and if you just go into the
documentation here
um basically if you search for anything
like home they have a huge library of
icons and whenever you click on one
let's say you like this one the first
two letters are r i and that would mean
that it would come from the subdirectory
r i uh in case you were wondering I
can't remember if I explained that I
apologize if I did not all right so
inside of this inner Flex box you want
to add that icon
all right so we're going to say icon as
TI home
and then underneath that we're going to
add some text
oh it's actually an import from Chakra
and we are going to put home here for
now and when we actually start getting
into the creation of communities we will
toggle this to show the current
community that we're on but in order to
do that we need to know which Community
pager on and we have not yet created
Community Pages yet so for now we're
just going to hard code home and this
icon we're going to add a font size of
24 and a margin right at Mobile screen
sizes it's going to be one and at medium
screen sizes it's going to be two and
this is the kind of just finicky stuff
that really really makes the design
replicate Reddit and make everything fit
in there nicely and this text also needs
a media query on it because you'll
notice that on certain screen sizes it
is not displayed because there is just
no room for it so what we need to do to
solve that is to create another flexbox
and then actually put the text inside of
there and add a midi query on it similar
to what we've done already we're going
to make at base screen sizes it's going
to be none and at large screen sizes
it's going to be flex and let's make the
font weight of this
600 and you'll notice here that if I'm
hovering over this button there is not
any space between it and the search bar
so what we need to do is just add some
additional margin to that menu button so
what that's going to look like is the
left one or the right one is always just
going to be two then on the left we're
going to also change this with screen
size and we're going to make it at base
screen sizes it's going to be 0 and the
medium screen size is it's going to be
two and these media queries just help it
look really good on all screen sizes to
make sure that not everything is
squished I'm just going to make the font
size of this
to be equal to 10 point
and that shrinks it down there nicely
and that looks good and then we also
just need to adjust the width of this
container because you'll notice that in
this demo it gets larger so in order to
achieve that we need to come into this
outer Flex box here and say justify is
going to be equal to space between
that's going to make sure there is the
maximum amount of space between every
child of this component and the two
children in our case are this flexbox as
well as this Chevron down icon so it's
going to maximize the space between
these two things here and then to add
that responsive width I'm just going to
add a media query on the width at Bay
screen sizes it's going to be Auto so
it's just going to take up as much space
as it needs and then on the large screen
sizes we're going to cap this at 200
pixels and this is what that looks like
so you can see it grows and it looks
great on all screen sizes if you go on
reddit.com and you play around with the
responsive myths it's the same thing all
right and the most exciting part of this
entire Dropout menu is what's inside of
the menu list and the menu list is going
to be the communities component and this
is where we're going to start to get
into the very very exciting Reddit
functionality where we can actually
create communities and join communities
and that logic is going to happen inside
of here and that is coming up very very
shortly so for now I'll leave a blank
component and I'll just put the text
communities in there so we can get
excited about communities one last thing
to make the behavior of the snapbar
pretty much exactly the same as Reddit
is to just modify the width of the
search bar if a user is logged in you'll
notice if I go to the demo the width of
the search bar just sort of takes up all
of the space that it can that is
available for it and if I log out it is
capped at a certain size you'll see that
it stops growing and it's very simple to
do it similarly I think a few lines so
all we need to do is come over to our
nav bar and just pass the user to our
search input exactly like we're doing
below
come to our search input
and I mentioned that we're going to take
in a user here long long ago so let's
actually take that in now it is going to
be a type user wrap it from our props
through destructuring all we're going to
do in here is add a single line to this
flexbox a Max width property and we are
going to say if there is a user
the max width is Auto and if there is
not the user cap the width at 600 pixels
so we're getting an error here it's user
that is not defined and that's because
we just need to add that same type to
our prop type and that should solve that
never mind it does not at all oh a user
uh let's just passed in the user object
user was not defined and we only want to
show this directory if the user is
logged in okay so if I log out we can
see that the directory is not even
displayed you'll notice that if we start
playing around with the responsiveness
when we're not logged in it gets really
really janky so we just need to add a
few properties to these Flex containers
here on this outer one I'm just going to
add Justified content or Justify for
short on medium screen sizes we want
this to be space between and that is
going to make an even amount of space
between all of its child components and
then on this one here on this inner
content we want the width to be
responsive as well we're going to give
it a 4 40 pixels at Mobile screen sizes
and then on medium screen sizes and up
we're going to give it auto width and
then our margin right is going to have a
base margin of zero and at medium screen
sizes it's going to be 2. and now we
should see a complete responsiveness
with our navbar and we can see that that
search bar container
is capped at that width and that looks
really good all right so we are
completely done with the nav bar the
only thing that's going to change is
that we're the only thing that's going
to change is that when the only thing
that's going to change is that this icon
is going to be dynamic depending on what
community that we're in it's going to
display the actual Community icon and
we're going to do that logic using a
custom react hook that we're going to
build once we are able to create
communities so let's now create the
model to actually create communities
that we can access through this drop
down menu so if I go to the completed
project and I open this up here when we
click this we want this to pop up and
we'll actually be able to create a
community so that is our next goal let's
get going on that all right you guys
let's build this model I'm honestly just
super pumped about how this looks it
just looks so clean I love it all right
so let's go back to our app and start
building this thing so we saw that
inside of directory we already defined
where this model is going to be so let's
actually bring that back in and go and
create that component
save that and let this error out and
this component is going to go inside of
this directory directory maybe the word
directory was a confusing name I
honestly did not even think of that when
I was building it
how confusing that would be so let's
drop our snippet in here and save that
and let's come back here and import it
I'm just going to refresh here
okay so we have our component have a
good coding which doesn't really make
sense not sure who made this snippet but
it doesn't make sense whatever it's
still a useful tool so inside of here
there's going to be a bunch of stuff but
for now this is the structure that we're
going to create we're going to have a
fragment and this fragment is going to
have a component called create Community
modal so since this thing is a modal
we're going to put it along with any of
its children inside of the moral
directory and we're going to give it its
own folder called create community
inside of this create Community we're
going to create another file and this is
going to be the root of the create
Community model so we're going to call
it create community modal.tsx
inside of here we're going to use our
snippet and I'm just going to come down
here and I will put in community
Perfect all right now let's come back to
here and just import that
and we should see it in there now this
is actually going to be a menu item that
is going to open an actual model and
we're going to need a menu item from
Chakra
and the reason we're using a menu item
is because the parent of communities is
a menu itself and so that's why we're
using a menu item all right so inside of
this menu item we're going to have a
flexbox and this is where we're actually
going to put that text create community
but we have an import effects yet so
let's do that save that and also inside
of this Flex box we're going to have our
icon
and our icon is going to be the same
icon that we're using in the nav bar
here it's going to be the add icon and
that icon is coming from
react icons slash g a it's right GR
and this is the gr ad icon just like
that and then inside of here we're going
to say icon as
PR ad
awesome and what does that look like
perfect so now we're going to Center
this I'm going to say align Center that
will Center that there and we're just
going to adjust the size of this text
and this icon
so our icon font size
is going to be 20. I'm going to give a
margin right of 2.
just so there's space between there okay
and on our menu item we're going to give
us some Styles as well we're going to
give this a width of 100
a font size of 10 point and then on
Hover
we're going to give it a background of
gray 100 and we can also add the on
click
because this is the thing we're going to
click on when we're actually going to
want to open the modal so because we
need access to the open state of the
model in this component as well as
inside of the model because the model
needs to know if it's open we are going
to Define that state in this component
so we're going to say open
set open and it's going to be used State
and we're going to say false starting
off we don't want to be open initially
and then this on click is just going to
call that set open and set it equal to
true
and then we can just pass open as a prop
to the create Community modal so let's
go to create Community modal and this is
going to take a prop in that is a
Boolean
and then we can destructure that here
awesome so now I'm going to go to the
chakra documentation and grab that model
once again similar to what we did before
with the authentication modal and I'm
going to grab this one here because it
has a footer which we're going to need
if you look at the demo one we have a
footer there so I'm going to grab the
one with the footer
I'm going to grab the entire return
statement
and that is what just like that and then
I'm going to Auto Import all of this
stuff at all missing Imports
and we're not going to need this button
because the thing that opens our model
was this menu item out here so we can
get rid of that button completely
and so we passed open as a prop to this
community just a second ago so that is
what I'm going to say here I'm going to
say is open is going to be that open
Boolean there and I'm going to actually
add another prop that we're going to
take in called handle close and this
handle closed function we're going to
pass it as a proper over here handle
close and all of this function is going
to do is just going to be a callback
that calls set open and sets it equal to
false
and the type definition of this function
is just going to look like this it's
just a callback function that does not
return anything and when a function does
not return anything we can just say void
and then we're just saying that the type
of this function is an arrow function
that takes in no arguments and returns
void that's all this means and in the
future we will see some more interesting
type definitions for functions all right
and then we can accept that prop here by
destructuring it and then and then on
close we can call handle close let's get
rid of this lorem thing because all that
is is just text here is the modal body
I'm going to write
and then here we can also just call
handle close
perfect so let's go see what that looks
like
we have an error what is going on here I
don't see oh something down here
I think we're just missing that bracket
there there we go okay so let's see what
this looks like so I open up this thing
I click create community and Bam we have
our modal I can close it
nice and so now all we have to do is
just build the inside of this model and
these buttons are going to look slightly
different but for now I'm just going to
make this say create community
because it's kind of cool because that's
actually the button we're going to click
on the create the community so it's
exciting it's going to look like this
all right so now we're going to start
building out this modal this component
is going to contain a lot of interesting
things it's going to have all of the
logic necessary to create a community so
it's going to be interacting with our
firestore database and it's going to be
our first Glimpse at creating firestore
documents we're also going to get to see
database transactions and batch rights
for the first time so it's going to be
very interesting and do not worry if you
do not know what those are I will
explain them when we get to them but
before we do anything that has to do
with firestore we actually need a
component to interact with so let's
build out the UI for this model I just
want to close the directory on the left
so that we have a bit more room because
this component is a bit long and let's
start off with this header so the header
is going to say create a community
just like that and we're going to add
some styling to here so we're going to
make the display Flex the flex Direction
is going to be column we're going to
make the font size just a bit smaller
we're going to make this 15 and we're
going to give it some padding of three
just like that so underneath the header
we're going to have a box component and
a box is just a div and we don't need
flexbox here so that's why we're just
using a generic box and we're going to
put everything except the footer inside
of this box so we're basically just
giving an extra container to our model
body so that we can apply some
additional styles to it and we're going
to give a padding left of three
and a padding right of three and we had
to wrap the body inside of this extra
box just so that we can apply this
additional padding here I was playing
around with trying to do it on the body
and it was just kind of weird and so to
get it to look exactly like Reddit I
just added this additional box here and
that seemed to work great and our modal
body we're going to add some properties
as well we're going to make the display
Flex
and we're going to make the flex
Direction
column
and we're going to give it some padding
and that padding is going to be 10
pixels so top bottom 10 pixels and right
left zero pixels and I'll add a border
here just so you can have an idea of
what it is that we're looking at there
okay and inside here we're going to have
some text from Chakra X is going to be
name and this text is going to have a
font weight of 600
and a font size of 15.
and underneath this text we're going to
have another text and this text is going
to say community names
including
capitalization cannot be changed this is
just something it says on Reddit there
must be some rule they have and our font
size of this is going to be 11 and our
color is going to be
Gray 500. awesome all right underneath
this we're going to have another text
and this text that we're about to add is
this part here it's the subtle bit of
text this R forward slash inside of the
input and styling this was honestly
quite tricky I had to inspect the real
Reddit styles for a while to figure out
how they actually did this because it's
kind of weird there's just a bit more to
it than meets the eye but I ended up
figuring it out so let's proceed all
right so this text is going to be the r
forward slash let's go back to our app
so we have the R4 slash and underneath
this is where we're going to have the
actual input for the community name
and this input is going to be the actual
input that the user puts the community
name in that they're creating so let's
go create some state so that they can do
that I'm going to call it Community name
and set community name
and it's going to be initialized as an
empty string
now on our input we're going to have
that be the value so our value is going
to be that Community name variable
and we're going to use a size of small
and I'm actually going to remove that
order red because it also applies to the
input it looks really bad so let's
remove that and um
here we're going to give this a padding
left of 22 pixels and then this has to
tie into that weird R forward slash
thing which I'll explain in a second
we're going to add an on change function
here which for right now we're going to
make an empty callback function and now
let's actually position that bar to be
properly positioned inside of the input
as it appears here so this is the reason
we added this padding left to that input
there we need to use it relative and
absolute positioning so what we're going
to do is we're going to make the
position
of this input relative
and then we're going to make the
position
of this text also relative
and this allows us to basically
customize the position of this
particular component and what I mean by
that is we can specify like how many
pixels it is from the top of its parent
container in our case it's 28 pixels and
from the left it is 10 pixels and the
width of this is going to be 20 pixels
so kind of weird this is literally
exactly what Reddit is doing this is the
same method they use so blame them if
you think that this is weird and then
also the color of this is going to be
grade 400 it's a bit lighter don't need
these brackets
awesome so that's looking pretty good
all right and then underneath this input
there is a text that indicates how many
characters we have remaining so if you
want to say some number characters
remaining and that number we're going to
need another state variable I think what
is the default I forget default is 21.
it's going to say 21 characters
remaining but we need to make this
actually a dynamic value so let's go up
to the top and let's create that
character's remaining state so Char's
remaining set chars
the meaning is equal to use State and
we're going to initialize it as 21 and
while we're here actually let's create
that handle change function
that our input is going to use because
it's inside of this function that we're
going to recalculate
how many chars we have left in the name
so then we can come back down to here
and place that on our input so it's
going to say
uh not on change handle change
perfect
and inside of this handle change
function it's going to implicitly take
in an event like we saw with our other
inputs in our login and signup forms is
going to be a react.change event and the
type of element that is outputting this
event is an HTML input element okay so
we need to do a few things inside of
this function so the first thing we need
to do is actually update the community
name state by using the
event.target.value that's the current
value inside of the input that the user
has typed and then the way we're going
to recalculate how many characters we
have remaining is like this we're going
to say set charge remaining and we're
going to take the total amount they have
available which is 21 and subtract the
length of the string that they have
currently entered and that's going to be
the characters remaining also we do not
want to set community name if they are
over that limit so we can do that by
adding a check here that says if
event.target.value dot length is greater
than 21 and just return do you not want
to do any of this we we just want to
exit the function so this is a guard
against going over that limit so what
does this look like now when we type in
here hello there that's not updating
it's because uh I forgot to change this
to charge remaining
okay so now if I type in there hello
there how are you we can see that it
doesn't let us go past that limit so
we're only allowed 21 characters cool
and let's modify this to be red when
they have hit their character limit and
so the color of this is going to change
depending on the value of characters
remaining so we can check does charge
remaining
equals zero
if it does let's make the color of this
red and otherwise let's make this gray
500. so you can see it's gray and if I
hit that limit it turns red which is
perfect very very intuitive and we're
also just going to make this a tad bit
smaller so we'll make this font size
equal to 9.
just like that okay that is super clean
I love this UI so much okay now
underneath this text we're going to add
another box component and in this box
this is where we're going to have that
Community type selection list just like
this
so the first thing we're going to put in
here is going to be text and that's
going to say community type and we're
going to write the fine weight a little
heavy and the font size is going to be
15. nice and let's add some margin top
and bottom to this box container so that
there are some space between it and the
character input so let's do some margin
top of four and the margin bottom
also four so now everything's laid out
pretty good all right and now this is
where we're actually going to put that
checkbox component
and the checkbox is going to be a
component again from Chakra
that's going to be wrapped in this stack
component and what stack is is it's
basically just a flex box that is going
to automatically handle the spacing
between all of its children for us so we
can capacitate a problem called spacing
and I think the default is two and it
basically just spaces everything kind of
evenly between it like that just like
that they come in handy when you have
you know stacks of things that are space
evenly and in this case that's what we
have with our checkbox all right so
inside of our stack we're going to have
three checkbox components from Chakra so
we can just duplicate this and the first
one is going to be a public Community
type
the second one is going to be restricted
and the third one is going to be private
those are the three Community types you
can have on Reddit okay except we're
only allowed to have one of these right
you can only make one but there's a
problem we can currently select multiple
so we need to implement some logic that
will only allow us to select one of
these so the way we're going to do that
is we're going to declare another state
variable that is going to be called
Community type I'm going to call set
community type and it's going to be use
State and the default is going to be
public and these checkbox elements also
emit an event just like any other input
does and we can use that event to
actually know which Community type we
have selected so if you recall from our
login and signup forms we had it built
that on change function that basically
took in an event and it used the name of
the event Target to update State and
we're going to do pretty much the exact
same thing here with those check boxes
so I'm going to create a function called
on community
type change
and this is going to take in an event
and that the event is going to be a
react dot change event and still the
type of it is an input element because a
checkbox is just an input element that's
all it is
and inside of here we're going to we can
set community type to be the
event.target dot name but we did not add
yet names to our checkboxes so the name
of this we're going to make public
because we need these for the event to
actually know which thing was clicked on
the name of this is going to be just
restricted
and the name of this is going to be you
guessed it private and checkbox input
elements have this property called is
checked and is checked is a Boolean that
represents whether or not this thing is
checked but since this is a Boolean I
can add some logic to actually toggle
that check state so in our case we only
want this public checkbox to appear as
checked if Community type is equal to
public
and then the ones down here we only want
this one to be checked
it's a community type is restricted
and we only want this one to be checked
if the community type is private
so now only this one's checked but we
have not added the on change function to
our inputs yet so let's do that now so
we're going to say on change
we're just going to call that on
checkbox or on community type change and
I'm going to place this on both of these
other check boxes so now when I actually
select one of them that state is
toggling and we're only allowed to
select one of them perfect that's
exactly what we need all right so we
need to style this input text slightly
different so in order to do that I'm
going to create a text element
put the public text in there and we're
going to give this a font size of 10
point and a margin right of one and the
reason we have a margin right is because
we're going to put another thing of text
that explains basically what a public
Community is so a public Community has
the description anyone can view post and
comment to this community
and in order to make these two things
appear properly we need to add them in a
you need to wrap them in a flexbox
like this
import Flex from Chakra and make a line
equal to Center
now they are aligned properly but we
need to change the size of this so let's
come to this description text here and
I'm going to make the font size
eight
and the color is going to be gray 500
padding top of one awesome and that
looks really really good so we can do
the exact same thing with those other
two so I'm just going to copy this Flex
box here
paste it here you can just do
restricted and the description for a
restricted community is anyone can view
this community
but only approve users
can post same thing down here I'm going
to paste that for private changes to
private
any description for private communities
is only
approved users can view and submit to
this community
now the only thing missing from each of
these checkboxes is an icon just like
this here so we're going to quickly
impart those three icons
and those icons are going to again come
from react icons and these are those
three here so we have one coming from
the hi sub library and two of them are
coming from the BS Library okay so we're
going to need our icon component from
shortcut UI and our public one is going
to be vs fill percent fill I hate when
you don't get autocomplete and the color
is going to be gray 500 and we're going
to give it a margin write of two just
there's some space there let's copy this
icon component and come down to
restricted and our icon for restricted
is going to be BS fill I I fill fill I
and then private is going to be hi
logged close
nice all right so this is looking a
little bit weird we are seeing some
overflow and the text is a bit too long
and luckily for us chakra has multiple
model sizes and all we need to do is
just pass a prop
with a string with the size you would
like and we can just specify a large and
that widens it a bit all right awesome
and the last thing we have to do for
this modal UI is just finish up the
footer let's come down here so we're
going to give our footer a background of
Ray 100 and a border radius zero pixels
zero pixels 10 pixels 10 pixels and if
you have not seen this four input
notation before for Border radius
basically just each one of these
corresponds to a specific corner so the
first one is this then this one then
this one and then this one so it goes in
a clockwise rotation okay so this first
button is going to say cancel instead of
close we can get rid of this color
scheme thing here we're going to make
the variant of this outline
and we're going to give it a height of
30 pixels just like that and then our
create Community button is also going to
have a height of 30 pixels and we can
just get rid of this variant because by
default it's going to have that solid
fill variant and we're going to add it
on a click here which is going to be the
on click responsible for actually
calling the create Community function
when we have that created but for now we
will leave this empty and we are now
done building out the UI for this model
it's looking super super good this was a
longer component that did take a while
to build I hope all of that makes sense
and we can now get into more of the back
end logic of actually creating
communities and we're going to start
creating Community documents in our
database and in doing that we're going
to get to see database transactions and
batch writes and it's all going to be
super exciting we're going to learn a
ton about Firebase all right so the
first thing we're going to do is inside
of our create Community modal we're
going to create the function that's
actually going to be responsible for
contacting our firestore database and
actually creating the community so let's
create that now we're going to call it
handle create community
and this function is going to need to be
asynchronous because we are going to be
communicating with our database which
our asynchronous operations so just use
the async keyword there so there are a
few things we're going to do in this
function the first one we're going to do
is validate the community name I'm going
to make sure that this name is valid
that it is between 3 and 21 characters
which is a requirement of Reddit and
that the community name is not already
taken by someone else because on Reddit
Community names are unique so only one
Community with a specific name can exist
so we need to check for that the second
thing we're going to do is actually if
it is a valid Community name we will
actually create the community
document in firestore
perfect now before we can actually
communicate with our five star database
we do need to create it so let's go back
to our firestore sorry Firebase console
and all we need to do is just go to
Cloud firestore you can access it from
this giant card here or you can uh
access it from the firestore database
tab on the left here and just go into
that and all we need to do is just click
create database and this model is going
to pop up asking you if you'd like it to
be in production mode or test mode and
in production mode this just says rights
are not allowed you have to write your
own Custom Security rules for production
which we are going to do later for now
we're going to use test mode which is
basically just going to allow read
writes by anyone at any time which is
perfect for development so let's click
that and then it's going to ask you to
set a location just use whichever one
appears for you first I think it's a
region based so depending on where you
are in the world it'll give you the
optimal one so you can just click enable
now it's just going to actually create
those resources on the Google servers
all right so perfect here is our empty
database on the left we're basically
just going to have a column of all our
collection names so communities for
example is going to be a collection post
is going to be a collection comments is
going to be a collection and then when
you click on one of those things and go
inside of it it'll show you all of the
documents inside of that collection and
a document is basically just a
JavaScript object inside of a collection
at the top here there is a section
called rules and this is what we briefly
saw in that model this basically just
allows you to lock certain parts of your
application and allow only certain users
or user types to read or create certain
documents or delete certain documents
and we are going to write our security
rules later once we have posts and
comments being created by the users and
then we have indexes which is basically
not really important for now it allows
Firebase to efficiently query your data
we will add some indexes to our database
in a little bit but it's super easy it
was just a single click of a button it
will add like so nothing to really worry
about here and the usage just indicates
the activity going on in your database
in terms of read writes and deletes so
you can kind of monitor what is going on
in your database and how heavy the load
is for now we're only going to be really
concerned with data that's just a little
brief introduction to the cloud
firestore console so once we create the
community collection which when we call
this function for the very first time
that collection will be created we will
see it in here and we'll also see the
document of any community that we create
inside of my collection as well and the
way in our app we're going to access our
firestore database is going back to the
client app file that we saw earlier it's
going to be through that firestore
object right this fire this get the
firestore is basically going to give us
access to our database so we're going to
be importing this in any file that we're
trying to read write trying to do
anything with our database
okay so let's start off with this
function so since we're doing some
Community name validation we do need to
add a error state to indicate to the
user if something goes wrong so we just
need to create error and set error and
that's going to be equal to use State
and it's just going to be a error
message string that we're going to
initialize as a false and once we have
created that error let's just go quickly
add the piece of text that's actually
going to show that error if it does
happen that's just going to be
underneath this character's remaining
text we're going to add a text here with
that error actually inside of it so just
do error
and The Styling we're going to apply to
it is just going to be the font size of
nine point
and a color of red and then just some
top padding of one awesome let's go back
up here and let's come back to our app
over here so to make sure that the
actual name String is valid we need to
check that it does not contain any
special characters and then we're just
going to make sure that it is at least
three characters because we're already
validating that it's 21 characters with
our character count so we need to check
for a length of at least three so
basically we can check for special
characters inside of our string using
reject now I found this Solution on
stack Overflow for this I will link this
in the description but basically we're
going to use rejects to make sure that
nothing inside of this particular array
is going to be inside of our community
name so all we need to do is just copy
this really weird looking thing over to
our file I'm just going to change this
to a constant variable and all we need
to do to test that our name does not
contain any of those things is to just
say format DOT test and then pass in our
community name this is basically just
going to do a quick check on all those
characters and then we have to also add
or if Community name dot length is less
than three
we're going to set an error saying that
Community names
must be between 3 and 21 characters and
also we'll ADD and can only contain
letters numbers or underscores
and this really ugly looking reject
expression basically just checks for
valid string characters and also if you
do get this error we just want to return
out of this function because we do not
want to actually proceed with the
creation all right so let's come back to
our app
all right so inside of here we're
actually going to now create our
community we need to basically check
that name is not taken
and then if valid name create a
community
so the way we're going to check if a
community exists is to create what's
called a document reference this
document reference is basically just a
reference to a specific document in our
firestore database and the way to create
a document reference I'm going to say
cons Community dot ref is equal to Doc
now this doc function is coming from
Firebase firestore so make sure that's
imported and then we're going to pass it
our firestore
object that I was talking about just a
few minutes ago from our client app
that's how it's going to connect to our
actual database and now this doc
function as a second argument we need to
know which collection we're actually
looking at like a document in what
collection and so the second argument is
going to be that collection name and
that collection name right now is
communities and there's a third argument
we need to know the ID of that document
and in this case the ID is going to be
the community name
because names on Reddit are unique we
can use the name as the ID so just to
read over this one more time for clarity
so this is basically just a document
reference to the communities collection
and it's referencing the document with
the ID Community name however this is
not the document itself this is just a
reference and this is basically just how
it works in Firebase we have document
and collection references and then we
have the documents and collections
themselves and then we can use those
references to actually read and write
from those two things respectively and
this will become a lot more clear once
you start working with them a lot more
and we always just pass our firestore
object as a first argument this is
basically just a requirement by any of
the firestore functions provided to us
because they need to know which database
they're actually looking at so now we
can actually go and try to get that
document with this document reference
from our firestore database and the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
say cons community
doc this is going to be the actual
document this was just a reference to
the document this is going to be the
actual document we're going to get and
the way to do that is going to use a
function called get doc provided Again
by firestore and all we need to get this
function is a document reference so that
it knows which document to get and that
is going to be our reference just
defined above which is community.graph
perfect and we are going to see this so
much we're going to be working with this
get Doc and Doc all these functions
we're going to see a ton we're going to
be doing a ton of document references so
this is the first look at it so if it is
kind of weird do not worry it will
become very very clear and with
repetition it becomes very intuitive so
now we can check does this document
actually exist like is if we go and grab
this document is there anything there
well lucky for us Firebase has a method
on their documents called exists and
this is going to be false if it does not
exist and true if it does so they were
saying if this document does exist
meaning that this community with this
name has already been created we need to
alert the user and we're going to say
set error
sorry name is already taken try another
and actually the exaction on Reddit is
going to be the string sorry R forward
slash name Community name
is taken please or I'm not even please
they don't even say please
how could they not say please try
another and the way to do this is just
with the attempted literal the back pick
notation in JavaScript awesome and then
we can return out of this function
because we do not want to proceed after
that if we get to here line 75 we have a
valid name
we have a unique name of a community
that has not been created yet so now we
can actually create the community and
the way to do that with a single line we
can just say await set Dock and set dock
is a function provided by Firebase that
will either update the existing document
or create a new one and what we need to
pass this function is a reference to our
document so we can say community dot
graph and then we're just going to pass
a JavaScript object which is going to
represent the data inside of that actual
document like the actual content of the
document and our community documents to
start off are going to have a Creator ID
which is going to be the currently
signed in user's ID because we ourselves
are creating the document
we're going to pass a creative at
timestamp to know when this thing was
actually created we're going to have a
number of members so we know how many
members are in this community and then
we're going to have the Privacy type and
our checklist is going to indicate that
are we public private or restricted and
we could put infinitely many things
right I'm sure Reddit has a ton of stuff
stored on their community in their
database but for now this is going to
work perfectly for us so we actually do
need the Creator ID and to do that we
need our user so let's call that use off
State hook we can import it up here we
can say const user is going to be equal
to use auth state to make sure that
imports from react Firebase Hooks and
then pass it our auth object from our
client app file
awesome now we can come down here and we
can say Creator ID is going to be our
user.uid
the created at value
we're going to call the function called
server timestamp and this is basically
just going to create a timestamp of the
current time and the server timestamp is
a function that is coming from Firebase
firestore so make sure that that Imports
up top here
our number of members
is going to be initialized as one
because when this community is created
we are going to be the only member and
the Privacy type
is going to be our community type which
is coming from our checklist and get rid
of these comments and we just need a
comma here so now we have actually valid
code to create this document so let's
test this out and see what happens and
before we do that actually I'm going to
also create some loading scene up here
so that we can indicate to our user that
the creation is in a process so loading
set loading is equal to use state
and we're going to initialize it as
false when this form is submitted
meaning that they click on the create
Community button after this validation
has been done and it's going to actually
start going to talk to our firestore
database I'm going to set load loading
to be true and then when this
successfully completes I'm going to be
set loading
false and actually what I'm going to do
is wrap all of this asynchronous code in
a try catch block to improve our area
handling I'm going to create a try catch
block and the way to do that in a
shortcut is to just check the word try
and this little menu will pop up and
just click on this try catch thing and
what we're going to do is put all the
stuff that we want to try
inside of our try block and then inside
of our catch block meaning that an error
actually occurred console log of the
error so usually in my catch blocks I
like to indicate what function actually
produce the error so handle create
Community error
and then I can just log at the actual
error and under here we're going to set
error to be error
Dot message
we just need to give this a type of any
and actually what we're going to do is
up here instead of setting the error up
here what we're going to do is we're
going to throw an error and then that
error is going to be caught by our catch
block and then we will set that error
down here it's going to do basically the
exact same thing to change that is
basically just copy this string here
copy that we can get rid of this line
and just say Throw new error and this
thing just takes an argument that is a
string and that is going to be the
error.message that we received down here
so same functionality and we don't need
this return thing anymore actually
because if we throw this error it's
going to be caught by this catch block
none of this is actually going to be
executed anyway
I'm gonna get rid of these comments just
for to create a bit of room and then I'm
just going to add a comment down here
just for you guys so if you're reviewing
this code later check if Community
exists in due
okay awesome so this looks pretty good I
don't see anything wrong with this so
let's try to actually call our function
we have loading stage and everything
which is nice let's come down here and
when we actually click on that create
Community we now have a function to call
which is going to be handle create
community and let's pass our is loading
prop and let's make that our loading
State variable
perfect now let's see if this works so
let's go to our database we can see that
it is empty let's come over here and
let's actually try to create something
so I'm going to create a community
called chatty
chatty's community
let's click create community and see
what happens okay so something happened
let's go see if it's in our database so
let me refresh
and boom check that out we have it has
created a communities collection as well
as a document with the ID chattis
community and this is the data we're
storing in that document so hopefully
this gives you a visual idea of what our
database is going to look like it's
basically just Collections and then
documents so we obviously have created a
community let's go check our error
handling so let's say I try to create
this community again what's going to
happen
so check that out our error was caught
down here handle create Community error
and we displayed that to the user sorry
this community name is taken try another
how nice is that so let's create another
one uh called new new
and click create community
that should have been created I'm going
to also make it so that the error that I
on submit I'm just going to check if an
error does exist let's just set the
error to the empty to that sort of a
fresh submittal so this should have been
created so I'm going to create a new one
saying random random string
and I'm going to click create Community
awesome so let's go to our database and
we can see that these have been added to
our database and the data is actually
real time which is really cool so watch
this
do hey dude and I create it watch on the
left
it appears there that is so cool and
we're going to see how sick real-time
data is this is so useful for like chat
applications and stuff but this is cool
it's super super cool I love firestore
so now we can actually create
communities all right you guys so now
that we can successfully create
communities the next logical thing we
need to start thinking about is people
actually joining these communities
because without people inside of a
community it's not really a community so
this is going to lead into a really
interesting conversation about modeling
data with a nosql database and it's
going to hopefully provide a really
interesting learning opportunity for us
to compare how we would model this type
of data in a SQL versus nosql database
I'm going to do some comparisons here so
I just want to kind of think about like
what actually happens when a user joins
a community like from a data standpoint
because there are two things we need to
know from a community standpoint we need
to know how many users are inside of a
community and from a user standpoint we
need to know which can communities a
user is in so that I can go to my
communities right our drop down menu in
the demo does that these are all the
communities that I am in and our entire
feed and all of the posts that we see is
built off of what communities that we're
in and from a community standpoint I
need to know how many members are inside
of this community and let's think about
the relationship between a user and a
community
a user can be a part of many communities
and a community can have many users
so therefore we have what is called a
many-to-many relationship now this isn't
a course on uh database relationships
but I do want to cover this a little bit
because it's really important to
understand this before we move forward
if it's your first time using like a
nosql database really good opportunity
for learning I think so what I've done
is I have created this diagram here
which I'm just going to expand this over
a little bit
and basically this is how we would model
this type of data in a SQL environment
in order to model this type of
relationship which is many to many we
would need what's called a join table
and this is a join table here right
again a user can have many communities I
can join as many communities as I want
and a community can have infinitely many
users uh so to model the many to many we
would need a join table however in nosql
we have a lot more freedom and we can
store data completely differently pretty
much however we want this does make our
lives easier it gives us more freedom
but it also introduces complications
because you can run into scalability
issues really fast if you don't think
through how to best model your data in a
nosql database now this again this is
not like a course on like SQL versus no
SQL but I do want to sort of compare a
few methods here so I just wanted to
show this diagram to give you a visual
representation of how this relationship
would be modeled in SQL let's look at
how we might do this in a nosql database
which fires store is all right so what
I've done is I've created this temp.js
file to kind of show how this freedom in
a nosql environment allows us to develop
many solutions to the same problem and
we can model our data in many different
ways normalization is not required and
we can therefore have this nested
structure here we can have arrays of
strings we can have arrays of arrays of
arrays of strings of objects of strings
we can do like whatever we want with our
data which is really great it can
simplify our lives a lot but it does
come with some cost because if we don't
do it carefully we could run into some
major issues down the line especially
when scalability comes into play so what
I've done here is I've just sort of
created three different solutions here
that we're going to go through quickly
to sort of illustrate the thought
process when designing data with a nosql
database the number one thing that I
learned when modeling data with a nosql
database something I saw on stack
Overflow was someone said when you're
modeling data with a nosql database the
number one thing think about is how your
data is actually appearing on the screen
like when you look at a certain
component what data is in there and it
really helps you efficiently kind of
think about where to have this sort of
nested structure and where to group
things together on your document and
this is sort of something that just
takes practice and you just have to like
kind of honestly practice developing
nosql databases for different sorts of
features in order to really understand
how to develop the optimal structure now
as we go through these examples let's
keep in mind the relationship we need we
need to know how many users are in a
community and we need to know what
communities a user is in so let's look
at this example these represent a
community document and a user document
okay so what we could do is we could
store an array of all of the users that
belong to a certain Community right
every time I join a community I can add
that user's ID to this array so now we
know how many users are in a community
and these comments just kind of
represent other data that would be
stored on the community document but
let's think about scalability on Reddit
communities can have you know millions
of users you know infinitely many users
there are some communities with 20
million plus users I'm pretty sure right
like that's a lot and in Firebase our
documents can only be one megabyte in
size which is about 40 000 Fields now
we're obviously over that 30 000 limit
here we're sort of in the 11 million
area and this is totally realistic for
Reddit right and I know that our little
demo app is not going to have 11 million
users or 30 million users but it's
really good to think about these things
and just kind of think about it how it
would be in the real world because it
helps you become a better engineer this
is not great because this array can get
infinitely long and it definitely puts
us over our limit so from a user's
perspective we could store all of the
community IDs that I am in on a
community's array inside of the user's
document for example like the Tesla ID
the baking ID and this is totally fine I
don't see any CL ability issues here
because you know a user is probably only
going to join like I don't know 20 to 50
communities like 50s even a lot I think
I don't know so I think this type of
approach is fine we're restoring you
know the communities on the user but
this is definitely not
um and so I think this this could work
for some or some variation of this could
work but we would have to sort of tweak
the community logic a bit let's talk
about option two so option two is
essentially just
the SQL approach right this is option
two and what we do here is basically
create a collection in our database uh
that would sort of mimic this sort of
SQL like join table over here but having
this sqlite structure calls for SQL like
queries which would be like join
statements and you know just querying
multiple tables and Firebase does not
support join statements therefore we
would have to make multiple queries and
one of the main benefits of nosql is
that we can actually use this NASA
structure to our advantage to prevent
that we can prevent making multiple
queries we can prevent join statements
and really simplify Our Lives if we just
do the nested thing properly so that's
why we're going to avoid having this SQL
like structure for this case
now let's talk about option three and
this is the solution that we're actually
going to go with the user document in
this case is quite similar to case one
where we had just an array of community
data on stored on the user and so we
know what communities the user is in
however in this case we're not storing
just the ID we're storing an array of
objects and those objects can contain
sort of snippet-like data of that
Community hence the name Community
Snippets now why is this useful well a
this is useful because what I mentioned
already we know all of the communities
that a user is in and B this is useful
because what if in some of our
components we need more than just the
community ID itself but we don't want
the entire Community document we want
somewhere in between let me explain this
with an example let's come to our demo
and if we look at this drop down menu
here we can see that we have this list
of communities that I'm in
but we really only have the name and the
profile picture we don't have all of the
data associated with all these
communities right and we don't really
need it like when Shady lands on
reddit.com I don't really care about all
of the data in Tesla all of the data in
NBA all of data and music I don't care
about that when I'm on this page I just
care about the names of the communities
that I make and the profile picture so
in this list component the name itself
which is also the ID is not enough but
the entire Community is too much when I
click on one of these things then I care
about all that data then I need to know
how many members in the community then I
need to know be created at and all this
other potential data that could exist
right Reddit probably has tons of data
stored on their Community documents in
their database
this design is perfect for what we need
because it allows us to store just the
minimum amount of data we need for each
Community to display it but we're not
over fetching data we're not getting
data about each community that we don't
really need and this is really good from
a front-end scalability perspective
we're not overloading our front end with
a bunch of unnecessary data we're just
grabbing Snippets to present it in a
meaningful way in this case all we need
are two things to name the profile
picture so as for the community for a
community all we need to know is the
number of members inside of a community
I don't need to know every user that's
in the community because on reddit.com
you can't really go into the list of all
of the members in that Community I don't
need that for Reddit maybe I would for
another app but for Reddit all I need is
a number of members right if I go to a
community page all that they're
displaying here is the number of members
so in terms of like the relationship
between users and communities I only
care about this and then all we need to
do is every time a user leads or joins a
community we just have to update this
number if this was clickable if I could
click on this and view a giant list of
all of the users in the community maybe
that would call for a join table like
this we are going to go with this
solution here it seems to satisfy all of
our needs it models the many-to-many
relationship okay that was a lot on SQL
versus no SQL I hope that did clarify
things and I hope it was insightful to
kind of see different examples of ways
we could solve this problem if you've
got absolutely none of that I apologize
and as I always say if this does not
make sense at first glance just give it
time like kind of absorb into your brain
and as we develop it into the app it
should become more clear and this
document structure will also get us into
using database transactions which we are
going to see next all right you guys now
that we have to solved the problem of
users joining communities we can now
actually Implement that data structure
in to our app so as you recall from our
discussion about notes SQL we do need to
create a sub collection on our user
document called Community Snippets and
store these little pieces of data in
there every time I join or leave a
community so that is what we're going to
do now but we have a small problem let's
go to our fire story database for a sec
so if you look at this we actually do
not have a collection called users which
is weird right like we have the ability
to log users in but we don't have them
in our database it's kind of weird isn't
it yeah it is weird so the way Firebase
works is their authentication is
completely separate from their firestore
database they're not linked at all it is
meant to be an authentication solution
only so in order to add custom things to
our users like I was mentioning before
with the karma score and usernames and
anything that's custom and in this case
the community snippet subcollection we
need to store these users in our
firestore database we somehow need to
get them in here and this is where we're
going to talk about cloud documents
which should not take very long at all
it's just going to be a few minutes so
what we're going to do from a high level
is just Implement functions into our app
and we're just going to write a single
function version that is going to be
listening to our authentication Service
and then every time an authenticated
user is created is going to just
automatically store that user in our
firestore database and then once the
user's collection is in here it'll
appear the same exact way these are but
then we can actually add custom things
to it so let's go ahead and do that very
quickly it shouldn't take any more than
five to ten minutes so once you go into
the function section of the console you
might see something slightly different
than this I already clicked like the get
started button if you're there for the
first time you might look a little bit
different than this I can't remember
what exactly what it looks like but
basically what this is saying to me is
that I need to upgrade my project so to
use cloud functions we need to upgrade
our project from a free project to a
pay-as-you-go project but do not worry
you are not going to be charged a single
Cent In order to be charged anything for
Firebase your app has to have like
millions and millions of users and
millions and millions of reads and
rights to your database you're not going
to be charged a single Cent to sign up
for a billing plan it will ask you to
enter a credit card but if for some
reason you do not want to proceed with
Cloud functions or whatever reason I'm
going to also right after this do
another workaround solution without
cloud functions to achieve this same
functionality of getting our user into
our database however I would recommend
you if you're able to use cloud
functions as it is the recommended
method by Firebase and the community for
this type of user authentication flow
totally up to you so I'm going to
quickly walk through the Cloud firestore
solution and then right after this I'll
just do like a quick five minute chapter
on doing the same exact thing without
cloud functions so depending on what you
want to do watch accordingly okay so to
proceed with Cloud functions let's click
on upgrade project or whatever is there
for you just click on it and it'll sort
of take you down a similar path so if
it's your first time seeing this it's
probably going to ask you to create like
a Google Cloud account or something and
that's where you're going to like
actually put in like your billing
information like your credit card and I
already have my account created so it's
just asking me to set a billing budget
I'm just going to put one dollar not
even going to be charged a dollar and
this is basically saying you will be
charged as you go don't worry no charges
will occur I promise but I'm sure click
purchase and now it says you
successfully upgraded okay so once
you've upgraded your project to a pay as
you go plan you can just click get
started and we're going to install a few
packages okay so let's click on this and
let's go to our project terminal and
just install that the dollar sign always
gets me okay so something I just noticed
that some of you may come across as well
is when I try to run this command here
on the right it gave me an error that I
do not have permissions so I just need
to change the command to use sudo so I
just added sudo in front of the entire
command cool so once we have the
Firebase CLI you can just click continue
and now we're just going to run a few
commands inside of our project to
initialize Cloud functions and then
deploy our functions so after we
initialize our project we will then
deploy them so that they are actually
deployed on the cloud and we can use
them all right so let's do Firebase init
okay so right now we just want to set up
functions so we just highlight the
functions option and press the space bar
and then we just press enter and it's
going to ask us which project we would
like to use use an existing project
because we have created a project on our
console and the one I want to link up is
Reddit clone tutorial I believe and it's
saying what language would you like to
use to write Cloud functions we are all
about typescript do you want to use
eslint and I'm going to say no do you
want to install dependencies with npm
now because I'm just going to say yes so
I'm going to click finish over here our
app should have functions and it's
waiting for us to deploy so if we come
over to our directory you will see that
in the root of our project we have been
given it three new things we have this
firebase.json file we have this Firebase
RC file and then we have this functions
directory now this is where we're going
to be writing all of our Cloud functions
in this index.ts file this functions
directory is your serverless backend
it's being run on the Google servers and
it may require different packages than
your front end you'll notice that if you
go to your package.json file it has
these two dependencies Firebase
functions which makes sense and it also
has this fire service admin package
installed and it's through this admin
package that we're going to be able to
actually interact with our database
let's go see how we can do that so here
we are inside of index.ts and I'm just
going to get rid of all of these
comments and at the very top here I'm
just going to say import Star as admin
from Firebase admin and on this admin
instance let's call this method called
initialize app which is basically just
going to boot up our app on the server
and then we just need to create a
database instance so that we can
actually write to our database all right
and underneath here we're actually going
to write our function so we're going to
say export cons and our function name is
going to be called create
user document
we're going to use our functions
instance and tap into our auth service
and then we're going to say dot user
because the user is the part of the auth
service we're interested in and then
we're going to say dot on create
and then we're going to give this a
callback function that is going to
trigger every time a user is created and
this callback function is going to be
asynchronous and it's going to take in a
user as an argument I'm going to save
this set of format inside of this
function we are going to say DB dot
collection
ml collection that we want to write to
is users and we want to set a document
by saying dot doc the ID of the document
we're going to create is going to be
user dot uid the ID of the user and then
we're going to set these documents to be
json.parse and then inside json.parse
we're going to say json.stringify and
then the user and this is kind of a
weird workaround that you have to do if
you do not do this you will get a
serialization error and this just seems
to be the solution among the community
that is our entire function it is just a
few lines and now we are ready to deploy
this function and actually store users
in our database so let's go back to our
terminal and there is a command that
we're going to run that is going to
deploy only functions because right now
we're only interested in deploying
functions so I'm going to copy this over
and paste this in my terminal
now this may take several minutes to run
the first time you run it it usually
does speed up uh after the first time
but I think the first time it sort of
has to go and actually provision the
resources on the Google servers so just
give it a few minutes okay so once yours
has successfully deployed go back to
your console and you should now see that
function inside of this dashboard here
and you can see what the trigger is to
actually determine that function so it's
pretty cool and the logs are a good
place to look if the function ever fails
or there's some sort of bug uh the log
usually have details on what might be
going on so now let's actually go try
this out and try to create a user and
see if it gets stored in our database so
I'm going to go to my app
and log out let's click sign up now
let's create a new user called Shady
that's shady
.com password is going to be Shady
actually and before we do this let's go
to our firestore database and we can
clearly see we do not have any users in
here so let's see if it is created let's
go to here
and click sign up let's go to here it
sometimes takes a second as well it
might take like somewhere between like
five to ten seconds so refresh
and there is no user which is odd okay
let's go to functions
let's check the logs
um
okay so this was at 9 24 so we're just
now pretty much
function execution executed finish with
status error oh okay it did not work
um entry.2 adjacent is not a function
okay I don't even know if you can see
this sorry this is really really small
um I'm getting it to Json error which is
really weird I think it has to do
something to do with this I don't know
why because I have this written the
exact same way in my demo all right so I
did some research on this and I'm
honestly not sure what is going on I
have no idea why I'm getting an error
and why it's not successfully writing to
the database it definitely has to do
with this because I tested out just
writing a plain JavaScript object to a
database and it did work so this
function is being triggered and we can
obviously see it's being triggered from
the logs um so I don't have no idea why
this is happening I did the exact same
thing just a few weeks ago when I built
the demo so no clue what's going on and
I don't want to spend too too much time
on this because it's not extremely
critical so for those of you that are
experiencing the air as well I'm just
going to do a quick workaround solution
if you're not having the error that is
amazing I hope you're not having the air
but if you are this is a potential
workaround so what we can do is we can
just create a new JavaScript object and
we can store basically just the most
important parts from this user object it
as a new object and if you look at kind
of one might be on this user object
there's a lot of stuff going on here and
a lot of it is kind of nested we don't
really need all this data especially for
our application so I'm just going to
store the most important things which
are like the uid the email and like the
photo URL and then maybe the provider
data so that we know it's authenticated
with Google or something just the most
important things
so like four things so I'm just going to
take this user and I'm going to say uid
is going to be user.uid email is going
to be user dot email
display name is going to be user dot
display name and this is only going to
exist for all auth users and provider
data is going to be user dot
providerdata okay and then instead of
this
json.parts.json.stringify thing I'm just
going to pass in new user and this
should work so if you did have to
implement this change we will have to
redeploy so let's go ahead and do that
and once this is done we will check back
in
all right so I'm going to try this again
so I'm going to go back to my app I'm
going to log out and then do this whole
thing again I'm going to create a user
called lol.com I love law.com it's one
of my favorite websites just kidding I
have absolutely no idea what's
outlaw.com sorry if there's something
not good uh okay and then let's go to
our database and see if this actually
works okay so it's saying that it's
successfully completed sorry if this is
super small but basically it says that
it finished with a status of okay so
let's go to our database and yeah look
at that so the user stable has been
created and that data that we indicated
has been stored in there now if yours
worked with our initial solution with
the json.parse thing there'd be a lot
more stuff in here but this is really
all we need and it's on this document
where we're going to create that sub
collection Community Snippets so now I'm
going to implement the solution for
getting our users into our database
without using Cloud functions for those
of you who chose not to do them and it's
actually very very straightforward it's
only a few lines of code okay so let's
start off with our signup component and
so basically what we're going to do is
in the signup component once a user has
been successfully created with this
create user with email and password
function we're just going to put it into
our database that's it so this function
itself does not return the newly created
user but we can access it as the second
parameter from the hook up here remember
these four arguments and it's called the
user cred because this is not the use
user object itself it is like the user
credentials but the user object itself
is on this object here which we will see
in just a second okay so I'm going to
create a function called create user
document and it's going to be an
asynchronous function that takes in a
user which is a type user from Firebase
okay so the way we're going to write
this user to our database is with a
function from Firebase called add doc
now we basically just need to tell this
function what collection we are writing
to so we can create a collection
reference using the collection function
from firestore and then we can pass this
function our firestore object from
Client app and then the collection that
we want to write to is users and then as
a second argument we're going to pass
the actual data that is going to be
written into this document and in that
case it is user now all we need to do is
just call this function so what we can
do is we can create a use effect and
this use effect can have the dependency
user cred so that every time user cred
changes it will run this function and if
user cred
is a non-null value meaning that the
user was successfully created we want to
do something with it and that something
is right it through a database so we can
call our function create user document
and we can pass the user object and the
user object is going to be user cred dot
user and that's what I meant before when
I said you can access the user on this
user cred object so when we do that this
should work exactly the same as our
Cloud function so let's go test it out
hey guys really important announcement I
have to make as I am editing this video
here please change this user that the
arrow is pointing to and wrap it in
json.parts json.stringify Firebase will
not like it if you do not it will error
out and it will not work the solution
shown in the video does work for the
first attempt but it eventually does
fail so I did have to refactor this part
of the code so please implement this I
do apologize for this confusion so right
now I only have a user called
lolatlaw.com so let's go create a new
one sign up let's sign up as dude at
dude.com
password chatty sign up okay let's go
check our database users we can see that
dude.com is in there perfect so it did
it did its job so we just needed these
two additions to use effect and the
create user document now we can do
pretty much the exact same thing in our
oauth bones so okay so we can pretty
much do the exact same thing in here I'm
just going to rename this user cred
and I'm going to create a function
called create user document same name as
the other one it's going to be async
it's going to take in a user
now inside of this function the only
difference between this and the sign up
is that in this function we're going to
call set dock the other function was
calling add doc so we need to call set
doc because when you're authenticating
with Google we don't know if you're
logging in or signing up we don't know
if you're new or if you've already been
here before the set doc function does
that functionality it's either going to
create a new document if it does not
exist or it's going to update the
already existing document so it can
handle both the login and signup case
for Google perfectly okay so what we
need to do is create a document
reference to that potentially existing
document or the new document and the way
we can do that is we can say cons
user.craft is going to be equal to Doc
pass in our Firestar object The
Collection we're interested in is users
and the ID of this new or existing
document is going to be user.uid
and all we need to do is just say await
set dock pass in our user doc graph and
then just give it the data that we want
to set the doc to be which is user
and we use this same set doc function
when we were creating our communities
and we can have pretty much the exact
same use effect in this function
give the dependency of user cred
check for a non-null value of user cred
and if it is not null we can pass it to
our create user document function
user cred dot user save this and let's
give this a go hey guys we need to do
the exact same thing here so please wrap
your user in the exact same thing we did
just a few seconds ago thanks so I went
to my authentication thing and I have no
Google auth user right now so let's go
try to create a thing for my Shady
gmail.com account because that's the
only Google account I have let's sign up
continue with Google
so it's going to authenticate and if I
go to my database now
firestore I should see a third user and
yes I do Shadowmere gmail.com it says
the provider id is google.com so perfect
now we can write users to the database
whether or not you use cloud functions
or not and we can proceed with the
community functionality all right you
guys now that we have users in our
database and we're able to actually add
custom properties to those users let's
move forward with our community logic
and actually build in this community
snippet functionality so now we are
ready to introduce what is called a
database transaction and a transaction
by definition is a set of read or write
operations on one or more documents and
transactions are really useful because
they represent an All or Nothing
operation so what that means is is if
you have a set of database operations
that you are doing like updating several
documents at once it is very useful to
have all of these things succeed or none
of them if one of them fails let's fail
them all because they're sort of
dependent on each other so in our case
when a user creates a community we are
doing two very important things the
first thing we're doing is we're
actually creating the community itself
in the community's collection and the
second thing we're doing is we're going
to add that Community to the users
Community Snippets right we are
automatically joining that user to the
community if they create it and we
either want both of these database
operations to succeed or none of them so
we do not want to create the community
if the community is not successfully
added to the user's Community Snippets
and we definitely do not want to add the
community to the users Community
Snippets if the community fails to be
created and so that's why transactions
are extremely useful here transactions
are very similar to batch rights and we
are going to see batch rights very
shortly there's just a slight difference
between the two but I will talk about
that more when we get to it okay so
let's go to our app okay so here is how
we Implement a transaction in Firebase
so we are going to use an asynchronous
option and that function is called run
transaction and this is coming from
firestore so import that the first
argument to this run transaction
function is our firestore object as
usual and the second argument is going
to be a callback function and this
callback function is going to be
asynchronous
and it's going to give us this
transaction object that we're going to
use to actually make rights to our
database so what we're going to do is
we're going to add this first check into
our transaction checking if the
community exists in our database rather
than calling this get doc function we
are going to change this to
transaction dot get
pretty much the same thing we're just
making it part of the transaction now
the next thing we want to do is we want
to create the community so let's move
this up here and we are going to
change this from set dock to transaction
dot set transaction set operations are
not asynchronous themselves because the
entire transaction is asynchronous we
don't need to put the away keyword in
front of our transaction sets we do need
them in front of our gets though and the
next thing we want to do is create the
community snippet on that user
we're going to say transaction dot set
so what we're going to do is write a new
document to the community Snippets
subcollection which lives on the user
document so we're going to use the doc
function from Firebase we're going to
pass it our firestore object and the
second argument to this doc function is
going to be the path to the document
we're about to create and paths are
absolute paths and they start at the
root of our database so if we go to our
database this is the root and then we
just have to sort of jump into each
column here that's sort of like how you
can think of a path we're going into
here then into here then into the new
thing so the path in this case is going
to be users because we're going into the
user's collection
the ID of the user document we're
interested in is user.uid
and we are writing to a sub collection
and the sub collection name is community
Snippets so this is the first time we've
seen this path notation and the way I
want you to think about this is
collection document collection document
collection document and you can go as
deep as you want in our case we're going
into the users collection the currently
users document and then that current
user's sub collection called Community
Snippets collection document collection
the third argument of this doc function
needs to be the ID of the document that
we're creating which in our case is
community name because their names serve
as IDs and now let's hop out of our doc
function and as a second argument to the
set function we need to just pass in the
actual data that we want to store in
this document and this and the data in
this case is our community snippet the
community snippet has a community ID
which is just Community name
and then we're going to add another
property called is moderator and the is
moderator key means am I a moderator of
this community and we are setting it to
be true here because if I created the
community I'm automatically being set as
a moderator and I'm going to be given
different permissions than other users
who are not moderators and that is it
that is our entire transaction so if one
of these things fail all of them are
going to fail which is really good and
it maintains a high level of data
Integrity all right so let's actually
see this in action and see if it works
what we should see happen is the new
community should show up here in
communities and then if I go to the
users collection and go to the actual
user that created the community we
should see a sub collection inside of
that document which should have the
newly created Community snippet on it
and hopefully this will clarify this
sort of path structure once we sort of
have a visual representation of what it
looks like all right so I'm going to use
a user that I know exists so let's use
lol.com let's go to our app and honestly
do not know who I am logged in as right
now so I'm just going to log out
actually I could have just checked the
username
wow uh whatever okay so let's login and
let's use lol.com
and let's go to here create Community
let's create a community called laws and
new group I have no idea that's a
terrible name okay create Community all
right no errors that we see so let's go
to our database and let's go to
communities so we see Law's new group
which is perfect that's awesome let's go
to our law user
okay so we're at law.com and now we can
see that there is a sub collection on
law.com document called Community
Snippets with an ID of Law's new group
and the community ideas in here is
moderators true and now you can kind of
see that path structure that I'm talking
about so users user ID and then
Community Snippets and then the ID of
that Community snippet and then the
actual document at that field and later
when we add profile pictures to our
communities this is where that URL is
going to be stored as well all right so
now we know what communities that law
that law.com is in which is super cool
star transaction is working successfully
all right you guys now that we are
successfully able to create communities
and store those Community snippets on
the user so we know what communities
each user is in let's now create the
Community page itself and this is going
to be our first look at server side
rendering with nexgis so inside of our
Pages directory we need to create a
folder structure that reflects the
Community page rep and if you go to
Reddit their page route is reddit.com r
slash Community name I don't know if you
can see this it's super small but it's
our slash Community name in this case
it's comp side but this can change right
there's infinitely many communities so
our folder structure needs to be very
similar and remember that the folder
structure in your pages folder
represents your client-side routes and
our clients head route in this case is r
slash Community name so inside of pages
we need to create a folder called r
and then inside of R we need to create
another folder called Community name but
this community name is going to be a
dynamic route because the route changes
it could be computer science it could be
reading it could be baking it could be
Tesla so it is dynamic and the way to do
Dynamic routes in an xjs is to put these
square brackets around it and then
inside of these square brackets we
actually put the name of the dynamic
variable and in this case the dynamic
variable is community ID so we're going
to say community ID and then inside of
this folder we can create a file called
index.tsx so we can access this index
route by going to localhost 3000 slash R
sum Community name and so just to really
illustrate this client-side routing
concept while we're here let's create
another file called submit
dot TSX because that's going to be the
page that we actually create posts on so
if I go to our demo we have our r slash
baking route this is the home page of
the community then if I click on this I
go to the submit page which is our slash
baking slash submit index is the home
page submit is the submit page all right
so let's go back to our app so let's
start with the index page so we're going
to start off by using our snippet as
usual and I'm just going to rename these
props to be Community page props
rename this one as well Community page
props just like that and then I'm going
to rename the component itself to just
be Community page
and Community page and I'm going to put
the text in here
Community page
so now if I go to localhost 3000 r slash
hey dude or something it's going to take
me to this page that should say
Community page so we actually on this
page now and soon we're going to see how
to actually grab this from the URL and
do something meaningful with it so for
this page we are going to use server
side rendering and to do that we're
going to use a function from next.js
called get server-side props get server
side props is called on the next.js
server and then data is fetched from our
database in this function and then pass
to the component and then the component
is rendered on the server and then pass
to the client and then the client
renders the component that's sort of the
path so when the user actually makes a
request to a web page all this stuff
happens behind the scenes on the server
and so I would basically just think of
this as the web page being pre-built
before it's actually shown to the user
and this whole process just makes it
appear as if the data on the web page is
just sort of magically there when the
user first sees it whereas in
client-side data fetching we would show
the component first then go get the data
and then use that data to update our
component and the user would you see
some sort of loader as the data is being
fetched so server-side rendering
basically just removes this loading
State and reddit.com uses a mix of both
server-side rendering and client-side
rendering so we are going to do the
exact same thing so the data that we're
going to server-side render on our
community page is going to be the
community data so that we can sort of
pre-render the page with all of the
community data in it and then show it to
the user all we need to do is export the
function get server-side props from this
file and next.js will automatically know
to servers had run to this page so what
that looks like is this we say export
async function
get server side props
and we're going to take in this context
variable which is going to be of type
get server side props context and this
is how we're actually going to access
the page router so that we can use the
community ID
and I'm just going to close my directory
on the left so that I have a bit more
room inside of this function we're going
to get the community data and pass it to
our client component so we're going to
have a track touch block inside of our
try block we're going to actually try to
get the community document and the way
we're going to do that it's going to say
cons Community dot graph is going to be
equal to Doc from Firebase we've seen
this kind of stuff already
firestore import all of these things
communities is the collection we're
interested in and the documents we want
to get is the community ID page that
we're on and that page is coming from
the router right I went to our slash hey
dude so I want to get the community data
for hey dude so we can access this
parameter from the router by saying
context
dot query
dot Community ID and the name Community
ID is coming from the name we gave it
right this Dynamic route right here so
whatever name we give this Dynamic route
is the exact same name we're going to
use to access it from our router in this
case Community ID and so technically the
URL parameter can be of type string or
it can be a string of arrays or it can
be undefined in our case it's always
going to be a string so what I'm going
to do is Typecast this to just a string
and that should solve that compiler
error
okay so now let's get the actual
Community document which is going to be
cons community
dot I'm going to say await get Doc and
the doc you want to get is
community.graph
awesome and so the way next.js is going
to pass this data to our client type
component which in this case is
Community page all we need to do is
return an object and inside of this
object we just need to return props and
this props object is what next.js is
going to pass to our client so inside of
our props I want to pass Community data
and our community data is going to be
the actual data inside of this community
doc we just got which is going to be
Community Doc and then we have to call a
function called The Dot data and that is
a Firebase thing this is how we extract
the data from this actual document
object
and then our catch block I'm just going
to log the error I'm just going to say
get server side props error and and
next.js allows you to create custom
Pages if errors occur inside of get
server-side props but I'm not going to
do that for this tutorial because I feel
like our time is better spent elsewhere
so I'm going to add uh could add error
page here
so this props object is being passed to
our component up here so what I'm going
to do is destructure the props and grab
that Community data
but we do need to include that on our
community page props type
and our community data
is going to be of type community and we
have not created this type yet so let's
go quickly create this community type
and we're going to do that in our atoms
folder because we are going to add some
Global Community State shortly so let's
go quickly set up the skeleton for that
so inside of our atoms I'm going to
create a folder called communities
atom
so we're going to eventually Define an
atom in here
that is going to contain a global
Community State that we need throughout
our application but for now let's
actually just Define that missing
Community type that we have over here
because that's really all we need at the
moment so I'm going to create an
interface
pop community
so if you recall our communities have an
ID which is a type string a Creator ID
which is also a string number of members
which is a number
privacy type
and the type of this is going to be one
of three strings which is either going
to be public
or
restricted
or private
we also want to have a created at field
which is going to be of type time stamp
and this is coming from Firebase slash
firestore and I'm actually going to make
this optional by adding the question
mark here and I'm going to talk about
why that is later and finally we're
going to have an image URL and I'm going
to make this optional right now because
when we initially build the Community
page we are not going to have it I will
come back later to add this but for now
let's make it optional so that
typescript does not get mad at us so now
we actually have an interface defined
for our community so let's come back
over here and we can import that to
import it from our community's atom file
and this file should be happy now okay
so I'm going to close the directories if
I have Smart room and inside of here I'm
going to render
just so we can see the data coming in
community data dot ID I'm going to add
welcome to community data.id perfect
okay so after refreshing the page you
are very likely to get this Json
serialization error from next.js so
basically what's happening is next.js is
not able to successfully serialize our
community doc data in order to pass it
from an xjs server to our client and
this typically happens when you use
timestamps and we are using a timestamp
for our created at parameter in our
community so basically next you ask is
just freaking out because it doesn't
really know how to serialize that data
type so I did some research on this and
the solution I found was to use a
library called safe.json stringify and
this basically just streamifies our data
to a form that next.js can actually read
and serialize so that's what we're going
to do so we just need to install a
package called save Json stringify so
I'm going to go run npmi save Json
stringify
so let's install that and then at the
top I'm just going to import it so I'm
just going to say save Json stringify
from Save Json stringify and it might
complain that we need to install the
types for this file oftentimes when
you're using typescript and you install
a library it'll tell you that you need
to install the types for that Library as
well in order for it to work and it
usually gives you the command in this
little pop-up window so let's go and
grab that and paste it in here and just
install the types
okay so this should make that go away
and not make it all happy Perfect all
right so to actually use this function
let's come down here and change the
value of our community data and the
value you want to change it to is going
to be json.parse and we want to parse
the stringified version of the data that
we want to send and we're going to do
that using the adjacent stringify
function and we want to pass an object
and this object is going to represent
our community data and on that object we
want the ID of the community so we can
say community doc dot ID and then we
want all of the data in the community
document so we can just spread Community
doc
dot Beta And this is a function.data and
so basically all we did is we just
created an object that represents our
community so the ID of the document is
not included in the dot data function so
in order to retrieve the actual ID of
the document we can just manually
declare it here by saying ID is the
community doc.ed all right so now that
we're using save Json stringify this
should solve our serialization error so
I think I need to run my development
server so let's do that
and you might have to recompile yours as
well if yours was running while you did
all those installations okay so now
let's come over here and refresh let's
go to localhost
okay that seems to be working let's go
to slash r slash hey dude and the actual
name of the community in the database is
with a lowercase dude so make sure that
matches so it says welcome to hey dude
and we had welcome to community data.ib
so this ID thing is being shown here
community dayback.id and you can log the
data if you'd like just so you can see
what it looks like data so if I log this
this thing we're looking at here is this
object so it has the ID and then we just
took all the other data and spread it so
we have all of the data of the community
and this is that timestamp thing that
next.js was having serializing no clue
why some weird conflict with the types
so that is why we have to use Save Json
stringify all right so what we're going
to do now is just handle the case of if
a community dock for the visited URL is
not found so if a user basically goes to
a URL through our community that does
not exist we should just display them
some kind of meaningful messages like
this community does not exist because on
Reddit if you do that if you go to
reddit.com and you do R some random
Community like this that obviously does
not exist Reddit shows you this page
it's like sorry there aren't any
communities with that name so yeah we're
going to do that quickly it's just a
single simple component and it just
makes the app slightly more robust and
realistic so we're gonna come down here
and this is going to be very minor
changes so all we need to do is
basically check if this thing actually
found something and if it did not we're
just going to pass in an empty string as
a prop for Community data and then our
component up here we're going to check
if this community data is an empty
string we will show a component that
said exactly what Reddit said sorry
there aren't any communities with
anything so basically all we're going to
do is inside of our client-side
component we're just going to say if no
Community data because we do not have a
community in our database with this name
we just want to return out of our
component early and we're just going to
say div does not exist and I'm going to
add a more meaningful component in just
a sec in just a second here but just to
get the overall flow set up let's do
this for now so down here we're going to
do is just change the value of our
community data by adding a simple
ternary operator to check for the
existence of that Community Dock and if
it does not exist we will pass an empty
string so we can say community doc dot
exists which is a function conveniently
provided by Firebase
if it does exist past what we're already
passing and if it does not exist let's
just pass an empty string so if it's an
empty string meaning we went to a
community page that does not exist this
is going to happen because an empty
string is a false value so if I want to
return this div and not the div for an
actual community so let's try this out
so in our database I know that there is
no Community called dogs right there's
only these five so let's try to go to
dogs
so r slash dogs
let's see what happens
okay yeah so I think Community does not
exist which is great so all we need to
do is just create a very simple
component to replace that dominate
component that we have in there right
now so inside of components I'm going to
create a new folder called community and
there's going to be a lot of stuff in
here but our first one is going to be
that not found component so we should
say not found dot TSX and I'm just going
to paste the component from My Demo
project because it's very simple uh it's
just it's just only like 20 lines so
this is exactly what it looks like so
now if I go back to my index page and I
import that component so rather than
showing this temporary div I'm going to
return not found which doesn't seem to
want to import automatically so I'm
going to try yeah okay so add imports
from components Community not found save
that so now we have a more meaningful
component that is displayed if they go
to a non-existing community okay so now
that this is out of the way we can move
to the actual ideal case of when there
is a community that does exist for that
URL which is probably going to be most
of the time right just an edge case but
it is good to think about these things I
recommend to just avoid going completely
happy path when you're developing your
apps because if you don't cover your
bases sometimes this can be catastrophic
in production or something it could
break something so it's always good to
just think about these rare cases that
might happen all right so let's go to a
community page that actually exists
let's go to a new new
so r slash new new
cool
and just go to one that exists for you I
don't know if you made this exact one
just one that exists okay so if you go
to an actual Community page in our demo
we can see that we have this header
component and then we have basically
this feed and then some components on
the right hand side here so we're going
to start off with this header and it's
in the header that they can actually
join and leave this community so let's
go make that now so inside of our
community directory let's create a new
file called header.tsx
and I'm going to use our snippet so our
header is going to take in that
Community data since we are showing the
name so this is going to be of type
community and we can import this again
from our community's atom file and then
we can just destructure the props in
here Community data so let's build out
the actual component there is going to
be some logic that we're going to add
inside of this component for the actual
joining and leaving of communities but
for now let's return the component
itself this is going to be a flexbox
from Chakra
import that and we're going to give this
a direction of column a width of 100 and
a height of 146 pixels and I'm just
going to add the text header so that we
actually have something to show and I'm
going to come back to come back to this
index file and rather than it should
show Welcome to community data I'm going
to actually
return just a fragment and inside this
fragment we want to put that header that
we just created
awesome so we can actually see the
header there let's go make this thing
look actually proper why is this red oh
yeah and so we need to actually pass the
community data in there so let's do that
Community data which is going to be
equal to
Community there
let's go back into here and continue
building now inside of our header the
first thing we're going to add is a box
component and this box component is
going to represent the upper half of the
header that is sort of that blue
Highlight thing here so let's go create
that so that's going to look like this
the height is going to be 50 of the
header height
and the background color is going to be
blue 400 and we can actually just make
this self-closing since nothing is going
to be inside of it underneath here we're
going to have another Flex box this is
going to have justify equal to Center
we're going to give it a white
background
and we can just say flexgro
is equal to one which basically just
means to take out the remaining space
available in this component which is 50
because you made this height fifty
percent now inside of here we're going
to have another Flex box this is where
our icon is actually going to go and
we're going to give this a width of 95
percent
and a Max width
of 860 pixels and I will explain why
this is in a second I'll add a border to
this too just so we can kind of see what
it is that we're creating over there one
pixel solid red all right so inside of
here this is what is going to be our
image URL for now since we don't have
image URLs which we want to add later
we're just going to use the Reddit icon
which will basically just act as the
default Community image
so we're going to create that icon
inside of here so we're going to say
icon from shortcut UI react and the icon
we're going to use is going to be that
same icon we've used before which is
going to be fa Reddit and we're going to
import that from react icons f a slash
fa just like that the CSS for this icon
is going to contain relative positioning
and the reason that is is because if we
look at the demo you can see that
there's a bit of an overlap here this
icon kind of overlaps with this blue
part so to do that we can use relative
positioning and kind of customize where
that thing is going to sit
so we're going to make this thing a bit
bigger we're going to make it 64 which
is about the same size as it is on
Reddit and the position is going to be
relative and because now we have
relative positioning we can kind of
customize where this thing sits so we
can give it a top parameter and we're
going to give this minus three so this
basically just means it's going to be
minus three units away from the top of
its parent and its parent is this thing
with the red border and the minus thing
moves it upward right if we were to make
this 3 it would move it downward three
units away from the top negative means
three units kind of above the top and
the color of this is going to be blue
500.
and we're going to say border of 4 pixel
solid white and a border radius of 50
and this border and this border radius
are the sort of outline around the icon
so you can see that there is the ever so
slightest Gap in between that so I think
a potentially better solution to what
I'm doing here would be to have a just a
circular icon that is slightly larger
than this Reddit icon sit outside of it
and that way you wouldn't have this
little Gap here I'm not too worried
about that it's not a huge deal so I'm
just going to leave it for now I think
this works pretty good okay and actually
while we're here I'm going to add the
logic to show you what it's going to
look like when we actually do have an
image URL for our community so inside of
here I'm just going to add a ternary
operator so I'm going to add curly
brackets and I'm going to say community
data dot image URL if this thing exists
let's show
that image and if it does not let's show
this icon so this icon is acting as a
fallback to the image outside of here
we're going to say image and this is
coming from Chakra UI react
so if we save that the icon still being
displayed because this does not exist
and we will come back and actually do
something with this when we do have
image URLs for our images like we do for
this baking one here
so underneath our Turner operator let's
add two more Flex boxes so an outer one
and an inner one the reason for all
these Flex boxes will make sense as the
visual Parts start appearing so many
Flex boxes on the inner one we're going
to give a direction of column
and emergent right of six
and it's out of here this is where we're
going to actually display the community
name and as always text does not want to
Auto Import from Chakra so I'm just
going to kind of manually add it myself
and inside of here we can say community
data dot ID which is the community name
so that's showing up there okay so let's
make this heavy so I'm going to say font
weight is going to be 800. let's make it
a little larger as well so I'm going to
say font size is going to be equal to 16
point
perfect underneath here I'm going to add
another text so I'm just going to copy
this downward this is going to be
slightly lighter so 600 it's going to be
slightly smaller so we're going to
change this to 10 and this is when you
say R forward slash Community ID the
exact same appearance on Reddit and the
color of this is going to be
Gray 400. awesome that's looking really
good and now this outer Flex box is
going to have a padding of 10 pixels 16
pixels just like that awesome
now let's actually add the button that
the user can click to join and leave the
community so that is going to be a
sibling of this flexbox here
so just underneath that I'm actually
going to create that button so I'm going
to import that from Chakra so the text
inside this button is going to change
depending if the user is in this
community already if they are not in the
community the button is going to prompt
them to join so it's going to say join
and if they are in the community it is
going to say joined so this is where our
community Snippets are going to become
useful and remember earlier how I said
we are going to add some Global
Community State to our communities atom
our community Snippets are going to be
part of that Global state right now we
do not have it so for now I'm just going
to create a variable called is joined
and I'm going to set it equal to false
but this is going to eventually read
from our community Snippets
check if this current Community is
inside of our community snippet so
that's something we're going to cover
very shortly and it's going to tie into
our Global Community State with our
communities atom but for now we'll just
leave it false we're saying that they're
not in the community but at least now we
have a variable to toggle this text so
inside of this ternary operator we can
use that is joined variable and we can
say is joined
if they're joined show the text joined
if they are not joined show the text
join
awesome now let's style this button a
bit the variant is also going to change
depending on if they're in the community
or not so we can say is joined again if
they are joined we're going to give it a
variant of outline and if they are not
we're going to give it a variant of
solid in addition to all of this let's
add a height
of 30 pixels let's give it some right
padding of six some left padding of a
six and we're going to give it an on
click as well which right now is going
to be empty but this is going to be a
function called on join that is actually
going to join them or remove them from
that community so we're going to save
that so the reason I added that Max
width to this thing that currently has a
red border is to prevent this thing from
kind of infinitely stretching across the
screen uh because if they aren't a large
device size it would look kind of weird
if it was just spread across this entire
header so we sort of keep it compact
like this and our feed and the
supporting components over here are
going to sort of have the same Max width
and this matches exactly how red it has
it and it just prevents all these
components from being like across the
entire screen so we just give it a Max
width to make it look good on all screen
sizes
let's remove that border now that that
makes sense all right and now we have an
actual visual representation of what our
header is going to look like minus this
image URL thing which we're going to add
but this is looking really good and so
all we have left to do in this component
is to just implement this actual joining
logic but first let's go work on the
actual page content of the Community
page all right now let's actually talk
about the content of this page beneath
the header so to start the section off I
want to go to our demo and I just want
to point out how pretty much every
single page on reddit.com has the exact
same layout let's open this up a bit to
make this more clear but we pretty much
just have this parent component and
inside of that we have this left hand
side with kind of the feed and this
right hand side with these other
components and left hand side kind of
takes up I don't know about 60 to 70
percent of that width and the right hand
side takes up about 30 and this is the
same across every single page so this is
the home page if I go to a community
page same thing right just different
components but the overall like
government learning layout is the exact
same let's even look at the submit page
so pretty much the exact same thing
we've kind of seen a similar situation
before right remember how I was like oh
we need the nav bar on all of our pages
and to solve that problem we use a
layout component and we just wrapped our
app in our layout component and put our
navbar in there well we can do the exact
same thing elsewhere right it doesn't
just apply to the global level of our
app and we can do that with the content
of our Pages because again we have this
left hand content and this right hand
content with this repeated overall
layout across every single page and so
what we're going to do is just create a
simple page layout component and then
wrap all of our pages in that component
and it's just going to automatically
handle all of the styling for us right
like the widths and the responsiveness
and all that stuff and we don't have to
repeatedly write the same CSS so let's
quickly do that in our apps let's come
back to here so inside of our components
folder and inside of layout I'm going to
create another component called page
content because it sort of represents
the layout of our content for all of our
Pages I'm going to use our classic
snippet I'm going to open up the demo
just so we have a visual guide of what
we're doing so we can model this entire
layout with just a few Flex boxes so I'm
going to return pretty much the entire
structure of this page content what
that's going to look like is we're going
to use the flexbox from Chakra so this
is going to be the outermost parent
container then inside of that we're
going to have the actual sort of content
container then inside of here we're
going to have the left hand side content
and the right hand side content and we
can represent each of those which is
their own flexbox component just like
this the outermost one is this kind of
like gray area like the container of
kind of everything the next one this one
here is going to be the parent container
of both the left hand side and the right
hand side and then the two innermost
ones represent the left hand side and
the right hand side respectively so a
total of four containers that's it
that's that represents this entire page
layout and it's going to represent our
page though for every one of our Pages
now we need to apply some additional
styling to these things to just make
them respond wanted to give them the
proper width but overall this is it this
represents like every single page layout
so for clarity I'm just going to add a
comment above this first flex box that
says left hand side and for the second
one right hand side okay so now let's
actually talk about what's going to go
inside of both of these left hand side
and right hand side Flex component well
just like every other layout component
this is going to take in a prop called
children
and if you recall if we go back to our
original layout component where we had
our navbar children basically just
represented our entire application
because we wrapped our entire app in
this layer component so children is just
a bunch of react components right and in
this case in layout.tsx this was our
entire app children's might look a
little bit different in here because
we're going to pass in two children we
can pass in as many children as we want
but we're going to pass in two children
because we need one for the left hand
side and one for the right hand side so
our first child is going to be the stuff
that goes inside of our left hand side
Flex component and the second child is
going to be the stuff that goes inside
the right hand side flexbox component
and so this is kind of a weird concept
at first but bear with me so if we come
over to our index.tsx file underneath
our header is where we want to apply the
soil component right we have our header
and then we have this left hand side and
right hand side layout that we want to
do so underneath here is where we're
going to actually put this so we're
going to say page content bring that in
from the other file and this is where
we're going to need to Define our
children that we're taking in for this
page content layout just like in
layout.tsx the original one children
represented our entire app right if we
go look at app.tsx we can see that this
component was the only child of this
original layout this one here
so in this case we want two children
because we again left hand side right
hand side so let's come back to our
index and what we're going to do is
instead of passing a single child like
we were doing in our app.tsx file we're
going to pass two children and we're
going to represent both of those two
children with react fragments just like
this and we are totally allowed to do
this we are taking complete advantage of
how react actually works from like a Dom
perspective so this first fragment is
going to be child one and the second
fragment is going to be child two but if
it's more clear you can just think of
these as divs right that's really all
they are in this case all we need them
to be are fragments and we're just
putting them there to create this left
hand side right hand side structure so
again child one on the left child two on
the right so inside of child one for now
I'm just going to put a div that says
left hand side
and I'm going to do the exact same thing
on the right hand side so we have this
again child one child two I'm repeating
myself because this is kind of an
abstract concept that I hope it makes
sense okay so now inside of our page
content file here children is no longer
just a single component it is going to
be an array of two components right in
layout it was just one thing
in this file we have two because we have
two fragments that we're passing here
what that means is that this children
thing is going to be an array of both of
those fragments so if I log this here is
children
let's look at what this looks like so
let's go back to our app and let's look
in the console here so see it says here
is children let me zoom in a bit zoom in
a bit
open this up and we can see all that is
in here is just two react fragments
right react fragment react fragment and
we could add three if we wanted to we
could add 100 if we wanted to but
there's two because we had two fragments
and that's all that these are so now
what we can do is take each of these two
children and put them inside of our Flex
containers here so our left hand side
is basically going to be children at
index 0 the first element and the right
hand side is going to be everything
inside of children
at index one to fix these typescript
compiler errors we can just do what we
did before we just have to make this 0
and 1 valid indexes of the children
array so what we can do is we can
Typecast it to be that so we can say as
key of type of children
okay and we're getting an error over
here that's saying that children is
possibly null or undefined so to fix
that what we can do is we can just add a
simple check and this just checks to
make sure that children actually exist
and is a valid value it is not null or
undefined only then let's render this
and we can do the exact same thing down
here so I'm just going to copy this
entire thing
and then just change this to a one
just like that perfect so now you can
see left hand side and right hand side
actually showed up on the screen here
and so we of course have to apply a few
additional styling here to these Flex
boxes to make them have the widths and
the responsiveness that we desire but
this is sort of the idea and I think
this is really cool this is like uh this
is a really cool way to take advantage
of how react actually works and create
custom page layouts this children thing
is a little bit weird at first but just
give it time and I think it'll become a
lot more clear when we actually start
building out real left hand side and
right-hand side components like the feed
and the about component and everything
but basically the idea is that we can
put whatever we want in here right I can
put another div it's like hello
and 10 more divs whatever it doesn't
even matter we can put as many
components as we want in our left hand
side and as many as we want in our right
hand side so depending on what page file
we're working in the actual components
that go inside of both these two
fragments will be different but they're
always just going to be the same
structure because we only have two
governing children I hope that makes
sense that I tried my best to explain it
in the clearest way possible but if that
doesn't make sense hopefully it does as
we build more of these and let's go to
our page content and apply the simple
styles that we need and responsiveness
to these flexbox containers and
hopefully it'll become more clear then
so I'm going to add borders to all of
these to make it more clear
what we're actually looking at so I'm
going to do one pixel solid red on the
outermost
I'll do one pixel solid green on the
actual content container
and I'll add one pixel solid
blue on our left hand side content and
then I will do one pixel solid orange on
our right hand side okay now it's not
very clear now because they're all sort
of blob together but let's keep going
with this so on our outermost container
we want to give this a justify Center we
kind of want to Center everything and
we're going to give it a padding of 16
pixels on the top and bottom and zero
pixels on the right and left okay now
our content container
we're going to give this a width of 95
justify is going to be Center as well
because you kind of want to Center the
content and we're going to give this a
Max width of 860 pixels and if you
recall this is the same Max width that
we gave that component in our header and
this is so that they match up evenly and
it looks really flush so we're done with
these two let's come down to our left
hand side so our left hand side
we want to make all of the content
inside of it Direction column and we
want to give this a width
and this width is going to be responsive
at Mobile screen sizes we're going to
make the width 100 percent because the
right hand side is not going to be
visible on Mobile screen sizes so this
thing can take up the entire width and
then on medium screen sizes we're going
to give it a width of 65 when it starts
to share the screen with the right hand
side okay things are becoming a bit more
clear and then we're going to make our
margin right responsive as well so our
base screen sizes 0 and that Medium
screen size is we want to give it six
let's come down to our right hand side
we can make the direction of this column
as well and we're going to make the
display responsive so at base on mobile
we are not going to have this thing
visible and then our medium screen sizes
and up we're going to make it display
Flex
okay and we're going to give it Flex
grow is equal to one just to make it
take out the remaining width okay so now
hopefully this is becoming more clear
and you can actually see this structure
with your own eyes and kind of see how
it works and see how that Max width
matches up with that header component so
it's nice and flush that's why we did
that
this is looking really clean and then on
mobile we don't have the right hand side
component we only have the left
and so now what we've done is we have
created a reusable page content layout
component and we can reuse this on every
one of our pages and wrap the content in
this layout component and it's going to
have the exact same look and feel and we
can have completely different components
inside of our left hand side and right
hand side due to these two children
fragments we created so where we left
off last time was we created this really
useful page content layout component
that we can reuse on all of our pages to
create this left hand side right hand
side layout that Reddit has and we made
it responsive so that we only have to
write these Styles once and we use that
on our community page here and we also
created our header component inside of
our community page which shows the
community name eventually the image of
that community and we have this join
leave button here that we created
however right now this button does not
do anything it's just an empty function
and it doesn't actually do what it's
supposed to so what this button is
supposed to do is join this user to the
community if they are not in it and
remove them from the community if they
are in it but in order to know which one
of those two things to do we do need to
know if they're already in the community
therefore we need access to the user's
Community Snippets which we created so
even though we are successfully storing
the community snippet data in our
database meaning that we do know which
communities this user is in we currently
do not have this community snippet data
on our front end so our front end
actually has no idea if I'm in this
community or not only our database does
it so what we need to do is actually go
and get those Community Snippets from
our database so that we know if the user
is actually currently in this community
and we also need access to this data
inside of our drop-down menu so that we
know our own communities so clearly we
can see that multiple components in our
app need access to this community
snippet data our header does so that we
can either join or leave our drop down
money does so that we know what
communities we're actually in and if we
go to our home page this top communities
component does as well it knows which
one of these we're actually in so we
need this data across multiple
components so therefore we are going to
put this community snippet data into a
recoil atom so that we have access to it
globally and last time if you remember I
briefly created this file called
communities atom.ts I only Define the
interface for a community last time we
didn't actually create the item so we're
going to do that now so just like our
auth modal atom we can Define some
interfaces in here that are going to
help make our code more robust and
prevent errors so what I'm going to do
is create a typescript interface to
actually model our community state so we
know exactly what's supposed to be in it
inside of our community State we're
going to store those Snippets in an
array called my Snippets so we're going
to go and get the users Community
Snippets from the database and store
them in this array and that way we will
have access to them throughout all of
these components that I refer to just a
second ago and we can actually make this
better by specifying what type the
things inside of this array actually are
rather than just saying that they can be
anything we can tell it okay well this
is going to be an array of strings or
it's going to be an array of booleans we
can specify what's going be inside of
this array and each thing inside of this
array is going to be a community snippet
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create an interface that represents what
a community snippet actually looks like
now if you recall from our create
Community model our community snippet is
going to have a community ID and it is
moderator key which is going to be
present only if we created this
community so what I can do is come back
here and I can say okay well our
community snippet is going to have a
community ID of type string it's going
to have an optional is a moderator key
optional because it's only going to be
there if we created the community
ourselves and we're going to put the
image URL as well and I'm going to make
this optional to start off because we
are not going to implement this
initially and I do not want typescript
to get mad at me I'm just going to make
it optional for now so now we can come
down here and say okay well we know that
everything inside of this array is going
to be of type Community snippet and
we're going to see how useful this is
when we actually start working and
building these components that are
accessing this data and in a little bit
we are going to come back here and add
another property to our community State
called visited communities which is
going to act as sort of a cache of all
of the communities we visited so we
don't have to refetch that data but
we're going to come back to that in a
bit basically we just want to store any
data that is Global and Community
related in this community State atom
that we're going to create for now we're
only going to have the my Snippets data
inside of our community state so now
let's actually create The Recoil atom
for our community state so I'm going to
say export const Community state is
going to be equal to a recoil atom
and the type of that Community state is
going to be the Community State
interface that we just defined up top so
our key is going to be communities
State and this is the unique identifier
that is required by recoil and we also
need to give it a default value and the
value of our state needs to be of type
Community State we cannot just give it
anything like if we give it a string
it's going to complain and say well
string is not assignable to type
Community State because that's what
we're telling it the type of the value
is so we can actually create a variable
that represents the default Community
State
I'm going to say default Community State
and this is going to be of type
Community State so that the types
actually match and inside of here we're
going to have my Snippets and we're
going to initialize this as an empty
array so it's going to start off as
empty then we're going to go get that
data from our database and then store it
inside this array and down here to make
typescript happy again we can say
default Community State so now the types
match and we are good to go all right
you guys now that we have defined our
community State atom we are able to
access our community State data globally
and we can grab the snippet data
wherever we need it and we saw that the
main components that we're going to need
it are is in this top communities
component our drop down menu and then as
well as in the headers of our community
pages so we have clearly established
that this community snippet data
definitely needs to be Global let's take
this one step further if we look at this
top communities component we can see
that we can join and Lead communities
from within here so we're calling some
sort of function that is responsible for
joining and leaving whatever one we
click on and we also have that same
exact functionality inside of our header
component in a specific Community page
so not only is our community snippet
data required by both of these
components the functionality for
actually joining and leaving a community
is shared by them as well so in react
when we have this sort of scenario where
we need data as well as certain
functionality shared across Global
components we can create what is called
a custom hook and in the custom hook we
can put State and logic that is repeated
across our app and we can use this
custom hook in any component that
requires this repeated functionality in
the same exact way as we would use a
native react hook like you state or use
effect so let me explain this with a
diagram so I created this diagram here
of what it is that we're going to create
so we're going to create a custom hook
that is called the use Community data so
basically this diagram represents the
data flow of this custom hook and so
this Hook is going to contain any
Community related data or functions that
we need across multiple components so
we've already established that we
clearly need Community State across
multiple components right we need those
Snippets and the community state
contains those Snippets so we can put
our community state in this hook we also
need the functionality of joining and
leading communities across two different
components and those two components in
this case are header as well as the top
communities component and then inside of
these components all we need to do is
just grab the specific pieces of this
global data that we need by using the
exact same hook and this is really good
architecture because it keeps our code
dry it prevents us from writing the same
functionality multiple times and it just
makes the code overall better quality
that way we don't have to define the
same functions over and over in all the
places that we needed we just have to do
it one single time and I've created this
diagram to model what our situation
looks like to hopefully make it more
clear as to why we are using a custom
hook but the main takeaway here is to
just understand that in react when you
have repeated logic or repeated data
that is required in multiple places you
can extract all that stuff put it into a
single place which is a hook and then
call that hook from wherever this stuff
is needed I do hope that makes sense and
it will become more clear as we actually
write the code for this so let's
actually go and Implement that diagram
in code and then we can refer back to it
once we have done that to solidify this
entire concept okay so let's actually
create this custom hook so inside of our
source folder I want to create another
folder called hooks
and then I'm going to create a file
inside of here called use community
data and if you've never written a
custom hook before it does have to start
with the word use just like all the
other hooks use State use effect it is a
requirement by react okay so let's begin
writing out this skeleton for this
custom hook to hopefully solidify that
diagram if it was not clear from the
beginning so this Hook is not going to
take in any props so we can just remove
that so this is where our recoil
Community state is going to live so
we're going to say Kant community
State value
set Community State value
is equal to use recoil state
and remember that this recoil hook
requires us to pass the atom that we
want to get from recoil and the atom
that we're pulling from is our community
State atom which makes sure that imports
from atom slash Community data now our
custom Hook is not going to return any
HTML like any other component it is
going to return an object that contains
data and functions and the stuff that we
put in this object that we're returning
is what's going to be accessible by the
other components that actually use this
hook so we have definitely established
that we want Community State value
available across many components so
let's put that inside of this object so
let's define the functions that are
going to be shared across components so
one of those functions if you recall
needs to actually join the user to the
community let's put that in here let's
create a function called join community
and we will leave it empty for now and
we also need leave community
so now I can also add these functions
to this object so that they're
accessible
by the components that call this hook
and since this Hook is not returning a
functional component we're going to
remove this return type here okay so now
let's talk about how to actually call
this hook and get access to this stuff
in the components that need it so let's
go to our header and let's import our
new custom hook import
use Community data from go up to
directories hooks use Community data
awesome now inside of our component the
way we're actually going to call our
Hook is pretty much the exact same way
we recall any other reactor you would
say const I'm going to leave it empty
just for a second I'm going to say this
is equal to use Community data
okay well now we can grab any of those
three things that we were returning out
of our hook remember we had Community
State value joint Community lead
Community well now we can grab that from
inside of here so let's grab Community
State value
now we have access to that recoil state
in our header component and we can also
grab those two functions join and leave
Community okay so let's go back to our
hook now I'm going to create a function
that is going to decide which of these
two functions to call and this will
become clear why in just a second so
bear with me so I'm going to say cons on
join or leave community
all right now this function is going to
take in two arguments the first one is
going to be the actual data of the
community that we are trying to join or
leave and this is going to be of type
Community which we will need to import
from that same community's atom file and
the second argument is going to be a
variable called is joined and this is
going to be a Boolean representing if we
are joined into this community or not
okay and I'm just going to close my
directory so I have more room and so
inside of this function the first thing
we're actually going to check is is the
user signed in
and if they're not signed in we want to
open up the auth modal and prompt them
to sign in because you can only join or
lead communities if you are signed in
and since our auth model state is global
we can totally do that here and this is
another reason why I made that State
Global so hopefully that's more clear
now if it wasn't before and we will
implement this in just a few minutes but
let's just get it working for a signed
in user first so if they are signed in
the next thing you want to do is check
are they joined into this community if
they are and they click on that button
that means they must be leaving the
community so we're going to call our
leave Community function and we're going
to pass in the ID of this particular
community so down here we just need to
indicate in our lead Community
declaration that we are accepting the
community
ID and the type of that is a string okay
perfect and if you do that we can just
return out of this function because we
do not want to proceed so if you make it
past that that means the user is going
to be joining the community so we're
going to call our function join
community and we're going to pass all of
our community data to this function
because we're going to need more than
just the ID inside of it so I'm going to
go down here and add that to the
Declaration and that is going to be
F-Type community so now down here rather
than having to return both of these two
functions separately we can just return
the single one on join or leave
community and this is the function that
our header and top communities component
is going to call so now let's go to our
header pull that function in from our
hook so on joinery community and then
down here is where we actually want to
call it on this button here so we can
say
on join or leave community and we want
to pass in that Community data and also
our is joined variable that we have
already defined if you remember R is
joined thing we just declare it as false
because we did not have access to our
community's state value yet but now that
we do let's make this proper let's
actually read from our community
Snippets so since my Snippets is an
array that represents the communities
that the user is currently in we can
search through this array and try to
find a snippet where the ID matches the
ID of community data which in this case
is the data for the community chatties
group if we can find one that means that
this user has indeed joined this
community and if we cannot then they
have not joined so what that looks like
is this we can say Community State value
dot my Snippets dot find
and defined function is a higher order
array method that we can use to Loop
through an array to see if a specific
item matches some condition and the
condition that we're looking for in this
case is if item dot Community ID is
equal to this community data.id
if the find function does find a snippet
that matches which in this case would be
a snippet with an ID of Shady's group
it's going to return that snippet if it
does not find it it's going to return
undefined and you can see down here that
this function is not happy because is
joined is supposed to be a Boolean but
right now it's either going to be a
snippet or undefined and the way to fix
that is we can just add a double bang
operator in front of this entire thing
and that is just going to booleanize it
to make it true or false it's going to
behave the exact same way but now it's
just a Boolean okay so now that is Happy
okay so now all we need to do is go and
fetch the user's Community Snippets from
the database and store them inside of
this my Snippets array so let's do that
and we're going to put that logic inside
of our hook here
okay so let's create a function called
get my Snippets and this is going to be
asynchronous because we need to
communicate with our database which is
asynchronous and inside of here I'm
going to create a try catch block to
help us with our error handling so if
there's an error I'm going to say get my
Snippets error and log the error and I'm
also going to come up here and create
some loading and error state so I'm
going to say loading set loading is
equal to use state
false and error and set error is going
to be initialized as an empty string as
usual perfect okay so just before our
try block and once you set loading to be
true as we are waiting for our Snippets
to come back from the database and
inside of here we're actually going to
go get this user Snippets
so because we are getting the Snippets
for the currently logged in user we need
access to that currently logged in user
so let's come up here and grab that from
the hook we've seen before use auth
state
pass it our auth object from Client app
as usual and now let's come down here
now let's actually communicate with our
firestore database and grab all of the
documents inside of this community
snippet collection for this current user
so how we're going to do that is we're
going to say const snippet Docs it's
going to be equal to a weight get docs
again coming from firestore and inside
of this function we need to pass it a
collection reference so that it knows
which collection to get all these
documents from and that collection is
going to be a collection object from
firestore and we need to pass this our
firestore object so the path to the
collection that we want to get all of
these documents from is going to be
users then outside of the users we want
to go into this currently logged in
users user ID document then on that
particular user we want to grab
everything from the community Snippets
subcollection
so that is the path to that collection
let's save this firestore is going to
return an array of objects of all the
documents inside of that collection and
what we want to do is take those
documents and extract all of the data
from each one and then store it in my
Snippets inside of Community State value
and we can do that using the set
Community State value function what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a new variable called cons
Snippets and we're going to take those
snippet docs return from Firebase until
you'll notice that there is a property
called the docs provided by firestore
and this is going to allow us to iterate
through these docs and convert them into
JavaScript objects to store into state
so we can say dot docs and then dot map
and then for each dock we want to
basically create a JavaScript object and
extract all of the data out of that
document so this is how we do that so
again we are looping through all of
those docs returned by Firebase and then
mapping them or converting them into
objects with all of the data extracted
from each document so to clarify this
let's just log Snippets
to see what they actually look like
okay so let's go to our console and
let's just refresh this page
so I was trying to figure out why it
wasn't showing up in the console and uh
it's because I'm not even calling the
function so uh that's probably why so
what we do is actually call the function
so we are going to call this function as
soon as the application loads and the
Dom mounts and the way to do that is
like we would in any other component
with the use effect we can use the same
exact methods in our hook as we would in
a regular component
and inside of this use effect all we
need to do is call that get my Snippets
function
if there's something we need to watch
out for here and that is that since we
are getting Snippets for a specific user
we don't really want to call this
function until we have an actual user ID
returned from this use off State hook if
you proceed like this there's going to
be a data race and this could
potentially be called before the user
actually comes in from that hook which
would result in this being undefined and
we just don't want to do that it's kind
of not a good idea so a way to protect
against that is to just add a dependency
inside of this use effect of the user
that way this Hook is going to trigger
every time user changes and then what we
can do is at the very top of our use
effect we can just prevent this function
from being called if there is no user so
we can just say if there's no user then
return out of this function because
there is no user to get Snippets for
this is a very common thing to do in
react if your functions that you're
calling from inside of your use effect
depend on this thing being valid so
we're basically saying oh okay like the
user is undefined get out of this
function don't don't proceed and then if
the user does become defined and say
they log in use author to finally loads
the data from the auth service then it's
going to pass this and then we will call
get my Snippets which will ensure that
we are getting uh valid snippet
documents okay so now we can see that in
our console we actually are getting
those Snippets so if I expand this here
we can see that this is coming directly
from the database and these are the
Snippets for this particularly logged in
user which is my Shad Mary at gmail.com
right in our database there is shatties
group is moderator true and that is what
we are seeing on the front end here so
this is just currently an array of one
Community snippet because Shady shadmary
gmail.com is only in my community right
now Shady's group if I was in 10 there
would be 10 okay so now all we have to
do is take these Snippets and put them
into our
communitystatevalue.my Snippets and then
we will actually have a valid way to
check if I'm in this community or not so
let's do that and we're going to see
that this button is actually going to
show us whether or not we're in here
okay so let's go back to here and let's
put that these Snippets inside of state
so we're going to do is we're going to
call that set Community State value
because that's the state that we're
updating and then take the previous
state and spread it because the only
thing we're modifying is my Snippets
thanks to typescript we have this nice
intellisense here
and what we're doing is we're just going
to set my Snippets to be sippets so we
are going to get a typescript compiler
error here and this is due to some
discrepancies between the types with
call signatures so the way to solve this
would be to just Typecast the Snippets
to be an array of community Snippets and
we have an interface to find four
Community Snippets in this file we just
need to import it into that other file
so I'm just going to export it out of
here and now inside of use Community
data we can just Typecast these Snippets
to be an array of community snippet just
make sure you import that from your
other file so this is happy now and so
just a quick fun typescript fact another
way you could write an array of a
certain type is to write it like this
you could say array and then put that
type in there like this this is the
exact same thing I personally prefer
this way it's totally up to you though
okay so now check that out now that is
joined variable is detecting that we are
indeed in this community because that
find function found that snippet of
Shady's group inside of my Snippets so
if I went to a different Community page
for one that I was not in this would not
happen and let me see if I can
demonstrate that so I'm going to log out
of my Chad Mary account and I'm going to
log in as someone uh I think I have an
account wall.com that still exists and
I'll sign in give me a chatty
yeah I did okay okay so you can see that
I logged in as lol.com and lawatlaw.com
is not in this community so is joined is
false pretty cool it's actually working
if I log out of this community
and signed back in as shadmare hey
gmail.com
check that out it detects that I'm in
this community automatically and the
reason it was able to do that without me
even doing anything is due to this use
effect right because we wrote this use
effect that is going to trigger every
time the user changes so what happened
was I was logged in as lawat law.com I
then logged out of law.com and the user
went from the law the law that law.com
object to null and so then this
triggered again but it did not make it
past this because null is a falsy value
then I logged back in as Shad Mary
gmail.com then the user went from null
to the shadmare he user object which is
a truthy value so it made it past this
it called get my Snippets it then went
and got the snippet docs for Shad
Marie's user ID and that is how that
happened so I think this is pretty cool
and now we're actually able to detect uh
whether or not I'm in this community and
so now all you have to do is just write
the logic inside of these to joining and
leaving Community functions and we'll be
and we will be able to actually click
this button and remove ourselves or add
ourselves now let's just come down to
the bottom of our try catch Block in our
get my Snippets function and just add
set loading to be false when that
fetching is complete and we actually
want to display this loading State
inside of this button here in our header
so what we can do is actually add the
loading state to the return object of
our hook just like this and then inside
of our head component we can just grab
that value from our hook and then we can
use it down here on our button I can add
is loading state
and set it equal to loading from the
hook so you saw that temporarily change
there so direct your eyes to here and
watch what happens when I refresh the
page
perfect so we can see that the loading
state is working and once that my user
has been grabbed from the auth service
it then fetches my Snippets and we are
in business and also one thing you'll
notice here is that if I log out nothing
happens but we should clear that and
this is super easy with recoil because
they have a hook that is called the use
reset recoil State and this will
basically just clear the atom that we
give this hook and a single line of code
we can do this so let's go over to our
user list component that we haven't been
into for a hundred years I think we are
logging out right here right here okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
grab this sign out function I'm going to
copy it come up here and create another
function called log out which is going
to be asynchronous
I'm going to put that sign art function
here and await it and when that
successfully completes you're just going
to clear our community state
which makes sense because now that the
user has logged out we don't really want
any Community data related to this user
in our state anymore so then all we need
to do is up here call that use reset
recall stay Hook and the way we call
that is we can create a variable so we
can say reset Community State it's going
to be equal to use reset recall State
and then just pass this the Community
State atom that we are interested in
resetting and then come down here and
call that function reset Community state
that is it and then we just have to come
down here and change the on click in
this log out button to be our new log
out function just like that so now when
I actually log out it should clear and
we should see this go back to the button
that says join so let's see
perfect so let's try that again so if I
log in
shed Mary gmail.com
cool log out
nice so I'm going to close this file
because we are never going to see it
again I don't think Vibe user menu now
let's actually write the functions for
joining and leaving our community and I
don't know what it is about these
functions I just find them super
satisfying to write they just flow and
they're just cool I don't know maybe I'm
weird but let's see if you feel the same
way so inside of our use Community data
we did Define these functions here now
this is where we're going to get into
batch rights with Firebase so let's
search up Firebase transactions and if
you remember I was mentioning how batch
rides and transactions are very very
similar and just we have a bit of a
reference let's open up our create
Community model because we actually
wrote Our transaction here and let's
talk about just the slight difference
between these two things so basically
transactions and batch rides represent
the same thing in the sense of doing a
group of actions with our database and
we only want all of them to succeed or
none of them to succeed so if one of
them fails fail them all that applies to
both transactions and Bash rights in the
case of transactions though you can do
read and write operations whereas batch
writes are only right operations that is
the only difference very minor so the
only reason we use a transaction in this
create Community modal was because we
were doing a read first we were just
simply reading from the database to see
if the community exists when we're
joining or leading a community we only
need to perform right operations like
deleting and updating documents so we
can just use batch rates that only
succeed all together let's go back to
our hook and let's write some batch
writes so inside of both of these
functions there are two database updates
that we need to make that we are going
to group together into a batch so the
first action inside of our batch is
going to be creating a new community
snippet for this user right if the
user's joining this community we need to
take this community and create a snippet
and then add it to that user's Community
Snippets that is the first thing and the
second right operation we want to do in
this batch is going to be updating
the number
of members
on this community right because if the
user is joining the community we need to
go in to that Community document and add
one to this value number of members so
these two actions are going to represent
our batch rate
so after this batch write successfully
completes and our back end has been
updated to reflect this user's joining
of the community we just need to update
our client data which is our recoil
state to actually update our UI and
reflect this change to the user so we
can just write update recoil state which
in this case is our community
state DOT my Snippets right we're just
going to Simply add this new snippet to
communitystate.my Snippets so these are
the three things that we have to do in
this function and the lead Community
function is just going to be the exact
opposite of this so the first thing in
the background I just want to simply be
deleting
the community snippet
from user and then we are also going to
update the number of members by
subtracting one up here it would have
just been one and then we will also
update our client to remove that
Community snippet from our Reflow state
so now that we've kind of defined what
these functions are going to be doing
let's actually write this logic out so
let's start with the joining of
community so I'm going to create a try
block inside of here and as usual I'm
going to log and error if it occurs join
Community error
error and then we can just set error to
be error Dot message
perfect and just to make typescript
happy let's make this type any and I
think actually down here we forgot to
set error as well in our get community
Snippets function so let's just quickly
do that set error
to be error Dot message
so now let's work on the ideal case so
here is how we're going to do a batch
write in firestore so we're going to
create a variable called batch and we're
going to use the function from a
pressure called Write batch and we're
going to pass this our firestore objects
on Client app as usual and so now on
this batch object is where we're
actually going to perform these
operations so let's create a new
variable called new snippet and this is
going to be of type Community snippet
which I think we're already importing
we're going to give this a community ID
of community data dot ID and we're going
to set the image URL to be the community
data dot image URL and if it does not
exist we're just going to make it an
empty string and again these are not
going to be this for now but we will
just add it here because why not so this
represents our new snippet and so we are
not a moderator of this community
because we are just joining so the is
moderator key is not going to be added
here so now to actually write this
snippet to the database we can use our
batch variable defined on line 68 and we
can say batch.set and this is going to
look exactly the same as the the set
dock function that we've used before so
we need to pass in a document reference
for the document that we actually want
to set so we can say Doc and then we can
pass this function our firestore object
from Client app so the path to the
collection that we are writing this new
document to is going to be users slash
user.uid
slash Community Snippets so this is the
community snippet subcollection that
lives on that particular user's document
and then as a third argument to the doc
function we give the ID of this newly
created document which is going to be
Community data dot ID and then the data
that we actually want to put inside of
this document is going to be that new
snippet object
just like this so the second thing we
need to do in our batch is update the
number of members on this community
document so because here we are updating
an existing document not creating a new
one we can use batch dot update and this
update function is also going to take a
document reference
and this particular document lives
inside of the collection called
communities and the ID of this document
is community data dot ID
and as a second argument to the update
function we're going to pass in an
object that is going to contain the
updates that we want to make to this
document and the field that we want to
update is number of members and what we
are doing to this field is increasing it
by one and firestore has a function
called increment
and then we can pass in the value that
we want to increment this field by which
in this case is just one and that is it
for our batch rights however just
writing these batches out does
absolutely nothing in order to actually
make them execute and update our
database we need to call the function
batch dot commit and that is actually
going to execute these batch writes and
this is an asynchronous function so we
need to put the await keyword in front
of it so do make sure that you have the
async keyword on your joining Community
function declaration up here okay so
after these batch writes successfully
complete without any errors and our
database is all nicely updated we can
now update our recoil State on our
client to reflect this change and we're
basically just going to add this new
snippet up here to the existing my
Snippets rate so we can do that by
calling set Community State value taking
the previous value of State
spreading it and the value we're going
to be updating is going to be my
Snippets and what we want to do is like
I said before append this new snippet to
the end of the existing my Snippets
array so we can take the previous value
of my Snippets and spread it so take
what's already there and then just add
this new one to the end of that array
perfect and that is it for this function
all we need to do down here at the end
of our catch block is just set loading
to be false just like that awesome and
I'm just going to quickly move this
comment down here so that it is
alongside what it's actually describing
so now let's work on the lead Community
function so let's come down here and
create a try catch block just like
before we can log and error leave
Community error
error.message
make the type of error any
so in our try block we can create a
batch variable again using that right
batch function from firestore
and the first thing we want to do with
this batch is delete the snippet off of
this user so we can do that by saying
batch dot delete we can pass in the
document reference for the document that
we actually want to delete so the path
to the collection that this document
lives in is going to be the exact same
path is up here so the currently signed
in users Community Snippets sub
collection is the collection we are
accessing and as a third argument the ID
of the actual Community snippet document
is going to be Community ID which we are
passing to the function up here okay
second batch rate we need to do is
update
our number of members again and this is
going to look pretty much exactly the
same as this update here with just a few
differences so I'm just going to copy
this one from join Community bring it
down here
and the only changes we need to make are
the ID of the document that we are
updating is going to be Community ID and
instead of incrementing this value we
are going to decrement this value by one
since we are leaving the community
firestore does not have a decrement
function so we can just make this number
negative so it's going to add a negative
1 to it and it will work exactly as we
desire so now let's actually execute
these batch writes by saying await batch
dot commit
okay so I'm just going to move this
update comment down here and now once
our database has successfully updated
without any errors we now want to update
our recall State and we can again do
that with the set Community State value
function take the previous value
spread it
the filter updating is again my Snippets
however this time we are going to be
removing a snippet from the current my
Snippets array not adding it and we can
do that by using the filter function
given to us by JavaScript which is
another higher order array function so
we can take the previous value of my
Snippets and call the dot filter
function on it and this is going to Loop
through and it's going to remove items
that do not meet a certain condition and
the filter condition that we're going to
apply here is we're going to check that
the item's community ID does not equal
to the community ID that we are removing
okay and that is it for this function we
just need to set loading to be false
down here and also we can set error in
the catch block of here to the error Dot
message just like that all right so
these functions are done they look good
to me let's give them a go so let's go
to my users document so Chad Mary and we
can see that I'm currently inside of the
community chatty's group because I
created it so let's go to our app so it
says yeah I am joined into this
community so when I click on this it
should remove me
okay so it works on the UI let's see if
the database updated yeah you can see
that that document no longer exists and
this is actually in real time so if I
bring this over here we can visualize
this a bit better so let me join now
and we can see that in real time that
added that document to that sub
collection so leave the community
join the community
awesome that is super cool let's go to
another community that I did not create
new new new
and let's try joining this one
so join
awesome it's added in there
leave
perfect now let's check the number of
members functionality
so we can see communities go to new new
we said there are two members in there
right now so if I join this it updates
to three if I leave it decrements to two
and these are our batch rights in action
so they are clearly working which is
amazing so let's put this back over here
okay so we can now join and leave
communities it updates the number of
members and this is a huge piece of
functionality of our app this is like a
critical piece of Reddit and we have
successfully implemented this and that
is super cool so all we need to do now
is just open that auth model if the user
tries to click on this if they are not
logged in so let's log out
and let's come up here and actually
implement this I did have some comments
up here we already have the user from
our US state hook so all we need to do
is add a simple check at the top of this
honor join the community function for a
valid user so you can say if there is no
user
then let's open the modal
so to open the model we can grab our set
off modal State function from recoil so
we can say cons set auth modal State and
we can use the use set recoil State hook
pass in our auth model State atom and
then come down here and call that
function set authmodal State and the
state we want it to be is open true and
we can set the view to be the default
view of log n and then we can return out
of this function because we do not want
to proceed with joining or leaving so
now since I'm now logged in if I click
on this Boom the model opens and it's
going to ask me to log in and that is
why I love having the auth modal State
Global in recoil so that we can protect
certain features against unauthenticated
users and that is so cool so if I did
want to join this community I would have
to log in
and then it would allow me to join
so we are done writing all of the
functions for joining and leading
communities and the best part about this
hook and these functions is that we can
reuse this logic in any component that
requires it in our case it's going to be
top communities but we could add more
components to this app in the future
that would need the same functionality
and we could just reuse this hook and I
think that is so cool really clean
architecture and I'm super excited about
it okay so now we're done with the whole
joining and leading a community thing
let's actually start working on creating
posts in the communities which is
probably the most exciting part of this
entire project so on Reddit how it works
is that inside of community there's this
component here that has an input in it
and then when the user clicks on it it
brings them to the URL R Community name
submit where the actual post form is and
then they can create the post from
within here so this thing is basically
acting as a link to the submit page so
let's work on that now and then we can
actually get rid of these really ugly
borders here and start putting in some
nice looking
all right so inside of components
and inside of our community directory
I'm going to create a new file called
create
post link
.tfx
and this is what is acting as this input
linky type thing here so inside of here
I'm going to use our snippet
and we are not going to take in any
props to this components we can get rid
of that and the actual HTML for this
component is relatively easy and basic
it's just a flexbox with a few icons
inside of it and then some additional
styling applied so now that we actually
have a valid left hand side component
defined let's just go back to our index
page for our community quickly and get
rid of this dummy left hand side div and
actually use that real component create
post link
and we can see that show up here in our
left hand side fragment okay so let's
come back here I'm just going to close
my directory so that's my room so what I
decided to do for this component is to
just paste in the code from my existing
project it is a lot of what we have seen
already and I do want to get to the post
functionality because it's a lot more
exciting this component is pretty much
just acting as a link to the actual
creation of post thing so I figured our
time would be better spent doing that
but I will explain the important parts
so I'm just going to paste that in here
and it's only about 70 lines it's not
super long there's only one important
function that would X over and it's a
pretty short one and I will put the link
to this component file in the
description so you can access it
directly all this thing is is just a few
icons and an input acting as a link to
the submit page the only function I want
to go over is this on click function
here which is being called when you
click on this input so basically all
this function is doing is redirecting
the user to the submit page of this
community which lives at this URL R
Community ID submit which we saw on our
demo the way we are doing that is with
the next JS router and we can access
that router from this hook use router
which is coming from next slash router
and the router does have this push
method on it where we can just pass in
string URLs and we can redirect the user
to wherever we would like and we're just
grabbing that Community ID from the URL
from router.query so we're just
stripping this particular piece of the
URL and just as a reminder it is called
Community ID because we gave it that
name in this Dynamic route down here
and just before this we are just doing a
quick check to see if you are logged in
before we redirect you to that page
because the only one authenticated users
to go to the submit page and so if I
click on this we'll notice that the
router works it takes us to the actual
submit URL if you recall we did Define
this page a while ago uh the submit.tsx
file there's nothing in here so that is
what this error is from so we're going
to just quickly come up with a component
here there's not going to be any props
so we can just get rid of this and then
I'm just going to rename this component
to be uh submit post page just like that
and I'll just make the text temporarily
submit page and we're going to work on
this page next we are going to be using
the router in the future parts of the
build so I wanted to cover how it
actually works so I hope that makes
sense and now we can actually start
working on the submit page and build out
the form for users to start creating
posts all right you guys let's start
working on the submit page this is
probably one of the most exciting parts
of the entire build because we're going
to get into the actual post creation
logic okay so let's go to our demo here
and this is what we're going to be
creating so we have a post form and then
we have our about component here which
we're going to create after we get the
post functionality working to handle the
overall layout of this page we can reuse
our page content layout component that
we created because we can again see that
we have this left hand side right hand
side layout here so let's come to our
submit page and let's actually use that
page content component and as you recall
all we need to do here is just give this
thing two fragments one for the left and
one for the right and it will handle all
of the layout styling and responsiveness
for us so inside of our left content on
this page this is where we are going to
actually have this new post form right
that's going to be one of the components
inside of the left and then inside of
the right here we're going to have our
about component which are going to
create after in addition to the new post
form we do have this Ted block here that
to post so let's create that so in this
left fragment we can do we can move this
down and above here is where we're going
to actually create this title we're
going to use a box component as its
parent container and we can import this
from Chakra and we are not using a
flexbox because we do not need Flex
styling here so we're just using an
ordinary box and inside of here we're
going to have the text create a post
and let's come back to our app so we can
see what we're doing here and actually
I'm going to remove these really ugly
looking borders because I don't know
about you but I am definitely done
looking at those
foreign
so we can close this and now we can see
that we have that title there so let's
just apply some simple styles to our box
component here so we're going to give it
a padding of 14 pixels on the top and
bottom zero pixels left and right
I'm going to give it a border bottom of
one pixel solid and the Border color is
going to just be white
all right and that is that we are done
with this okay and now we can actually
start creating this new post form so
let's go into our components folder and
we're going to create a new folder in
here called posts because we're going to
create a series of post-related
components our first of those components
is going to be this new post form
Newport farm.tsx
and let's use our snippet so we are
going to take in some props here in a
bit and I'm trying to leave this blank
for now let's come back to our submit
file and actually import this and use
the real component itself all right so
we are going to build our form to be
nice and modular clean components so
that it's very easy to read and
extendable so we basically just have
this stateful nav bar here and then for
each nav item we have an Associated
component for example for post we have
these text inputs for images and video
we have this uploading component and
we're not going to work on these
features here because if I were to build
on this tutorial would be massively long
plus these two are a lot more
interesting but feel free to add these
to your project these would be great
exercises after building these other two
you're going to have a really strong
understanding of how this form actually
works and it would be a really good
exercise to build these on top of it so
let's come back to our app and let's
actually start building out the
structure of this component so the
outermost container of our form is going
to be a flexbox let's import this from
Chakra and this is going to have a
direction of column
we're going to give it a background of
white
a border radius
of 4 and a margin top of two now the
first component inside of this Flex box
is going to be another effects box and
this is going to represent our nav bar
nav bar has five items in it it has post
images and video and these other three
so we're going to do is we're going to
create a static array outside of our
component that is going to be an array
of tab items and each tab item is going
to have a piece of text and an icon and
this is kind of the typical way to
create multi-tab navigation so we're
going to create this outside of the
functional component because it is a
static variable it is not really react
related so we can put it outside so we
can create the array called form tabs
and this is going to be an array of
objects and each object is going to have
a title
and an icon so for example the first one
is going to be post and for the icons
I'm just going to grab the imports from
my project and paste them in here so
make sure you have these imported as
well the icon for post
is going to be IO document text
second nav item is images
and video the icon for this is going to
be i o image outline
the third nav item
has the text link and the icon for This
is BS link 45 degree
the fourth one is poll and the icon is
bi Pole
and the very last one is talk
and this one has BS mic
perfect now down here we are going to
actually map through these tab items and
for each one
they're going to return some sort of
HTML and then HTML is going to be its
own component called tab item and we're
going to define the tab item component
in another file for each tab item
component we're going to be passing a
single tab item from our array as a prop
so we actually want to create a type
for our tab items so we're going to say
export type tab item
as we saw a tab item has a title of type
string and the icon has kind of a weird
type it is type of the chakra icon
dot arguments if you recall when we
create icons it has this as prop here
and it accepts a type of Icon and so
this is actually what the type of these
icons are perfect so let's actually
create that component inside of posts
we're going to create tab item dot TSX
use our snippet
and this is going to accept a prop and
that prop is going to be of type tab
item and why doesn't that want to import
tab item
there we go and we can grab that from
our prop tier all right so now if I take
that item
and I just return the title let's come
back over here and rather than just
returning this fragment let's return
our newly created tab item and this
thing is expecting a prop of type tab
item so we can pass in the item let's
come back to our app over here and we
can see that we are getting the titles
of those tab items but they look
terrible so we have some work to do on
the CSS but at least you're getting
submitted in there now something else
you'll notice about this navbar that is
really important is that we need to know
which one we are currently clicked on
because the Styles change and it also
changes which components we're actually
seeing in the form so we're going to
need some form of state to actually
track which tab item is currently
selected so I'm going to create a state
variable called select a tab
and the setter function is going to be
set selected Tab and this is just going
to be local state so we can just use the
use statehub and the default one we just
want to be this post one here which is
going to be form item tabs at index 0.
that is the initial value of state so we
can say form tabs at index 0 and we're
actually just going to use the text for
our selected State and I'm just going to
close our nav on the side so we have
more room so now we actually have a way
of detecting which one is selected
because when we iterate through them we
can pass in a prop called selected which
is going to be a Boolean which
represents if this particular tab item
is the currently selected one that
Boolean is going to be the result of the
statement that this particular item's
title is equal to the currently selected
tab State so if the current one we're
iterating through is the one that's
selected then this is going to be true
so only one of these is going to have
selected being true at a single time
because we can only have one selected
tab item so inside of tab item we now
need to accept that as a prop so we can
say selected Boolean
grab that from here and we're going to
use that to apply that conditional
styling cool let's come back to our app
here and let's start working on the
structure of our nav items so basically
each nav item is going to be represented
by a flexbox and inside of the flexbox
we're going to have another flexbox
which is going to be the parent
container of the icon and each tab item
is going to have the icon of the item
that's being passed dot icon and
underneath this you're just going to
have some text
and that text is just going to be item
dot title perfect so now we're actually
seeing those icons show up there okay
and this icon container we're going to
give it an align items of Center and a
height of 20 pixels and a margin right
of two and this text here we're going to
give a font size of 10 points so it's
going to be a little bit smaller there
let's actually work on this parent
container now which is where all of this
conditional styling is going to go using
the selected State all right so on this
outermost container we're going to say
justify Center and align
Center so that we're centering
everything inside of the nav item we're
going to give it a flex grow of one so
that they all take up an even amount of
space
we're going to apply a padding of 14
pixels top and bottom zero pixels left
and right and we want to make the cursor
pointer
because this thing is clickable okay and
our hover styling is going to just have
a background of gray 50. as you can see
now when I hover over these things we're
starting to get some Dynamic stuff going
on here let's actually use the selected
state to apply this conditional styling
so the color of the text is going to
change depending on if you're selected
or not if we are selected the color is
going to be blue 500 and if you're not
it's going to be gray 500 the Border
width is also going to change if we are
selected and we're going to give four
parameters to the Border width here one
for the top right bottom and left so
it's going to be 0 pixels one pixel 2
pixel
zero pixels if we are selected and if
you are not selected you're going to
have 0 pixels one pixel 1 pixel 0 pixel
the next style is going to be border
bottom color
and our border bottom color is going to
change depending on if we are selected
if we are selected we are going to have
a border bottom of blue 500 if we are
not it's going to be gray 200 okay we're
starting to see some stuff up here on
the UI there the border right color is
going to be gray 200. okay and that is
all of the CSS we're going to add here
the very last thing we need to add to
this flexbox is just a non-click
function and that on click function
needs to toggle the selected state so
that we're actually selecting the one
that we click on in order to do that we
need access to the set selected function
defined up here so you're going to pass
that as a prop as well so as a third
prop to each tab item we're going to
pass the function set selected tab
and it's going to be equal to set
selected Tab and then inside of tab item
you just have to add that to our tab
item props so we can say set selected
tab so this function is going to take in
an argument of type string because we
are sending it a title of the particular
tab item that we clicked on and it's
going to return void so now we just need
to set this as a prop here
and then down here add that as an on
click function so we can say set
selected Tab and pass in our item dot
title
okay so now if I click on these things
you can see that we're actually toggling
the state and the conditional stylings
are being applied and actually one thing
I did miss in these Styles here is just
the font weight and we're going to make
this 700 so that makes it look nice and
bold okay so we are completely done with
this tab item component we are going to
close this and come back into our new
post form alright guys let's continue on
with our post form I'm going to collapse
these form tabs so they are not in our
way and actually we can make the type of
this I don't know why I didn't do this
before let's make the type of that an
array of tab items all right so inside
of our component here I'm going to
define the three sort of core functions
that are going to be used and that
really make up our post form so the
first one is going to be the one
actually responsible for creating a post
so I'm going to call it handle create
post and it's going to be asynchronous
the second one is going to be on select
image and this is going to be the
function that actually handles what
happens when a user selects a particular
image from their operating system and
puts it into our post form and then the
third one is going to be on text change
which is going to be pretty much the
exact same as those on change functions
that we created in our login form and
sign up form that just handle what
happens when a user types into a text
field okay so these are the three
functions that are going to govern this
entire component and this is the one
that actually is going to create the
post and send it to Firebase but in
order to send a post to our database
we're going to need some content in that
post which is where these two functions
come into play all right at the very top
here I'm also going to create some state
for our text input and the two inputs
that a post contains is a title and a
body all right so I'm going to call this
text inputs and set text inputs
and then we're going to set this equal
to use State and inside of here like I
just said we're going to have a title
we're going to initialize as an empty
string and a post body which is also
going to be empty and then under here
I'm going to define the state that is
going to represent the actual selected
file for the image that the user
selected so we can create a state
variable called selected file and then
set selected
file
and this is going to be used state
and the type of this selected file is
going to be of type string it's going to
represent the actual name of the file or
the thing that we would use as the
source of the image and we're going to
Define some more State variables in a
bit but these are the core ones required
for creating a post and these are the
functions that we're going to use so the
next component that we're going to
create is going to be our text inputs
like these inputs over here so let's
come back to our app and start building
this all right so underneath our navbar
Flex container we're going to create
another Flex container which is going to
represent the container of all the other
components displayed in the form so our
first component inside of here is going
to be those text inputs so I'm going to
call this text inputs and I'll comment
that out okay and let's go create this
text inputs component so inside of our
posts folder here I'm going to create
another folder called post form and
inside of that folder I'm going to
create text inputs
dot TSX and use our snippet and this is
going to take in some props but we will
Define that after we have built out the
HTML for it
so the text inputs are going to be a
stack component from Chakra and just as
a reminder stack is just a flexbox with
the direction of column and then handles
the spacing for us and we're going to
space out our inputs with a value of
three and we're going to make the width
of this 100 so that it takes up the
entire container and essentially all
that's going to be in here are going to
be two text inputs and then the button
to actually create the post so one of
those inputs is going to be an actual
input from Chakra and the second input
for the text body is going to be a text
area component from Chakra so it's a
little bit larger than just a regular
input and then underneath that we're
going to have a container for our button
so we can just put that in here for now
just like this and this button is going
to say post that's the button they're
actually going to click on to create a
post and we just need to import Flex
from Chakra here now that we have
something defined let's come back to our
new post form and bring this thing in
import from text inputs
and we have the new form displayed there
it doesn't look very good but we will
make that a lot better right now and
we're going to give this Flex container
here a padding of four just to make it
look nice and clean there now let's go
in here and work on the styling of these
inputs and they pretty much have the
exact same style length we just need to
write out the Styles once and then we
can just paste them for the other one
all right so the name of this input is
going to be title because it's the title
of our post the value is going to be
coming from our props from that text
input state that I created but we'll
come back to that our on change is also
going to be coming from our props so I
will also come back to that our font
size is going to be 10 point
our border radius is going to be what we
always use for and then our placeholder
for this is going to be the text title
all right and I'm just going to comment
these out for now because it was
complaining there okay and let's apply
our pseudo class styling so our
placeholder we're going to give a color
of gray 500 we're going to apply Focus
styling so when the user actually clicks
on this thing what does it look like
we're going to give it an outline of
none a background of white
a border of one pixel solid and a border
color of black
nice so if I click on that we can see
that that is what it looks like that
looks super clean nice and that is it
for our styling so I'm just going to
copy these and paste them down on our
text area because we're doing the exact
same styling down here
let's just change the placeholder of
this to be
I forgot what the placeholder is
actually what is it text optional
and that is indeed what it does say on
Reddit because I think you only need a
title which is kind of weird in my
opinion and the last thing is that we
just need a name here and that is going
to be body and just as a reminder these
names are required because we need them
inside of our on change function in
order for that function to know which
part of the state to update okay and
actually one last thing I've got to this
text area is just a simple height of 100
pixels just make it a little taller than
it is by default all right now let's
come down to our button and on Reddit
the button is sort of over here so we
can do that with our Flex container and
we can just give it a property of
justify and we can say flex and then
I'll move it over there and on our
button we're going to give this a height
of 34 pixels heading of 0 pixels 30
pixels we're going to add some disabled
State here because we're going to
disable the button if the user has not
put a post title and then on click when
the user actually wants to post this
post what is going to happen this is was
going to call our create post function
okay and I guess it will not allow us to
just have this empty so I'll just say
disable false for now
perfect and that is it for the layout of
this form so all we need to do now is
just add the on change function to these
two inputs so that we actually have some
text being put into our new post so
let's come up here and let's define the
props that we're actually going to take
in to this component so the first prop
is actually going to be our text input
State and this is going to be an object
with two parameters and the first one is
going to be the title type string body
is also going to be string so this is
how we can Define types for objects in
the typescript I don't think we've seen
this before so our on change function
for our inputs is going to take in an
event
and the event is going to be of type of
react.change event and the element
producing this change event is going to
be an HTML input element or an html text
area element and this function is just
going to return absolutely nothing so we
can just say that it returns void it's
also going to take in the very critical
function and I'll create post because
that's what our button is going to
actually call and we're going to declare
this as a callback function that returns
nothing and then we are going to also
take in a Boolean for our loading State
okay let's come down here and actually
destructure those props so we can say
text inputs on a change handle create
post and loading
just like that all right then on our
inputs here we can use the on change so
on change is equal to on change same
thing down here for our text area the
value of this title is going to be text
inputs
dot title and the value of our text area
is going to be
it's a text area sorry text inputs dot
body
perfect and this is not happy I think
because we are not passing in any props
from our parent yet that is why this is
complaining okay so let's actually pass
those in all right so our text input
prop is going to be equal to the text
input State variable handle create post
is going to be equal to handle create
post on change is going to be equal to
our on text change function save that so
it formats and the last thing we're
going to take in is our loading state
which we have not defined yet so I'm
just going to say false
we will Define this when we actually
build out this handle create post
function okay so we actually have our
form being displayed now and now let's
toggle the visibility of this component
using our selected tab State okay so we
only want to show this component if our
selected tab state is equal to post
so only show this if we are currently on
the post tab so if I come here we're not
going to show it we're going to show the
image upload component and this is
really cool this is how you can create
sort of multi-tab components using state
so let's work on this on text Gene
function because it is something we have
seen before I'm going to copy the input
type from our text inputs file paste it
in here
okay save that to a formats in this
function I'm going to de-structure all
of the values that we need off of our
event so the way we can do that is we
can strip the Target off of it and then
instead of the target we can destructure
the name and the value
perfect so now we have the name of the
inputs that produce this event and we
actually have the value that the user
has created by typing into the input now
we just need to update our state by
saying set text inputs
take the previous value of State
spread it and then only update the field
that produces event and that is going to
be at field name and we want to set it
to a value all right so now if I come to
my react extension here and I inspect
this form
let's open this up a bit so text inputs
we can see that we have this form State
here body title there empty if I start
typing in here
that is changing so down here hey this
is a nice post perfect so our state is
working for our text inputs and we might
as well Define that loading state that
we are going to need in just a little
bit so we'll say set loading is equal to
use State we will initialize it as false
come down here pass that to our text
inputs component and then we will come
into here and use that properly for our
button our button is going to have
loading state that is going to be equal
to that loading crop
and then now that we have our text
inputs we could say disable this button
if there is no title inside of our text
inputs and then our on click is going to
be handle create post okay so we are
completely done with this component so
we can close this and now we can start
working on the image uploading component
which I think is really exciting I love
working on image functionality so if we
come over to our demo here and we come
over to that tab we can see that it's a
relatively simple component we just have
a box and this button on the inside that
says upload and if I click on this it
just opens up our file system and I can
select an image and it will display a
preview of the image and then we can
either just go back to the post for the
text inputs or we can just remove this
image to select a new one same exact
flow as Reddit all right so let's start
building this out let's come back to our
app here this component is going to be a
sibling of our text inputs component
here so let's come into our directory
and create inside of post form a new
component called image upload.tsx
famous old snippet so we are going to
take in some props I will leave the
blank for now though let's get the
actual structure of this component built
out and then we can worry about the
props so I'm going to close my directory
so as usual we're going to use a flexbox
for our outermost container here and we
want to Center everything inside of this
container so we're going to give it a
justify equal to Center and a line equal
to Center as well and we're going to
make the width 100 so that it takes up
the entire width and I'm going to put
the text image uploaded here and then
let's go back to our new post form and I
think I'm getting a react key error here
yeah react key and the reason that is is
because I am forgetting to pass a unique
key to our tab item components here this
is just a requirement of react when you
do map through an array and return a
component we do need to pass each
component a unique key and that should
make that uh that error go away in the
future all right so let's come down here
beneath our text inputs and we can use
our selected tab State again except this
time we want to check if the selected
tab is equal to images and video
and if it is we want to show our new
image upload component
just like that so now if we come over
here we should see that there let's come
back into here and build the rest of
this out all right so let's handle the
case where there is no image selected
yet we are going to bring in an image as
a prop and we will do some conditional
rendering to display that image if it
exists but let's get that upload button
working okay so inside of this flexbox
we're going to have another flexbox and
this is actually where our button is
going to go so let's import a button
from Chakra
and this is going to say upload and on
this button container flexbox we're also
going to make the justify equal to
Center and align Center as well we're
going to give us a padding of 20 so that
it gives it a nice height of the
container there and we're going to give
this a border of one pixel dashed it's a
dashed order and the Border color is
going to be gray 200 and then let's make
the width of this container equal to 100
so that it spans the entire thing and
then we can just add a border radius
of four so it's nice and rounded there
awesome that looks super clean our
button is going to be the outline
variant variant is equal to outline and
we want to give it a height of 28
pixels
and we will have an on click on this
thing in just a second as well so let's
create that here as just an empty
function so what needs to happen when
the user actually clicks on this button
is it does need to open up the file
system like I was showing before and it
needs to prompt the user to actually
select a file so in order to do that we
cannot just use a regular button we need
to also use an input element and make
the type of that input element file and
that way it is automatically going to
know to open up the file system for the
user to select the file so that's going
to look like this we're going to have an
input
and that input is going to be of type
file so if I save this we automatically
get this button that says choose file
and no file chosen so you can see that
if I choose a file here and I select
this image you can see that it displays
the file name here but we don't want to
show this input it's kind of ugly and we
already have a button that we want to
actually do that same functionality and
so what we can do is actually hide this
input and then have this button click on
this input sort of behind the scenes
it's kind of cool and the way we can do
that is by using the use ref Hook from
react okay so let's come to the top of
our component and let's create a new
variable called selected file ref and
this is where we're actually going to
bring in the use ref Hook from react so
you can store any value inside of the
selected file ref however it is
typically used to store HTML elements in
it so that we can manipulate and
interact with these HTML elements in
certain use cases it's a kind of lesser
used hook I don't use it super often but
it does come in handy for situations
like this so what we can do is we come
down to our input here and we can make
the value of these input ref to that
selected file graph and this is going to
complain and it's going to say that the
types do not match up so we can come up
here and we can fix that we can make the
type of this ref HTML input element
because that is the value we're storing
in this graph and then we can initialize
it as a null and that should make this
happy and very conveniently the input
element has a property called hidden we
can just pass that as a prop and it'll
just make it disappear but it's still
there it's just not being displayed so
the reason that this is going to be
helpful in our case is that because we
are storing this input inside of a file
ref here we can interact with this input
using this ref variable and this will
make more sense as I actually write out
this function here so in this on click
what we want to do is implicitly click
on that input which will actually open
up the file system
so the way we can do that is we can pass
in this callback here and this callback
is going to interact with that selected
file ref dot current and Dot current is
just the current value of this ref then
we want to actually click on that HTML
element here and just to rewind a second
there we can see all of the available
methods on an HTML element and we can
interact with it without actually kind
of interacting with it so it's pretty
cool and they do come in handy sometimes
so here we want to use click okay so now
when I click on this button the button
is going to go click I'm using
quotations with my hands right now on
this input element which is kind of cool
so check this out so if I click on this
that opens up the file system and that
is super cool we are we are implicitly
clicking on this input so now that we
actually have an input to accept a file
from the user what do we actually do
with that file when it has been selected
and how do we do something useful with
it which in our case is throwing it in
state and then displaying a preview of
that image on the screen for the user so
in the same way that text inputs have an
on change function that triggers every
single time the user actually types a
key file inputs also have a non-change
function but this one triggers once a
file has been selected and also with
text inputs we grab the value that the
user has typed using the event that the
input generates and in this case it's
the exact same thing we can grab the
file that the user selects from the
event that triggers from the file input
and this is where that on select image
function is going to come into play this
is the function that we're going to pass
to this input on change function so
we're going to say on change is equal to
our on select image we haven't passed
this as a prop yet but this is the idea
so when the user selects a file that on
select image function is going to be
triggered and we're going to take that
file from the change event and do some
processing with it and sort in state so
that is the idea so let's just leave
this blank for now I'm just going to
leave this as a empty function here for
now and let's go back to our new post
form so inside of this function we are
still going to take in an event and this
event is still going to have the same
type as the text input change event and
we're going to say that the thing that
generates this event is of type HTML and
development same exact thing as the text
change all right and let's just take a
closer look at this event for a second
here so typically what we're used to is
grabbing the value off of this event
from text inputs but the target as we
can see also has a property called files
so this is how we're actually going to
access the file that the user has
selected so I'm just going to remove
this for a sec so what we need to do is
actually read the data from this file
and kind of process it and convert it to
a form that is going to be useful to us
and the way we're going to do that is
we're going to create a variable called
reader and this reader is going to be a
new file reader and this is a class
provided by JavaScript and it is used in
cases like this for file uploading and
to actually read the data from files so
the first thing we're going to do is
check that there is an actual valid file
that we can read data from and the way
we're going to do that is by again
accessing the event.target.files but the
value of this is actually going to be an
array because the input is actually
built to accept multiple files in our
case we're only uploading one so this is
only going to be an array of one element
but you could upload many if you would
like so what we want to do is grab the
value at the first index of this array
and we're just going to do some optional
chaining here to avoid accessing an
undefined array and inside of this if
statement is where we're actually going
to read the data from that file using
our reader so we're going to do is we're
going to say reader dot read as data URL
and we're going to pass this function
the actual file that the user uploaded
just like this and we do not need
optional chaining here because this if
statement already checks that this is a
valid value so typescript knows that if
we make it inside of this if statement
this is a valid value so once the reader
has finished processing this file and
this method completes we want to take
that result and actually sort in state
because that is going to be the actual
image that we can display on the screen
and that we're going to store in our
database on our post
so the reader has an event listener
called on load and this is going to
trigger once this read as data method
completes and we can create a callback
function that is going to be executed
when this event happens so this on load
event is going to emit what is called a
reader event and we can take that meter
event and actually extract the result of
the loaded file and store it in state so
inside of this function we're going to
say if reader event dot Target dot
result so we're saying is there a valid
result if there is let's set our
selected file to be that selected result
event.target.result
and as we can see typescript is not
happy here and it is saying that type
string or array buffer is not assignable
to type string or undefined and the
reason this is happening is like I was
saying before how the input is built to
accept multiple inputs so the result
could technically be a single file or an
array of files and in our case we are
just going to only ever have one so I'm
just going to Typecast this three string
and that should satisfy typescript and
that is it for this function here so
what we can do now is pass this function
as a prop to our image upload component
but first let's go into our image upload
component and just kind of Define all of
the props that we're going to accept in
here so the first prop that we're going
to select is going to be the actual
selected file and it's going to be of
type string as we just saw and we want
to make this optional because the user
may or may not select the file so it's
not always going to be defined so the
second prop is going to be that on
select image function and we saw that it
took in an event of type
react.changevent
change event and this takes in an
argument of type HTML input element and
it does not return anything so void the
third prop is going to be our set
selected tab function and that is
because after user uploads an image we
show them that back to post button that
returns them to the post tab so we need
to be able to toggle the tab State in
here as well so this takes in a value of
type string and does not return anything
and as a last prop we are going to
accept set selected file and that is so
that the user can clear select a file
state and select a new one if they
choose and this is going to accept a
value of type string and we do not
return anything so void so that's it for
our props so let's actually come down
here in the component and destructure
those so selected file on select image
set selected Tab and set selected file
perfect now we actually need to pass
these props into our component so let's
come over here so our first one is going
to be the selected file this is going to
be selected file we're going to do on
select on select image
is going to be equal to on select image
third one is going to be set selected
tab
this is equal to set selected tab last
one set selected file
perfect just like that and look at how
clean this component is it just is
satisfying to look at it's so modular
okay let's go into our image upload
component here and for our on change on
that file input let's actually pass it
that on select image function let's see
what happens to our state here when we
actually select a file so new post form
so this is our state here we can see
that for the file state there is nothing
there it is undefined so what happens
when I actually select a file
okay so there was a little bit of delay
there as it was loading the data you can
see that it's storing
this ginormous
piece of data in our file state and so
this is what we can actually pass to an
HTML image to render that image on the
screen so just to show you that very
quickly if I create an image component
here and I pass in the source
and the source is going to be selected
file
let's see what happens we can actually
see that the image is being displayed
there so it is actually taking this
ginormous thing and and is able to
interpret it as that image and now all
we have to do is just make some styling
improvements to this component and then
we will be able to work on that handle
create post function so inside of our
image upload component we basically just
want to check for the existence of the
selected file meaning that the user has
indeed selected a file and if it exists
let's just display that image and if it
does not we will want to display this
upload button here so it's going to be
quite simple all we need to do is just
add a ternary operator
inside of here and we're going to say if
there is a valid selected file let's
show we're going to show the image which
is going to be in Phoenix right in here
otherwise let's just show this thing
that we have already created which is
going to be this flexbox here just have
to adjust this a little bit
just like that so now inside of this
fragment we're actually going to put
that image in here and those buttons
that allow the user to clear the image
State and then go back to the post tab
the first component is going to be an
image from Chakra
and the source of that image is going to
be the selected file itself
just like that and I'm going to upload
an image here so that we can actually
see what we're doing perfect so we have
the image selected there and on this
image we're going to set a Max width of
400 pixels and a Max height of also 400
pixels because we don't want the image
to be too too large if the user uploads
a super big one and underneath this
image here we're going to add a stack
component from Chakra and this is where
those two buttons are going to go so
we're going to make the direction of
this row because stack is by default
column Direction and the default spacing
for a stack is 2 which is going to work
here so we don't really need to modify
the spacing and our stack is just going
to have two buttons inside of it so just
like this and our first button is going
to say back to post and the second
button is going to say
remove as in remove that image from
state so that they can select a new one
all right so let's style these buttons
so the height of this first button is
going to be 28 pixels and on click we
want to call
that set selected
tab function that we passed in as a prop
and we want to pass this the post title
so that it actually takes us back to the
post tab so if I click on this now it
will take us back here perfect and let's
just make sure that we have a
directional column on this outermost
Flex container
there we go and on our stack here we're
going to add some margin top and this is
going to be 4 so that it kind of adds
some space between the image and the
buttons the second button is going to be
our outline variant
also going to have a height of 28 pixels
and then on click for this one all we
need to do is empty out that selected
file state so we can say set selected
I don't know why I'm not getting
autocomplete set selected file to be an
empty string just like that
okay awesome this looks great so now if
I click remove
the file is removed from State and the
user can select a different one and then
once they select an image and they like
it they can go back to the post and this
back to post button is kind of
unnecessary because they can just you
know technically go back to here but uh
just for improved user experience I
think that's why Reddit put it here to
make it more intuitive like oh okay I'm
gonna go back to the post because that
is actually where I can post this post
awesome so we are completely done with
this image uploading component we can
close it and start to work on the actual
Logic for creating this post and sending
it to the database because we can take
in text inputs we can take in an image
we are ready to actually store these
things in the database all right you
guys let's start writing out this handle
create post function so let's talk about
the series of steps that is going to
happen inside of this function so the
first thing that is going to happen is
that we're going to construct our new
post object
and we're going to make this of type
post and we have not created this type
yet but we will do that in just a few
minutes the second thing that we're
going to do is actually store the post
in our database in our posts collection
the third thing that we're going to do
is check and see if the user has decided
to include an image with their post
which will mean that there will be a
truthy value for this selected file and
so what we'll do if they have selected a
file is actually take this image and go
and store it in our Firebase storage
which is actually separate from our
database storage and database are two
separate things and if you recall from
our client app file we did Define this
storage instance here but we have not
yet used it so this is going to be the
first look at that we're going to
actually see how to store media content
okay so if there is a file we will go
and store in storage and this is going
to be done using some Firebase functions
and one of those functions is going to
be this get download URL function so
this function is actually going to
conveniently return a URL to that image
and that is the thing that we want to
store on our post document in our
database and you might be wondering well
didn't we already store the post in the
database why did we do this image
uploading after creating the post if we
need this image URL on our post and that
is a very good question the reason is is
that we want to ensure that a post has
successfully been created and stored in
our database before actually uploading
that Associated image into our storage
because if we did it in the reverse
order and we uploaded the image first
there is a chance that there could be
some sort of error in actually creating
the post itself and if that does happen
we just now have this kind of random
image in our storage with no post that
it belongs to so this is why we kind of
create the post first once it has been
successfully created then update it with
this image URL so the third step then
would be to update the postdoc by adding
the image URL and the very very last
thing I'm going to do is just simply
redirect the user back to the
Community page
I'm back on the Community page there is
going to be a component called posts
which we are going to create very
shortly and that component is going to
be responsible for actually going to the
database getting all of the posts in the
current community and then actually
storing them in state and then actually
rendering them and so that is how we're
going to see our newly created post
let's tackle step one of this function
and that is actually creating our new
post object that we are going to store
in our database and as I mentioned in
this comment this is going to be of type
post but we do not have that yet so we
do need to Define it and while we are
doing that we are also going to create
our post atom for our recoil State
because we're going to need it across
multiple pages so let's go into our
atoms folder and inside of here I'm
going to create a new file called post
atom.ts
so let's go ahead and import Adam from
recoil
and here we're going to Define our type
for our post and what I'm going to do is
actually open up our demo here so we can
actually see all of the data that is
displayed on the post and that is going
to help us create the type for this post
okay so the most important thing is it's
going to have an ID of type string it is
going to also have a community ID so
that we know what community it belongs
to also type string we're going to store
the Creator ID so the user who actually
created this post and we are also going
to store the creators display name
is going to have a title of type string
it's going to have a body a type string
lots of strings and we're also going to
sort the number of comments that this
post has because we can see that down
here we are displaying that data here so
we do need to include it on our post and
that is going to be a number we are
going to store the vote status so the
number of uploads are down both this
thing has and that is going to be a
number it is going to have a optional
image URL because they are not mandatory
for creating posts and lastly we're
going to add the created add timestamp
and this is going to be up type
timestamp from Firebase so make sure
that import that top there okay and
actually one last thing I forgot up here
is the community image URL and this is
going to be optional as well because we
have not yet built this in and we're
including this because you can see on
each post that we do have that little
image for the community that that post
is a part of so that should be it for
our post type now let's create a
typescript interface to actually model
what our actual what post date is going
to look like so the first parameter in
here is going to be selected post and
this is going to be used when we
actually do single page view of posts so
when a user clicks on a post it's going
to store that post in its selected post
the second parameter is going to be all
of the posts that are part of our
community so when we go to Community
page we are going to store all of those
posts in this stage here and it's also
going to start the posts that appear on
our home page we're going to come back
here and add a parameter called post
votes and we're going to add this in
when we build in the voting
functionality and as usual we need our
default State value so I'm going to call
this default Post State and this is
going to be up type post date
and we're going to initialize
selected post to the null
and posts are going to be an empty array
and now all we have to do is create the
actual post date recoil atom so post
date is equal to atom inside of here
we're going to give this a key of Post
State and our default value is going to
be default host date and then we can
pass in the type of the state by passing
that in here
so this atom is of type post date okay
perfect this is all we need for now
we're going to come back in a bit and
add this voting functionality but for
now we have everything that we need so
now we can actually import this type
from that file if it's going to pick it
up there we go
since our posts are going to contain
actual user data we do need access to
the currently login user so what I'm
going to do is actually come back to our
submit page and grab the user in here
and pass it as a prop to run your post
form and the reason I'm doing it up here
is because we're going to use it in here
for some other reasons as well so we're
going to say cons user is equal to use
auth State pass it our auth object and
then in our new post form we are going
to pass that as a prop
user is equal to a user awesome then
inside of new post form we can declare
that prop up here
so we can say user and it's going to be
of type user from Firebase auth and if
you remember we also need to include the
type of null because it is initialized
as null as well as undefined so we can
make this optional and this should
satisfy typescript over here and we also
saw that our post needs the community ID
that is being created in so we're going
to need to grab that somehow as well and
we're going to get that from the router
using the use router hook like we saw
already so let's come up to the top here
and grab the router so Contour router is
equal to use router from next router and
now inside of our handle create post
function we can destructure the
router.query object and grab that
Community ID from it and let's just
accept our user as a prop here and now
we actually have all of the data
necessary to actually create a valid
post and tie it to all the proper
entities like the user and the community
all right let's actually populate this
new post object now so we're going to
store our community ID in there that we
just grabbed off the router our creator
ID is going to be our user.uid our
creator display name is going to be the
same thing we did in our drop down menu
over here when we did that splitting of
the email to kind of grab this display
name type thing so that's going to be
user dot email dot split
we want to split at the at sign in the
email and then grab the first index of
that split array the typescript compiler
is not happy here and this is basically
having to do with the way we declared
our user type up here so I'm just going
to change the type of this a bit to make
our lives a bit easier with typescript
so what I'm going to do is always
declare this user as type user and we're
going to be able to safely do this
because we're going to come back to our
submit file and wrap this in a condition
and not even show this component until
there is a truthy valid user from this
hook so that is how we're actually
safely able to pass this user as a valid
user we are still getting some here
though so we can remove this optional
chaining and then since we do know that
there is going to be a valid user
because we are not even showing this
component unless there is I'm just going
to add the bang operator here and this
bang operator in typescript is our way
of telling the typescript compiler that
we know for sure that this is going to
be a valid value so it is safe to
proceed and then this error up here has
to do with the router being a string or
an array of strings or undefined but
since in our case we are only going to
have a single non-array string and we
are going to assume it is not undefined
I'm going to change the value of this
and just Typecast the community ID from
the router to be up type string to
satisfy the typescript compiler this is
actually better I prefer to have this
always as a user and then just kind of
protect against even showing that
component uh without even having a valid
user so I think that's just a bit more
safe sorry that was a bit of a
typescript tangent that we had to go on
there but it was a grid lesson now the
next part of our post is going to be our
title and this is going to be from text
inputs dot title our body is going to be
text inputs.body and we can initialize
the number of comments to be zero
because all new posts have zero comments
and the vote status is also going to be
zero all we're missing is our created at
timestamp and to do that we can call
that server timestamp function from
firestore and this is basically
complaining because as the server
timestamp function is only available on
the actual firestore servers we don't
really have access to it on the client
so that is why typescript is kind of
freaking out here and we could
technically create our own custom type
to match what is created on the
firestore server and put all these
fields on it but we can also just as a
simpler solution just Typecast this to a
timestamp from firestore so do make sure
that Imports up top here
all right let's actually move to step
two of this function which is going to
be actually storing this in our database
and this is where we're actually going
to start writing some asynchronous code
so I'm going to create a try catch block
to help us with our error handling so if
an error occurs we were going to log
candle create post error log the error
and then make this of type any
and actually I just want to see the
message of this error
okay so inside of our try block we're
going to create the reference to our
newly created post document so it's
going to be called post doc ref and this
is going to be the result of our add doc
function from firestore and we need to
tell it what collection we want to write
our new document to so we can pass in
the collection function this is going to
take in our firestore object from our
client app file and the name of the
collection that we want to write to is
posts now as a second argument we can
just pass in the data that we want to
write into this document which is going
to be new post okay now let's get into
this image processing stuff so let's
bring this up here so we have some good
comments so let's check if there is a
selected file so we can say if there is
a selected file we want to create an
image ref which is going to be a
reference to the image in our Firebase
storage so we can use this function
called ref from Firebase and this is the
function that's actually going to
connect to our storage instance so we
can pass it our storage from client up
and the path at which we want to store
this image is going to be post slash
postdoc ref dot ID and this is actually
how we're tying this image to this
specific post we're actually putting the
ID into the storage path and then slash
image
image source and kind of this posts
image but this is just a reference we
actually need to upload this image and
the way we're going to do that is by
using the upload string function from
Firebase storage we're going to pass it
our image ref and we're going to pass it
the actual thing we are uploading which
is our selected file and so we're
uploading our selected file inside of
our image ref and as a third argument we
need to pass the format of this file and
our reader returned a formatting type of
data URL because we said read as data
URL so that is what the format is for
that and then once that is finished
uploading we need to actually get that
download URL which is going to be the
actual URL that we can use to view this
image which is kind of what I was
referring to up here so let's move these
comments down so check first selected
file store in storage and then we want
to get the download URL and then update
our post so we can create a new variable
called download URL and this is going to
call that function
get download URL which is from Firebase
storage and the thing we want to get the
download URL for is our image ref
now that we actually have a valid image
URL let's update our post document so we
can say await update doc pass in the
document ref that we want to update and
the update that we want to make is to
the field image URL and that value is
going to be download URL
awesome now let's just add our loading
State up here so set loading true and
then at the bottom of the try catch we
can set loading to be false and now what
we need to do is just redirect the user
back to where they came from which is
the community home page so you can call
this function router dot back and that
handles that for us I'm just going to
comment this out for now though so we
can actually kind of analyze the post
creation a bit more while staying on
this page all right I think we are done
writing out this function let's actually
give it a spin and see if we can create
a post and store this image in our
storage all right before we do that we
do need to go in to our firestore
project here in our console and go into
storage and just change the permissions
a bit because if you go into the rules
by default the storage is completely
locked it's saying allowed read write if
false and false is always false so it is
never going to allow you to do this so
I'm just going to change this to True
which is going to allow us to always do
it in all circumstances which is fine
for development we are going to come
back and write some rules in a little
bit so let's go see if we can actually
upload these things we should see a new
folder in here and we also should see a
new collection here called post so let's
come to our form let's create first post
here is the first post
the exclamation points and let's upload
an image as well and this image is going
to be our classic demo image and then
back to the post and let's give it a go
oh what they doing what they're doing
okay so it was loading for a while and
we did not see an error here so let's go
see what happens okay our database let's
refresh this
we can see that yes there is a post
collection very nice new post document
in here awesome and look at this the
image URL is probably the most exciting
thing of all this
um but yeah all that data was stored in
there so this image URL is actually the
thing we can literally type into our
browser and in a new tab and like it
will take us to this image that is so
cool and that is how we're actually
going to display our images on our posts
in our communities very cool and we can
go see the actual image
inside of our storage here if you come
to storage
we can see that there has been a new
folder created called posts because that
is what we gave as our first path
segment here inside a post we're going
to see a folder for that specific post
and then we have stored a file called
image in here and if we click on this we
can see that it gives us a little
preview and very nice this is so cool
this makes posts so much more exciting
because images are just fun and they
make it look really cool and just for
good measure let's try creating a post
without an image so we would redirect
after a successful post so we would be
already back on the Community page right
now so the post form would be clear but
since we kind of commented out the
router here we just have to kind of
manually clear the form I'm just going
to create a new title called
second post and here is the second post
and we do not have an image so let's
give this a go
much faster this time because there's no
image uploading come to our firestore
database posts
you can see that there has been another
post created but this time there is no
image URL which is good so it can handle
both cases just like Reddit awesome so
now we can actually create posts which
is another ginormous piece of
functionality solved and now all we have
to do is go back to the Community page
call the database get those posts and
then actually view them on the screen in
the feed okay guys one last thing I
actually do want to add here as well is
just a quick error component and it's
going to make our app just a little bit
more robust so underneath our loading
State here I'm just going to create the
error State and it's just going to be a
Boolean so we're going to say use State
false and we're just going to use a
Boolean here because we can just put the
string in ourselves in the error message
so inside of our catch block
in the handle create post function we
just need to set error to be true if an
error does occur and we're going to come
to the very bottom of our component here
between these two outermost Flex boxes
and we're going to check if there is an
error and if there is an error we are
going to display some component and that
component is going to be an alert
component from Chakra UI so chakra makes
it super easy to place these really nice
looking alerts here so it's going to
come to the alert docs and grab this one
here then we can just paste it in here
like this add all of the missing Imports
okay and we can save this and see what
this looks like
and we will just make this true so we
can see it okay so that looks kind of
not good so we're just going to get rid
of this close button we don't really
need that we don't really need this
description and I'm going to make this
regular text from Chakra and this is
going to just say error
creating post
perfect so that looks pretty good and
that is all we have to do so let's
change this back to error and yeah now
we are covered for errors for creating a
post so now we are going to go back to
the Community page so let's go to that
index Community ID page and we're going
to create our second left hand side
component which is going to be the
actual post component and that is the
component we're ever going to actually
go and grab all of the posts from the
database and then display them on our
feed for that community and then once we
can actually view posts in the
communities we will then work on this
drop-in menu here so that we can
actually more easily navigate through
communities because right now we kind of
have to go into the URL manually and go
to one that exists so let's create the
actual file for that component and
that's going to go inside of our post
folder here so inside our post I'm going
to create the component posts.tsx
so this is sort of the root of the post
folder then we're going to use our
snippet this component is going to take
in a few props and the first one is
going to be the actual Community data
from its parent which is the index page
of the community and this is going to be
up type community so let's import this
from our communities atom and then we're
also going to take in the user ID and
this is going to need to be optional
because this is not always going to be
defined because the user does not
necessarily have to be authenticated to
view the posts
okay let's change this text to posts and
then come back to our index page here
and actually bring this in from that
file just like that and then we can pass
in our community data as a prop just
like this
perfect so now we actually have our post
there okay and you know what actually
I'm going to actually not take in this
user ID as a prop and I'm probably going
to call the use auth State hook here but
we will worry about that in a bit so
basically uh what's going to happen here
is once this component renders we need
to go actually fetch the post from the
database store those posts in state and
then map through them and then display
each one and we're going to create a
separate component for each individual
post it's going to be called a post item
but for now we can write sort of the
governing logic of this component so the
main function in here is going to be
called get posts and it's going to be
asynchronous because it's going to be
asynchronously talking to our database
and then we're just going to have a user
effect in here as we're going to run as
soon as this component actually mounts
and this is where we're actually going
to go and fetch those posts so right
inside of this as soon as the component
mounts we just want to call get post and
we are going to create a custom hook for
our post as well because we are going to
be sharing a lot of post logic between
pages and components like voting on
posts and deleting posts Etc and
actually just sharing Post State so we
are going to create a hook called use
posts let's get our posts first and then
we will worry about starting the mistake
and this custom Hub stuff that I'm
talking about all right so inside of our
get post function we do want to create a
try catch block to make error handling
much smoother and then up top here we're
going to create some extra States you're
going to have our loading State as usual
set loading is equal to use State and
this is going to be equal to false
initially so in our error block let's
just create a log of a get post error
and you will log the error Dot message
and let's make this type any and what we
want to do in here is literally just get
posts for this community that is it and
this is going to be our first look at an
actual like database query with Firebase
if you go take a look at our post
collection here I know there's only two
of them and they both have the same
Community ID so perhaps not the best
example here but picture a hundred Post
in here all from different communities
the only one to get the post documents
that have a community ID that matches
the community that we're currently in by
the way we can grab that from our
destruction props here and we're going
to use the query function from firestore
to do this so let's come inside of our
try block here and let's create a new
variable here called post query and
we're going to bring in our query
function from firestore the first and
only mandatory argument of this function
is going to be a collection that we
actually want to query so let's create
our collection reference using that
collection firestore function and as
usual we need to pass this our firestore
object from Client app and the
collection saying that we are querying
is posts so you can see that is happy
with just that it will just go get
literally everything in this collection
but we don't want everything in this
collection so we need to pass in some
query specifications here and the first
one is going to be a where Clause so we
need to import where from firestore and
we want all of the posts where Community
ID is equal to the community data's ID
so the parameter that we're actually
interested in is going to be Community
ID
so the second argument is going to be
our operation clause and in our case we
want to check if the community ID is
equal to some value but there's all
sorts of operations you can do in here
but we want to use the equals we want to
graph all of the documents in post where
Community ID is equal to community data
dot ID that is the exact set of
documents that we want and we also want
to just order these documents by a
certain field as well and that field is
going to be our created at field and the
order that we want them in is a
descending so that they are reverse
chronological okay so now that we
actually have a valid query built we can
pass that query to our get docs function
to get all those documents so we can say
postdocs is equal to await get docs and
all we need to pass this is our post
query
okay now we want to actually extract all
of the data from each of those postdocs
and store them in a JavaScript object
that we can actually store in our recoil
State we did something very similar with
our Snippets so it's going to look very
much the same so we're going to say
posts is equal to post docs dot docs
which is an array of all of the actual
firestore document objects we want to
map through all of these and extract the
data and return an actual JavaScript
object with each one's ID so we can say
doc.id and then spread all of the data
inside of that document and this is what
we're going to actually store in our
post State here so let's log what this
looks like so we can see if we are
getting some data
posts okay so our use effect is working
the component is rendering so we should
be seeing this data in our console and
we are getting an error nice okay so
this is where we are going to actually
create our first database index if you
remember when I sort of did the intro on
the cloud firestore I briefly said that
indexes are a way for firestore to
actually efficiently query your data in
order to perform queries we actually do
need and index on that document but it's
extremely easy and firestore handles all
of the heavy lifting all we have to do
is literally click on this link
and all you have to do is literally
click create index
and it's going to have a status of
building for a few minutes it takes a
few minutes for it to Cloud fire starts
to actually do this indexing so give
this a minute and when it is done we
will come back all right you guys we are
now back and this index has a status of
enabled so we should be able to safely
make queries okay so let's refresh this
Community page and see if we can now
successfully see these posts in the
console
okay yeah you can see them here let's
take a look at them so we are getting
the data on the front end here which is
super cool and so these represent all of
the posts inside of this current
Community Chinese group and now we
actually have this data on the front end
so we can store this in our post date
which is going to lead into US creating
this new use post hug that I mentioned
which is going to manage our post date
for us so inside of our hooks directory
here let's come create another one
called use posts dot TSX I love custom
hooks like when I was first learning
react I kind of didn't really understand
the point of them
um
and I was like I just didn't feel like I
had enough knowledge to actually build
custom hooks I just didn't understand
them enough but now I'm actually really
really seeing the um the benefit of them
just to kind of extract repeated logic
that's why I want to give you guys
experience building something with this
project so you can learn how to actually
know when to use a custom mug okay So
eventually in this hook we're going to
have about six or seven State variables
the only one we need right now is our
post date Atom from recoil so we can
bring that in using our reuse recoil
State hook we can say Post State value
and set post date value
is equal to use recoil state
and we want to pass in our post State
Atom from atoms slash post atom I'm
going to close my directory actually so
as far room and if you recall in custom
hooks we do not want to return HTML we
want to return some data and functions
so we're going to wrap all of that stuff
in an object and what's going to go in
there for now is going to be that post
State value as well as our set postate
value and while we're in here I'm going
to create the actual function
declarations for the ones that are going
to be coming so that you can kind of
maybe understand why we're creating this
hook in the first place so the first
function that's going to be in here is
going to be the onboard function
that's going to be used when we actually
vote on post another one is going to be
on select posts when we actually click
on a post and go into single page view
and then another one is going to be cons
on delete post
this is going to be asynchronous
okay and the entire reason we created
this custom Hook is because we are going
to need this data and this functionality
across multiple pages and components so
hopefully that provides some
clarification if you were confused let's
come back to our post component and we
can bring in that data now from our use
post Hook by calling it just like this
and the data we want to bring in for
this component right now is our post
State value as well as set to post a
value
just like this so let's store these
posts in our recoil State and we can do
that with our set Post State value
function and we can take the previous
value of post date
and spread it because we only want to
update a single field and that field is
going to be posts and our updated value
post is going to be the above posts and
we're going to Typecast them to an array
of posts and we can import this type
from our atom file just like this
so now we're actually going to have
access to our posts via this post date
value all right you guys now that our
posts are inside of our recoil atom we
can now create our post item component
and actually start displaying these
posts on the UI so inside of our post
folder I'm going to create another
component called post
item.tsx and use our snippet all right
you guys I'm going to start by declaring
all of the props that are going to take
in to this component because I think it
will help make the building out of the
HTML a lot more clear and intuitive all
right so the very first prop and the
most important prop that this thing is
going to accept is going to be the post
itself so let's bring that in and make
sure you import the type from our post
atom file the second prop I'm going to
take in is going to be called a user is
Creator and this is going to be a
Boolean which represents if the
currently signed in user actually
created this post and is the owner
because if they are we're going to allow
them to do certain things like delete it
the next problem we're going to take in
is going to be the current user's vote
value on this post have they voted on
this post and if they have was it an
upvote or a downvote and we're making
this optional here because it's only
going to exist if this particular user
has actually voted on this particular
post and we are also going to take in
the functions from our use postage hook
because our parent which is post is
going to grab those functions from the
hook and then pass them to this
component and I'm going to just declare
their types as empty callback functions
for now you're going to come back to
these and specify the type definitions
once we actually are passing them in but
for right now we are not so I'm just
going to declare them as empty
so we have our on delete post and we're
just going to have our on select post
just like this okay you can come down
here to our component and actually
destructure our props to grab them
use their vote value on vote on delete
post and then on select post awesome I'm
just going to close my directory so we
have some more room there now what I'm
going to do is paste in all of the icon
imports from react icons for this
component because there there's quite a
few and this is going to be the icons
that we are seeing for like the voting
the uploading the downloading and all of
these like messaging and sharing and
saving icons there are quite a few icons
in this component so I'm just going to
import those from my repo I will put a
link to the uh this component in the
description so you can directly access
it but uh these are them here lines
three to thirteen okay with all of our
props passed let's come down here and
actually start building out the UI for
this component here so the outermost
container of our post is going to be a
flexbox from Chakra and this is going to
have a border of one pixel solid and a
background of white and just so we can
see actually what we're doing here as
we're creating it I'm going to render
the post dot title text here and then
come back to to our post parent here and
inside this div I'm going to just remove
this actually and create a fragment and
then inside of this fragment I'm going
to map through all of the posts and
return for each one a post item let's do
postatevalue dot post dot map and then
we want to take each post item inside of
that array and create a post item
component for each one
and this is complaining because we are
not passing at the required props so
let's pass in all of the required props
and we will need to bring in those on
vote and on delete functions from our
use post hook and I believe I did not
actually put that inside of the return
object here so inside of here I'm just
going to add on vote on select post and
on delete post so that we can actually
access them from our hook so let's go
back to posts
and inside of here let's grab on vote on
delete post and on select post awesome
now down here we have everything we need
to satisfy typescript here so post is
going to be equal to the current item we
are iterating through the next one for
user is Creator we need to check does
the current user's ID match the Creator
ID on the post item so we're going to
need to actually bring in our user here
and if you remember I kind of mentioned
that before with this use offset hook so
we're going to bring them in
cons user is equal to use off State auth
now we can check okay well does this
user's uid equal to this post items
Creator ID
and so this is going to be a Boolean
again that represents whether or not the
currently login user is the owner of
this post user vote value is going to
tie in to that voting functionality
which we do not currently have so I'm
just going to hard code this as
undefined because that is what the value
is actually going to be if they have not
devoted on the post so we're going to
sort of mimic that
the next prop is going to be our ongoing
function on vote is equal to on vote
on a select post is going to be equal to
on select post
and lastly on delete post is equal to on
delete post
and this is complaining here
type void is understandable to type oh
okay so for are on select post function
we do need to specify that it is
returning a void the reason we don't put
the other ones is because we declared
them as asynchronous and when you have
an asynchronous function you don't
necessarily need to specify the return
type
okay so that is happy now and we
actually are seeing data show up on our
screen here so our post item component
is working I'm actually going to change
this fragment to be a stack from Chakra
so that it nicely spaces them out for us
by default and we don't have to apply
any extra margin on the post items this
stack will handle that for us so let's
come back to our post item and continue
on with the styling okay so on this
outermost Flex container we're going to
add a border color of gray 300 as well
as a border radius of four all right and
let's apply some hover styling with our
hover pseudo class we can say hover the
Border color we want to be gray 500. all
right and we want to apply a cursor of a
pointer because they are clickable items
and then we can add our on click
function here which is going to call
that on select post which currently does
nothing but we will put it here anyway
okay so let's go take a look at a post
item inside of our demo here to kind of
look at the overall structure of this
thing so this entire thing is
represented by this Flex box that we
just created here and inside
we can see that there is a left hand
side column this kind of gray background
thing with the voting buttons in here
and then on the right hand side we
actually have a majority of the post
content so from a high level we really
only have three major containers here
and I just wanted to show you that so
that writing of the HTML is a bit more
intuitive
so our first child of this Flex box is
going to be another flexbox which is
going to represent that gray voting
column so you're going to make the
direction of this column and we're going
to make the Align equal to Center so
it's nice and centered and we want to
give this a background of gray 100. you
want to apply some padding of two and
the width of 40 pixels
okay so we can kind of see that show up
on the UI over there then lastly we want
border radius of 4. okay so then inside
of here we're essentially going to have
two icons the upload and the download
icon and the actual text for the vote
status on this post so we can create our
first icon here so icon make sure that
comes in from Chakra and the icon we
want to display here is actually going
to be conditional as well depending on
if the user has uploaded or downloaded
this post okay so we can use that user
vote value and we can check does it
equal to one meaning that they have
upvoted this post if it does we want to
show sort of a filled orange icon right
like if you go to the demo here if I
click on this you can see that it does
change to a more filled icon so if they
have indeed uploaded this post we want
to show Arrow up Circle sharp I don't
know why I'm not getting autocomplete
that's kind of annoying to type that
entire thing out okay and if they have
not voted on this post we want to just
show Arrow up Circle outline
and the color of this icon is also going
to change depending on if the user has
upvoted this post so if the user vote
value is equal to one you're going to
make the color of the icon that orange
Reddit color brand 100 if they have not
we want it to be gray 400. all right
we're going to make this a bit bigger so
we're going to say font size is going to
be 22 and then when the user actually
clicks on this icon we want to call our
on vote function underneath here is
going to be just a piece of text that
shows the vote status of this post so we
can say post dot vote status
and these words have not been voted on
so it is currently zero and all we want
to do to this text to just make it
slightly smaller so we'll say uh nine
point okay now underneath this we're
going to have another icon which is
going to be our downvote icon so I'm
just going to copy the output one and
come up here for the downvote we want to
check does the user vote value
equal negative one meaning that the user
has downloaded this post if they have we
want to show IO arrow down Circle sharp
okay the autocomplete isn't now working
which is super nice and if they have not
downloaded this thing we wanted to show
IO Circle that line if I just change
this to like true just so we can see
that we can see that that thing is sort
of filled in now and we haven't applied
the color yet but I just wanted to show
how the icon actually changes depending
on what the user row value is all right
our color again we're going to check how
they downloaded this thing if they have
we want it to be this hex code 4379ff
[Music]
which is the color I found that most
closely resembles the download color on
Reddit
then we just want gray 400 if they have
not voted if they have not downloaded
and actually on both of these I'm just
going to add the cursor
of pointer
I forgot that on the f01
okay awesome this is looking pretty good
let's keep going all right so we are
done with the left hand side boating
container so let's just get rid of this
title here and we're going to start
working on the right hand side of this
component which is going to be most of
the other post content bringing it is a
direction of column as well as a width
of 100 and then inside of here we're
going to add another stack and this is
just going to again evenly space
everything that's going to go inside of
here we're going to give this a spacing
of one and then padding of 10 pixels so
inside of this vertical stack we're
going to actually have a horizontal
stack and this is going to contain that
text that says posted by and then the
username that posted this and then the
community icon if it exists so we want
to make the direction of this row and we
want to make these spacing
equal to 0.6 and we want a line to be
Center so everything is centered
vertically and then we want to make the
font size of everything in here nine
point okay so the first item inside of
this horizontal stack is actually going
to be the community icon here
however we can see that this only is
there when we're on the home page of
Reddit if we actually go into a
community
that icon is no longer there because
they all belong to the same Community we
don't really need to uniquely identify
it like that so we're going to add a
condition here in this stack that's
going to basically check if we are on
the home page or not we're going to come
back to this one we actually fill out
the home page it's a very simple
addition uh but I'm going to put a
comment in here for now we are going to
do a check if you're on the home page
and if we are we want to actually
display the icon of the community that
this post is part of but for now we are
sort of building the in community
version of this so there is no icon the
next component then would just be simply
the text so this is where the actual
posted by username is going to go and if
you remember we stored the author's user
display text on the post you can say
post dot Creator display name so let's
come back to our app so we can see what
we're doing here and you can see that my
username is actually showing up there
because I created both of these posts
and in addition to this we're actually
going to say when this was posted like
posted by Shad merhi 10 days ago or two
minutes ago we want to show the actual
time that it was posted right and in
order to do that you're going to use a
library called moment so just go to npm
moment and we can basically pass this a
date of any kind and it will basically
format it in a very nice human readable
way very popular Library you can see it
has 17 million weekly downloads so very
heavily used and it's going to make our
app display very accurate and human
readable at times for our users to see
so we're going to install that
okay then once that's done the text we
want to display next to the username
we're going to need some JavaScript
because we're going to call a function
from that library and that function is
going to be called moment so we're going
to import moment from moment so the
argument to this thing is going to be a
date so we're going to say new date and
the date that we want to pass it is
going to be our posts dot created at
dot seconds because if you recall the
type of this is actually a timestamp and
the timestamp is not at eight but the
timestamp does contain the seconds
parameter on it that can be used to
create a date
okay then we need to actually multiply
the seconds by a thousand here and then
we can actually call a function on this
called from now and that is going to
format the date as in like x amount of
time from now so 18 hours ago so very
cool I think this is awesome I love
moment okay so typescript is not happy
here and you can see that it's saying
that the object is possibly undefined
and by object it's referring to the
created act parameter on the post the
reason it is complaining about that is
because if you recall in our post atom I
actually made the created that thing
optional which means it could be
undefined and I actually realize that we
do not need to do this it is always
going to be there so I'm just going to
remove that question mark save this and
that should make this happy and so my
apologies about that I initially thought
that it was going to be an optional
parameter okay so we are done with this
inner horizontal stack so let's come
outside of that but still inside of our
vertical stack here and we want to
actually put the post title in here now
we are ready for the Post title awesome
inside of a text component we're going
to actually use post dot title
okay we're going to make the font size
of this equal to 12 point
and the font weight we're going to make
it heavy we're going to get 600.
whoops font weight
all right so underneath this title text
is we're actually going to display our
post image okay so let's write a
condition to check that it exists so we
will say
post.imageurl if this does exist let's
show some component and that component
is going to be an image and the
container of our image is going to be a
flex container
okay and we're going to make the justify
of this equal to Center as well as the
Align here and then we're going to give
this a padding of two and inside of here
we're actually going to have our post
image so bring an image from Chakra and
our source for this image is going to be
the post.image URL awesome so if I save
this we can see that the post is
actually there how cool is that we want
to set a Max height on this image to
prevent it from taking up too much room
if it's a very large image so we'll set
a Max height of 460 pixels and we're
just going to add an ALT key which is
typically used for images and we're just
going to say post image just some
alternate text if the image for some
reason is not available and actually I
forgot a really important piece just
above the image here we do want to add
our post body that's also another really
important thing post dot body
just like that
and we're going to change the size of
this as well to be a font size of 10.
perfect so this is looking more and more
like Reddit by the second okay so now we
are done with this vertical stack here
we can come outside of that still inside
of our Flex column here though and we're
going to put in the container for kind
of the post footer there where we have
all those icons and user actions where
they can share the post delete the post
Etc and comment on the post so let's
come down here okay so the container for
this is going to have a margin left of
one it's going to have a margin bottom
of 0.5 and it's going to have a color
Gray 50. and we're going to give this a
font weight of 600 so everything inside
of here is going to have the font weight
of 600. okay so and then essentially we
just have a series of basically icons
with a company text we have icon text
icon text right each each little thing
has an icon and a piece of text so each
icon is going to have its own Flex
container so we can create our first one
by saying icon and this icon container
we're going to give it an align of
Center a padding of 10 uh sorry a
padding of 8 pixels top bottom 10 pixels
left right and a border radius
of four
okay and on Hover we want the background
color to be gray 200
and then lastly just make our cursor
pointer
perfect just like that so if I hover
over this thing we can see that it has
that sort of gray background there okay
so this first icon is going to be the
comment icon which is going to be BS
chat and we're going to give this a
margin write of two and right next to
the comment icon we actually want to
display the number of comments that this
post has so we're going to say post DOT
number of comments
and then we can give this a font size of
nine point
there we go okay and actually I decided
to remove this font weight of 600 here
you can leave it if you choose I just
think it looks a bit cleaner if the text
is a bit lighter okay perfect so now
what I'm going to do is just copy this
and clone it downward uh for the other
icons and the second icon is going to be
our i o Arrow redo outline which is sort
of the share icon so inside of the text
here we want to say share then the last
icon down here is going to be the save
icon so we're going to say I O bookmark
outline and we want to display the text
save
awesome how good is this looking this is
so cool and I love how the number of
comments is actually Dynamic so every
time a comp is created this is actually
an accurate number and actually we are
missing one icon here and the icon is
going to be the delete icon but we only
want to show this if the user is the
creator we do not want to give anyone
the option to delete any post only if
you're the owner of this post you can
see this button here and this icon is
going to be
the AI outline delete and it's going to
say delete okay and the on click for the
container of this delete icon is going
to be the on delete
okay so we are completely done building
out the UI for the Post item component
and the only thing that's going to
change actually is this home page check
that I was talked to before where uh if
we see them on the home page it just
displays the community icon but that's
very minor okay perfect so now that we
can actually create posts and view them
on our page let's go try creating one in
the submit page and then actually have
it redirect us back to this page and see
what happens and I just want to make
sure that we actually did implement the
router we did not okay so I'm just going
to uncomment this so that when we do
create a post successfully it is going
to Route us back to the page and
actually we really only want to do this
when the post has been successfully
created if an error occurs we don't
really want to reroute the user only in
the successful case so I'm going to move
this up into the try block of the try
catch okay so let's actually go try
creating a post and seeing what happens
so so let's create the title of I love
chakra UI and the text is going to be
uis made easy with chakra awesome let's
go add an image here
okay and the only other image I have
here is
um is this image of me I'm using for the
thumbnail here so let's let's use this
one and we'll come back to the place I'm
actually going to change this to am I
good at photoshopping
and then the the description is going to
be null okay I'm going to tell myself no
so I'm going to click post
and let's see what happens so we are
redirected back to the page and then it
fetches the post from the database and
we can see it as soon as we post it how
cool is that I think that's really cool
okay and one last thing I'm going to
very quickly add is going to be our post
loader component which displays those
sort of skeleton components when the
posts are being loaded from the database
so inside of our uh post folder here I'm
going to create a new file called post
loader dot TSX
and I'm going to use our snippet here
and chakra makes doing something like
this so easy they have this component
called skeleton so let's go see what
this looks like chakra skeleton and you
can basically create any shape you want
of this like skeleton loader component
and so you can kind of build it out to
look exactly like your component and I
think these are cool I think these
really really really improve user
experience like when I'm on a website
like Airbnb or something and I see these
loaders it honestly just makes the app
feel better rather than just like seeing
nothing or something like spinner
Spinners are good too but I really like
these skeleton components I think
they're fun
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to paste in my loader from my
completed project just because it's only
like 15 lines and it's just basically
something that's really easy to copy and
paste so I'm going to put this in here
like this
add all missing Imports
and I will put the link for this in the
description so you can just quickly grab
it but very simple component and all we
need to do to use this component is come
back to our posts component I'm going to
close my directory here and inside of
the return statement of our post.tsx
file I'm going to create a outermost
fragment and wrap everything in the
fragment and the reason I'm doing that
is so I can add some JavaScript in here
what I want to add in here is check if
loading is true and if loading is true I
want to show our post loader
and for some reason it's not importing
there we go
okay and if you are not loading then
let's show the actual post content so
we'll move the stack inside of here just
like this
okay so now if we come back and if I
just make this true for a sec we can see
what this looks like so you can see that
created these components using the
skeletons from Chakra to make this
really nice looking loader and honestly
I just I just get so fired up about
these loaders I just think they look so
cool and they really do improve the user
experience so anyway we can actually
check if loading is true using the real
loading
so now if I save this and I reload
I actually don't know if we're setting
loading to be true I don't think we are
no we're not okay so inside of our Drive
lock here I'm just going to set loading
to be true and then at the very end just
set loading should be false
awesome so you saw for a second there
that it actually was loading let's do
this again
cool so I think that's amazing all right
and we just need to add a key to our
post item here to prevent that console
error we are seeing on the right hand
side over here so I'm just going to make
the key the unique ID of this post and
also we can actually improve our image
loading State because if you see there
if I just refresh it loads the post but
then for another second after the image
is still kind of loading and that can be
improved with just a simple additional
State variable inside of our post item
so let's quickly add that it's just
going to be a few lines so up top here
we can create a state variable
so basically for each post item we can
add a state called loading image and set
loading image
and we can initialize it as true because
initially the image is going to be
loading and for folks that don't have
images this doesn't even matter it's
just kind of a redundant State variable
but if you come down here to the
container of our image and inside of
this container we can add a condition to
check to see if loading image is true
and if it is we want to show one of our
skeleton components
so we can say skeleton and we want to
make the height of this 20 sorry 200
pixels the width 100 percent and the
Border radius 4. and this is basically
just going to mimic the shape of an
image if the image is kind of loading
and this is not the same loading as
loading from the database this is like
the posts have been loaded from the
database but the image is just sort of
in the process of still rendering and
this will make sense when we see it in
the app here okay so if we save that we
can see that there is a sort of loader
beside the image here but we don't want
to display that all the time obviously
that looks kind of weird so on our image
component there is a property called on
load and this is going to trigger when
this image has actually successfully
loaded so we can call our set
loading image function and just set it
equal to false just like this okay and
since the updating of state is
asynchronous we can hide this image to
actually prevent the image from being
shown at all until that state variable
has updated as well so that there's no
sort of flash of both of these two
things appearing
okay so if we save this and then if we
refresh
this is how it behaves
awesome so it's just a bit cleaner and
it kind of signifies to the user that
there is something being loaded into the
image awesome guys so that is it for our
post item component other than those few
minor things with the whole home page
icon thing and now we can create posts
in communities and actually view them
the next step is going to be to actually
implement the voting functionality and
the commenting functionality so we are
making solid progress I'll bet you guys
so we're going to start off with
handling the deletion of post
functionality because now that we can
create them it would be nice if we could
delete them as well and it's not an
overly complicated function so we might
as well just get it out of the way now
all right so I am inside of this post
item component here and just underneath
this loading State here I'm going to
create a new function called handle
delete and this is going to be an
asynchronous function
okay so we're creating this function but
we also have this on delete post
function that we saw that we defined in
our use post hook here so you might be
wondering why do we have two delete
functions and that's a really good
question this function is actually going
to call this onto the post function and
the on delete post function is going to
be responsible for actually updating our
database and uh and state but the handle
delete function is going to handle the
error handling for us inside of this
component and a few other things event
propagation but I don't want to get too
deep into that until we get to it okay
so inside of our handle delete function
I'm going to create a try catch block
and at the top of our try block let's
create a variable called success and
this variable is going to represent a
successful response from the on delete
post function so basically we click on a
post that we want to delete that post is
sent to the on delete post function the
undelete post function is going to reach
out to our firestore database and delete
that document when that is successful is
once you return to this function a
success message and then we will know
inside of this function that the post
has successfully been deleted so we're
getting some errors here and the reason
that is is because our prop type for
this function is currently this and type
script is saying well this function that
you declared up here definitely does not
match what is going on down here so we
do need to fix that okay so to fix our
type declaration here we're going to
change this to a function that accepts
an argument of type post and this
function is going to return a promise of
type Boolean and it's returning a
promise because the on delete post
function is asynchronous because it's
asynchronously communicating with our
database and then JavaScript
asynchronous functions can only return a
promise so our on delete post function
is going to attempt to delete the
document from our firestore database and
if it's exceeds it's going to return
true and if it fails it's going to
return false and that is what the
success variable represents I hope that
makes sense and that should make more
sense when we actually write out this
onto the host function which is coming
very soon and this helps us with our
error handling because we can say if
there is no success if the undelete post
function was not successful then we want
to throw a new error error and say that
we failed to delete the post then now
here we can set
our error state which we can create
right now so you can say class error set
error is equal to U State we can set it
equal to false then down here we can
actually call it's a set error and set
it equal to error Dot message
and the message in this case is just
going to be this failed to delete post
string here that we're throwing in the
error here okay so if we make it past
this if statement we can just throw a
log in here saying that the post was
successfully
delete it and there are a few more minor
things that we're going to add to this
function when we create these single
page postview in a little bit but I will
come back to that when we get to it and
then what we want to do is add this
function to the on click of our on
delete here we want to add the function
handle delete
so let's come back up here and now let's
actually go work on this on delete post
function in our use post hook so we just
saw a few minutes ago that this function
is going to need to take in an argument
of type post so we can add that in here
and that is also going to need to return
a Boolean promise and in typescript we
specify the return type after these
parentheses here with a colon and then
we can just type the return type and in
this case that is going to be a promise
of type Boolean and just one more time
for clarity because of this function is
asynchronous we have to wrap the return
type in a promise so you can see that we
have a compiler error on our return type
there and this is basically just
typescript saying while you're telling
me that this function is supposed to
return a promise of type Boolean but
you're not returning anything so to make
this go away all you have to do is just
return a value of that type so this
function is going to do a total of three
things the first thing it's going to do
is it's going to check if post that
we're trying to delete has an image
attached to it and if it does it's going
to delete it from our Firebase storage
bucket then it's going to actually
delete the post document itself in our
firestore database and that is just
going to update our recoil state so that
we do not see the deleted post on our UI
okay so let's create a try catch block
here and I'm just going to write out
some comments to outline what I just
said so the first thing is check
if there's an image and if there is
delete it from our Firebase storage
the second thing is just going to be
delete the post document
from firestore and the third thing is
just going to be update recoil state
then at the end of all of these things
successfully completing we will return
true and if an error occurs we want to
return false and so if it fails and it
returns false then the value of success
over here will be false and we will
throw an error over here and be able to
actually update our component to display
that error to the user okay so let's
actually build this out so the first
thing is you want to check for the
existence of an image URL on this post
because only posts with images are going
to have an image URL if there is a post
image if you're going to create an image
reference to that image inside of our
storage and we can do that with our ref
function from Firebase and we just have
to pass this our storage instance from
Client app
and inside of here we just need to
specify the path to this image and if
you remember from when we actually
uploaded the images the path is going to
be post slash
post dot ID
slash image to actually delete this
image from our storage we can call a
function called delete object and this
is going to be from again Firebase
storage and then we can just pass it our
image ref perfect and that is all we
need to do to delete it from our storage
all right so next let's delete the post
from our firestore database so let's
create a reference to the document that
we're actually going to delete so we can
say post doc graph and we can use our
doc function from Firebase firestore and
we can pass this our firestore instance
from Client app
The Collection that we are deleting from
is posts and the ID of the document that
we're deleting is going to be post dot
ID
just like this okay so typescript is
complaining here because the ID is an
optional parameter on our post type but
because we know for sure that if we're
deleting a post this ID is going to
exist I'm just going to add the bang
operator here to tell typescript that it
is safe to proceed in using this value
all right now to actually delete this
document from our database we can call
the function delete doc from Firebase
and pass it the document reference we're
trying to delete perfect so now let's
just update our recall State and we're
going to use our set posted value
function up here so we can call that
down here and say set Post State value
take the previous value of State
spread it because you're only updating a
single value and that value is going to
be posts and the updated value of posts
you basically just want to remove this
post that we're deleting from the
current value of posts so we can say
prev.posts.filter and filter is going to
iterate through all of the items inside
of posts and the condition that we want
to filter on is that item dot ID does
not equal to post dot ID
okay so let's check to make sure that
everything is in place so if I go to my
post item we can see that we are calling
this um handle delete function when I
click on this delete button here and
that is going to call this which is
going to call on delete post which is
going to do all that stuff we just wrote
so theoretically this should work so
let's give this a go and we're going to
add some loading state in a second here
but let's see and let's go talk about
what should actually happen on the back
end when we do click on delete before we
do it so we know that it happens on both
the front end and the back end
if I go to storage
and I go to posts and I think it's going
to be this one because it's second okay
so yeah let me delete this post this
image should be deleted from our storage
bucket here so let's try doing this
let's delete
okay so it worked on the front end and
we're saying that post was successfully
deleted but let's go check out our
storage
okay so let's try it refreshing here so
let's go into posts
okay yeah so it was deleted which is
perfect the only one thing for now is
that other post okay so it did work uh
let's go to our database
continue to posts
and I don't even remember I think it had
to do with Photoshop yeah okay so it was
deleted perfect so we can actually
delete post now which is super cool okay
and let's quickly add some loading state
for our deleting so we can actually
indicate to the user that the deletion
is in progress so I'm going to create a
state variable called
um called loading delete
set loading delete
is equal to use State and we're going to
initialize this as false then at the
very top of our kind of delete function
here I'm going to set it equal to true
and at the very bottom just want to set
it to false set loading false
once everything has successfully
returned now all we need to do to
actually update the UI with our loading
state is you can come down here and we
can toggle the display of this icon and
this delete text here this sort of
garbage can text over here all right so
let's just cut these out for a second
and let's create a ternary operator that
is going to see if loading delete is
true if it is we're going to show a
spinner and if it is not we're going to
show the icon in text let's say delete
what the garbage can I'm just going to
wrap these in a fragment here
just like this
okay and type here we're going to use
our spinner component from Chakra UI
react and we're going to make the size
of this equal to
small
awesome so if I just make this true so
we can see what this looks like
that is what that looks like so it's
super clean it only appears inside of
that button there so let's see what this
looks like when we actually delete
something so I'm going to say loading
delete
all right now let's delete this post and
see what happens
beautiful I love Spinners and skeletons
and loading state is just nice
all right the very last thing I'm going
to add is just displaying an error
message if the deletion fails so I'm
just going to create a new post quickly
I'm going to call it here is a post here
is a post body let's post this
okay so let's go back to our new post
form and I'm just going to grab the
exact same UI component using the chakra
UI alert let's go back to here and I'm
going to paste this inside of this
column Flex container here so just right
in here say that okay that looks pretty
good now we just have to change this
text in here to B our error State
variable just like that and then change
this from True to error
okay awesome so now if our post fails to
delete for any reason inside of here
then we will return false to our handle
delete function and then the error will
be set and you'll see that there was an
error deleting the post awesome and that
is it for deleting posts all right you
guys so the next thing we're going to
work on is the about Community component
that is going to go on the right hand
side here and that'll be sort of the
last thing we need to do to wrap up the
Community page so if we go back to the
demo I just have a quick look at this
component did I go into a community here
this is the about Community component
here and it's responsible for actually
rendering the data of the current
community that we're in we can see that
it's going to appear on three of our
Pages the first one is the actual home
of the Community page r slash baking the
second one would be in our submit page
baking slash submit and the third one
would be in a single page view if I
actually click on this post here uh it
is appearing in here as well in this r
slash baking slash comment slash post ID
and we've seen this before right when we
need data across multiple Pages or
multiple components that live far away
from each other in the react component
tree we can do that by putting our data
into our Global recall state so we can
access it from any
so as of right now if we just look at
the home Community page the community
index page we only have access to this
community data in this page only we
currently do not have access to it in
our submit page and we also don't have
access to it in a single page view
because we have not even created this
page basically right now we only have
access to it in this home page of the
community and so what we're going to do
is take this community data and just
throw it into our recoil state in our
communities atom and then all we have to
do is drop this component into the right
hand side fragment on all three of these
Pages passive the community data from
our recall State and then it will just
have everything it needs to render
successfully and if this isn't super
clear right now just wait until we get
into it and it should become more clear
so I want to start off by going back to
our communities atom file here and if
you remember this was a while ago but if
you remember I created a comment here
that was called visited communities and
I'm actually going to change this to a
key called current community and this is
going to wrap present the current
community that we are in so if I click
on baking baking is going to be stored
here if I click on Tesla Tesla is going
to be stored here and that way when we
want to access that data from any one of
those three pages that I just mentioned
we can just grab it from our community
state DOT current Community okay so as I
just mentioned the value that is going
to go in here is going to be an actual
Community it's the type of it we can use
our community interface and I'm going to
make this optional because the user is
not always in a community so it doesn't
necessarily have to be defined so let's
Trace back to the actual index page of
this community and look again at how we
actually fetch that data so if you
remember we are server side rendering
this page with get server side props and
on the next.js server we fetch the data
for the community and we've passed that
as a prop to this component as this
community data variable up here and that
is what we have been using in our header
and our post Etc but as we were just
discussing we do not have access to this
community data on those other two pages
that we needed so all we're going to to
do is just take this prop Community data
and throw it into the current Community
value inside of our community's atom and
we want to do that as soon as this
component renders and if you recall
whenever we want to do something after
the component renders we want to use our
use effect hook so let's bring that in
and create an empty callback function
here okay so inside of this user Factor
we just want to do one thing we just
want to take this community data and
throw it into our current Community
inside of our community State value and
we can do that by bringing in our set
Community State value functions using
recall so we can say const set Community
State value
is equal to use set recoil State and
pass it our community State atom make
sure all of those things import then
down here inside of our use effect all
we want to do is say set Community State
value we want to spread the previous
value because you're only updating a
single value the value of your updating
is going to be current community and we
want to populate current Community with
the Canadian data all right so let's
come back to our app here and we
definitely already know that we have
access to community data on the home
page of our community but let's go check
our submit page and see if we have it
there so let's go to submit and if this
recoil setting worked we should have
access to this data over here all we
need to do is read that value current
Community from Community State value so
I can just say community
State value
is equal to use recoil value and again
pass it our community State atom just
like this and let's just take a quick
peek at the console log of the value
here
no autocomplete very nice okay so this
is the log here it's from our submit
page if I just open this out let me let
me expand the console here if I open
this up we can see that the current
Community has been populated with
Shady's group and all of that data and
so now we actually have access to the
data required by the about Community
component so we can just reuse this
component across all of these pages and
just posit this data as a prop all right
so now that we have solved the data
problems surrounding this component
let's actually go build out the UI for
it let's go back to our app over here
and go to our shines group page and then
I'm just going to go to the index page
of our community and that about
component is just going to go right in
here all right so let's go create the
file for our about component so inside
of community
I'm going to create a new file called
about.tsx
use our snippet and so the first prop
that this component is going to take in
is going to be the current Community
data so we can call that Community data
and it is going to be of type community
we can make sure that imports from our
atom file save that and then come down
here and restructure it in the props
Community data
okay so I'm just going to close my
directory here and Shrink my console a
bit because it's a little large and
let's just change the text here to be
about
and then inside of our index page I'm
just going to actually bring the real
component in about
just like that and we can see that show
up here on our right hand side so now we
just have to pass in the required
Community data prop so we can just copy
the thing from post here because it's
going to be the exact same and in this
case we can pass the community data
variable that we're getting from our
server side rendering function but on
the other Pages we're going to need to
grab it from State the other pages are
not going to be calling get server-side
props because that would result in
making the same query multiple times so
if we just put this data in state once
then they can all share this data and
only a single query has to be made now
there is the case of when the user
refreshes either the submit page or the
single page post view page meaning that
they are not starting off on the home
Bridge of the community in those cases
we would have to go fetch the data and
actually make this query from those
pages since this home page is
responsible for getting that data on the
next JS server and putting it in stage
four of those other pages to use but we
will handle that case after it just is a
simple workaround for now we're just
going to focus on the user flow of the
user starting in the community page and
then going to those other Pages which
assumes that that Community data is
always going to be available by the time
those users go to either the submit page
or the single page postview page or we
will handle the refreshing of those
other two pages in a bit alright so now
that we're actually passing that data to
our component let's go back to that
let's just take a quick look at the
about component so that we can kind of
see the overall layout of it okay so
essentially it has this overall parent
container here and then there is this
header component in the top and then
this other content component in the
bottom so really there's only three main
containers here so let's come over here
and let's model that out so our first
outer container is going to be a box
component from Chakra and I want to make
the position of this sticky because when
we scroll down the Community page we
want this to actually stick to the top
just like that we don't want it to go
above the screen and we can do that with
sticky positioning and then we can
actually specify the sticky position of
this component and we're going to want
it 14 pixels from the top
and then the blue header component that
says about Community is just going to be
a flex box and then the white background
container is also going to be a flexbox
so pretty much our entire component is
just a box with two Flex boxes in it and
of course there will be other stuff
inside of it but this is the main
structure all right so let's come back
to our app so we can actually see what
we're doing and let's work on this
header component so we're going to give
this a justify of space between and an
align of Center
we want our background color to be blue
400 we're going to make the text color
white
we're going to give this a padding of
three and we're going to give this a
border radius of 4 pixels four pixels
zero pixels zero pixels and that is top
left top right bottom right bottom left
so we can see something showing up over
there okay now inside of here we're
going to have the text that actually
says about community
okay and as always text does not like to
Auto Import from a chakra so let's do
that ourselves and we're going to shrink
this a little bit so let's make the font
size equal to 10 point
just like that and let's make the font
weight equal to
700. all right and then we're going to
have an icon here I'm just going to
paste in the icon import that we're
going to use for this
so this is it here the high outline dot
circle thing and I'm just going to add
that to our icon down here by saying as
and it's going to be equal to high
outline dots horizontal
all right there we go so those are those
three dots over there okay and that is
it for this header component here let's
work on the actual body so this Flex
container is going to have a direction
of column
and we're going to give it a padding of
three a background of white and lastly
we're going to give it a border radius
that is the complete opposite of the
header component so it's going to be 0
pixels zero pixels four pixels four
pixels just like that inside of this
Flex block you're going to have a stack
component here and the stack is just
going to handle the spacing between this
component here with the members and the
number of online as well as this thing
down here with the created at date and
this create post button let's come back
to our app here all right so inside of
our stack the first component is going
to be a flex container which is going to
represent the container of the number of
members and the number of online people
and we're going to give that a width of
100 percent
a padding of Two and a font size of 10
point and inside of here we're going to
have a flex container for each of those
two metrics and we're going to give both
of them
a direction of column as well as a flex
row of one so that they take up exactly
half of the width each and this will
become more clear when the visuals start
showing up on the screen here so in the
first one we are going to display the
text
and that text is going to have the
community data DOT number of members
okay and on this number we want to call
a JavaScript function called two local
or low Locale I'm honestly not sure have
the best way to say that and that is
basically just going to convert it to a
nice number with commas in it and stuff
if we do not have that two local string
function it's just going to be this
ginormous number without the nice comma
formatting so make sure you call that so
that when your community has millions of
members in it it looks very good okay
and then right underneath here we're
going to have another piece of text that
says members
just like that so three members I'm just
gonna go back up here to the first flex
container inside of the stack and make
the font weight a little bit heavier and
I'm just going to make it 700. there we
go that looks a lot better all right so
in the second Flex container here we are
going to have two pieces of text so the
first piece of text is going to be the
actual number of people online and we're
not building this feature because it's
not super critical so I'm just going to
hard code this to one and the text below
it is just going to say on line okay so
we are done with this first flex child
of our stack container here so
underneath that but still inside of our
stack we're going to add a divider
component from Chakra this is going to
be that nice Gray Line and then
underneath here we're going to have
another Flex box for the created update
and the create post button all right so
on this Flex container we are going to
vertically align everything by making
the line equal to Center we're going to
give this a width of 100 percent
padding of One Fund rate of 500 500 and
a font size of 10 points
okay and inside of here we're going to
have the birthday cake icon to represent
when this community was actually born so
we're going to bring in an icon so I'm
going to copy that important over here
and paste it under the other one react
icon slash RI then I'm going to add that
to this icon here as RI cakelake alright
so let's make this icon a little bit
bigger and I'm going to give it a font
size of 18 and I'm going to make the
margin right 2. now right next to the
icon we want to have some text and this
is going to be the text that actually
says when this thing was created at so
we're going to have the text created and
in order to format the date nicely we
can use the same moment library that we
use for our post here but we're going to
use a slightly different function we
need some JavaScript so I'm going to
wrap this in curly brackets I'm going to
call in moment from moment so make sure
that Imports
and as you recall we need to pass this a
date and the date that we're going to
pass is going to be Community data dot
created at we're going to do the exact
same thing we did with the other
timestamp we're going to grab these
seconds from here multiplied by a
thousand and this is complaining saying
that created at might be undefined so
what we're going to do is just prevent
this text from being shown at all if
there is no Community data dot created
at so we can say community data dot
created at and this text so now
typescript is going to be happy because
it knows that if we get to this point
over here it is going to be defined so
we can actually get rid of this optional
chain in here and we need to call a
function on this moment date here so at
the end of it we can call the dot format
function and the format we want is going
to be month month space Day Day comma
year year four of those just like that
and that is what that looks like I love
this moment Library it's so customizable
and it just formatted for you exactly
however you want it's pretty cool thank
you moment for helping us get closer to
the Reddit appearance all right now
underneath this Flex container but still
in our stack we're going to create our
create post button and this is actually
going to be a link from next link that
is going to Route us to the submit page
of this community and the link component
from next allows us to perform
client-side routing by clicking on a
certain component so whatever we put
inside of this link is going to Route us
to the page that we specified and the
element that we want to click on to take
us to the submit page is going to be a
button let's import that from Chakra and
the button is going to say create post
and we're going to give this a margin
top of three and a height of 30 pixels
and the reason this is unhappy is
because we are not passing it the href
prop and the href prop represents the
actual client-side route that we want
this thing to take us to you want to
take us to forward slash R forward slash
and then we're going to need to grab the
community ID from the router which in
this case is chatty's group but we don't
have the router in this file yet so
let's come up to the top of our
component and bring that in with the use
router hook so we can say const router
is equal to use router then down here in
our link we can access that we can say
router.query dot Community ID
then we want to go to this community's
submit page at slash submit just like
this so now if I click on this create
post button it takes me to the submit
page for Shady's group how cool is that
okay and now what we're going to do is
add the functionality to update the
community image if you are the moderator
creator of this community so if you go
to our demo and I just go into a
community that I created and I'm
moderating socialize Community I can see
that I have this little admin section
here and I can change the image and that
will actually show in the community icon
up here so that is what we're going to
do now the process for doing this is
going to be pretty much identical to
what we saw in the new post form when we
were uploading an image using this on
select image function and using the file
reader so it should be pretty much the
exact same so what I'm going to do is
actually create a custom hook and
extract that logic into it and it's only
going to be about a 30 line hook it's
pretty small and then we can just reuse
it in both of these components here so
it's going to be a lot cleaner just so
we don't have to rewrite the same
functions all right so inside of our
Direct directory here inside of hooks
I'm going to create a new file called
use select file dot TSX
use our snippet get rid of the props
as well as the return type
okay and inside of here this is we're
actually going to have that on select
image function and we're going to manage
the selected file state from within here
so let's go back to our new post form
I'm going to close my directory as well
and I'm going to actually copy this
image
over into this hook here
just like this and I'm also going to
grab that state selected file
so let's put this at the top of our hook
okay let's make sure we import use state
from react and then at the bottom here
we're going to return an object and that
object is going to contain our selected
file our set selected file as well as
that function on select image and
actually I'm going to rename this to on
select file to sort of match the name of
our hook here and that is it for our
hook now we can reuse this function and
state in both of these components for
our image uploading all right so let's
go back to our new post form and just
refactor this to use that hook it's very
very simple to do that so we can get rid
of this selected file state here and we
can get rid of this on select image
function here I'll just leave it
commented out for now I'll delete it
once we actually have the hook
implemented and just underneath this
comment that outstate here I'm going to
call that hook by saying const is equal
to use select file
then what I'm going to grab is selected
file set selected file as well as on
select file so those three things that
we were returning from our hook then
down here
all we need to do is just change the
name of this so I'm going to say on
select image is going to be named on
select file inside of image upload it
will still be called on select image but
we're passing it the on select file
function from our hook as that value now
we're done that is all we have to do to
refactor this component to use discuss
hook so now I can just delete this on
select image function here delete this
state where it is it yeah right here
delete that and now our Hook is going to
handle all that logic for us and we can
test this out by actually creating a
post so let's do this let's create a new
post called testing hook testing out the
hook we made and let's upload an image
to make it that classic demo image we
can see that the state is still
functioning as we expect back to the
post if I post it
awesome so it functions exactly the same
but the logic has now been extracted
into this use select file hook and we
can reuse this exact same Hook when
we're doing our image uploading for our
about Community thing over here so very
clean reusable code
okay so we can close the new push form
because we are done with that we don't
need it and we can start implementing
this in our about component here all
right so let's actually create the UI so
the user can input an image here so
underneath the create post link but
still within our stack we're going to
create a new section here but we only
want to display the section two
moderators of this community and in
order to do that we need to check if the
current user's ID matches the ID of the
creator of this community so we're going
to need to grab the user from our use
off State hook so we can say const user
is equal to use odd State pass it our
auth object from Client app and down
here the condition we want to check here
is that user.uid is equal to the
community
data.creator ID
if that is the case we want to show some
sort of fragment with admin options here
so inside of this fragment I'm going to
start off with having a divider from
Chakra okay then underneath the divider
I'm going to create another stack
and the stack is going to have a spacing
of one as well as a font size of just 10
point here inside of the stack we are
going to have the text that actually
says admin
and we're going to make the font weight
of this 600
underneath the admin text we're going to
create another Flex container which is
going to actually have the upload image
button and this is going to have an
align of Center
and a justify
of space between
all right inside of this Flex container
we're going to have text and the text is
going to say change image this is going
to be the thing that the user actually
clicks on to upload an image it's
similar to the upload button from our
new post form and if you remember from
our new post form this thing has to
actually implicitly sort of behind the
scenes click on an actual file input
that we're going to create in a second
in order to prompt the user to upload an
image from their computer so we're going
to need to create another ref up here
similarly to what we did with the new
post form so I'm going to I'm going to
create a ref called const selected file
ref and this is going to be equal to use
ref and again it's going to be of type
string and it's going to be initialized
as null all right and we're going to
attach this to an actual file input in
just a second but for now what we can do
is change the appearance of this text so
this text is going to have a color of
blue 500.
there's going to be cursor
pointer
okay and on Hover we want to make the
text decoration
underline
awesome so this kind of looks like that
and then r on click this is where we're
actually going to click on that selected
file graph I'm just going to leave it
blank for now until we create that input
and attach the ref to it and this is
going to be the exact same thing we saw
already under this text we are going to
check for the existence of a community
image if it exists we will display it if
it is not we will just display the
classic Reddit icon there sort of as a
default but the community image can
exist in two ways it can either be
inside the community data dot image URL
or if the user is adding a new file
there is going to be an image inside of
our selected file state which we're
going to bring in from our hook so let's
do that right now so at the top of our
about component let's call the hook
use a file sorry use select file and
from in here we can grab selected file
set selected file as well as on select
file perfect so now down here this is
defined and then if this is the case if
we have either of these two things we
actually want to show an image from
Chakra
so inside of our source of this image we
want to show one of these two things and
I'm going to add the statement we want
to show the selected file or Community
data
dot image URL and this is basically
going to first check for the existence
of a selected file if it does not exist
it will show the community image URL the
reason I'm putting the selected file
first is because the selected file sort
of takes priority over a potential
existing image URL because they're
updating it right they want to see a
preview of the updated image that
they're uploading so that is why we are
checking for the existence of this first
and if it does not exist it will go and
render this okay and we're just going to
apply a few minor styling to this image
so we're going to say border radius is
going to be equal to full and our box
size
is going to be equal to 40 pixels
okay and then we're going to give this a
alt of community image and this is not
happy because we do not have anything
for the falseness of our ternary
operator and if we do not have either of
those two things what we want to display
is our classic Reddit icon so I'm just
going to paste that over from my
completed project just like this and
we're going to need to import this icon
as well f a Reddit and that is coming
from react icons F A let's throw that up
here with the other icons
so now if I save this we can see that we
have no image for the community yet so
it's just displaying this icon but if I
click on an image to upload it oh I
haven't created the file input yet
um so let's do that now that's pretty
pretty critical so underneath this Flex
container here but still inside of our
stack we're going to add another
condition to check for the existence of
a selected file and if there is a
selected file meaning that the user is
attempting to upload a new image we want
to show the text save changes so it's
like okay you've selected a file you
want to upload for this community image
click on this to save these changes and
actually upload this file and I'm
actually going to quickly add some
loading State for the uploading so we
can see that the uploading is in
progress and I'm going to come up here
and create a new state variable called
uploading image set uploading image and
this is going to be equal to use State
and initialize it as false then down
here I'm going to cut this out for just
a second and I'm going to add a ternary
operator inside of here that's going to
check if the image is in progress of
uploading so if it is we want to display
a spinner
okay and if it is not we want to display
that text just like this
and when we actually upload an image we
will see what this looks like and then
on this text we are going to give it a
cursor of pointer and then we're just
going to add an on a click to the save
changes text which is going to call a
function that is going to actually go
upload this image to our Firebase
storage and update our community
document with that image URL so we can
actually create just the definition of
that right now so just coming to the top
here I'm just going to create a function
called on update image and we're going
to make this an asynchronous function
and just leave it empty for now but then
we can add that to the on click of this
to save changes text here on update
image
perfect now the only missing piece is
that file input and I'm going to paste
that over because it's the exact same as
the other one just throw it under here
and just change this to on select file
okay and this is complaining
um oh I think I put the wrong type on
this here okay yeah so this is supposed
to be HTML input element my apologies
the string type was for the selected
file state itself make sure that the
selected file ref is a ref of type HTML
input element my apologies for that then
we can just pass it a initial value of
null and that should satisfy that ref
texture error down here okay perfect now
all I have to do is write this on update
image function
so let's come back up here and start
writing this out so this function is
going to be very similar and actually a
lot simpler than our handle create post
function all we have to do is take this
file upload it to our storage and then
update our community Dock and then we
just have to update our recoil state to
use that new image URL so that the fun
end actually updates with that new image
so let's create a try catch block here
at the very top here I'm just going to
add a guard that says if there is no
selected file let's just return so that
we don't try to do anything or upload
anything if there is a not a file
through upload then in our log here
let's just log on update image error
and log the error and then also under
here I'm just going to set uploading
image to be true
so the first thing we're going to do is
take the file that the user is trying to
upload and upload it to our storage
bucket so we can create an image ref
and we can use our ref function from
Firebase storage and we can pass this
our storage instance from Client app and
the path to this image inside of our
storage we are going to store it at
communities
slash Community data dot ID
slash image so pretty much the exact
same path as the post image just for
communities now all right now to
actually upload this thing to our
storage we can use the same function
upload string from Firebase storage pass
it our image ref pass the file that
we're actually going to upload inside of
this image ref and then also the format
of the file which is going to be data
URL and as a reminder this is coming
from the format we told our file reader
to format this image in after it's
successfully uploaded we can get the
download URL for that image
so download URL is equal to a weight get
download URL
and this is a function from Firebase
storage and then pass it our image ref
now all we need to do is update our
community document in firestore so we
can say await update doc
the first argument is going to be our
document reference to our community doc
so we're going to say Doc pass it our
firestore instance from Client app The
Collection we're interested in is
communities
and the ID of the document we are
updating is community data.id and as a
second argument to our update.function
we pass it an object with the updates we
want to make to this document in that
case and in this case we want to update
our image URL on our community documents
to be download URL
just like this now we just need to
update our recoil state to actually show
this new image on our front end and so
in order to update our community State
value we're going to need to bring our
set Community State value function in
from recoil so you can come up here and
grab that from recoil saying set
Community State value is equal to use
set recoil State pass it our communities
atom
from our atom file then down here after
all of this successful uploading we can
call set Community State value to take
the previous value of the state spread
it okay and now we want to update the
image URL of our current Community State
so the field we're updating on our
community state is going to be current
community and we want to change the
image URL of our current community so we
can spread the previous value of current
Community those are only changing a
single field on a current community and
that field is image URL and we want to
update this to be download URL just like
this if you satisfy the currently
freaking out typescript I'm going to
type cast this updated current Community
object to be a community one last thing
we're missing is just the set loading
set uploading image to false at the very
bottom here all right so let's give this
a go and see what happens so if I go to
our Firebase storage we should after
uploading an image see a new folder in
here called communities and then we can
go in there and we should be able to see
the new image and also in our firestore
database if I go to that Community
document for status Community we should
see actually with Chinese group I think
it was called we should see a new field
on here called image URL so let's give
this a go and see what happens so I'm
going to change the image okay it's not
even opening the thing which is not good
oh I think I've got to add okay yeah so
I forgot to add the on click for this
change image text to actually click on
that input which is pretty important so
let's make this callback actually click
on this thing so we can say selected
file
ref.current dot click
just like this okay now this should work
so let's click on this
and just choose this Google logo because
it's nice and round
you can see it show up here so now we
actually have a selected file in state
so it's showing the same changes text
here and now when I click on Save
changes we can see the loading State
happens and now we should have uploaded
that to our storage so let's go find out
and we're going to make the change in a
second to actually make this update here
well let's go see if the image first
successfully uploaded okay yeah so
Shadow's group now has an image URL
which is perfect and if I go to storage
the image should be there because the
successful storage upload is sort of a
prerequisite for that image URL yes or
Shadows group
image and you can see that it is the
Google logo there perfect super cool so
now let's figure out how to actually get
it to display in here and actually if I
refresh this page it should show up in
the header there
let's see
okay so it's not but let's go fix this
so inside of our header
so what we're going to do inside of here
is instead of using the community data's
image URL we are going to use our
community's state value dot current
Community Dot imageurl and the reason
there is no image is because there is no
Source on this image so the source of
this is going to be that exact thing
Community State value
no autocomplete very nice dot current
Community dot image URL so now we can
see we have this ginormous image here so
I'm just going to add some additional
stylings to make that better and I'm
trying to copy over the settings from my
completed project
um feel free to do that as well so this
is going to look like this
and that is going to actually control
the size of that image and make it
appear really nice like this and the
reason we're using the image URL from
our current Community State and not from
Community data is because in our about
component inside of our on update image
function we are updating our current
Community state with the latest image
URL so the community data variable
inside of our header is not going to
have that updated image unless we
refresh the page and it's getting it
from the database but to show the
updates without refreshing we would have
to use the latest value which is going
to be stored in our community State
value dot current community so now let's
try this again if I change the image and
I change it to this thing of me because
that's the only other image I have if I
save changes we should see this update
immediately without having to refresh
the page once it's done uploading so
like to save changes
perfect and without refreshing the image
updates inside of our header that is
super cool and now we can actually
change the image of our community if we
are the moderator
so technically inside of our header
component here you could remove the
community data altogether and just
simply access Community State value dot
current Community because they are
pretty much the same thing because on
our index page of our community we took
that data and we stored it in current
Community State however the component
renders slightly faster when we use
Community data because that data is
coming directly from the server and it
is rendered on the server rather than
having to wait for the state to be
populated by that Community data on the
client side which actually happens
completely after the component Mount
because we put it in a use effect
causing a bit of a delay because the
component actually has to re-render once
the state has been updated which causes
this sort of glitch on the UI for the
case of the image though if we want that
functionality for this header image to
update without having to refresh the
page then we do have to use the
communitystatevalue.com community to
make it dynamic because we actually
update that state on our client side
when we change the community image but
for the other field I'm just going to
leave it as Community data but I just
wanted to touch on that in case you were
wondering okay and one other thing that
I noticed that I want to change is
inside of our about component here I
realize that I'm using router.query dot
Community ID and I honestly have no idea
why I did that because we have access to
that same exact thing on community data
dot ID so we do not actually need the
router at all some of you probably
noticed that so my apologies for that we
do not actually need the router in this
file so we can just get rid of it
completely and this create posting we'll
do the exact same thing
so we are completely done with this
about Community component and we're
going to move on to the voting
functionality and I think the voting
functionality was probably the most fun
feature to build in this app because it
contains some really interesting logic
and I'm pretty excited to build it here
and show you guys how to do it okay so
in our use post hook if you remember
from a while ago we actually defined
this function on vote but it is
currently empty and now we are going to
write this thing out and get into the
nitty-gritty of the voting functionality
all right so before we get into actually
writing the code I just want to briefly
touch on how we are going to be modeling
the data for our voting functionality so
we're going to do something kind of
along the lines of what we did for the
community Snippets because if you look
back at the community Snippets we had
this sub collection on the user so we
knew what communities the user was in
and then on the community documents we
had this field called number of members
and so when a user would join a
community we would add a document to the
user's Community Snippets sub collection
and then we would go also update the
number of members of the community we're
going to do something similar here
because if you look at our posts we have
a field on the post called the vote
status which needs to be updated every
time a user votes on this particular
post and on our users we are going to
create another sub collection called
post votes and the post vote
subcollection is going to allow us to
know which posts the user has voted on
and in which communities and then we can
add documents remove documents or edit
documents in this collection depending
on what the user is doing doing and how
they're voting and then all we need to
do is just go and actually update the
associated post with the new vote status
depending on what vote the user has
placed so you're going to be dealing
with batch rights again because you're
going to be updating two documents post
votes as well as the post and we only
want both of these things to succeed or
none of them at all so we're going to be
using a batch write for this logic okay
so let's talk about this on vote
function now so I'm going to come over
to our demo and just go to the home page
here and when a user tries to vote on a
post there are three really important
things that we need to think about the
first thing is well what is the value of
this vote is it a nut Vote or a down
vote probably important to know the
second thing is has this user voted on
this post before
and the third thing and this sort of
ties into the second is if this user has
voted on this post before are they
changing their vote to be the opposite
or are they removing their vote
altogether all right so this post for
example I have not voted on this post so
I can upvote it or I can download it so
let's upload it okay and now if I want
to vote on this post well I have voted
on this post already so there are really
only two options here I can remove my
existing Vote or I can change my vote
from an upvote to a down vote and so
this type of logic is important when
we're writing out our function because
it dictates how we change this value you
can see that if I go from an up vote to
a down vote it changes by two and if I
go from a downward to knock out it
increases by two and if I remove an
existing upvote it goes down by one and
if I remove an existing down vote it
goes up by one so this is the logic
that's sort of going to drive the
structure of this on-road function over
here okay so for now this function is
going to take in three important
arguments the first one is going to be
the post that the user is trying to vote
on that is going to be a type post
second one is going to be the actual
vote value which is going to be a number
and the third one is going to be the
community ID in which this post is in
that's going to be a string so we can
write out this logic with just a few
simple if else statements so we can say
if this is a new vote
do something otherwise do something else
and this else statement represents an
existing vote meaning that they have a
voted on the post before and they're
making a modification to that vote and
sorry ignore this undefined error I'm
just trying to explain the concept here
but inside of this else statement there
are two things that can happen the first
thing is the user could be removing
their vote and this would just basically
be like going from an upvote to neutral
or down
to neutral
that is what I mean by removing the vote
the second thing that can happen though
is that there are flipping
their mode and this would look like
going from Up
to down or down
to up and both of these scenarios can be
handled by another if else statements we
can say if removing vote
then do something otherwise they must be
flipping their vote so do this other
thing
so in the case of a new vote the first
thing we want to do is either add or
subtract one to or from the post dot
vote status that is going to be the
first thing in our batch rate the second
part of our batch is going to be
creating a new postal document on the
user's postcode subcollection so in the
case of removing an existing vote we are
again going to be adding or subtracting
one from the post dot vote status
whether or not we're adding or
subtracting depends on the voting
direction that we are moving in the
second thing in the past is going to be
deleting the post vote document
and in the case of flipping a vote we
are again going to be adding and
subtracting from the vote status but in
this case it is going to be 2 because
we're flipping it so we need to add or
subtract 2. and this is the part that
tripped me up the most when I was
working on this logic here uh it's kind
of weird at first at least for me it was
uh the second thing in the batch is
going to be updating the existing post
vote document in the database so this is
a high level overview of this function
and I just wanted to spend a few minutes
to walk through this because I think
that will help when we're actually
writing out the code rather than just
diving right into it and being like Oh
yeah here this is how it works I think
this is much better for you to grasp so
um if I'm wrong I'm sorry but that is my
assumption so now we can actually start
working on writing out the code all
right you guys so the first thing we
need to do is go back to our post State
atom and actually create a spot where we
can store all of the postcodes from the
database so if we go back to our post
atom file here you may have remembered
that I briefly mentioned the post vote
section here on our post date and so now
we're actually going to implement that
here okay so we can re-enable this and
I'm actually going to create a
typescript type for our post votes so
we're going to need this in other files
so I'm going to write export and I'm
going to say type host vote and on our
post vote we're going to have an ID of
type string we're going to have a post
ID which is going to be the ID of the
post that this book belongs to and we're
also going to have the community ID
of the community that this post is in
and then of course we need the value of
the votes I'm going to create a new
parameter called load value and this is
going to be a number and it's going to
be a 1 for not vote and a minus one for
a download okay then down here on our
postage we can declare this as an array
of post photos just like this and then
on our default State we can just
initialize post votes as an empty array
and now typescript is all happy and we
are set up and we have a place to store
our post votes that we can actually use
them so let's go back to our use post
hook and start working on this function
okay so inside of this function I'm
going to create a try catch block as
usual and I'm going to move all of this
logic inside of our try block because
it's all of these stuff that we want to
attempt to do and then I'm going to fix
this spacing here and then if there is
an error we will log in the error so
let's say on vote
error and then log the error so we're
going to protect our voting feature
against users who are not authenticated
so at the very top of our function we're
going to check for a user and if there
is not an authenticated user we are
going to open the authentication model
but we will add that at the very end
because it's very simple so at the very
top of our try block we are going to
destructure the vote status from our
host that we're voting on so I'm going
to grab the vote status key here just
like this because you're going to use it
throughout all of this logic so the way
we can tell if the user has voted on
this post before or not is we can search
through the user post votes array in our
post item State here that we just added
and see if there's a vote with the post
ID that matches this post if there is
not an existing vote we are in the case
of a new vote if there is an existing
vote then we are in the case of the
existing vote okay so let's actually
create this so we can say const existing
vote this is going to be equal to post
State value dot post votes dot find we
want to search through this array for a
specific vote and the very next thing
we're going to do after writing out this
function is actually go and fetch those
post votes from the database and
populate this array with them but for
now just assume that this array is
populated with the user's post votes and
so we can iterate through every single
vote and we can check is there a vote
with the post ID that is equal to this
particular post's ID and so the find
function is either going to return to us
the existing Vote or it's going to
return undefined and then we can change
this to if there is no existing vote
which is equivalent to saying that it is
a new vote and also above all of these
if else statements I'm going to create
our batch instance using our right batch
function from firestore pass it our
firestore instance from Client app the
next variable I'm going to create is
going to be a copy of the post argument
just like this I'm going to create an
object and just spread the post inside
of it and I'll explain why I'm doing
this in just a second here underneath
here I'm going to create updated post
which is going to be a copy of our post
State value dot posts array and then
finally I'm going to create a updated
post votes array which is going to be a
copy of Hope statevalue dot post votes
okay and so the reason we're creating
these copies of these particular State
variables is because these three things
post posts and post votes are all going
to need to be modified depending on what
piece of the logic that we enter here
and so basically we create copies of the
current value of State modify these
copies throughout these if else
statements and then at the very end we
can take those modified values and use
them to update our state
and this creating copies of state and
mutating the copies rather than the
state itself is very common in react and
it ensures you avoid mutating State
directly because we definitely don't
want to do that because it can have
unwanted side effects and so this
pattern of creating copies of State
modifying those copies and then updating
state with that modified copy is a very
common thing to do in react and the last
variable I'm going to create up here is
going to be called vote change and I'm
going to initialize it to be the value
of a vote and this vote change variable
represents the amount that we are either
going to add or subtract to our post
documents vote status and again it's
going to be modified throughout this
logic here depending on what is
triggered within the logic and then at
the very end we will write that update
to our post document in the database so
it starts off as the value of vote and
depending on what logic is triggered
it's going to be modified and then we're
going to apply that change at the very
end and if all of this is a massive blur
and you're just like what is going on
don't worry once we actually start
writing this out it will become a lot
more clear this function is probably the
most like difficult to wrap your head
around in the entire build
um just give it some time let it absorb
and it should make sense with time all
right so let's start off with the case
where there is no existing vote that is
found meaning that this is a new vote so
I'm just going to put that comment here
and the first thing we're going to do
inside this if statement is create a
document reference to this new post vote
doc that we're going to store in our
database so you can create a variable
called post vote ref
and it's going to be a document
reference so we can use our doc function
for firestore and inside of here we want
to create a collection reference to the
collection that this document is going
to be in and so we can pass this our
firestore instance the collection that
we're going to write this document into
is going to be users and now we just
need to provide a path to this user's
post votes subcollection so we're going
to need our user object from our use off
State hook so let's bring it in up here
we can say cons user is equal to use
auth state
pass out our hot instance okay now down
here this path is going to be user.uid
slash post votes
so we are writing a document to the
user's post subcollection so you can
save that and now we can actually create
the new vote object that is going to be
stored in this document as well as on
our front-end state so we can call this
new vote this is going to be of type
post vote
and the ID is going to be our postvote
ref.id the post ID is going to be the
click on posts ID so post.id and we can
add the bang operator here to tell
typescript that we know that this is
going to be a defined value inside of
this function we can add the community
ID and then the vote value of this vote
is going to be the vote argument pass
the function so it's either going to be
1 or -1
and now we can add the document creation
operation to our batch so we can say
batch.set and the document we want to
set is post vote ref and the data we
want to store in the document is new
vote
and if you recall in order to make the
batch actually perform these operations
we do need to call the function
batch.commit but we are actually going
to call this at the very end of all of
this logic because depending on which if
else statements are triggered in here
the batch is going to contain different
operations so you're going to let it be
modified throughout this logic and then
at the very end we're going to commit
all of the tasks that it has been
assigned now let's actually update the
post vote status so we're going to
modify this updated post object because
if you remember it's just a copy of post
and it's this updated post that we want
to make the updates to so we can say
updated post
dot vote status and we want to update
this value to be the current vote status
which we grabbed off of the post from up
here so this represents the current vote
status and we want to add the value of
vote to it so either going to be adding
1 or adding minus one depending on if
the upvote or downvote okay and we also
want to add this new vote to our post
vote state so we can take our updated
post votes
and we basically want to append this new
vote to it so we can set this equal to
an array and inside of this array we
want to take all of the existing
postcodes so we can spread the value of
itself and then just add a new vote to
the end of it and make sure when you
declare updated post votes up here that
you use the let keyword here I believe I
initially had this as const but you will
get an error down here if you try to
reassign it if you use the const keyword
here make sure you do use let to allow
you to resign this variable here okay
and if it is a new vote the value of
vote change is going to remain the value
of vote so either 1 or -1 we do not need
to modify it inside of this if statement
because we're going to use this vote
change value in updating our post
document in our database which we're
going to add to our batch operations at
the very end of all of this if else
statements so we do need to make sure
we're updating this accordingly but in
the case of a new vote we do not need to
modify it it's just it's just going to
remain the value of vote okay let's talk
about the case of an existing vote so in
the case of an existing vote whether
we're removing or flipping the vote we
are going to be doing some sort of batch
right involving the post vote document
in our database so we can still create a
reference to that so we can say post
vote ref however this is going to be a
reference to an already existing
post-work document before we were
creating a reference to a newly created
document that doesn't exist yet whereas
this one does exist so we can pass this
our firestore instance the collection
that we're interested in is still users
and the path to this existing post hope
document is going to be on the user.uid
document slash post votes slash existing
vote.id
all right let's handle the case of the
user removing their existing vote so we
can tell if a user is removing their
vote if the vote that they're trying to
make matches the value of the already
existing vote okay so as an example let
me upload this post here so I just
created a new post vote with a vote
value of one because it was an upvote so
if I click on this out vote again and
send a value of 1 to our function that
is going to be equal to the already
existing vote value which is one so
that's how we can tell if the user is
removing their vote
okay we can say if the existing vote dot
vote value is equal to the vote that
they're trying to place that means
they're removing their existing vote
okay so now we want to add or subtract
one to or from the postpone status so
let's do that we can say a biddedpost
DOT vote status is equal to the current
vote status
but this time we want to subtract vote
because we want to go in the negative
Direction so let me upload this post if
I upvote it again I do not want it to go
to 210 I actually want it to go down to
208 right so we want to go in the
opposite direction
on the flip side if I download this if I
download it again I do not want it to go
to 206 I'm removing my downloads this
actually should go back up to 208. so
we're going in the negative Direction so
that is why we are subtracting the value
of both here and now we want to update
our post vote state but now we want to
remove the existing vote from our post
votes so you can set the SQL to
updatedpost votes dot filter
and our filter condition is going to be
that the vote ID does not equal to the
existing vote.id so this is going to
remove the existing vote from the post
votes array and we're storing that
filtered version inside of updated
postcodes which are going to use later
to update state so now we want to delete
the post vote document so we can add
that delete operation to our batch by
saying batch dot delete and the
documented delete is post vote ref
and also in the case of removing the
vote we want to negate the value of vote
change here so we're just going to
multiply it so we're going to say vote
change times equals negative 1. and
we're just going to negate it and if you
don't understand the complete purpose of
this vote change variable yet don't
worry it will make a lot more sense when
we actually get down to writing the
batch update for updating the post
documents vote status now let's talk
about the case of the user flipping
their vote in this case we're going to
be adding or subtracting 2 from the post
vote status so if I upvote this post
here if I flip my upvote to a downvote
it should not go back down to 208 it
should go down to 207 so it's decreasing
by two and on the flip side if I go from
a downvote to an upvote it increases by
two so to update our post vote status we
can take our updated post dot vote
status and we want to update this to be
the current vote status and we want to
add 2 times the value of the vote that
the user is trying to make so if I
download this vote is going to be
negative 1 but I want to subtract 2 from
209 so I want to do 2 times negative 1
which is negative 2. so I want to do 209
minus 2 which is going to be 207 in the
opposite direction it'd be 207 plus 2
times 1. so 209. I find this kind of
confusing at first I don't know about
you uh but yeah I don't know it was kind
of weird to wrap my head around the
first time I was doing it okay and now
we want to update our post votes array
but this time we're not adding 1 like in
the case of a new vote and we're not
removing one like in the case of
removing the vote we are editing one and
so in order to edit one we need the
index of this vote inside of the post
votes array and JavaScript has a very
handy array function called find index
where we can find the index of a
particular item in an array and then we
can use that to update the value at that
index so I'm going to create a variable
called vote index so I want to call the
function find index on the post notes
array so I can say post date value
dot postvotes dot find index
and this is going to iterate through all
of the votes and we want to find the one
where the vote ID is equal to the
existing book ID so we are finding the
existing vote so now we know the index
at which this existing vote sits inside
of this postbooks array so now we can
actually update that value of post
floats array to be the updated vote so
we can say updated post votes
at vote index
and we want to set this equal to a new
vote and that new vote is going to be
everything inside of existing vote but
with a updated vote value of the vote
that the user is trying to place and now
all we have to do is add our post update
operation to our batch rights so we can
say batch dot update and the document we
want to update is post for ref and the
update we want to make is to the vote
value field and we want to update the
value to be vote
okay so now at the end of all of these
if else statements we want to actually
update our post document in our database
so now we can create a reference to our
post document so that we can add the
update statement to our batch operations
so you can say post wrap is equal to Doc
pass in our firestore instance we want
to access the post collection and the ID
of this document is post.id and again we
can have the bang operator here to tell
texture that we know that this is going
to be a valid value and now we want to
add the post update operation to our
batch so we can say bash shut update we
want to update the post wrap and the
update that we want to make is to the
vote status field and this is where that
vote change value is going to come in we
want to do update vote status to be the
current value of vote status plus vote
change so the value of vote change is
going to be different depending on which
if else statement we triggered in here
it could be -2 it could be plus two
could be one it could be minus one
depending on where we ended up in those
statements it was modified and now at
this point we have all of the batch
operations set up so we can actually
execute them by saying await batch dot
commit and this is going to write those
updates to our database so now all we
have to do is update our front-end
recoil State and we're going to do that
using these copies up here that we
created because the copies were modified
and updated throughout all this logic
and now we can take those values and
actually store them in state and our
state will contain all of the updates
necessary so we can call our set post
date value function take the previous
value of state and we're going to update
a few values here we're going to update
our post array and the updated value of
this is going to be updated posts
and we also want to update our post
votes and our updated value of this is
going to be updated host votes
awesome so now I hope the idea of making
these copies and then modifying the
copies and then using those copies to
update State at the very end makes more
sense now that we've kind of written out
this logic okay so this is completely
fine and we are updating State except we
are missing one thing
this updated post array has not yet been
updated to contain this newly updated
post so if you remember we created this
variable called updated post which just
represents the post that we're voting on
and depending on what type of vote the
user placed we updated that post vote
status right we added one to it added
two to it subtracted to it whatever we
updated the vote status but we did not
take that newly updated post and store
it inside of the updated post array so
updated post does not yet contain the
newly updated and modified host with the
new vote status okay so in order to
update the single post element inside of
the updated post array we are going to
need access to that post index pretty
much the exact same thing we had to do
with our vote here we needed the vote
index to update that vote inside of post
vote we need the post index so that we
can update the value at that index so we
can find the host index very similarly
to how we found the vote index above we
it's a post index is going to be equal
to post statevalue dot posts dot find
index
okay and then we want to iterate through
all of the post items and find the one
where the ID is equal to the post that
we're voting on ID so post dot ID just
like this so now we can use this index
to actually update our updated post so
we can say updated posts at post index
is going to be equal to updated host
just like that and now updated post
contains the post with the latest vote
status value so I think we are all done
with the logic of our on vote function
the last thing we need to do is just go
back to our post component and if you
remember we had this prop that we
defined here user vote value and we just
temporarily passed it as undefined
because we had not built the voting
logic yet so now we can actually make
this the correct value and also we're
getting a typescript compiler error here
for on-vote thing I think we just have
to fix the um the type declaration for
our function but we will do that in a
second Let's ignore that for now okay so
now that we actually have an existing
post votes array we can basically search
through that array and and see if there
is a vote with the post ID of this item
that we're currently iterating through
is ID so that would look something like
this so we could say post date value
dot post about dot find so we can
iterate through all of the votes and see
if there's one with a post ID that
matches this particular post items ID
so then if the find function does end up
finding a vote we can grab that vote
vote value and if it does not find it
then user vote value will just be
undefined and it will behave as if the
user has not voted on the post which is
exactly what we want now we can just
quickly fix this on vote compiler error
so I just have to go into our post item
and yeah change this to be the proper
function declaration type so if you just
go to our use post I'm just going to
copy these argument types here and bring
them over to our post item
paste them in there and then this
function is going to return void okay
now that should satisfy X group over
here and what's going on in here okay
now now we just have to change the
actual way these on remote functions are
being called so I'm just going to change
it to a callback function that calls on
vote and we need to pass it three
arguments and the first one is the
actual post the second one is the actual
vote value so for an upvote it is going
to be one and the third one is going to
be the community ID which is going to be
post doc Community ID
perfect we can just copy this
and paste it on our downvote one here
but we want to change the value of our
vote down here to be negative one our on
vote function I think is complete we
have successfully passed the user vote
value to the post item component so that
we can tell if we have voted on this
post and what that value is so I think
we are ready to give this a go so let me
try this out and see what happens if I
click on this
you can see that we are seeing those
changes and what happens if I flip my
vote
perfect if I remove my vote
awesome so it seems to be working let's
go back to the back end and see what
should be happening over there so I'm
going to come over here and split screen
this with our app okay so what we want
to see is inside of users if I vote on a
post I should see
um the post vote subcollection appear so
I'm going to find the Shad Mary one here
so let's go back to our app so if I vote
on this
and then I just refresh this on the
first time when that collection is
created you have to refresh because the
collection doesn't exist but after that
it is in real time so yeah you can see
that there is a post votes collection
here
um and it has the post ID of that post
it has the vote value and then if I flip
this vote
you can see that that is being updated
if I remove the vote it's deleted how
cool is that I think that's so cool
awesome okay and the other thing that
should be changing is if I go look at
the post
we should see the vote status has been
updated so that's the other thing that
is in our batch right remember so if I
downvote this it updates to negative one
a vote goes back to one if I remove the
vote zero awesome so our batch rights
are working we are able to actually vote
on posts and the vote status of the post
document is updating as well how cool is
that
let's put this back over here all right
you guys so the last thing we need to
add here is just a quick function that
is going to actually initialize the
value of this post votes array by going
to the database and getting this user's
post votes for the current community and
I briefly mentioned before that we were
going to do that because right now the
post quotes is just an empty array and
so if I were to vote on a post the array
is populated but then if I refresh this
page we can see that that vote is not
going to be persisted because we do not
go and get those user votes from the
database so the one persists because the
post document was updated but in terms
of our post votes we have not retrieved
them yet so we actually can't see that
we have indeed voted on this post so to
fix that we just need to add a function
that is going to be called as soon as we
land on a community page to actually go
and get all of our votes to the posts in
this community so it's pretty simple and
we are going to add that inside of our
use post hook here so at the bottom I'm
going to create this function called get
community post votes and it's going to
be asynchronous and it's going to take
in a community ID which is of type
string and it is going to go and
actually fetch all of this user's post
votes for the current community that
they are currently in hence the name get
community post vote and it should be
plural books and votes with an ads so we
can just write a simple query for our
post votes collection and then store
those documents inside of our post votes
array in our recoil state so let's write
that out so we can say const post votes
query is equal to query so bringing the
query function from firestore and the
first argument is going to be the
collection that we want to query so we
can pass in our collection function
which is going to take in our firestore
instance the collection we are querying
is users and the path to the postcode
subcollection is going to be user.uib
slash post votes so the second argument
to our query is going to be a where
Clause because we only want to find the
post votes where the post votes
Community ID matches the community ID
that we're interested in so in this case
chatty's Group whatever Community we're
in we only want the post votes for that
community so the field we're interested
in on our coursework documents is
community ID and we want to check if the
community ID is equal to this community
ID that is being passed in as an
argument just like this
okay so now we can pass this query to
our get docs function to actually go and
get this set of documents from our
database you can say post vote
stocks is equal to a weight get Docs and
we can pass in our post votes query
and this is going to return to us an
array of firestore documents and we want
to extract all of the data out of each
of those documents so we can create a
new array called post votes and we can
take our post docs and map through all
of them so we can say
postcodeocs.docs dot map and for each
one of those documents we want to return
a new JavaScript object with the ID
as well as the extracted data from that
document just like this
and now we can store this post votes
array in our recoil postcode state so
you can say set Post State value take
the previous value
spread it and the only field we want to
update here is post votes and the value
in this case is going to be post Focus
and to satisfy the 10th trip compiler
here we can just headcast this to be an
array of post votes so make sure that
that type imports from our post item
file so that is it for this function
here but we have not yet called it so we
want to call this function as soon as
the user lands on any given Community
page and so to do that we can create a
use effect make sure that imports from
react
and inside of our use effect we can call
our get community post votes function
and then we can pass in the community ID
so we can get the community ID from our
communities atom inside of the current
community so if you come up to the top
here
of our hook we can use our recoil hook
to grab the value of the current
community so I'm going to create a
variable called current community
and I'm going to use the hook use recoil
value
and I'm going to pass to meet
communities
atom Community State atom and I want to
access the current Community just like
this
now down here
I can pass this as an argument to that
function so I can say current Community
dot ID
just like this
now typescript is complaining and we're
going to fix that by adding a guard
above this function to prevent calling
this function at all if there is no
current Community because it doesn't
make sense to get community post votes
if there is not a current community so
what we can do is add a dependency here
of the current community and so every
time the current Community changes this
is going to trigger and we want to make
sure there is a defined Community before
calling this function so we can just add
an if statement here to return out of
this function if there is no current
Community dot ID
and that will make Tech strip happy down
here now there is one more dependency we
need to add here because if we look at
our community post votes it depends on a
valid user ID as well we do not want to
call this function if the user has not
been logged in or if the user has not
yet been loaded from our auth service so
we can add a dependency here of the user
and in our if statement here we can add
if there is no user or no Community ID
return and do not call this function
because well this function is pretty
useless without either of those two
things okay so now if I actually refresh
this page my post votes are going to be
fetched from the database as soon as
this component loads and then they are
stored in the post vote state so that I
can see which post I have voted on on
refresh so if I download this post and
then I were to refresh
we should see that vote as soon as the
page refreshes which we do awesome and
so now every time we go into a different
Community this use effect is going to
trigger because the value of current
Community is going to change to the new
community and it's going to go get the
post votes for that new community so
that is how this logic Works cool and
just for fun just we can see more
exciting values other than 1 minus one
and zero I'm going to go through this
post here and just modify this to like
450 462 and come back here and save it
so that we can actually see this value
modify it's a little bit more exciting
so now if I download this it goes down
to 460. if I go back up 462 and I move
that vote 461 downvote remove the
downvote very cool the logic seems to be
working I love it I think this voting
functionality is super cool it is
another extremely important pillar of
the Reddit functionality without voting
Reddit would not be Reddit so so we have
successfully implemented voting
functionality and we have written out
probably the most complicated function
of this build so congratulations for
making it to here I hope that I was able
to explain that in the most clear way
possible if anything is unclear please
ask in the Discord I would love to help
you or just comment down below but I
hope it makes sense and now we can move
on to other things so now we can
actually protect this feature against
unauthenticated users by adding a simple
check at the top here to see if they are
logged in and if they are not we can
open the modal and this is exactly what
we've done with other features like
trying to a community it's the exact
same thing but there's another
interesting thing related to this that
we need to take care of so watch what
happens when I log out
so I logged out but my votes are still
there and that doesn't really make sense
our community Snippets were cleared
because it no longer knows that we're in
this community because there is no user
signed in but our votes are still there
so we definitely want to clear those out
of state when the user logs out so the
way we can do that is by just adding
another simple use effect to listen to
changes in our user object so let's
create that so we can say use effect
and we can add a dependency here of user
so this is going to trigger every time
the user object changes and if on one of
those changes there is no user
we want to clear the post vote state so
we can say set or state value take the
previous value and we want to update
this state
to have empty post votes so we can set
post votes equal to an empty array just
like this
okay so you saw that they cleared there
so I'm just going to add a comment here
for clarity clear user post votes
all right so now what happens when we
log back in let's see if it actually
goes and fetches our post once for us
okay so it does not it's weird right
because we have voted on these posts
it's not picking that up it's not
fetching them it fetched our Snippets
because it knows we're joined into here
but it's not getting our vote okay so it
fetched our Snippets because it knows
that we're in this community but it did
not go and fetch our vote and the reason
that is is because on this use effect
here we have a dependency of current
Community but we are not getting to this
get community postcards function because
we are not getting past this if
statement and the reason that is is
because if you remember when we logged
out we reset our entire Community State
atom meaning that current Community is
currently null therefore there is no
current Community dot ID so this if
statement is protecting against running
this function so you just need to
slightly refactor the log out flow here
because on the logout we only want to
clear the community Snippets we don't
really want to reset the entire
Community State atom so if we go back to
this user menu here this is where we did
that on logout we just called this reset
Community State function and completely
cleared that Adam so I'm just going to
comment this out here and what we're
going to do instead is go into our use
Community data hook and basically do
something similar to what we're doing
with the post votes here we're going to
add it use effect with a listener on our
user and then if there is no user we're
just going to clear these Snippets only
not the entire Community State itself so
let's go and do that so inside of our
use Community data hook we already have
a use effect that is listening to
changes in the user and then if there is
indeed a valid user it will go get the
Snippets for that user so all we need to
do is just refactor this if statement
very slightly so instead of returning
what I'm going to do is inside of this
if there is no user we want to set our
community State value to be the previous
value
but with empty my Snippets basically the
exact same thing we're doing with our
post votes over here clearing them out
if there is no user and then at the end
of this we can return just like this so
now when the user logs out we are only
clearing these Snippets we are not
clearing the current Community State so
then when we log back in it will
actually go get our post votes so let's
see if this works so I'm going to log
out
and I'm just going to refresh to reset
everything
so if I log back in it should know that
we have joined this community and it
also should pick up the votes on these
posts here so let's try this so let's
log in
perfect so it works it went and got our
Snippets and it also got our votes now
let's see if when we log out it clears
those things
perfect so all we're doing in these use
effects here is just clearing all of the
user specific data inside of our post
date as well as VAR as well as our
community state so the post votes as
well as these Snippets should be cleared
when there is no user perfect so I'm
just going to go back to the user menu
delete this and we actually do not need
this reset Community State value
function can close our user menu so now
all we have to do is just add a simple
check at the top here if the user is
attempting to vote on a post and they
are not locked in we want to prompt them
to log in so we can say if there is no
user.uid then we want to open the modal
and in order to do that we're going to
grab our set Automotive State function
from recoil so we can say set off model
state is equal to use set recoil and
pass in our auth Moto State atom so make
sure that Imports and then inside the
safe statement here we just want to call
that set off Motor State function and we
want the state to be open
as well as the view to be logged in and
then we can return because we do not
want to proceed so now if I try to vote
on a post and I'm not logged in it is
going to ask me to log in so now we can
log in
and once I log in it'll go and actually
fetch that data for us which is super
cool and then I can change my votes if I
would like to awesome guys so we have
successfully implemented the voting
functionality into our app and we have
written out probably the most
complicated function of this entire
build so congratulations for making it
here I really hope that I was able to
explain all of that in the most clear
way possible but if anything is unclear
please do ask in the Discord I would
love to help you or just leave a comment
down below and I'll also answer that but
I do hope that it makes sense and that
was a long Sprint we had to do to
implement voting functionality but we
are done and it is an essential part of
Reddit without voting Reddit would not
be Reddit so I am glad we have
implemented it and we can now move on to
other things all right you guys so the
next thing we're going to work on is the
single post page so if we go to our demo
here we want to build the functionality
so that we can click on posts like this
and then it takes us to a page that is
specific to that post and this is where
we can see all of the comment comments
on this post as well as comment
ourselves and if you look at the URL up
here it is at the route r slash baking
slash comments slash post ID so this is
the route we need to build and that is
what we're going to do now so let's come
back to our app here and if we just take
a quick look at our post atom you may
have remembered that we actually did
Define the state for the selected post
so selected post represents the single
post that we are currently viewing so
when I click on a post we are going to
store that post inside of selected post
and then when we're on this page here
that is where we're going to read data
from and also in our use post hook we
did Define that function right here it
is currently empty this is the function
that is going to be called when we click
on a post and all it is going to do is
just take that post and put it into that
selected post date it's a very simple
four to five line function okay so the
first thing we're going to do is
actually create the page route for this
page so again the route for this page is
going to be r slash Community ID slash
comments slash post ID so inside of our
community ID folder we need to create
another folder called comments and
inside of our comments folder we can
create our Dynamic post ID route so we
can use our square brackets and inside
here we can put PID dot TSX square
brackets because again it is a dynamic
route the post ID can change depending
on what we click on okay then inside of
here we can use our snippet and we can
get rid of these props here
and I'm going to rename this component
to be host page just like this and we're
not going to have any props we can get
rid of that and that is good to go and
then we can just add the text post page
here so now if I go to this route here
if I just go to R shatters Group slash
comment slash some random posted it
could be anything
we should see this post-page text here
and we do awesome now if we go back and
look at the demo we can see again that
it has the same layout as every other
page so we can again use our page
content layout component with our posts
and comments in the left hand side and
the about component in the right hand
side once again the page content layout
saves our lives and we do not have to
write any more Styles we can just drop
components in and it is easy peasy Plug
and Play Let's go back to our app here
and this is what we're going to do we
can get rid of this div and we can
return that page content layer component
to make sure that imports from that file
there then we can have our two left hand
side right hand side fragments here okay
and on the left this is where we're
going to have the selected post as well
as the comments for that selected post
okay and then on the right hand side
we're just going to have our about
component
and our selected post is going to be a
component we have already created which
is just post item and we're just going
to pass it the selected post as the post
prop so the first thing we're going to
do is work on the post item for the
selected post so we can reuse our
prosthetic component like I was just
mentioning so make sure that Imports and
if you remember from our posts component
which is the place for that map through
all of the community posts and returns a
post item we pass this a bunch of
functions that come from our use post
hook so again in this PID page we are
going to need to bring in those
functions from our so at the top here we
can call our hook we can say use posts
make sure all of this Imports and the
values we're going to get from this hook
are going to be posted value set post
date value on delete post as well as on
vote and we do not need the on select
post function in this page here because
we don't really need to select a post if
we are already in the single page view
so we are not going to pass the select
post function to our post item component
on this page like we were on the
Community page so we do not need this
from the hook now down here we can start
passing in some of these props so the
first thing we need to pass is a post
and that post is going to be our
selected post from our post date so you
can say hostate value
no autocomplete dot selected post and
ignore these compiler errors for now we
are going to deal with that our second
prop is going to be our on vote function
so on vote is equal to on vote on delete
this is equal to on delete post save
this so it reformats our user vote value
is going to be the exact same we can do
our host date value dot postvotes dot
find and we want to iterate through all
these items and look for a vote with the
post ID that matches the postatevalue
dot selectedpost dot ID perfect and then
if there is one we can grab the vote
value just like that
okay the user is Creator we are going to
check if the user's ID matches the
selected post Creator ID so we are going
to need to bring our user in up here
from our use off State hook so current
user is equal to use off State passes
our auth object from Client app
now our user is Creator prop is going to
be the Boolean that the user's ID is
equal to the posted value dot selected
post dot Creator ID that is how we will
know if this user is the owner of this
post and typescript is currently
complaining because the selected post is
initialized as null and to prevent this
we can wrap this component in the
condition that we only want to show it
if there is actually a valid truthy
selected post so we can save this and
it's still complaining because on select
post is missing okay so we want to go to
our post item and we want to make the on
select post function an optional prop
because again this is only going to be
passed to the post item on the Community
page not in the single post page and
that should satisfy the typescript
compiler on this page awesome so now we
have a happy component we currently do
not have a selected post because we have
not done anything inside of our on
select post function but when we do it
will show that post so let's go do that
now let's go to our use post hook and
actually work on this function it's a
very simple function so this function is
going to take in an argument which is
going to be the post we are clicking on
and it's going to be of type post and
all we want to do inside of here is take
that post and put it into the selected
Post State so we can say set post date
value
and the only value we want to update in
our state in this function is going to
be selected post and we want to set it
equal to the past and post and when the
user clicks on the post we actually want
to take them to that page so we can use
our router to do that so we can bring in
our router up top so we can say cons
router is equal to use router from next
router then down here inside of our on
select post function we can use the
router to direct the user to that path
so we can say router.push and the route
we want to take them to is forward slash
R forward slash then the community ID
which can be accessed on post dot
Community ID then slash comments slash
post dot ID and that is how we can take
them to that route and I think we added
this to the on click of the post item if
I remember correctly so I'm just going
to close some of these files here
um if you go to our post item I think we
did add this to the on click okay yeah
we did we're gonna need the changes a
bit though because we need to pass in
some arguments so what we're going to do
is change this on click to a callback
that is going to call our on select post
and as an argument we just needs to pass
in that post typescript is unhappy about
two things here so let's take a look at
these so the first one is it saying that
expected zero arguments but got one and
that is because our type definition for
our on select post function in our props
does not say that we are taking in an
argument so we can change that to be
exactly like this
and we should be good down there for
that first compiler error the second
compiler error is that it is saying that
we cannot invoke an object which is
possibly undefined just a few seconds
ago we made the on select post function
an optional prop meaning that if it is
not passed the value for it is going to
be undefined and typescript is basically
saying well this can be undefined
sometimes but you're trying to call an
undefined instance so that is not
allowed that's really bad and the way we
can fix this is to basically just add
some simple logic here to make sure that
it is passed as a prop and that it is a
defined function before calling it and
we can do that similarly to how we do it
with react components we can say on
select post
and on select post so we are so on click
we are first going to check for a truthy
valid value of on select posts if it
exists then we will call this function
here and so now when I go back to the
Community page
chatty's group
I should be able to click on a post and
take me to that post page so if I click
on this it does indeed do that so we are
on this page this is the ID of this
particular post and I can go back and I
should be able to click on another one
perfect so it's functioning exactly how
we want it and now this post is inside
of the selected Post State here because
our on select post function did that all
right the next thing we're going to do
is apply some very slight modifications
to the style of this component if we are
indeed on the single post page if you
look at this demo here if I click on
this post
you can see that it's styled differently
we don't have the great background
number here the Border radiuses are
slightly different there is no mouse
hover because it's not really clickable
so it is very very minor things that we
have to go and modify inside of our post
item component over here so let's do
that quickly so inside of our post item
the way we can tell whether or not we
are on the single post page versus the
Community page is if the on select post
proc is passed because remember that we
are only passing the on select post
function as a prop to our post item
component on the Community page we are
not passing it on the PID page because
we do not need to select the post any
further than we have already selected it
so that is how we can tell inside of our
post item if we are on the single post
page or the Community page if this is
defined we are on the Community page if
it is undefined we are in the single
post page and that is how we are going
to conditionally modify the styles of
this component all right so applying
this logic we can create a new variable
called single
post page
which is going to be a Boolean that
represents if we are on the single post
page so this is going to be true if on
select post is undefined okay so if
there is no select post then it is true
that we are on the single post page so
that is how we can detect which page we
are on and so the purpose of this
variable is that we can use it inside of
our Styles here to just conditionally
apply certain Styles and there's only
about four or five things you have to
change here so it's pretty minor the
first thing is going to be our border
color so now we can get rid of this gray
300 and instead we're going to use a
ternary operator to check the truthiness
of our single post page variable so you
can say single post page if this is true
we want the Border color to be white and
if it is false we want the Border color
to be Gray 300. perfect the next thing
is going to be our border radius so if
we are in the single post page view
then we want the order rate is to be
four pixels four pixels zero pixels zero
pixels and if you are not we just want
it to be four pixels and as for our
hover styling we do not want to apply a
border color if we are hovering in the
single post page so you can say single
post page if we are we do not want the
hoverboard color if we are not we do
want it and we want to be Gray 500. so
now if I hover we're not seeing that
there and we can do the exact same thing
to our cursor so for our cursor we can
say single post page if that is true we
do not want a cursor so we're going to
use the keyword on set if it is false we
want pointer
perfect so now we do not have that
cursor on this page now there are just
two more things we have to change and
they're both on this loading container
here so for our background if we are on
the single post page we want a
background of none and if we are not we
want a background of gray 100 okay now
you say live background disappear which
is perfect and the very last thing is
the Border radius so you can have the
ternary operator once again if it is
true we do not want a border radius and
if it is false we want the important
radius of 3 pixels zero pixels zero
pixels three pixels all right and that
is it for our styling modifications okay
so what we need to do now is make two
very very small tweaks to our on vote
function because currently it will not
work on this page if I try to vote on
this post the voting works I'm able to
actually place a vote but you can see
that the vote status of the post is not
working and so we do have to fix that
all we need to do inside of our envelope
function is check for the existence of a
selected post because that means we are
voting on these elected posts from the
single post page and if there is a
selected post we just want to update it
to be that updated post it's very very
simple it's a single if statement
awesome so what we can do is come down
here and just underneath this first set
post a value function we can write an if
statement to say if post a value
dot selected posts if there is a
selected post we want to call our set
post date value function and update our
selected post to contain that latest
vote status which is going to be on the
updated post object here so we can
spread the previous value and update
select a post to be updated post just
like that so now if I click on this you
can see that the vote status is indeed
updating and our voting functionality
does work okay now there's one more
thing we have to change in this function
and I'm going to show you what it is so
if we go back to the Community page our
slash chatties group we are going to see
something very interesting when I try to
vote when I click on the vote here
you can see that it takes us to the
Community page it does place the vote
but it's still uh reroutes us to that
page and we don't want to do that right
we don't want to reroute the user if
they are trying to get more on the post
you only want to do that if they kind of
click on the main body of the post here
and so this can be solved by what is
called event propagation so basically
What's Happening Here is that these
icons here have on click functions
attached to them which is our on-boat
function but our post item also has a
non-click function and since the vote
icons are children of the post item it's
triggering both and we do not want to do
that and we can stop this Behavior with
what is called event propagation all we
need to do to fix this is just accept
the click event as an argument to our
ongoing function and then call it
function on that event called stop
propagation and that will prevent the
event from traveling upwards to the
parent which in this case is our post
item all right so let's add that as our
first argument here so it's going to be
called event and the type of this is
going to be a react.mouse event because
it is a click
and the type of element that is
generating this mouse event is going to
be an SVG element because our our upvote
downward icons are svgs and then as a
second argument here we can pass the
mouse event type and we can save this
and we're actually going to copy this
and we need to update our type
declaration for this function inside of
our post item here so we can just add
this as that first argument save this
hit and then we can come down to the on
click functions here and all we need to
do is in both of these cases I'm going
to add the event
as a first argument to this function
here
okay so let's go back to our ongoed
function and at the very top the very
first thing we're going to do is say
event dot stop propagation
now if I place a vote
we are not being redirected because that
event is stopped that in its tracks it
is not traveling upwards and triggering
the on click of the post item perfect
but if I still click on the other parts
of the post item it still takes us there
which is great and now I can vote from
it here very very cool voting Works in
both pages and we also need to add our
event.stoppropagation function to our
delete function because right now if we
were to click on delete it would do the
exact same thing as the voting was
before and it would actually take us to
the single post page view which we do
not want so I'm going to copy this event
type from here because it's going to be
the exact same in our delete function
then inside of our post item since we're
handling the delete in here I'm going to
paste that event in here and we just
have to change this from an SVG element
to an HTML div element because that is
the type of the component that's
generating this event this time and the
very first thing we want to do in this
function is the exact same stop
propagation function as it are on vote
and also if I delete a post from the
single post page view I wanted to take
us back to the community page and so we
already have this variable to detect if
we are on the single post page so we
just can add a quick few lines here to
rewrap the user back to the Community
page if they are indeed deleting the
post from the single post page so we can
bring in our router to do that we can
say cons router is equal to use router
then we want to do after the post is
successfully deleted is checked are we
on the single post page view
if we are then let's push the user back
to the Community page so we can do that
by doing router.push forward slash R
forward slash
benypost.unity ID so now if I delete the
post from the single post page view it
should
take me back to this page and the post
should be gone so now I can delete them
from both the pages so let's create a
new one just to test this out I don't
want to delete that other one because it
has the image in there hey dude blah
blah random post this okay so now if I
delete this I can delete it from both
Pages just like the voting functionality
so perfect so let's come back to our
post ID page here and I want to show you
something interesting what happens if I
refresh this page
what do you think is going to happen
let's find out
okay so nothing is there so the reason
this is happening is because our
selected post state is actually
currently null and why is this happening
let's backtrack to the logic of how
selected posts actually got to be not
null in the first place
if we go back to our post component
which is again on the Community page we
sent this on select post function to the
post item component and then when we
clicked on a specific item within this
list
it took that post and it put it in the
selected Post State so right now our PID
page only works if we're coming from the
community page so if I click on this
post yeah it works fine I can go back if
I click on this it works fine but if I
refresh this page our app is not yet
built to get the selected post which is
required if we are not coming directly
from the community page we want to build
it so that we can visit this link
directly and view that post without
having to come from the community page
because that's probably a very common
occurrence on Reddit there's probably a
lot of times where people share the
links to certain posts and then that
person who received the link clicks on
it and they're visiting reddit.com to
only view that post they don't want to
go to the Community page and then go to
the Post page you know what I mean and
as of right now we could not share this
link with anyone because it would come
to this link and be like oh well
nothing's here cool so we just need to
make a simple addition to account for
this all we need to do is on our post ID
page when a user visits this page we can
check if there is a selected post inside
of the post date value and if there is
not meaning that they are visiting this
page directly and not coming from the
community page we can go and grab it
ourselves from the database and then put
it into the selected Post State directly
from here and on this page we have
everything we need to do that in the URL
we have the post ID so we can query our
database to grab that post and then put
it into State and it'll function exactly
as it was before all right so what we
can do is create a function called Fetch
post and this is going to be responsible
for fetching a single post from the
database and we are only going to call
this sometimes and we're going to see
what that sometimes is so let's get
taken a post ID of type string
and we're going to leave it empty for
just a second and we want to check if we
need to call this function as soon as
this page loads and to do that we can
use a use effect because this is going
to run as soon as the component amounts
to the dot and I'm just going to leave
the dependencies MP for now so inside of
this use effect we want to check a
condition that will tell us whether or
not we need to call our fetch post
function and that condition is going to
be if there is a valid post ID in the
URL and there is no selected post that
means we need to call this function
fetch post and actually go and get this
post because it means the user has
refreshed the page or they are visiting
our website for the first time on this
link so we can grab the post ID from the
URL using our next router so we can
bring that in up here we can say const
router is equal to use router
and on this page we know that there is a
parameter called PID inside of the
router query and it's called PID because
that is what we call as our Dynamic
route in our square brackets so we can
grab that value from our router.query
object just like this
PID
now we can write the logic for that
condition that I just said a few seconds
ago so if there is a PID
and there is no selected post inside of
post date value
then we want to call our fetch post
function and pass it the PID as an
argument and again typescript is
freaking out here because the query
parameter can technically be an array of
strings or a string in our case it's
always just going to be one host ID so
we're going to type pass it to a string
now because the logic inside of our used
effect does depend on the router.query
as well as the post date value selected
post we do need to add those as
dependencies in this use effect here so
we can say router dot query as the first
one and then post datevalue.selected
post as the second one
and that is it for this use effect all
we have to do now is just write this
function which is very simple it's just
a single query to get this post from the
database we can as usual create a try
catch block and log the error if it
occurs
fetch
post error
log of the error and inside of our try
block we want to actually attempt to go
and get this pose document from our
database so we can create a reference to
that document so we can say post doc ref
is equal to Doc
tested our firestore instance from
Client app the collection we are getting
this document from is posts and the ID
of this document is going to be the post
ID argument of this function and then we
can actually get this document from our
database and we can create a new
variable called postdoc and we can use
await get doc
and pass it our postdoc ref just like
this okay and now we can take this
result and update our selected post date
to contain the data from this document
so you can take our previous value of
postage
and we can update our selected post and
the value our selected post is going to
be a post object with an ID that is
postdoc dot ID and all of the data from
the postdocs data so we can spread
postdoc dot data just like this and then
to satisfy typescript we can Typecast
this as a type host
awesome and so I saved it and you can
see that it did go get that post for us
so now if I refresh this page it
actually gets the post for us which is
amazing we do not have to come from the
community page and we are going to face
this exact same refresh problem with our
community data as well because that data
is originally coming from the community
page let's go take a look at that
Community page just as a reminder
so this page is server side rendered if
you recall we are calling the get server
side props function and we are getting
the community data from the database and
then we are passing that to this uh
Community page here so then we take this
community data put it into our current
Community State right here as soon as
this page renders and then we can access
this stage from the other pages that
need it like the submit page as well as
the single post page that we're going to
see so if I were to go to the single
post page and we are going to display
the about component on the right here if
you remember right now the current
Community data is populated with the
strategies group data but if I refresh
this page it is not going to be there
because again the home Community page is
responsible for completing that initial
population so we can only access it if
we come to this post page or the submit
page after the Community page so if you
visit these Pages directly it is not
going to be there so we have the exact
same problem that we had with our single
post and we can do something extremely
similar to what we did here where we
just attack for a community ID in the
URL and then we go okay there's a
community ID in the URL but there's no
current community in state that must
mean we didn't come directly from the
community page so we should go get the
community data and put it in state
directly from where we're trying to
access it and let me further illustrate
this by actually bringing in the about
component here so I can show you how
it's going to be there initially but not
when we refresh the page similar to our
post item in this page
so we can bring in the Bell component
and this requires the community data as
a prop so we can grab that state from
our use Community data hook up here
use Community data make sure that
Imports and the only value you want to
grab from that hook in this component is
going to be Community State value then
down here we can pass the Community
State value dot current Community as a
prop okay and typescript is complaining
because the current Community is
initialized as null but we're telling
the about component that we are always
passing valid truthy Community data so
what I'm going to do is add a condition
here to say we don't want to show the
above component unless we actually have
Community State value dot current
community so if I save this you can see
that this component does appear over
here because we actually do have current
Community State right now because we
came from our community page but watch
what happens when I refresh this same
thing is going to happen and it's not
going to be there
so it's not and you also notice that my
post vote data is gone as well I have
uploaded this post but after refreshing
that data is gone and the reason our
votes aren't there is because if you go
to our use post hook we had that use
effect that gets our votes in a certain
Community only if there is a valid
current community in state and as of
right now that only occurs if we come
directly from the community page
so inside of our youth Community data
hook we are going to do the exact same
thing that we are doing here however we
are going to be looking for a current
Community as well as the community ID
from the router.query in that case so
let's go over to our use Community data
hook so we're going to create that
function called get community data and
this is going to be asynchronous
I'm just like our fetch post function we
are only going to call this sometimes
and that sometimes is when we are going
directly to the single post page or
directly to the submit page we do not
need to call this function if we do
indeed come from the community page
because the community data will already
be in state so underneath here let's
create a use effect
and I'm going to leave the dependencies
empty for now
and I don't know if we have our router
imported in here yet we do not okay so
at the very top here but we need our
user I'm going to grab our router so
cons router is equal to use router from
next router and inside of this use
effect
we can grab the community ID parameter
from our router.query so you can say
router.query and we want to destructure
the community ID which in this case is
going to be Shadow's group now we can
write the exact same if statement as we
did before with the post we can say if
there is a community ID
and there is not a community State value
dot current community
we want to call that get community data
function and we can pass in our
community ID as an argument just like
this and then up here we just need to
accept that
like that as an argument and then down
here this is a similar router type error
we had before we can just type cast that
Community ID to a string and then up
here we just have to write a simple
query to go and actually get the data
for this community all right so let's
create a try block
um first things first log the error
good old error handling
then inside of our try block we can
create a reference to that Community
document
is equal to Doc firestore the collection
we are interested in querying is the
communities collection and the ID of the
document we want is community ID now
let's actually get that document from
our database by calling our get doc
function and we can call this community
Doc is equal to a weight get doc pass in
the document you want to get which is
community.graph and now all we need to
do is just put the data from this
community dock inside of our current
Community State so you can call set
Community State value
and when we want to update the current
Community to be a community object with
the ID of community.id and all of the
data inside of that document so we can
spread the community doc dot data and we
can tell typescript that that this is
going to be of type community
okay and that is it for this function
now all we have to do is just come down
here and add those two dependencies to
our use effect dependency array first
one router.query and Community State
value
dot current community
just like this
so now if I save you saw that the
community data is now in state so that
about Community component appears and it
went and got our post votes for this
community because again if we go back to
look at this use effect here this is
listening to changes in the current
community of state and it's like oh now
there's actually a current Community
there I should go get the votes for this
community
and so then it did and amazing so now I
should be able to refresh this page
without coming directly from the
community page and it should just go and
get that data for us perfect so that is
great and that improves our user
experience significantly and it makes
our product realistic so now what I'm
going to do is I think I forgot to put
the about component on the submit page
actually
um yeah I did so let's go to our submit
page here yeah I totally forgot to put
that in there and so we are grabbing our
community State value from recoil but
I'm going to change this to get the
Community State value from our use
Community data hook so that it actually
triggers this use effects here because
the use effect is only going to trigger
from that component if the component
calls that hook so let's comment this
out and we want to get the same value
from our use Community data hook so make
sure that Imports
and we want to only grab the Community
State value so if I save this this
component is actually going to call that
hook now which is going to trigger that
use effect which should have populated
the current Community State so if I look
at this log over here so you can see
that it did go and get the community
data so now if I bring in our about
component here
drop it into our right hand side
fragment and then as our community data
product we can pass in Community State
value
dot current community
and then same thing as our PID page we
can add a guard here to only show this
component if we do have a truthy
community State value in state so if I
save this now that component appears on
the right hand side and I should be able
to refresh this page
and the same exact thing should happen
perfect that is amazing we no longer
have to come from the community page to
see this data here and that is perfect
so if I go into here
if I sent the link to somebody now now
they can actually see the post and see
the community data and everything see
the boats and whatever so awesome now
our app is so much more versatile and
realistic and Link sharing is possible
so I'm glad we covered that because it
is very very important and we can now
move on all right you guys you are now
going to move on to building the
commenting on post functionality which I
think is a super exciting feature and
it's really fun to build and it's pretty
much the exact same thing as creating a
post but it's actually easier because we
don't have images to deal with the first
thing I want to talk about is how we are
going to model this data in our database
because that's always a good place to
start so let's go to our database and
let's briefly talk about the way we are
going to structure our comments
collection so really we're faced with
two different options for storing the
comments in our database we can either
create a top level comments collection
at the same level as these ones here
communities posting users or we could
create a comment sub collection on the
post document and either one of these
are fine in different circumstances but
in our circumstance we need to think
about how we're actually actually
querying the comment data because again
how the data is displayed on the screen
what your queries are going to look like
should really Drive how you model your
data and in our case we are going to
store our comments as a top level
collection here along with the post
communities and users rather than a sub
collection on the posts and here is why
if we go to the real reddit.com and we
go to our profile page it's just a
random Reddit account that I made for
the purpose of this demo you can see
that there is a section on our profile
page called comments so on this page it
would display a complete history of all
of the comments you have made on Reddit
which means that there are sections of
the app that require access to comment
data outside of just the post now we are
not going to build this profile page but
I did want to model our data to best
reflect Reddit in case you did want to
build this functionality on top of this
project if we wanted all of the comments
that we ourselves have
think about how much harder that query
would be if the comments were stored as
a sub collection on the posts we would
have to query every single post and then
go into all of those posts and see if
there's a comment that we have made like
where the comment has an author ID that
matches our user ID that's really
inefficient and doesn't really seem
necessary and so that's why I decided to
store the comments as a top level
collection up here because we can query
The Collection directly then right we
can just go let's go find all the
comments where the author ID matches my
user ID and for the posts it's just as
easy to find all of the comments with a
certain post ID so it's sort of The Best
of Both Worlds here it simplifies our
lives significantly if we just have the
comments up here as a top level
collection so I just wanted to discuss
these two ways of modeling the data
because again with nosql we have all of
this freedom and my first thought
actually was to put a sub collection on
the post right because it's so it makes
so much sense it's like oh I only really
need to see the comments of a post if I
already know the post therefore I'm
going to sort of a sub collection but
then I was like oh well on reddit.com
there's this whole comments section of
your profile and so making that query
with the sub collection pattern would be
very very challenging which is what led
me to decide to store the comments up
here as a sibling a post rather than as
a child of posts just wanted to clarify
that because I don't want to just be
like oh we're modeling the data this way
except it I wanted to provide some food
for it to Hut so I hope that is helpful
and now we can actually build the
functionality into our app okay so let's
go back to our app and it's going to be
on this PID page that we're going to
build in the comments functionality so
let's go into here and the comments is
going to be as I have indicated here a
sibling of the post item inside of the
left hand side fragment here so let's
actually build the real comments
component so inside of our directory
here and inside of the posts folder I'm
going to create a another folder inside
of here call
because the comments are a child of a
post and so then inside of here I'm
going to create the main root file of
this folder which is going to be
comments.tsx I'm going to use our
snippet txed and then I'm going to just
put the text in here here are the
comments
awesome
I'm going to close my directory come
back to our PID page and actually import
the real comments component here
comments
just like this and so now we should see
that show up right there and just uh
again to look at our demo let's go look
at what we're actually creating here so
I'll click on this post
and this is it we just have an input and
the actual comments themselves let's
start off with the props that we're
going to accept in our comment component
here so the first prop we're going to
take in is going to be our user object
so this is going to be object User make
sure this type imports from Firebase
auth our second prop is going to be our
selected post which is going to be of
type post make sure that Imports as well
and then the third one is going to be
the community ID because we are going to
store this on all of our new comments
then we can destructure them from the
props down here so user select a post as
well as Community ID just like this all
right and let's go back to our app so we
can see where we are building and let's
briefly Define the functions that are
going to be in this component to provide
some clarity as we are building this out
all right so the first function in here
is going to be the function that
actually creates our comments so this is
going to be called oncreate comment and
it is going to be asynchronous because
it is going to talk to our database and
it's going to take in an argument that
is called comment text and that is going
to be a string
and we're going to leave it empty for
now our second function is going to be
responsible for deleting a comment this
is also going to be asynchronous and
this is going to take in a comment but
this is going to be of type comment
which we have not created yet which
we're going to do in a second but for
now I'm just going to make it any so
that typescript doesn't kill us and our
third function is going to be
responsible for fetching all of the
comments for this post so I'm going to
call this get post comments
asynchronous
and empty for now and the very last
thing I'm going to create is going to be
a use effect because we want to do
something as soon as this component
mounts and that thing we want to do is
get the post comments for this post that
we're currently looking at and we only
want to run this once so I'm going to
leave the dependency array empty so
essentially as soon as this component
maps to the Dom it's going to go fetch
the comments from the database and then
put them in stage so that we can
actually see them on the screen so that
is pretty much the skeleton of this
component and now we just have to fill
all of these things out let's build out
the actual container for our comments
component so we can get rid of that div
there and our outermost component is
going to be a box from Chakra and we're
going to give this box a background of
white and a border radius
of zero pixels zero pixels four pixels
four pixels and then in here I'm just
going to say here are comments that we
can see something show up on the screen
and you'll notice that these border
radius inputs are just sort of the
complete opposite of the Border radius
inputs for the Post item and it's to
make it appear as though it is a single
component there they sort of look like
one if you go to the demo they look like
kind of a it looks like one massive
thing uh and we are doing that by having
the Border radiuses sort of mirror each
other so to speak and we're also going
to give this a padding of two all right
we can get rid of this text and inside
of here we're going to have a flex box
so import that from Chakra and inside of
this text box is where our comment input
component is going to go which we are
going to create in just a second here
but let's style out this flexbox first
we're going to give this a Direction
of column
padding left of 10 heading right before
and a margin bottom
of six let me give this a font size of
10 point
and a width of 100 percent perfect and
actually before we create our comment
input let's create the state that we're
going to have in this component here so
the first piece of State we're going to
create is going to be for our actual
comment input and is going to represent
the actual comment text that the user is
entering when they're creating a new
comment so we're going to call this
comment text
accept comment text and we're going to
initialize this to be an empty string
our second piece of state is going to be
all of our comments for this post that
come from the database and so we are
going to initialize this to be an empty
array
okay and we're going to have two loading
States here one for fetching our
comments and one for creating a comment
we want to keep them separate because
there are two separate things so our
first one is going to be called Fetch
loading
set fetch loading and it's going to be
equal to use State initialize it as
false the second loading state is going
to be called create loading and set
create loading
and also false
okay so that's going to be it for now
now let's create the component for our
actual comment input so inside of our
comments folder I'm going to create
another file called comment
dot TSX
and use our snippet
and let's define the props that this is
going to take so the first prop is going
to be that common text State component
that we declared before second one is
going to be the set comment text
function and this is going to take into
the value of type string and it's going
to return void the third one is going to
be our user which is going to be a type
user the third one is going to be our
loading state for creating a comment
because you're going to need that one in
here to display a loading State when the
user presses create comment
so we're going to have this be Boolean
here and the last one is going to be our
on create comment function because that
is the function that you're going to
call when they click on the create
comment button and this is going to take
in a piece of comment text and it's
going to return nothing now down here we
can destructure all of these comment
text set comment text user
loading and oncreate comment just like
that now for this component what I'm
going to do for the sake of time is just
paste in all of the HTML for it because
it's pretty much just a input with a
bunch of fancy styling and a button so I
figured it's not worth going through a
bunch of CSS so I thought it'd be better
to focus more on the actual commenting
and creating comments functionality I
will put a link directly to this
component on my GitHub down below so you
can grab it as well so I'm just going to
drop this in here and add all of the
missing Imports command period
I love that keyboard shortcut
and text as always does not like to Auto
Import so I'm going to
throw that in here manually
perfect
so this is all styled and all of those
functions that we passed in are hooked
up to it properly it's just an input
with a button and then with an on click
that calls our on-create common function
so nothing super fancy that you're
missing here just a bunch of fancy CSS
that I thought was not worth going
through because you've already seen so
much of this already it's more fun to
actually work on the creation of
comments in my opinion so let's go back
to our comments component and import
that actual comment input
from that file
and now we can pass it the required
props so the first one is going to be
our common text which is going to be
equal to our common text State variable
the second one is going to be set
comment text
I do not like when I don't get
autocomplete but sometimes you just
can't have everything you want okay the
third one is going to be the user
so we are going to pass in the user
which I believe we still have to get oh
no it's coming as a problem okay and
then we can pass in our create loading
State create loading just save this so
that formats and then the last one is
going to be our on create comment
function
on create comment
okay so I saved this and as you can see
here we are displaying this component
here that's asking the user to log in or
sign up and this is just part of the
comment input component that basically
just checks if the user exists or if it
does not and if it does not it just asks
them to log in or sign up and the reason
that it is saying we are unauthenticated
even though we are logged in is because
we are not yet receiving a user as a
prop to this comments component so let's
fix that so that we can actually see the
real component fun fact this is the
exact same auth buttons component that
was used in our nav bar this is why I
love react and the reusability of
components is so cool okay so let's
actually pass the user in to our
component here
user is equal to user okay and we are
also meeting the selected post which is
going to be our hostate value dot
selected post
and we also want to pass in our
community ID which we could get from the
router but we can also get access to it
from postdatevalue dot selected post dot
Community ID okay so typescript is not
happy with the misalignment of types
here so what I'm going to do for the
user is I'm going to Typecast this to be
of type user and for the community ID
I'm also going to Typecast this to a
string however for the selected post
what I'm going to do is just come into
our comments component here and change
the type of our selected policy since
our selected post is initialized as null
in our post date atom I'm going to use
the pipe operator and add null as
another type for this prop here so if I
save this and go back this should now be
happy and we should be good to go and
now we can actually see our new fancy
input component here which is super cool
our button is even hooked up to our on
create comment function although it's
empty but it is hooked up once you start
once we build out the logic here it will
work all right let's start right out the
on create comment function and actually
starts storing some comments in the
database so when we create a comment
there are two things we need to do the
first thing is of course creating a
common document in the database the
second thing is we need to update the
posts number of comments because if we
go back to our database here you might
remember that we store a field on our
post documents called number of comments
and the reason we do that is because if
we go to our demo here we do store that
information you can see it here and it
is also displayed on all of the post
items here so 328 and 4 and 458 so that
is the data coming from the number of
comments field on that post document so
we need to update that as well every
single time we create a comment so
Update hosts
update post number of comments
all right and for both of these
operations it makes sense to either have
both of them succeed or none of them
succeed so for that reason we are going
to use batch rights once again because
they are amazing and why not they help
keep our data super clean with a high
level of integrity and then once our
batch write successfully completes we
can update our client
recoil state
to show the new comment as well as the
new number of comments
and then they hit and then in the
awesome
okay and then okay
all right so
okay
perfect and then in our delete function
we're going to do pretty much very
similar things we are going to delete
the comment document we are also going
to update the host number of comments
but this is going to be the minus one up
here was plus one and then we are going
to also update The Recoil State as well
to reflective changes so let's work on
the creation of comments so let's create
a try catch block as usual
and we will log the air
on create comment
error all right then at the top of our
try block we can create our batch
instance using our right batch function
from firestore pass it our firestore
instance
and let's work on this first thing of
creating a comments document our new
comment object is going to be of type
comment which we have not created yet so
let's do that now and for now we're just
going to put it at the top of this file
but we are going to move it to the
comment item component once we actually
create that component very shortly so
you can say export type comment
so our comments are going to have an ID
which is a type string a Creator ID so
we know the user that created this the
Creator display text so we can display
that on the UI
Community ID that belongs to this post
that we're commenting on the ID of the
post that this comment belongs to
the title of the post
and as well as the comment text itself
and the last thing is going to be our
created at timestamp which you want to
be up type timestamp make sure that
imports from Firebase firestore and that
is it so now down here when we're
creating a comment I'm actually going to
create a reference to this new comment
document so that we can use the ID on
our new object here
so you can say const comment dot ref is
equal to Doc from firestore and we can
pass this a collection reference of the
collection we want to sort this document
in
and that collection is going to be our
comments collection just like this and
now we can populate our new comment
object
so we can pass this an ID a
comment.ref.id the Creator ID
of user.uid a Creator display text which
if you remember was our users email and
then we split the email at the at time
and then we grab the first element in
that split array and we're actually
going to add the bang operator here
because we know that the user is going
to be defined at this point because only
authenticated users can create comments
we can add in our community ID the post
ID is going to be the selected post dot
ID and we are going to again add the
bang operator here because we know that
at this point we are going to have a
selected post the post title is going to
be our selected post dot title
again can add the bank operator and our
text is actually going to be our state
variable which is going to be comment
text and we actually don't need to
accept this as an argument to this
function here we can just use it
directly from State I don't know why I
initially passed that as an argument it
doesn't really matter but we don't
really need to so I'm just going to use
the state variable all right and for our
created ad we are going to use our
server timestamp function and we're
going to Typecast this to a timestamp to
avoid the type conflict between the
server types and the client types just
like this
okay then we can actually add the
creation of this document to our batch
operations so the document we want to
create is going to be our comment doc
ref and the data we want to store in
that document is going to be our new
comment now let's update our post
documents number of comments field
so let's move that comment down here
so let's create a reference for the Post
document that we are updating so we can
say postdoc ref is equal to Doc
passes our firestore instance the
collection that this document in is
posts and the ID of this document is
selected post dot ID and to fix this
compiler error here we can do one of two
things we can either add the bang
operator like we were doing up here
or we can Typecast this to be a string
either is fine but we do know at this
point that we are going to have a valid
selected post to be consistent with
above I'm going to add the bang operator
here to tell typescript that it is safe
to proceed then we can add the update to
our batch operations the document we are
updating is postdoc ref and the update
we want to make is to the number of
comments field on this post and we want
to increase this value by one so we can
call our increment function from
firestore and give it the value one just
like this now we can actually write
those operations to the database we can
say await batch dot commit and then
after our database documents have been
successfully created and updated we can
update our client recoil state so the
first thing we want to do is set our
common text to be empty so we can clear
the input and the other piece of State
we have to update is our comments array
we want to add this new comment to the
top of that array so that it shows the
updated list on the UI so we can call
our set comments function
and we want to take the previous value
of this array and update it to be a new
array with the new comment at the top
and all of the previously existing ones
behind it
and this is complaining because type
never
okay yeah so I think when we yeah we
have to specify the type of this comment
State here and since we have our common
type defined
we can indicate to react that this is
going to be an array of comments and
that should satisfy this array down here
perfect okay so typescript is happy I
can save this
and I think all we are missing is our
loading State actually so at the top of
our try block we can set create loading
to be true
and then at the bottom
we can set create loading to be false
just like that okay so let's actually
test out this function because our
button is actually hooked up to it so um
we should be able to create a comment
let's go to our database and what should
happen is we should see a new collection
appear in here called comments with a
new comment but we should also see that
this post this one we're looking at
right here should have an updated number
of comments with a value of one so let's
try this out and see what happens so I'm
going to do hey nice post dude
click comment
okay it um
it didn't even load like the loading
State didn't trigger are we sure we have
that hooked up
comment input
on create comment
comment text okay
um what is happening here I'm not sure
is our reacts
did anything get created in the database
no okay nothing I created
um I'm gonna just try maybe refreshing
this maybe my hot module
thing was being weird Okay so let's try
leaving another comment hey dude nice
post
okay so that seemed to work though I
don't know what it was happening for
um okay so if I go to the database now
we can see that the yes the um the
number of comments on the post was
updated and I just have to refresh the
database because the comments collection
is being created for the first time and
yes it was created and we can see that
brand new comment in there which is
super cool so obviously our batch rate
worked because it created the comment
and our post number of comments was
updated so let's create another comment
second one
comment
this was updated to two and that second
comment should be in there second one
nice
all right so now we are able to
successfully create comments so let's go
back to our app and there is actually
one more piece of recoil state that we
have to update here and that is going to
be the selected posts number of comments
here we did that on our post document in
the database but we do want to do it in
the client as well so that those changes
are reflected on the UI right away so in
order to update our selected post we are
going to need our set post date function
from recoil so we can bring that in up
here we can say set Post State
and we only need to set post it here we
don't really need to read from it so we
can use our use set recoil safe hook and
pass in our post date atom
then down here after adding the new
comment to the comments array we can
call our set post date function
take our previous value and the value
that we want to update here is selected
post and we only want to update one
field on the selected post and that
field is going to be the number of
Commons so we can spread the previous
value of selected post preview.selected
post and we just want to update the
number of comments to be incremented by
one and the way we can do that is we can
just say preview.selected post
DOT number of comments
plus one and we can tell a typescript
that this new post object is indeed of
type post and then we can add the bang
operator here to tell Cat script that we
know that there is going to be a
selected post at this point so now if I
were to go make a comment
on this post I should see this number
here update without refreshing the page
okay dude this is cool this is cool so
if I comment
you can see that that change to a three
immediately which is super cool awesome
so now all we have to do is create our
comment item component so that we can
actually see the comments of this post
underneath here alright so let's work on
the comment item component here so
inside of our directory here inside of
the comments folder I'm going to create
a new file called comment item dot TSX
and this is going to represent an
individual comment item similar to a
post item so let's use our snippet in
here close our directory and I mentioned
before that we were going to move this
comment type over to this comment item
file once we have created it so that's
what I'm going to do now and the reason
I'm doing this is just because I feel
like it just makes sense to store the
individual comment type inside of the
individual comment item component just
the preference of mind though it doesn't
really matter where you store it to be
honest so let's import this timestamp
from firestore
save this and now we just need to go
back to our comments and actually import
this comment type from that file we just
created
so let's do import
from comment item
and we want to import the comment type
there and now this should be happy down
here we can save this and go back and
I'm actually going to move this above
the comment item props I feel like if
you have multiple types inside of your
react components the component props
type should be at the bottom kind of
closest to the component just a
preference honestly that's uh just what
I do it doesn't really matter but up to
you all right so the first prop that
this thing is going to take in is going
to be the actual comment itself so we
can declare this as a type of comment
our second prop is going to be our on
delete comment function because we're
going to be able to call that directly
from within the comment item component
this is going to take in a comment
argument which is of type comment and
it's going to return void our third prop
is going to be a Boolean that represents
if we are in the process of deleting
this comment so I'm going to call it
loading delete and I'll explain more
about this in a bit once we have the
component actually built out and the
fourth one is going to be the user ID so
that we can know if the current user is
the creator of this comments that we can
display the option to delete it to them
if they are all right let's come down
here and destructure our props comment
on delete comment loading delete and
user ID all right so let's go to our
demo and look at what a comment item
actually looks like
so we have the icon here we have the
username we have the time that the
comment was posted we have the text
itself and then we have the option to
edit and delete it and we're only going
to build the delete functionality we're
not going to build the edit
functionality but you can see here that
as a creator of this comment I have the
option to edit and delete it whereas
these ones I'm not the Creator so I
cannot see those icons so that is the
reason why we are passing in the user ID
here as a prop all right so let's go
back to our app so let's get rid of this
div here and we can start off by
creating the outermost container which
is going to be just a flexbox from
Chakra now the first component in here
is going to be the actual Reddit icon
that we saw in the demo so this is going
to be contained within a box component
so bring that in from Chakra and we're
going to have a icon
and this icon is going to be our fa
Reddit icon and I'm just going to import
all of the icons here that we are going
to be using
um so I'm going to paste in these
Imports at the top here
and these look like this there's only
three of them
perfect okay so then the first one is
going to be that fa Reddit
and right next to our icon container
we're going to create a stack here and
this is going to contain all of the
actual content of the comment I'm going
to give this a spacing of one the first
thing inside of here is going to be
another stack but this is going to be a
row stack and this is going to contain
the username as well as the created add
timestamp so we can declare the
direction of this to be row and we want
to make the Align Center so everything's
vertically aligned and we're going to
make everything inside of here font size
of eight point
and we're going to have two pieces of
text in here one is going to be the
username and one is going to be the
timestamp so let's bring in text from
Chakra because as usual we do not get
that Auto Import for some reason don't
know why I mentioned that every single
time and you're probably like yo we get
it we we get the text is not Auto Import
we get it okay so then the first one is
going to be our comment
dot Creator display text which is sort
of our like little username thing and
then our second one is going to be that
timestamp and we are going to use moment
once again so that we can get a nice
formatted time stamp 10 minutes ago or
four months ago or whatever so Our
Moment function takes in a new date
object and the date we're going to pass
is going to be our comment dot created
at dot seconds because the type of this
is a timestamp and that has the seconds
parameter attached to it and we're going
to need to multiply this by a thousand
and then we can call the Dot from now
method from a moment to declare this as
that nice four minutes ago or eight
months ago type of text okay so
typescript is not happy because created
ad could possibly be undefined and what
I'm going to do is actually remove the
question mark here and make this not
optional because it's always going to be
there
um so I'm just going to save this and we
don't need optional chain here at this
point so now that we have just a little
bit of this built out let's go back to
our comments and actually
iterate through our comments and create
the comment items for the existing
comments so that we can actually see
what we're doing when we're building up
this comment item okay so underneath
this Flex container here I'm going to
create a stack
and this stack we want to give a spacing
of six and this is going to space out
all of our comments very nicely and
within me stack this is where we want to
actually display all of our comment
items so we want to take our comments
array and map through all of them and
take each one and create a new comment
item
okay and the props you need to pass into
this comment item is the comment itself
comment is equal to comment our on
delete comment function
on delete comment our loading delete
which for now is just going to be false
but we're going to come back to this as
well as the user ID which is going to be
the current user.uid
perfect we can save this and now we can
see that we have something here we have
not fetched all of the comments from the
database yet so only the ones we have
created on the front and are going to be
here because you have not fetched them
and I did create that one a few minutes
ago that's why there's one here like so
if I create another one now shaded it
should show up right immediately and
state here okay so we're getting an
invalid date here and this has to do
with our created at timestamp and we're
going to fix that
um should I do that now or after the
Styles okay let's do the date now
actually so the reason that this invalid
date thing is happening is because of
this server timestamp function here if
you remember from a while ago I
mentioned that the server timestamp
function is actually only callable on
the Firebase servers so we tell Firebase
that we want our created at field to be
a server timestamp so that when this
object does reach the Firebase servers
Firebase will call this function you
know create that typeset for us but on
our client we actually cannot call this
function and since we want to put this
comment into our client state right away
without having to go fetch from the
database we do need to actually sort of
manually create our own timestamp here
with our own seconds field on it with
our posts we did not have to do that
because we created a post using the
server timestamp function and then we
went back to the Community page and all
the posts were fetched from the database
after the server timestamp was
successfully created on the Firebase
servers but in this case we are taking
this thing and immediately inserting it
into client state so that it shows up on
the screen immediately there is no
fetching after creating a comment my
point in saying that is we do need to
manually create our own timestamp on the
client so that we can see a valid date
here okay so what we can do to fix this
is after adding this new comment right
operation to our batch we can take this
new comment object and modify the
created at field so that it works on our
and set this equal to our own little
client version of a timestamp and our
timestamp needs to contain a seconds
field on it here and the value we want
to set to our seconds you can use our
date object from JavaScript and copy.now
Method on it and then we want to divide
this by 1000 and then we can tell
typescript that this is a timestamp
because it's sort of our own little
custom version of a timestamp so that it
works on our client so now I can save
this
and if I were to create a comment now we
should see a valid date will this work
date
comment
perfect so you can see now that we're
seeing a few seconds ago and so moment
is able to actually read that as a valid
date because the seconds thing actually
exists on the create that thing now
awesome I hope that makes sense it's
kind of confusing and it's kind of weird
with this whole server timestamp thing
but um this is a way around it so that
we can directly insert this thing into
our client State all right let's go back
to our comment item and actually
continue building out the UI and fix up
these styles of It Go on our creator
display text we are going to change the
font weight of this to be heavy 700 and
then for our date we are going to change
the color to be Gray 600.
and let's actually change the style of
this icon up here as well we're going to
make the font size equal to 30 to make
it much larger and then we can make the
color of it gray
300.
very nice that looks very good all right
now underneath this inner stack here
we're going to actually show the common
text itself which is probably the most
exciting part of the comment so inside
of this text you want to say comment dot
text and we can style this to have a
font size of Cam point to make it
slightly smaller there we go we can see
the actual comment there and then
underneath here we're going to create a
another stack which is going to contain
all of the user actions that is on a
comment so like these icons the edit
delete buttons it's going to be a row
stack so that's all spaced nicely okay
so let's make the direction
of this is equal to rho and we're going
to vertically align our items again so
we can say Center for our align we want
to make everything inside of here cursor
pointer because they're all sort of
clickable actions and we're going to
make the color of everything inside of
here gray 500. now the first two things
inside of the stack are going to be the
upvote and download icons that we see on
the comments
so the first one is going to be the i o
Arrow up Circle outline and the second
one is going to be the down one so we
can paste this in here and just change
this to i o arrow down
perfect looks very good then underneath
here we want to show the edit and delete
option but only if the user ID is equal
to the comments Creator ID only if I'm
the owner of this comment do I want to
see these options here and we can create
a fragment from within here and we're
going to have two pieces of text
and one is going to say edit
and the other is going to say delete and
we're only again building the delete
functionality but this is where you
would click the edit functionality if
you decide to build that so on both of
these I'm going to add some common
styling and The Styling for these is
going to be font size of nine point and
hover styling of a color of blue
500 just like this and then on the
delete since we actually have this
functionality built in we're going to
add the on click function and this is
going to call
our on delete comment function and we're
going to pass in the comment product
just like this
so now we actually have this hooked up
to our delete function so when we build
it it'll actually work okay and one
thing up here next to our created at
text is we're going to actually also add
a loader for when the user does delete
this comment we're going to just clean
up display a little spinner here
indicating that the delete is in
progress and that's sort of where this
loading delete Boolean is going to come
into play so right here I'm going to add
that in and I'm going to say if loading
delete is true we want to show this
spinner so bring in the center from
Chakra and we're just going to make the
size of this small
cool so if I make this true just we can
see what this looks like that is what
that looks like it looks really cool and
it just tells the user that the deletion
is in progress awesome and I think I
forgot you had padding on the stack
container of all of these comments
because it looks like they're not
positioned properly so here on this
stack here I'm going to add a padding of
two
there we go that looks much better and
while we are here actually I'm going to
use this fetch loading parameter to
display a skeleton loader for our
comments because that makes it look so
much better so inside of this stack here
I'm going to create a ternary operator
that is going to see if fetch loading is
true if it is true
we are going to display our loader and
if it is not we're going to display our
comments
so I'm just going to paste in the loader
from the component because it's just a
bunch of skeleton components here
and let's add these missing Imports
cool and I have this like hard-coded012
array just so that it creates three of
these box skeleton components here so if
the fetch is complete meaning that we
are in the fussiness of this ternary
operator we want to display to the user
that there are no comments if the
comments array is empty after they have
been fetched so inside of here I'm going
to create another fragment and in this
fragment I'm going to add the condition
to check if the comments dot length is
equal to zero and if it is we are going
to display this component that says no
comments yet and I'm just going to paste
that in it's just a flexbox with some
text in it so that is what this looks
like and if we do have comments in our
array we want to show them so then I can
create another fragment over here and
inside of here we want to actually put
in this comments.map function
just like that so I can save that and
now I need to just import text from
Chakra
save this so now if I refresh this page
because we have not created our effect
comments function yet we should see this
thing here that says yeah no comments
yet even though there are comments but
again we haven't created our fetch
function yet to create our initial value
of comments so pretending that there are
no comments this is what that would look
like okay so let's write out this get
post comments function so that we can
see the initial state of this post
comments when this component loads right
now we can see that there are five so
once we write this out the initial value
of our array should contain those
comments after they have been fetched
and all we need to do inside of here is
query our comment collection to find all
of the comments with the post ID of the
selected posts ID so we can create a try
block and inside of here let's log the
error get post comment then inside of
our try block I'm going to create an
object called comments query that we're
going to pass to our get docs function
to perform the query so we can create
this using our query function from
firestore the first argument to our
query function is going to be collection
reference to the collection we are
querying we can pass this at our
firestore instance and the collection we
are carrying is comments the second
argument is going to be our where clause
which set of documents do we want to get
from the comments collection we want to
get all of the comments where the post
ID of the comment is equal to the
currently selected posts ID so selected
post dot ID let's save this so that it
formats then as the third argument to
our query we can tell Firebase how we
want these ordered by so we can pass in
our order by function make sure that
imports from firestore and we want to
order by the created at field in
descending order so if they come in with
the latest comments at the top now we
can actually fetch this set of documents
from our database so let's create a new
object called comment Docs and we can
call our get docs function and pass in
our Comics query
then after we get all of these documents
back from firestore we want to extract
all of the data out of them and store
them in state so we can create our new
comments array and we can map through
our comment docs dot Docs
so comment docs.map and we can take each
document and extract the data out of it
and create a new JavaScript object with
the ID of dot dot ID and then we can
spread all of the data inside of that
document
so we can save this now all we have to
do is put this in our common state you
can say set comments
and throw in our comments result from
firestore and we can tell typescript
that this is going to be an array of
comments so we can indicate that like
this and actually what I'm going to do
is initialize our fetch loading to be
true so as soon as this component
renders we can indicate to the user that
the fetch is in progress because that is
sort of exactly what is happening so if
you save this this is what those loaders
look like I think they look so cool I
don't know why I love these these
skeleton loaders so much I don't know if
everyone gets as excited about those as
I do but they just look so good to me
and then once this fetch has been
complete
um get post comments at the very end of
our try catch we can set our fetch
loading to be false
perfect
okay so we are getting an error here and
I believe it is because yes we do need
an index on our comments collection this
is what we had to do with our posts as
well if you remember in order to perform
queries on our collection uh we do need
an index on that collection so what we
can do is just click on this link and do
the exact same thing as we did last time
this will open up the console and let's
create the index on our comments
collection by just clicking create index
and this will take a few minutes I think
last time it took about four to five
minutes so come back when this is done
okay we are back and the index has been
successfully created with a status of
enabled so now if I go back to the app
and I refresh this page here
we should
see those comments which we are not
cool okay there's another error here uh
function where called with in valid data
unsupported field value
undefined okay all right so I think
what's Happening Here is it is trying to
uh make this query here but our selected
post ID is undefined on the first render
of this component because we do need to
go fetchup from the database and
actually populate state so there is a
moment where the selected post is null
and the ID is undefined so to prevent
this what we can do is actually add a
dependency in this use effect here and
only call the get post comments function
when we do indeed have the selected post
successfully fashioned the database and
in state okay so we can add a dependency
here of selected post then as we've seen
before we can protect against running
this function by simply checking for the
truthiness of the selected post and if
there is no selected post we can just
return out of the use effect and not
call our function so let's save this and
that should work and it seems to have
worked but let's try refreshing the page
and make sure that that actually does
work
perfect so it does work that looks
amazing I love it and we should be okay
I'm just gonna say we should be able to
delete them but we have not written out
that function yet I'm getting ahead of
myself here uh on this error in the
console is saying that we do not have a
key prop in our comments item so yes
when we do map through uh the items here
we want to add a key as required by
react and the key we can just make the
comment dot ID
if I refresh so we get rid of that ugly
error in the console
we can see all of the nice loading State
boom and to make this even actually a
bit cleaner we can hide our input
completely until the comments have been
fetched as well just so we don't see uh
the input as the only thing on the
screen while they're being fetched so we
can add a condition here to only show
the common input if we are not in the
process of fetching these comments so
now if I refresh
awesome that looks just a little bit
better but it makes a big Improvement in
my opinion so that looks amazing all we
have to do now is write out the delete
function which is pretty much just the
complete opposite of the create function
so not super difficult there and then we
will be able to delete comments create
comments and we will be done with the
comment functionality and we are even
closer to the finished product all right
you guys all we have left to do to
complete our commenting functionality is
to write out the on delete comment
function and if you remember we outline
the steps that we are going to do inside
this function and they are pretty much
just the mirror actions of the oncreate
comment function so nothing crazy here
and we just have to undo the creation of
one so underneath these comments I'm
going to create a try catch block
and I'm going to remove that return
statement there
and we can start off by logging the
error on delete comment
okay and let's move these comments into
our try block and let's start off with
deleting our comment document so we're
going to need to create our batch
instance because we are going to be
working with batch operations so we can
bring in our right batch function and
test this our firestore instance okay
let's create a reference to the document
that we're going to be deleting so we
can say comment doc ref is equal to Doc
passes our fires for instance the
collection we are deleting from is
comments and the ID of the document we
are we are deleting is comment dot ID
and we can actually change the type of
this to a comment now because we have
that type defined
then we can add the delete operation to
our batch batch.delete and we are
deleting the comment document okay
second thing in our batch is going to be
updating the number of post comments on
the post document so we can create a
document reference to that post so post
doc graph is equal to Doc as in our
firestore instance posts collection and
the ID of the post we are updating is
going to be our selected post dot ID and
we can have the bang operator here and
then we can add the update operation to
our batch exact same as what we did in
the creation of posts and we are
updating our postdoc ref and the update
we want to make is to the number of
comments field and we want to increment
this by negative one decrease it by one
so that is it for our batch operations
now we can actually write these to the
database so we can say awaitbatch dot
commit
and then when those have successfully
completed we just need to update our
client state so let's do that all right
so just like in the creation of a
comment we updated the number of
comments on the selected post by one so
now we're just going to decrease it by
one so we can do that by calling our set
Post State function take the previous
value
and we want to update the selected post
and the field we want to update on the
selected post
is number of comments and we want to
take the previous value of the number of
comments
and subtract 1 from it and we can add
the bang operator here and then we can
tell type script that this is an object
of type post now what we need to do is
just remove that comment from our
comments array so we can filter our
comments so we can say set comments
take the previous value of this array
and turn it into a filtered version by
calling preview.filter take each
previous comment item and check to make
sure that its ID does not equal to the
ID of the comment that we are deleting
to save this so the very last thing we
are going to do is Implement our loading
state for deleting and if you remember
we just temporarily passed in a value of
um where is it here
a value of false but we're actually
going to implement this now now if you
remember what the Spinners look like on
these things we had individual voting
States for each individual comment item
so we knew which one was in the process
of being deleted and so there are two
ways to do this and if you remember from
deleting a post if you go back to our
use post hook here
um on our delete post function what we
did was we had this function return a
promise and we called this function from
with inside of our post item
like this we created another function
called handle delete that is local to
the post item and that function called
our on delete post function which
returned a promise and this allowed us
to do independent error handling and
loading handling in each individual post
item and in this case we're going to do
a little bit of a different approach
just so I can show you another method to
do this inside of our comments function
here rather than having loading State
declared in each individual comment item
we are going to have a single delete
loading state so we are going to create
a single state variable for our deletion
so rather than using a Boolean like the
other one so just true or false sort of
this binary method here we are going to
instead have this be a string State
variable and when I click on a
particular comment to delete it it is
going to set the delete loading ID to be
that comments ID that way when we're
mapping through our comment items here
we can use that logic to send a Boolean
to the specific comment item and it will
have hobby true or false of whether or
not this is the one that is being
deleted it's very very similar to having
selected state if you remember like in
our in our new post form nav we were
able to determine which one was
currently clicked on very similar here
um very similar idea so hopefully this
will make more sense once we write it
out if it if you're kind of confused so
we're going to call this uh loading
delete ID and set loading delete ID
and as I mentioned we are going to
declare this as a string not a Boolean
and an empty string is falsy so we're
pretty much initializing it as false and
inside of our and delete comment
function at the very top we want to set
loading delete ID to be the ID of the
comment that we are trying to delete and
at the bottom down here we can set it
equal to an empty string which is again
falsi then down here to actually pass
this prop to this component and to have
it know whether or not it's being
deleted we can say does the loading
delete ID equal to this particular
comment that we're iterating through is
ID just like this okay so let's try this
out so let me try clicking delete
and you saw that only that one had the
spinner there and that is thanks to this
loading delete State we store the ID of
this particular post so watch up here
so that's pretty cool I think that's
cool the other option to do it like I
said before was with how we did it with
the post where we would create another
function inside of our comment item
which would call our on delete function
inside of here and then this function
would return a promise when it is
successfully deleted and then inside of
the component we would know locally
whether or not it was successful and we
could show the loading State and blah
blah blah but in this case we sort of
are having a single state variable that
is acting as the loading state of all of
them so hopefully you find those two
methods sort of interesting and yeah
just a few a different way to handle
loading States but yeah so now we can
delete comments and create them so here
is a new comment you can post this
and then if I don't like it delete it
very cool if you go to our database and
check this out in real time if I create
a new comment hey there do nice post if
I post this watch on the left
the document appears instantly and if I
go to the posts
there's four comments
which matches our client State here
perfect I create a new one nice
that updates to five if I delete this
four
three the loading State works the batch
rights are working and that wraps up our
commenting functionality all right you
guys so now that we have built all of
this amazing Community functionality we
have been able to create communities we
have been able to create posts within
communities comment on those posts
delete the posts and the comments vote
on those posts change the profile image
of communities we have done all this
amazing stuff the next logical step
would be to actually be able to navigate
between these communities that we are in
using our drop down directory menu up
here long long ago I mentioned that we
were going to cover this kind of more
towards the end because it is a simple
component and we're already doing the
heavy lifting for it we're already
fetching our community Snippets you just
have to build out the UI of this
component so from within here we are
able to create Community successfully
with our create Community model the only
thing that is missing is the actual list
of communities that we are in if we go
to our demo here to look at what I'm
talking about let me expand this a bit
so we can we can see that we are going
to build out the menu items here for
each of the communities that we are in
and have a moderating section for the
ones that we ourselves have created as
well as our option to create the
community and this is going to at the
top in the menu show which Community we
are currently in in our app right now
it's just by default home and there's
nothing else going on me it's just sort
of hard-coded the home in there and it
doesn't matter what community we're in
it just always says home now we want to
build this component to actually know
what community that it is currently in
and display that as well as the profile
picture and allow us to navigate between
these communities and in building this
component we are going to build another
custom react hook and have it manage the
global recoil state for our directory
and the reason we are making this Global
using recoil and having a hook manage
the state for us is because we are also
going to build the functionality to be
able to open the directory from the
create post link on the home page here
if they click on the create post link
and they're not in a community we open
this menu to allow them to choose which
Community they want to build the post in
I know on Reddit that you don't have to
necessarily Post in a community but it
seems like posting in communities is
much more popular than just posting in
not a community so I've decided to build
the functionality to only be able to
post in communities it is going to
prompt them to choose which Community
they would like you post it and then I
can go directly to that so for that
reason because we have this component
that is far away from this component in
the react componentry we are going to
manage the state of this menu from
recoil and using a custom hook so that
both components can toggle and read from
that state okay so I just did some quick
Version Control here to get us all set
up to develop this new feature and I'm
just going to remove all of these files
because we do not need them anymore and
I'm going to go back into the directory
file from way way back that we haven't
touched in a while and if you remember
we created just the skeleton of our
communities component which if I open it
up I believe that is where our create
Community model is right now so that is
how we are actually able to open up this
model and create a community so
essentially all we need to add in this
component is just the actual list of our
community Snippets and create a menu
list item for each one so what we're
going to do is start off by pulling in
that
from our recall State Community State
value so we can declare that up here in
a variable called my Snippets and we can
use our use recoil value hook and we can
pass this our community State atom
Community State and we only want to grab
my Snippets from Community State we
don't really care about anything else in
this component okay so underneath our
community modal here let's add in a box
component from Chakra and this is going
to be a container of all of the list
items so the first component inside of
this box is going to be a piece of text
and that text is going to say in all
caps my communities
so let's open this up so we can see what
we're doing here okay on this outermost
container we're going to add some
satellite here so we're going to give
this a margin top of three as well as
eight margin bottom of four on this in
my communities text we're going to give
this a padding left of three and some
bottom margin of one you're also going
to make it quite small and make the font
size seven point
and the font weight is going to be 500.
and we're also going to make it gray
gray 500 just like this
so underneath our create Community menu
item we are going to actually Loop
through our community Snippets and for
each one we are going to create a menu
list item with a community name in it so
we can take our Snippets and map through
them and for each snippet we want to
actually build out some piece of HTML
and that piece of HTML is going to be
its own component called menu list item
but for now let's just make an empty div
with the Snippets
dot Community ID so we can see something
showing up on the screen there so now we
can actually see the list of my Snippets
okay so now let's actually build out the
menu list item component and this is
going to lead us into building out the
recoil atom for a directory state so
inside of our directory folder here I'm
going to create a new file called menu
list
item.tsx we can use our snippet so the
first prop that we're going to take into
this component is going to be called
display text
and this is going to be Hub type string
and it's actually what's going to be
displayed in the menu item here
um in the in the list here the r slash
Community ID
the second prop we're going to take in
is going to be the link to that
community so when the user clicks on it
they can actually go inside of that
community
the third problem we're going to take in
is going to be an icon and this is going
to be of type icon type so make sure
this imports from react icons our fourth
prop is going to be an icon color and
this is going to help us differentiate
between the moderator list and the
regular Community list and this is going
to be a type string and the fifth prop
is going to be the image URL which is
going to be the profile picture of the
image and this is going to be actually
optional because not all communities
have to have an image URL so sometimes
it's going to be undefined so down here
we can destructure these
display text link
icon icon color and image URL
and the HTML for this component is
relatively straightforward it's only
about 10 to 20 lines so each menu list
item is going to actually be a menu item
component from Chakra so menu item make
sure that imports from Chakra and we are
going to apply some styling to these we
are going to give all of these a width
of 100 percent
a font size of 10 point
some hover styling
which is going to have a background of
gray 100 and we are also going to have
an on click function that is going to
Route us to this community but for now
we're just going to leave it as an empty
callback we will come back to this when
we build out our custom hook for our
directory then inside of this menu item
we want to have a flex container
on our Flex we're going to make the
vertical alignment center
inside of here we're going to add a
condition to check for the existence of
an image URL because if the image URL
exists we want to display that and if it
does not we're just going to display our
famous Reddit icon so if there is an
image URL we are going to have an image
component from Chakra
the source of our image component is
going to be our image URL we are going
to give this a border radius of full to
make it round and we're going to give it
a box size of 18 pixels and we're going
to give it a margin right of 2. to add
some space between this and the text
that is coming up if there is no image
we're just going to display an icon
and the icon is going to be the icon
prop that we are going to pass in we are
going to give this a font size of 20 and
some margin right of 2 and we're going
to give this a color equal to the icon
color prop then underneath this ternary
operator is where we're actually going
to show the display text
so let's go back to our app so we can
see what we're doing here and let's
actually bring this component in so we
can get rid of this div here and we are
going to render our menu list item
component that we just created we can
pass this a key of this snippet dot
Community ID because that's a unique
identifier the icon we're going to pass
in is going to be fa Reddit
our display text is going to be a string
and we're going to use a template
literal here and it's going to be r
slash then snippet
dot Community ID so it's like r slash
Chinese group or r slash baking
okay let's save that so formats we're
going to pass in a link string so that
our next JS router can take us to this
link and the link is going to be forward
slash R make sure to include the forward
slash before the r here so that our
router knows you place it after the
domain name it says forward slash R
forward slash then it's going to be our
snippet dot Community ID and that is
that and so this is what we're going to
pass to our router our icon color
is going to be blue 500
and our image URL is going to be snippet
dot image URL and so the reason we have
a prop for our icon color as well as our
icon is because we are going to reuse
our menu list item component up here in
a little bit when we display the list of
communities that we are moderating
because they're going to vary slightly
and so that's why they're capacitance
props and not used directly in the menu
list item okay so let's let's save this
okay so I think the reason that it's not
showing the image URL here is because we
added the functionality of uploading
Community images after we had created
this community and after the community
snippet was inserted into my users
Community Snippets array and so I think
the community snippet does not have the
image URL right now okay and this is
because we built that functionality
afterwards so all we would have to do to
fix this is to just go back to the
Community page and then join and leave
the community and that should put a new
snippet with the imagery on it so if I
leave the community
that should have been deleted from the
database yeah I'm not in that Community
anymore if I rejoin it should have
created a new one yeah with the image
URL so now if I open up the directory
the image isn't there okay so now let's
quickly build out the moderating section
of this list because it's extremely
similar to this we just have to apply a
filter we go to our demo it pretty much
just have the moderating section and
then the my community section and the
ones you are moderating also do appear
in the my communities list that's how it
appears on Reddit so that is how I made
it so then inside of our directory here
the component for our moderating section
is going to be very very similar to this
I'm just going to grab that entire box
and paste it up above here like this but
we can get rid of the create Community
menu item
and this is going to say instead of my
communities it's going to say moderating
okay so if I save this now we have a
duplicate list so we need to apply a
filter here to this Snippets rate so
before we map through it we want to
actually
filter these to only be the ones that we
are moderating and to do that filtering
we can look at each snippet in this
array and see if the is moderator key
exists and is true and then once that
filter is done we can then map through
those results okay so I save this and we
can see that there are no communities
that I'm currently moderating okay so
the user I'm currently logged in as is
clearly the creator of this community
because I can change the image right
only only creators and admins of this
community can do that however it is not
showing up in my moderating section of
the list even though I clearly am the
creator of this community so it should
definitely be in here I should
definitely be a moderator and the reason
that is is because what we have to do
just a few minutes ago with having to
leave and then rejoin the community to
allow that new image URL functionality
to be included in the snippet So
currently it's built so that even if you
create a community and you're added as a
moderator if you leave that community
that you created and then rejoin you're
not automatically added back as a
moderator and we can actually add that
functionality because I do think it
makes sense now that I think about it
too if you leave a community that you
created and then rejoin maybe you should
be added back as a moderator so we can
do to fix that is go to our use
Community data hook and go back to our
on join Community function so inside of
our join Community function all we have
to do is on this new snippet that we're
creating we can add that is moderator
key here and we can just check like does
this user's ID equal the community data
dot Creator ID that's all we have to add
so I think now that we've added this
code we should be able to leave this
community
and then rejoin and now it should end up
in my moderating section yeah because if
I go to the database now
um and go back to community Snippets I
should be a moderator right because I I
rejoined a community that I am the
creator of and so now it's showing up in
here successfully which is perfect but
I'm kind of glad we discovered this
because
um I think it does make sense to just be
automatically added back as a moderator
and also if I change the community image
here
to be say this Google logo
if I save those
take that change now if I were to
refresh this page the community snippet
should have that updated image because
the community snippet and the community
are pointing to the same image URL and
so when I update the community image the
community snippet is also going to be
updated as well so that is super cool
okay so now we're going to start working
on the actual recoil atom that
represents the state of our directory
menu so the openness of it as well as
the currently selected directory menu
and then we can build out our custom how
to manage that state so that we can
toggle the openness from the create post
link on the home page okay so inside of
our directory here uh I forgot how
confusing it is to have the directory
component called the directory and we
have a file directory it's kind of
confusing inside of our folders inside
of atoms let's create a new file called
directory menu Adam dot TS
okay so we can import Adam from recoil
so just like all of our other atoms we
can create a typescript interface to
model what this state is going to look
like so for our directory menu State we
can create an interface called directory
menu state
and there's only going to be two things
in here the first one is going to be is
open is this thing open or not similar
to our modals and the second thing is
going to be the selected menu item so
what is currently selected in this drop
down menu and right now I'm going to
make this up type any but we're going to
actually come up here and create a type
for our selected menu item and this is
going to tie into the props that we are
passing to our menu list item here so
bear with me if that doesn't make sense
I'm just going to close the left hand
side directory and let's create the type
for our directory menu so directory menu
item so our directory menu item type is
going to have the same properties that
we are passing as propped to our menu
list item here because for each menu
list item we're pretty much creating a
directory menu item and so they're going
to have the same properties so this is
going to have display text
type string a link of type string an
icon of Icon type make sure that imports
from react icons
icon color which is a string as well as
an optional image URL
and also I think I forgot in the
communities component the icon color we
want to pass to our menu list item in
the moderating section it is not
supposed to be blue 500 it is supposed
to be brand 100 which is that Reddit
orange so um in the directory menu item
if this did not have an image the icon
would be orange which would sort of
indicate that we are a moderator of that
community and that's sort of how we
differentiate them there that's not
super important though that's just a
very small detail okay back to our
directory menu item here now we can
declare this selected menu item as type
directory menu item and we can also
create a variable to represent our
default menu item and our default menu
item is just our home page right it's a
home text with the sort of home icon
that's sort of our default when we're
not in a community so we can say export
const default menu item
and we're exporting it because we're
going to need it in our custom hook
and this is going to be up type
directory menu item
and our display text for this is going
to be home
our link is just going to be the index
route the icon is going to be an icon
called Ti home so make sure this imports
from react icons TI and the icon color
is going to be black so this is sort of
why we have those props for Icon and
icon color because they're not always
the same and so I wanted to make a sort
of a generalized solution where we could
really have any icon or any icon color
and so that's why they're being passed
as prompts then what we can do is as you
as usual create a variable to represent
our default state for this atom so we
can say export const default menu State
and this is going to be of type
directory menu state
and we want the is open parameter to be
false because we want it to be closed
and when the user opens the application
and our selected menu item is going to
be our default menu item and so to start
off as the home item and then it'll
change depending on what community they
are in if they navigate to a community
all right now we are ready to actually
create The Recoil atom so we can say
export const directory menu state is
equal to atom
and this is going to be up type
directory menu state
then inside of here our default key can
just be directory menu State and the
default initial value of state is going
to be our default menu state
just like this awesome and that is it
for this file this is all that
represents our directory menu so this is
like the most important part here that
we have just two pieces of State
representing our directory menu we have
whether it is open or not as well as the
currently selected menu item which is
just one of those Community list items
okay so this is how we're going to use
this is open parameter from our
directory menu state so if you go back
to our directory so Shocker's menu
component allows us to pass in a prop
called is open
so for example if I pass this as false
it's never going to let me open this
thing so the reason this is useful is
because we can pass in the value of our
is open state from our recoil atom to
our directory menu here and that is how
we are going to be able to actually
toggle the openness of this menu from
other components and this should become
even more clear when we build out the
custom hook so let's start working on
that so let's go into our hooks folder
and let's create a new Hub called use
directory
dot TSX
okay use our snippet here
and we are not going to be taking in any
props we can get rid of this
okay and we are just going to return for
now an empty object and then we can get
rid of the return type
react.xc so just like our other custom
hooks this Hook is going to manage our
recoil state of our directory menu and
we can access this state from any other
component just by calling this hook so
we can pull in our directory state by
saying directory State set directory
state is equal to use recoil
State and we want to pass in our
directory menu State atom so make sure
that Imports all right so before we
actually build the rest of this out I
want to show you how this is going to be
used inside of our directory to provide
some clarity so the first thing we're
going to return from our Hook is going
to be the actual value of our directory
state which if you remember has two
pieces is it open and the currently
selected menu item so inside of our
directory here now we can pull in that
state from our custom hook
so we can say const is equal to use
directory
and it does not want to import
there we go okay and now we can actually
pull in that directory State and so the
value we want to pass to our is open
prop of our shotgun menu is going to be
our directorystate DOT is open
so hopefully this is starting to make
more sense now so I'm getting an error
here use directory oh I think I have to
save this okay that's probably why yeah
okay okay so now it's false so so we're
not we're not actually able to toggle
the state of that yet but we're going to
work on that but now we can control
whether or not this menu is open using a
recoil atom so let's go back to our hook
here all right so let's create these
sort of skeleton outline of this
component here it's a pretty simple hook
it's not super long at all so the first
function is going to be called toggle
menu open and this is going to be
actually responsible for changing the
open state of our directory menu and
this is the function we're going to be
able to call from anywhere in our app to
actually open up our directory so we can
create this as a function and inside of
here all we want to do is call set
directory state
and toggle the value of the is open
parameter to be the opposite of what it
currently is so I want to update the is
open property of our directory menu
State and I want to change it to be the
value that is that is opposite to the
current value that's sort of what
toggling is on off on off so if it's off
I'm going to turn it on and if it's on
I'm going to turn it off
so now if I save this and I return this
from a hook
just like that then I go back to the
directory component and I pull that
toggle function in toggle menu open and
then I pass this to the on click of our
menu button here which is our like this
thing here in our in our nav bar if I
pass this to the other click so if I say
on click is equal to toggle menu open
now I should actually be able to open up
the menu so how cool is that and this is
the same function we are going to call
from The Post Line from the home page
and the Community page is just going to
take us to the submit page but on the
home page it's going to call that toggle
menu open function which is going to
open up this menu so now at a global
level we can toggle the openness of this
menu thanks to our recoil atom and this
hook let's go back and continue building
up this hook the other function that
we're going to have in here is going to
be the function that is triggered when
the user actually clicks on a menu item
in the directory so we're going to call
that on select menu item
and this is going to take in a menu item
and it is going to be archetype
directory menu item which we if you
remember exported from our recoil item
file
so we're going to take this and we want
to update our directory state
to have this passed in menu item
as the selected menu item so we can
update selected menu item to be the menu
item that was clicked on so when I click
on Tesla motors for example that menu
item is going to be sent to this
function and then our directory state is
going to be updated with the Tesla
Motors menu item and probably the most
important thing is when the user clicks
on a menu item we actually want to take
them to that route right like they're
going they're clicking on it to go there
not just for fun so we need to bring in
our router from next router so router is
equal to use router and after we set
State we can call
router.push and we can tell the router
to take us to the menu items link
so hopefully this is all starting to
piece together now let's actually go see
how we're going to use this on select
menu item from within our menu so if we
go back to our menu list item component
which again represents a single item in
our in our list here so when we click on
one of these menu items we actually want
to call that on select menu item
function and set that state to be the
one we clicked on so at the top we can
pull that function in from our hook use
directory and we can bring in toggle
sorry not toggle menu item on select
menu item and in this on click function
here we actually want to change this to
call that on select menu item function
so inside this function here we can
package up all of the props that are
passed to this component into an object
that is of type directory menu item
because that is the type of the argument
that is required by our on select menu
item function and so that is why we are
passing in all these props and that is
why our directory menu item type has the
exact same properties of the process we
are passing in to this component here so
we want to pass this an object and again
this object is up type directory menu
item which has property display text
link icon icon color and image URL
optional so now if I actually click on a
different Community new new we should
actually be taken to that Community page
so let's click on it
okay so the community updated and the
data updated but the image is still
showing okay I think on the um Community
index page here yeah so we need to I
initially declare this as an empty
dependency array in this use effect here
we need to add a dependency of community
data and so this is so that every time
we actually change communities and
Community data changes we update our
current Community State to be that
latest community of data before without
the dependency it was just running a
single time we want to run this every
single time the user navigates to a new
community and Community data changes so
if I save this now now that should
update all right so the header updated
but you'll notice that the post did not
we're still seeing the posts from
Shady's group and the reason that is is
we have to go do the exact same thing in
our get posts function use effect in our
post component we need to add a
dependency of community data so we go to
our post component here yes we created
this use effect and it's currently only
built to run once because there's an
empty dependency array and we want to
call this function get posts every
single time the community changes
because you want to get the post for the
community that the user is currently in
so we can add a dependency here of
community data which is being passed as
a prop to this component and so now if I
save this it should fetch the post from
this community which currently there are
none so let's create one just for fun
inside new new blah blah blah blah blah
blah random text okay post
cool so now I'm in new new and I see
this post I just made if I go back to
Shady's group it should like resetch all
of that data so now all that data
updates the community data updates the
header updates and everything so go back
to new new the data updates so perfect
so all we had to do was just add
dependencies in our use effects to make
them trigger every time we switch
communities okay and also you'll notice
that when I switch communities when I
click on one of these menu items the
menu just stays open right it'd probably
be nice if it just closes once I click
on a menu item that kind of makes sense
so all we have to do to do that is if we
go to our use directory hook here so
right after we push the link to our
router we can call our toggle menu open
function to close the menu so we can say
if the directory state
dot is open then we want to close it we
can call toggle menu open just like that
and so now when I click on a menu item
it should close it
very nice that is beautiful okay so what
we want to do now is actually change it
so that the display text of the
community as well as that icon are
displaying in our menu here because
right now it's always just home because
I think we have home hard coded
um in the menu button so if you go to
our directory here
thing yeah so we just have home here we
need to change the icon as well as the
text to be dynamic and pull from our
state which we're already grabbing from
our hook here okay so inside of here
let's change this home text to actually
be the currently selected menu items
display text so we can say directory
state
dot selected menu item dot display text
so now if I save this we should see
Shady's group in the thing that awesome
so now it's actually the community we're
currently in so if I go to new new
updates now we need to change the icon
so what I'm going to do is above this
icon I'm going to add a ternary operator
to check for the existence of the
selected menu items image URL and if the
image URL exists we want to display that
instead of the icon and if it doesn't
exist we will display the icon okay so
let's check for the existence of the
directory state DOT selected menu item
dot image URL if this exists let's show
an image from Chakra with the source of
the image being the image URL from the
selected menu item and if it does not
exist we are just going to show the icon
and the icon we want to pass in the as
prop as the directory state DOT and
selected menu item dot icon just like
that and we want to make the color of
this icon the icon color from the
directory state so you can see directory
state DOT selected menu item dot icon
color Okay so let's save this so that a
format okay so now we can see the icon
of this community is actually in this
component here so let's make it so we
can see the image if it exists so we're
going to make the source of this image
equal to the directory state
no autocomplete dot selected menu item
dot image URL okay and we're going to
make the Border radius full so that it
is circular
and we want to make this a box size of
24 pixels
and we can give this some margin right
up to you
so now if I go to a community that
actually has an image URL like Chinese
group it should show there
which it does perfect that is so cool
and if I expand this out
we can see that it says our Chinese
Viewpoint actually has the icon or the
image for that community so that is
super cool all right so we are very very
close to being done our custom look
there's just one more thing we have to
add and this has to do with what I'm
about to show you so right now our
directory menu is showing properly it's
currently Shady's group and it has our
image URL which is perfect but what
happens if I refresh
and we're starting off on the schizer
page you can see that it's initialized
as the home icon and that is if you
remember the default value of our
directory menu we have the default menu
item which is our home so right now it
is not built to know what community it's
in if you're starting off on that
Community page right it has to do with
again that refreshing thing so the
initial state of this needs to be
toggled if we're starting off on the
Community page because right now we're
only updating that state if we actually
click on something right but we it
doesn't know how to update by itself
based on the value of current community
so that's what we have to do so let's go
into our use directory hook and we can
handle this very similar to how we
handled the refreshing problem for the
community data as well as the single
post page view so we can create a use
effect that is essentially going to
listen to the current Community value
and based on what that is it is going to
you update the selected menu item by
itself without having to click on one
explicitly so we're going to have this
user effect have a dependency of the
Community State values current Community
because we already solved the refreshing
problem for the community data so the
community data is being fetched on
refresh and so current Community state
is being updated so if we listen for
updates to the current Community State
we will also be able to update our
directory menu item to be that current
communities item so we have this like
really nice data flow triggering thing
like where the community updates and
then that triggers another thing and
it's just a nice data flow so at the top
here we're going to need to bring in our
community State value so we can create a
variable called Community State value
and we can use our hook use recoil value
and we want to pass in our community
State atom then as a dependency on this
use effect we want to listen to changes
in the community State values current
community so now every time current
Community updates we are going to
trigger this use effect so I'm just
going to destructure the Community State
value and grab the current Community
from it like this current Community okay
so now we can check for a truthy value
of their current community and if there
is 1 we want to update our directory
states to be that Community as a menu
item and this is extremely useful for
the refresh case because we're basically
telling this component how to update
itself without needing to explicitly
click on one of those menu items because
this use effect is going to listen to
changes in the value of current
Community which is updated by our used
Community data hook so you can say if
current community
we can call our set directory State
function take the previous value and we
want to update our selected menu item
and we want to set the selected menu
item to be an object of type directory
menu item so we need this to have all of
the properties that is required by that
state here which are all of these things
here directory menu item our display
text
we can make R forward slash
then we can take the ID of the current
community so we can say commute current
Community
dot ID
the link
we can set to be forward slash R forward
slash
current community
dot ID
okay
typescript is freaking out right now
this looks all these red underlines the
next one is going to be our image URL
which is going to be the current
Community Dot imageurl and then we just
want to pass in a fallback icon in case
the image URL does not exist then it's
just going to show our fa Reddit Icon by
default and the default color of that is
just going to be blue 500.
just like this perfect so now typescript
is happy thank God all those red
underliners are gone
okay so now if I save this this updated
okay so now if I refresh the menu item
should no longer be home by default it
should update to be Chinese Group which
it did the image URL is there and you
can see that
perfect
that is so cool so I can go into here I
can refresh this and it's no longer just
going to be the home value because it's
picking up that there is a current
community in state here and then it's
updating our directory menu item to to
be that current community and as well as
its image URL Chinese group can refresh
awesome that is amazing
and then what we want to quickly do is
make it so that if they click on the the
logo here it just takes them to the home
page that's pretty much how every
website works if you click on the logo
it just takes you home so let's go back
to our navbar component here okay and on
our logos here this flexbox represents
our logos if you remember from way back
from like part one we can add it on
click here to these logos
and we can call that select menu item
function from our hook so we can bring
that in up here we can say cons is equal
to eu's directory
and we can bring in our on select menu
item function and then our on click for
the logos in call
are on select menu item function and
pass in the default menu item which if
you remember is just the home value it's
the home tax with the home icon I'm
actually going to make the cursor equal
to pointer now
because it's clickable
so now I have to click on this it just
takes them home and the menu item
updates to just be the home icon as well
as the home text and then go back size
group it updates that is amazing so the
very last thing we have to do related to
our directory here is just go back to
our create post component and actually
have it open up the directory if there
is no current Community meaning that
they are on the home page so if we go
back to our create post link component
here we already have created this on
click function that routes the user to
the community submit page so if I click
on this I go to the submit page of
Shady's group we just want to add a
condition to check if there is no
Community ID let's open up the directory
because if there is no Community ID that
means that they're on the home page all
you have to do is after grabbing the
community ID off of the router we can
check is there even a community ID if
there is
then we want to call router.push and
take them to the submit page and if
there is not a community ID we want to
open our directory menu
okay so in order to do that we need to
bring in our toggle menu function from
our hook so you can say const is equal
to use directory
bring in our toggle menu item function
then down here we can call toggle menu
open and we actually want to return out
of this function if this if statement is
triggered because we don't want to open
the menu as well so if I save this now
so if there is a community ID which
right now there currently is a create
post link is going to take me to the
submit page but when I'm on the home
page which we have not created yet when
we add the create post link to our home
page it's actually going to open up the
menu and so that is how we're actually
going to open up our directory menu from
the home page and the home page is
extremely simple to make because all
we're going to do is just drop in
components that we have already created
and it's just going to magically work
all right you guys so as I just
mentioned we are going to be working on
the home page of our app here because we
have already covered all of the
community based functionality and all we
need to do now is work on the index page
of the app and we basically just have a
post feed very similar to the
communities and then these right hand
side supporting components here like the
top communities and then these other
sort of simple components here all right
so since on the home page we are not in
any particular Community we just need to
write a few functions to actually build
out the posts that will be inside of the
user's feed because when we go into a
community that query is very simple we
just go find all the posts with the
community ID that we are currently in
but on the home feed we sort of need to
write some different logic to actually
determine what we're going to show to
the user and we want to do this for both
logged in users and users that are not
logged in meaning that they're sort of
visiting the site for the first time so
if I log out you'll see that the feed
changes and it's slightly different and
then if I were to log back in it builds
a feed that is specific to this
particular user so we just have to write
two functions one to build the feed for
a logged in user and one to build the
feed for a non-logged in user and our
functions are going to be a very
simplified versions of What Reddit
probably does to build up the user's
feed they probably have very very
Advanced backend functions that use
machine learning and everything to
actually determine what to show to the
user in our case we're going to be
writing some simple functions so we're
not going to get into any sort of
machine learning or anything so our
functions that build out our feed are
going to be much simpler than what
Reddit probably uses and our home page
just like every other page we've seen
follows the same exact layout pattern
with the left hand side or right hand
side so we can again use our page
content layout component and then just
drop the components in there and it'll
style it all very nicely just like the
other Pages all right so let's actually
go to our app and go to our own home
page here which should be just
completely blank because we have not
written really anything inside of here
and the file we're going to be working
in here is this going to be our index
page so if we go into Pages it's the
root of the entire app this is where all
of the initial next.js page stuff went
we have not touched this file since way
back in part one when we sort of just
deleted everything inside of it so now
we're going to actually fill this thing
up and put some meaningful content in
here all right so I'm going to close my
directory here and let's start with the
actual HTML layout on this component so
as I just mentioned we are again going
to be able to use our page content
layout component that we have created
and we can just create the two empty
fragments in here all right so in the
first fragment we are going to have our
actual Post Feed and then in this
left-hand type container we are going to
have our our recommendations
and those other two very simple
components
um in the right hand side here
all right so that's sort of the skeleton
for our HTML let's work on the skeleton
of the functional part of this component
so the first function we're going to
have is going to be called build user
home feed and this is going to be
responsible for building out the feed
for an authenticated user that is logged
in second function we're going to have
is going to be called build no user home
feed and pretty self-explanatory this is
going to be for users who are not logged
in and our third function is going to be
called get user post votes
and this is only going to be called four
authenticated users and if you remember
the way we got our votes when we were
inside of a community was that we got
all the votes for posts within that
Community but since on the home page we
are not in a community we're going to
get the votes that may possibly exist
for the posts that do end up showing up
in our feed depending on what this
ability user home feed function ends up
putting into our post date and this
function is a very minor detail on the
home page because if you think about the
home page of really any application like
Reddit or Twitter or Facebook when you
refresh your homepage you're typically
seeing content you haven't seen before
it's new so you probably would not have
voted on it but there is a chance
especially in our demo we don't have a
ton of user generated data like on
Facebook and Twitter so it just makes
sense to have this function here to sort
of just cover the basis to make it
actually make sense in case a post is in
the feed that we have previously voted
on so that is sort of how this is going
to work but we'll cover a lot more on
that when we get to it so don't worry
about this for now and beneath these
functions there's going to be a few use
effects that we're going to have to
to actually sort of manage the logic and
the data flow and govern how these
functions are actually called depending
on if there's a user logged in and
depending on other state in our
application so the most important thing
on our home page is whether or not we
actually have a user logged in that
really drives how our feed is built and
what functions we need to call here so
the first thing I'm going to bring in is
going to be our user object from our use
off State function I'm going to pass
this our auth instance from Client app
and we're also going to bring in the
loading parameter returned from our use
off State hook which we're going to call
loading user and this is going to help
us in our use effect logic to know which
one of these functions to call and this
will become more clear let me actually
start writing them out all right so now
that we actually have our user object
let's write out our use effects and see
how they are going to interact with the
user object and the loading user
parameter to actually determine what
functions we're going to call
so our first use effect is going to have
the dependencies of user as well as
loading user
all right so inside of this user fact we
basically want to know if the user is
logged in or not and if the auth service
has attempted to try to get the
authenticated user because there is a
delay there as soon as we boot up our
application there might be an
authenticated user that was logged in
previously from like a previous session
or the user might be logging back in or
sign up but the auth service has to go
and actually get that from the Firebase
servers and while it is attempting to
fetch the authenticated user the user is
null and that is the purpose of this
loading user state it starts off as true
and then it goes in attempts to fetch a
user and then when it comes back either
with or without a user it's going to set
loading user to be false it's like oh
okay I tried to go get it and there
either is one or there isn't one um and
if there is one this will be a truthy
value and if there is not one this will
be a falsy value so if we just wrote an
if statement like this like saying if
there's no user then build the no user
home feed that actually would not work
because like I said before when the
application is initialized and the
person actually navigates to our website
this is always going to be undefined or
null or some policy value at first while
they use off State hook attempts to
fetch that user from our auth service so
at first we're always not going to have
a user but that doesn't mean there isn't
going to be one that is returned from
the use off State hook and so that's why
this wouldn't work because we can't just
assume that no user initially means that
we should build the no user home feed we
need to know that the service actually
attempted to fetch the user and then if
it did attempt to fetch one and there
still isn't one then we want to build
the no user home feed so I hope that
makes sense so what we can do to
actually implement this is to say if
there is no user and we are no longer
attempting to fetch the user then build
a no user home feed that means that the
auth service tried to get the
authenticated user and there was not one
and we should build our feed for a
non-authenticated user so there is
another use effect that we are going to
write in a bit that is going to tell us
if we need to call the ability to
Homeview function as well as the get
user post votes function but we are
going to work on the no user home feed
first and then we will Circle back to
the actual user home feed alright so
let's start writing out the logic for
our no user home feed so what I'm going
to do is at the very top here just below
our user here I'm going to create some
loading state so that we can actually
use our post loader again very similar
to how we use it inside of the Community
page and once you set it equal to false
to start off and inside of our build no
use your home feed function I'm going to
create a try catch block and the very
first thing we're going to do at the top
is set loading to be true and then at
the end we can set loading to be false
just like this and we can log our error
build no user home feed
error
so our very simple no user home feed
algorithm is just going to be simply
grabbing the 10 most popular posts in
our database and a really good feature
to add in your app would be pagination
so that you could you know load 10
initially and then if the user keeps
scrolling it would load another 10 so
that it keeps your front end nice and
light so you'll notice fetch all of the
potion database you can start off with
10. pagination is really good for
front-end optimization and it just
ensures you're not fetching too much
data in our case we're just going to
create a simple query that grabs the 10
most popular posts in our database and
the way we can do that is by querying
our post collection and ordering them by
the vote status so to do this we can
create our post query object which is
going to be created using the query
function from firestore
the first argument this requires is a
collection reference to the collection
we are querying so import collection
from firestore pass it our firestore
instance from Client app the collection
we are querying is posts so after our
collection reference we can pass in some
query specifications to tell firestore
what exactly we want from this
collection reference so we want to grab
documents from our post collection but
we want to order them by the vote status
so we can bring in our order by function
from firestore and the key that we're
ordering by is vote status that's the
name of the field on our posts and we
can pass in a second argument of
descending because we want the highest
rated at the top
okay and as a third argument we can pass
in another query specification and in
our case we're going to pass in a limit
so you can bring in the limit function
for firestore and you can pass it 10
just like this so This query is going to
get 10 posts from the post collection
that are ordered by vote status in
descending order so that the highest
rated is at the top so now we can
actually get these documents from
firestore by passing our post query to
our get docs function so we can say post
docs is equal to a weight get Docs
and in order to use the await keyword we
do need to make this function
asynchronous so let's do that
and then we pass in our post query to
this function here and as usual we can
create another array called posts and
extract all of the data from each of the
post documents inside of post docs so
you can say postdocs dot Docs
.map take each one and turn it into an
object with an ID of dot ID
dot ID and spread all of the data inside
of the document to extract it all out
now in order to put these posts into our
post State we are going to need to grab
our set Post State function from recoil
so we can grab that value from our use
post custom hook because we're going to
grab a bunch of other stuff from this
hook as well so we might as well grab
the state from here too so for now we
can grab our set Post State value
function returned by our hook come down
here and take the post array that we
just created and call set post date
value and we want to update this to
contain those posts and we can tell
typescript that this is going to be an
array of posts we can say posts is going
to be equal to posts as an array of
posts so make sure the post type imports
from post atom that is a lot of same
posts kind of a tongue twister after a
while so now we have successfully
retrieved posts from the database and
put them into our post State now all we
need to do is actually show them here in
our feed so we're going to do something
extremely similar to what we did in our
posts component if we go back to this
component here all we did was take our
post date and map through them and for
each one create a post item and we're
going to do the exact same thing here
it's actually going to look exactly the
same as this even with the post loader
so let's go back to our index page
and we can remove this comment
and inside of our left fragment here we
can put the same ternary operator that
we had in that post component so we can
say are we loading the post right now so
if loading is true we want to show our
post loader which we can import
and if it is false and we are not
loading we want to map through all of
those posts inside of post date and
return a post item for each one okay so
we're actually going to need our post
State value from our hook as well so
let's come back up here and just grab
that
Post State value and we can come down
here and we actually are going to wrap
all of our posts in a stack to space
them out nicely so import stack from
Chakra and inside of our stack we are
going to say postatevalue dot post dot
map
take each post
and for each one we want to create a
post item component just like this and
actually if you remember from our last
part we also want our create post link
on the home page as well which is what
triggers the opening of our directory so
let's put this at the top of our
fragment here above our stack so you can
say create post link
and if we save this we should see the
create post link unless we get an error
we're not seeing post because post item
thing is broken and we're not even
calling that function yet but we can see
the create post link which is perfect so
our post item component if you remember
requires all those functions like on
vote and on delete and on select so
let's go back up to our use post hook
and grab all of those so we're going to
grab on select post on delete post and
on vote okay so let's come back to our
post item and pass all these in as props
so our first prop can be a key which is
going to be our post dot ID
second one can be the post itself post
is equal to post third one can be our on
select course function
on select post is equal to on select
post that's on delete post
we can pass on vote
on vote we can pass in our user vote
value and if you remember this is where
we're going to check if a vote for this
particular post exists in the user post
post state so you can say Post State
value
dot posts of votes dot find
and we want to iterate through all of
these votes and see if one has a post ID
that is equal to this current post or
iterating theories ID just like this
okay let's scroll down here and if we
can find a vote then we just want to
grab the vote value from that vote okay
we're going to pass another prop called
the user is Creator to know if we are
the author of this post so we can say
does the user ID
equal to this post Creator ID
and the last prop we are going to add is
going to be a Boolean called home page
to tell this component whether or not we
are currently on the home page and this
is from a while ago but let's go back to
our post item and if you remember I
briefly touched on that here I had this
comment saying home page check and that
is so that we can display the community
name and the image URL here if we're on
the home page because if we're inside of
the community we do not show that
because we don't really need to because
we're inside that community so we don't
need to display what community it is but
on the home page we do want to show that
so that the user can actually click on
it and see what community it's in so
inside of our post item here we can come
to the top and on our post item props
type we can add an optional Boolean prop
here that is going to be passed if we
are indeed on the home page so then we
come down to our component here and grab
that from the props from the structuring
then on our index page we should now
actually be able to pass this in just
like this and just by simply passing it
in it is going to be true perfect and
this is actually it for our entire left
hand side fragment so I can save this
and all I need to do now let's go back
to our app here is just have it actually
call this function so if I log out let's
see what happens
it actually called the function and it
went and got those 10 posts from the
database now our database only has one
post
um so it's going to get up to 10. yeah
there's only one post
but it would get 10 if there were 10.
and like I said before after we finished
the no user case we're going to write
out the logic to actually build the feed
for what happens when I log in and there
actually is a user but now this is
pretty cool because you can actually see
some posts on our feed and they appear
exactly the same as they do in a
community it's just a more generic feed
so now let's go into our post item
component and quickly write out that new
Logic for checking if we are on the home
page and display the community image URL
and the link to that Community if we are
indeed on the home page so just
underneath this comment here we can add
some logic to check if we are on the
home page so we can say home page and
then write the double Ampersand sign to
say if we are on the home page we want
you to display this additional
information that we're going to right
here so I'm going to create a fragment
inside of here so now if I just put a
given here that says home page just to
test this out
if I save this we should see that here
so let's get rid of this div and inside
of here we're going to add a ternary
operator to check for the existence of
the community image URL and if it exists
we're going to display it and if it does
not we're going to show our generic
Reddit icon this is our classic image
icon turnaround operator so you can say
does the Post contain an image URL
if it does let's show that image so we
can use our image component from Chakra
and if we do not have an image let's
show our classic Reddit icon simple icon
and then we can say as
fa Reddit icon so this icon we're going
to give a font size of a 18 point
and a margin right of one as well as a
color of blue 500. okay so on our image
component we want to make the source
equal to that post dot Community image
URL and we actually have not added this
parameter to our post yet in our new
post form but we're going to go do that
in just a second it's a single line
addition
we want to make the Border radius of
this equal to full to make it round and
we want the box size to be equal to 18
pixels and we're going to give this a
margin write of two just like this so
underneath this ternary operator here
now we're going to actually add the link
to that community so you can bring in
our link component from next link and we
want to give this an href value
of the page that we want to go to when
we click on this thing and that is going
to be our forward slash
then we want to pass the post dot
Community ID
okay inside of our link we're going to
have some text we can add some curly
brackets because the text you want to
display inside of here is going to be R
forward slash then the postdoc Community
ID
okay so if I save this now we can
actually see that link in there let's
add some styling here so we're going to
make the font weight of this text
heavier so we're going to make it 7 and
we're also going to give it some hover
styling to make it appear as if it's a
link because it is and links usually
have a underline text decoration so you
can say text decoration and we can give
this an underline value here just like
that and to create some space between
this link as well as the posted by
username text rather than just adding
some margin we're going to add this
little dot icon here because that's how
Reddit has it and it looks really nice
okay so just underneath this link here
we can create another icon but this icon
is going to be the value BS dot so make
sure that Imports and we're going to
give this a color of gray 500 and a font
size of eight so it's very small and
very subtle but it does get some spacing
there and I think it looks really good
so now I can actually click on this link
and it'll take us to this community so
let's watch
so it took us to the community but just
for a second there it actually took us
to the single post page view so if I go
back
the first route that it went to was the
single post page view and then it went
to the Community page and this again has
to do with event propagation because we
haven't on click on the post item here
that takes us to the single post page we
do need to do some event propagation to
prevent us from triggering that when we
click on the link inside of the post
item so what we can do is just add a
simple on click to our text here
and we can just simply take the click
event that is generated and call the
events.stop propagation function on it
and so now if I were to save that if I
click on this link now it will take us
directly to the Community page it is not
going to first go to the single post
page view and then the Community page so
now if I go back
the previous route is the home page not
the single post page and now we just
need to go back and quickly add the
community image URL to our new post
documents if it exists because chatty's
group if I go into here does have a
custom Community image and we need that
to be inserted onto the post as well and
we are currently not doing that very
simple to fix we can just go to our new
post form file so in order to insert
this on this new post object we do need
access to that value so what we're going
to do is add the community image URL as
a prop to our new post form so if we go
back to where this new post form is
actually rendered it is on the submit
page
we can see that the new post form is
here and we have the Community State
value inside of this file so what we're
going to do is pass this as a prop to
our new post form so you can say
community image URL and this is going to
be equal to Community State value
dot current Community dot image if URL
just like that then inside of our new
post form we have to actually add that
to our prop type here okay so underneath
our user we can add Community image URL
and we're going to make this optional
because if it does not exist on the
current Community the value of it is
going to be undefined so we need to tell
typescript that it's going to be either
undefined or a string okay so now we can
grab that from our restructured props
here Community image URL and on our new
post object
underneath the community ID we can add
Community image URL and we want to make
it the value of community image URL or
if it does not exist and it is undefined
we're going to pass an empty string and
the reason we're doing that is because
Firebase will not like it if we pass a
value of undefined here we need to pass
in a empty string instead they're both
policy values but Firebase just wouldn't
like the value of undefined it is happy
though with an empty string so the value
of community image URL is going to be
this variable if it exists and if it is
not we're passing an empty string so now
if I were to save this and inside of
Chinese group create a new post oh I
have to log in let's log back in
as Shah merhi
oh forget my password okay so if I go to
create post and I call it uh Community
image feature and I can say newest
feature
okay and if I post this
and go back to the home page we should
see the community image URL in this post
because it was inserted this post
however does not contain it because this
feature we did not have when we created
this post and actually if I go into
Shady's group and I change the image to
something else like the Google logo here
and I save that
if I went back to the home page and were
to refresh
the posts should have the latest
Community image that would have to log
out to see that because our feed is only
Built for logged out users and you can
see that the Google image is indeed
there so you can close this new post
form we can close the submit page and we
can come back to our index page here now
let's start working on the actual Logic
for building out the user feed for our
authenticated users okay so for users
that are logged in we are going to show
them posts from the communities that
they have actually joined and we know
all of the users communities thanks to
our community snippet State inside of
Community State value so what we can do
is build some sort of query that is
going to grab a set of posts from the
various communities that the user is in
so the main thing that this function
needs to accomplish is to get posts from
the users communities
okay so let's create a try catch block
and log the error if it occurs build
user home feed error
okay then at the very top here we're
going to set our loading state to be
true and at the very bottom set loading
state to be false
okay
so the way we can write our query such
that it fetches posts from multiple
communities rather than just one is we
can create an array of the users
Community IDs using the community
Snippets and we can write a where clause
in our query to find post documents with
the community ID that is inside of that
array so since we are going to be
fetching posts from specific communities
we do want to make sure that the user
has indeed joined some communities so we
can write an if statement to check for
the length of the community Snippets
array so we can say if Community State
value dot my Snippets dot length meaning
that there are indeed communities that
this user has joined then we are going
to get posts from the user's communities
and if the user has not joined any
communities meaning that they're like a
new user or they just haven't joined
anything yet we're just going to call
our build no user home feed function
because that's going to build them a
nice generic feed so we're going to need
to create an array of the user Community
IDs because it's going to be required by
the query we're going to write and we
can do that using their Community
Snippets so we can create this array and
we can call it my community IDs
and what we want to do is basically
extract the ID from all of the users
Snippets so we can take the Community
State value dot my Snippets and map
through them and for each snippet we
want to sort of convert it into just the
community ID so we're basically just
converting the full snippet object to
just a single string that is the snippet
dot Community ID so my community IDs is
just going to be an array of all of the
extracted Community IDs from all of the
Snippets and we're going to use this in
our post query which we can create right
now so we're going to say cons post
query
and we can use our query function again
first argument is going to be our
collection which is going to take our
firestore instance collection name is
post so the second argument to our query
function is going to be our where clause
and this is where we're going to
actually use that Community ID array so
we want to get posts where the community
ID of the post is in
the my community IDs array
and this is how we can write that using
this where function repair server so
this is going to find all of the posts
where the post Community ID is inside of
the my community's ID array that we just
created and we're also going to set a
limit on this so that we don't
fetchulate hundreds of posts if they
exist so we're going to set a limit of
10. and again this is a very simple
query to build out the user home feed a
really good thing you could build on top
of this app would be to make the actual
feed functions a lot more sophisticated
this works though for the purpose of
this demo then we can actually fetch
these documents from firestore so we can
say cons post docs is equal to a weight
get docs and pass it our post query then
we can create our post array and map
through all of the postdocs dot Docs
take each document and convert it into
an object with the ID of doc.id and with
the data inside of the document okay
then we can just call our set post date
value function and actually put these
posts inside of our post state so we
want to update posts to be posts as an
array of posts very similar to what we
did in the no user home feed function
okay so just to reiterate we are
checking if the user is inside of any
communities if they are we're going to
go get some posts that are inside of
those communities and if they are not in
any communities we're just going to call
the no use at home feed function that's
going to build them the generic feed
that is not specific to any Community
okay so now that this function has been
written we do need a way to call it and
the way we're going to do that is going
to be with another use effect that is
going to run some logic and check if it
is appropriate to call that function
very similar to what we did with our
build in the user home feed function
down here so we can create another use
effect here
okay so just like this use effect down
here that is listening to some
application State and then waiting to
read those values to see if they match
some condition that it makes it
appropriate to call they build no user
home feed function we're going to do
something extremely similar inside of
here as well we want to basically know
when we should call our build user home
feed function now if we look at this
function we can see that it is fetching
data based on the values inside of
Community State value dot my Snippets
meaning that this function and the posts
that we want to retrieve in this
function depend on this state here
Community State value dot my snippet so
we don't really want to call this
function until we have fetch those
Snippets from the database so that is
what we're going to do down here in this
use effect we're going to check and see
has our application attempted to fetch
the user Snippets from the database if
it has then let's go call that function
so as a result this use effect is going
to have a dependency of Community State
value
dot my Snippets because we want to
listen for changes in this value here
because it's initialized as an empty
array and then our app goes and gets
them from the database and then it puts
that data inside of the states we want
to know when these updates occur but
there's a slight problem here we saw
that in our function build use your home
feed that we check for a length of the
array and if there is a length meaning
that the user is inside of communities
we go and get posts for those
communities and if they are not in any
communities meaning that that array is
empty we just build them the generic
feed but we need a way to know that our
app has attempted to try and fetch the
Snippets because it's just simply
checking for the length of the snippet
so if you were to say something like if
Community State value dot my Snippets
dot length and then in this case we
would call build user home feed this
doesn't actually work because what if
the user has not joined any communities
like the database could attempt to go
get those Community Snippets but there
could be none because it's like a new
user or they just haven't joined
anything yet meaning that this would be
false meaning that this would not get
called so simply just checking the
length of the community Snippets is not
enough information to know whether or
not we should call this function we need
some other piece of State similar to how
down here just checking the truthiness
of the user was not enough we needed to
look at this loading state to see has
our use offstate hook attempted to fetch
the user and the solution to this is
basically creating something similar to
this loading user State on our community
State value so all we need to do is add
some sort of parameter to our community
State value that is going to change once
our application has indeed tried to
fetch the sentence from the database
only after it has tried to fetch these
from database and put them into 8 we
will call this build user home feed
function and in this use effect here we
actually do not need to worry about
checking for the existence of a user and
the reason is because if you go to our
use Community data hook the use effect
that's responsible for fetching the
Snippets in the first place already
depends on the user and it's only going
to go and get the Snippets for that user
if the user exists meaning that this use
effect over here inside of our index
page implicitly depends on the user so
we don't have to explicitly Define it
here because the way we're going to
write this use effect is going to make
it impossible for it to even trigger
before this one has actually finished
so all we need to do is go into our
communities atom here and add some piece
of state that's going to tell us if we
have attempted to fetch the community
Snippets in the first place so all we
need to do is on our community State
interface here we can add a parameter
called Snippets fetched which is going
to be a Boolean that is going to be
initialized as false because as soon as
the application loads we have not fetch
the Snippets and once the Snippets have
been fetched for the first time this is
going to be set equal to true and then
that is the variable we can listen to
inside of our index Patron have the
Snippets be fetched oh okay they have
let's go build up the user home feedback
let's go back to our communities Adam
and inside of our default Community
State if you're going to initialize this
value to be false now back in our index
page over here we are going to change
this dependency from my Snippets to be
that Snippets fetched Boolean parameter
and then in this user effect we're going
to say if my community State DOT
Snippets fetched is true then go build
out the user home feed because then it
is appropriate to do that and then
inside of our abilities your home feed
function it would make sense to check
for the length of that array to see if
the user has joined any communities or
not so the only thing missing now is to
actually set this thing equal to True
inside of our fetch Civic function so
inside of use Community data
inside of the getmycipits function
right up here as soon as we fetch these
Snippets from the database for the first
time we can just update the value of
Snippets fetched to be true okay so the
data flow is like this the user is going
to log in which is going to trigger the
get my Snippets function to happen to
get my Snippets function is going to
fetch the Snippets from the database and
it is going to put them in state and
it's going to set the Snippets fetch
parameter to be true them inside of our
news effect over here on our index page
this use effect is listening to changes
on that Snippets fetch thing when this
is changed to true this user's effect is
going to trigger this if statement is
going to be triggered because it is true
and then as you're going to call the
build user home feed function and build
out the appropriate user home feed okay
so I hope that makes sense and this is a
very common thing in react to have your
user effects so listen to certain pieces
of state and wait for that data to come
in before triggering other things and
it's sort of this nice data flow logic
and I just make sure all of the data
that your functions depend on actually
exists or at least has been attempted to
have been fetched so now when I actually
log in it should go and fetch the
Snippets for shadmarehand email.com
which should trigger this build user
home feed function and a new feed should
be built so let's test it out
so sign in
okay nothing happened okay my Snippets
are not even being fetched
okay so there's definitely a user
because I'm logged in
oh okay you think that okay so I think
what's happening currently is that if
you go to a used Community data hook
this use effect that is um down here
that is supposed to call get my Snippets
which is listening to the user object is
actually not even happening because
we're currently not calling this Hook
from our index page we need to call this
hook in order to trigger these use
effects here uh so the way we can do
that is instead of pulling in Community
State value using the use recoil value
hook we can actually grab it from our
use Community data hook so we use
Community data
import that
and we can grab Community State value
and it's going to return the exact same
value that recoil did because this Hook
is after all just grabbing from recoil
but we are now going to actually trigger
the hook to call those use effects that
we needed to so now if I save this
okay so it did rebuild the feed there's
only two posts in our entire database
and there's only one Community I'm going
to need to create some more posts in
different communities that I'm not in to
test this out but if I log out it should
yeah it rebuilds the feed for a
non-authenticated user and also when the
user logs out and there is no user
anymore we want to actually reset the
value of that Snippets fashion Boolean
and we can do that inside of this use
effect here as well because we're
already kind of doing that when there is
no user we clear the my snippet State
because it is specific to a particular
user so if the user logs out we just MP
that array we can do the same thing with
these Snippets fetch thing here and this
ensures that if a user does happen to
log out and the feed is rebuilt for a
non-authenticated user and then they do
decide to log back in it will trigger
another update to rebuild the feed for
that user again so if I save this if I
log out it rebuilds the non-user feed
and if I log back in as chatty
it builds a feed for shady okay and both
of the user and non-user feeds look
exactly the same right now because our
database only has two posts in them and
so to actually differentiate the two
feeds here let's go back into that uh
new new new community or go into some
other community that you have created
and I want to create a post in here
uh new new blah blah blah blah blah blah
I'm going to post this inside of here
okay then what I'm going to do is come
to my home page
so okay we can see that this is in my
home feed because I I am in new new so
let's log out
so I see the same feed right let's log
back in and I should see the same feed
just in a different order
shot man cool okay but now what I'm
going to do is go into new new and leave
this community and after I go back home
I can see that the post is no longer in
my feed because I am no longer in new
new if I log out though it rebuilds the
feed and that post is in my feed so now
we can actually see a difference between
a user and a non-user feed if I log back
in
foreign
with only posts from the communities
that I am in and I actually realize
there is some missing logic inside of
our create Community model that I forgot
to add after we actually created the
Community page because we want to
actually create the community and then
be re-routed to that Community page and
currently it's not doing that it's just
creating the community and it just stays
with the model open and so to fix that
all we have to do is go back to our
create Community model which we haven't
seen in a long time so inside of our
handle create Community function and so
after our transaction runs and our
community is successfully created we
want to Route the user to that page and
we can do that using our router from xjs
so let's come up to the top here and
just unloading seed here let's bring
that in the cons to router is equal to
use router okay
than underneath our transactions inside
of our try block we can call router dot
push
and we want to push this user to the
route of our forward slash and then
Community name and that is the name that
they entered inside of the input in the
modal and we actually want to close the
community modal and we can do that with
our already existing handle close
function okay and one more simple thing
we can do is just close our community
directory here and we can do that with
our already existing toggle menu open
function from our use directory hook so
just underneath our router we can call
that hook use directory and we want to
bring in the toggle menu open function
then just after the handle close
function we can call toggle menu open
okay so now if I create a community and
it is successfully created it should
close the modal it should close the
directory and it should route me to that
new Community page so let's give this go
let's do create community and let's call
this Tesla Motors
create community
perfect okay so Tesla Motors was created
it brought me to the Tesla Motors page
and the directory closed and now I can
see Tesco Motors inside of my community
Snippets and that is exactly what we
wanted to do okay so let's go back to
our home page and we can close our
create Community model okay so let's go
back to our index page here and we are
now done with the build no user home
feed function as well as the build the
user home feed function and the last
thing we need to do is just write this
simple function to get the post votes
for the posts that end up appearing in
our feed and because post votes depend
on a user being logged in this is only
going to run if the user is indeed
logged in so we're going to create a
third user fact that's going to run some
logic to check whether or not we should
run our get user post Source function
okay so there are two important pieces
of state that we need to listen to
before we know if we should run our get
user postcodes function and the first
one is going to be our user and our
second one is going to be our post
datevalue dot posts because we want to
wait until there are actually posts in
that array before we go and try to get
votes for posts so we need both the user
as well as actual posts in the feed to
exist before it actually makes sense to
even call to get user post function okay
so then inside of here we can just write
a single if statement to say if user and
postdatevalue Dot posts dot length then
call the get user post votes function
because we have both of the things
required by that function hit then for
this function here we need to make this
asynchronous because it's going to be
fetch any data from the database and we
can create a try catch block and log the
error if it occurs get user post votes
error
and so what we want to do is query our
users post votes sub collection and try
to find the votes with a post ID that
matches any of the possible posts inside
of post date value and so to do this we
can write a similar query like we wrote
up here in our post query in this one we
are finding all of the posts with a
community ID that is inside of this my
community IDs array down here we're
going to be finding all of the votes
with a post ID that is inside of a post
ID array that we're going to create so
let's create that array and we'll call
it post IDs and this is going to be
equal to postatevalue dot posts and
we're going to map each of these posts
into just a post ID string so now post
IDs is just going to be an array of
string IDs then we can build out our
post votes query we can say post about
query and it's going to be equal to
query the collection we want to query
passes our firestore instance
and the path to the collection that
we're querying is going to be users
slash
user.uid slash postcodes
you can save this so it formats then as
the second argument to the query
function we can pass in that where
function and in this case we want to say
where the votes post ID is in
the post IDs array that we just created
then we can actually fetch these
documents from the database so we can
say post about docs is equal to a weight
get docs and pass in our post votes
query
then we can create our post votes array
and extract all of the data out of all
of these docs so you can say
postmodocs.docs.map
and map each document into a object with
the ID of that ID as well as all of the
data inside of Doc dot data and now we
just need to put these votes inside of
our post votes state so we can say set
Post State value
and update our
post votes to be post votes and we can
tell typescript this is going to be an
array of post votes so import that type
from your post atom file and indicate
that it's an array of postcodes so let's
come back to our app here so now we can
see that the votes for these potential
posts in the fee here are actually being
fetched because it's indicating that I
have voted on this post without calling
this function uh so if I comment this
out here in our use effect and we don't
call it you can see that the votes are
not being fetched uh if I call it back
in they are and kind of like what we
were talking about before with building
up the feed if there was enough data
being generated by the users most of the
time the content you're seeing in your
feed is brand new and you have never
seen it before and you have likely not
voted on it and in our case since we
just don't have a lot of data in our
demo here we just have to build this to
make it make sense because uh naturally
due to the lack of data some of the
posts that are showing up in our feed
here are posts that we have seen and
have voted on but just because there is
not enough data and to prevent duplicate
post votes from showing up in our postal
state to say on the home page we don't
fetch a bunch of votes for the posts and
then if we go into a community it's
going to fetch the post votes for that
community there could be some overlap
there and to prevent that we can inside
of this third use effect here that's
calling our get user post votes we can
create what is called a cleanup function
so in react when you return a callback
function inside of a use effect this
function runs when this particular
component Dismounts so in this case our
component is our index page so inside of
this use effect here we can return a
callback function which will be
triggered when we navigate away from the
index page hit end in react this is what
is known as a cleanup function because
we typically use them to clean up our
data and remove any sort of like stale
data from our state so inside of here
all we want to do is just clear our post
mode so if the user navigates to a
community page the post votes are sort
of started off on a new Clean Slate so
you can say set post date value and
simply just set our post votes to be an
empty array just like that and this is
typically what cleanup functions look
like so that is it for the entire
functional part of this component we
have written out all of the required
functions all we need to do now is just
create those right hand side components
alright guys we are now going to start
working on the top communities component
here on the right hand side of our home
page and it's relatively straightforward
component all we are going to do is
fetch the top five communities rated by
number of members and then we will
display them to the user here and give
them the functionality to join and leave
these communities from right within here
now on reddit.com every time you visit
the website you see a different list of
five communities here sometimes it's
like top sports communities sometimes
it's top pet communities or something
it's always changing and they have again
Advanced algorithms that are
recommending you certain communities
based on your interests and your user
actions our simplified version of that
is to always display the top communities
and grab the top five communities rated
by the number of members parameters
stored on the community document so
let's go back to our app and create this
okay so let's go into our files here and
inside of our community
folder which is up here I'm going to
create a new file called recommendations
dot TSX
okay I'm going to close my directory so
we have some more room and I'm going to
use the snippet and we are not going to
take in any props to this component so
we can remove that
so it's a pretty simple component all
we're going to have is a single function
that is going to be responsible for
fetching those top five communities so
we're going to call this get community
recommendations
and it is going to be an asynchronous
function
and we can create a try catch block
inside of here as usual and log the
error if it exists I'm going to paste
the function name in here because it is
difficult for me to type
also inside of this component we are
going to add a single use effect that we
are going to give an empty dependency
array so that it only runs a single time
after the component mounts to the Dom
and when the component maps to the Dom
we want to just call that get community
recommendations function okay and at the
top of this component here I'm going to
create two pieces of state and the first
one is going to be the actual
communities array where we are going to
store the top Community documents from
the database so we can say communities
and set communities
is equal to eu's State and we can
initialize this as an empty array and we
can indicate the type of items inside of
this array by importing our communities
type from our community atom file and
indicate that it is an array of
community items and I'm also going to
create some loading State inside of here
so we can display a nice skeleton loader
to the user which is going to be a
simple skeleton and we're going to
initialize loading as false and also
inside of this component we are going to
need our use Community data hook so we
can call that in here and what we're
going to need is the Community State
value as well as the on join or leave
Community function because we are
allowing the user to join or leave
communities from right within its
component so we need that function in
here all right so let's build out this
function so at the top here I'm going to
set loading state to be true and at the
very bottom we can set loading to be
false okay then inside of our try block
we can just build a simple query that is
going to grab the top five communities
ordered by the number of members
parameter so we can say cons Community
query is equal to query import the
queries function from firestore create a
collection reference to the collection
we want to query past collection our
firestore instance and the name of the
collection is going to be communities
and as a second argument we can pass in
our order by function
and we want to indicate that we want to
order by the number of members key and
we want them in descending order so that
the most popular is at the top and then
we can also just pass in a limit of 5
because we are only displaying the top
five okay so let's actually grab these
documents from the database so we can
say cons Community docs is equal to a
weight get docs as in our communities
query
and then extract all of the data from
each of these documents you can create
their communities array and say
community docs dot Docs
dot math
and map each document into a JavaScript
object with the ID of a DOT ID I thought
this so many times to be done this 100
times doc.id and the data from inside of
the document so
spread.data
just like this okay and then what we can
do is just set our communities array
state to be the value of this
community's array that we just created
here so we can say set communities
to be communities and we can indicate to
typescript that this is going to be
indeed an array of community just like
this and this community state in this
component is local here because we don't
really need it at a global level so it
makes sense to just have it local to the
component because that's really all
where we need it awesome and that is it
for this function and all that is left
is to build out the actual HTML of this
component here okay and if we look at
our demo here there is an image at the
top of this component here and this is
an external image that we are getting
from this images folder inside of our
public folder here and I think very back
in the early stages of this project I
had or I recommended you guys to grab
all of these images off of my GitHub and
put them in here but if you did not grab
all of them uh the one we're going to be
needing here is reccoms Art and we're
also going to be needing this one down
here this kind of like spaceship one and
I think that is
um Reddit personal home so these are the
two we are going to need retcoms art and
write a personal home so please ensure
that you grab those off my GitHub and
put them inside of your images folder in
your public folder okay so I'm going to
close this close the directory let's go
back to our app here and let's get rid
of this div
and the overall container is going to be
a flex container and inside of this Flex
container we're going to have two more
children Flex containers one for the
sort of header part which is that top
communities image thing I was just
talking about and then the other Flex is
going to be the container of all of the
communities here okay so let's go back
here and let's add the styles for the
outermost Flex container okay so this is
going to have a direction of column
we're going to give it a background of
white a border radius
of four we're going to add a border on
Pixel solid and the Border color
of gray 300. now let's work on this
header component here this first flex
child okay so the header component is
going to have an align value of flex end
because we want the text to appear at
the bottom of the um of the container
okay we're going to make the text color
white
we're going to give this padding of six
pixels top bottom 10 pixels left and
right we're going to make the height 70
pixels the Border radius is going to
take four inputs and it's going to be 4
pixels 4 pixels 0 pixels zero pixels
save this so it formats a little bit
nicer I'm going to give this a font
weight of 700 okay and this is where
we're going to place our image in here
so we're going to say the background
image and we are going to use that image
I was just talking about in the images
folder and we can access it via the URL
function through CSS and inside of here
we can pass in the path to that image so
it's slash Images slash Rec comms
art
dot PNG
just like this okay and then we're going
to add a background size that is going
to be equal to cover so that the image
fits the entire container and then all
that's going to be inside of our header
here is going to be the text top
communities just like this okay now
let's go back to our index page and
actually bring this in so we can see
what we're doing so where this comment
is in our right hand side fragment let's
bring that in so we can say
recommendations
perfect and I think you just have to
refresh because my hot reload thing is
uh kind of frozen or something
okay so we're not seeing that image for
some reason oh I'm missing images here
this is images there we go and to make
it so that we can actually see that top
communities text a little bit better
um I'm going to place the the sort of
like black overlay filtery blurry type
thing over the image just so it makes
that white text Pop a little bit more
okay so what we're going to do is add a
background gradient here
um and this is kind of a long string
here so I'm just going to paste this in
from my demo
and it's basically just a linear
gradient basically just that sort of
black overlay uh with some like light
opacity so that it's sort of see-through
and it just sort of makes the white text
Pop a little bit more okay and that is
it for this top communities header
component here okay so let's move on to
the actual communities list part of this
component here so we're going to give
this a direction of column as well
column and inside of here we are going
to also add a skeleton loader so I'm
going to add the turnaround operator
loading if we are loading we are going
to display a skeleton component that I'm
going to paste in from my project here
it's about 15 lines or something it's
just like a stack
just like this and I'm going to add all
of these missing Imports
okay and if we are not loading we
actually want to display those top
communities okay so inside of here I'm
going to create a react fragment so that
we can add some JavaScript we want to
iterate through all of the communities
so we can say communities.map and for
each one we're going to return one of
those list items and in each of these
list items we need to know if this user
has joined this community or not because
we need to toggle the display of this
button to make it say joined or join and
to make it blue or white and so to do
that for each one on each map iteration
inside of communities.map we can create
an is join variable and do the exact
same thing we did in our community
header to determine if the user is in
this community so we can just say
Community State value dot my Snippets
and try to find a snippet in here with
the community ID that matches this
particular item's ID okay so we can take
each snippet and check if it's Community
ID is equal to the item dot ID an item
is the current community that we are
iterating through here okay and then I'm
just going to booleanize this and add
the double bang operator here and then
underneath here is where we can actually
return the HTML for the community item
list component here okay so let's go
back to our app here all right so the
outermost container of this component
here is going to be a next link because
you're going to make these clickable and
direct the user to that Community if the
user does click on it okay so we can
bring in our link component from next
link and to satisfy reacts requirements
when I'm mapping through a list of items
we need to pass this a key so we can
give this a key of item dot ID and the
href prop of our link is going to be the
string that is forward slash R forward
slash then item dot ID so that's like
the community ID and inside of the link
we're going to have a flex container
here in this container is going to have
an align of Center so everything is
vertically centered we're going to give
this a font size of 10.8 order bottom
property of one pixel solid and a border
of color of gray 200
and we want to give this padding of 10
pixels top bottom 12 pixels right left
okay so we can save this okay then
inside of here we're going to have
another Flex container
and we're going to give this one a width
of 80 percent
and also an align of Center
inside of here we're going to have
another Flex container that is going to
contain the actual uh number here with
the one two three four five okay and
where we can get that number from is by
in the map function we can take
advantage of the fact that JavaScript
also gives us access to the index of the
current item we are iterating through
and so down here inside of this Flex
container we can add some text and that
text is going to be the index plus one
because we did not multiplicate 0 1 2 3
4 we participate one two three four five
and we need two important text from
Chakra which it does not Auto Import
good old text okay so if I save this
okay let's go back to our app here uh we
can see the one two three four five
thing there and the flex container of
this text you're going to give a width
of 15 here now as a sibling to this Flex
container with a width of 15 we're going
to create another Flex container and
this is going to be the parent of the
community name as well as the image or
the icon if there is no image okay so
we're going to give this an align of
Center as well as a width of 80 percent
then inside of here we can add our
famous image URL ternary operator we
want to check if the item has an image
URL and if it does we want to display
that image and if it does not we're
going to display our famous Reddit icon
so let's do the image here so let's
bring an image from Chakra
and we want to pass a source value that
is going to be equal to item dot image
URL
you want to make the Border radius equal
to full to make it round as well as a
box size of 28 pixels and we can give
this some margin right of two to add
some space between the image and the
community name okay and if there is no
image URL we want to display an icon and
that icon is going to be our fa Reddit
icon
to make sure that imports from react
icon F A if you want to make this a bit
bigger so we can give it a font size of
30 and a color of brand 100 our good old
Reddit Orange
brand 100 and a margin right of two
perfect okay so we can see those showing
up over there now underneath this
turnery operator here I'm going to
create a span element where we're going
to display the actual Community ID okay
and the reason I'm creating a span is
because we need to apply some CSS to the
text name so that if it's super long it
has like the triple ellipses like the
dot dot dot and so the text doesn't
overflow because that's how they do it
on Reddit and that styling wasn't
working on like the flex container
component from Chakra so I'm just using
a span and it seemed to work on there so
for this we just need to add some inline
styling and The Styling is going to be
white space which is going to be no wrap
and we're going to add overflow which is
going to be hidden
and you're going to give text overflow
to the ellipses just like this so if the
community name is super long it's just
going to show the triple dots which
looks pretty nice
let's go back to our app here and inside
of here all we need to do is display the
text that is going to be R forward slash
then item dot ID which is the community
name so if I save this now we can see
those names drop here so yeah you can
see the triple ellipties here for this
one with the longer name now all we are
missing for each of these list items is
just the button that the user can
actually click to join or leave the
community so two Flex containers down
from the span component we just created
I'm going to create a box which is going
to wrap our button component and inside
of here we're going to add our button
can I scroll up a bit okay so we can
give this button a height of 22 pixels a
font size of eight point then we can add
the variant property and we can make
this Dynamic depending on if the user is
or isn't joined in this community so we
can use our is joined Boolean then we
just create it up top and we can say if
they are joined we want the variant to
be outlined and if they are not we want
it to be solid and whoops I did not mean
to make this button self-closing we do
need a closing tag in here and the text
we want to display inside of our button
is also going to be dynamic depending on
that is joined parameter so we can
create another ternary operator if they
are joined we want to display the text
joined if they are not we want to
display join awesome so we can see that
showing up over here and then we just
need to add the on click to this button
to actually call our join or leave
Community function and inside of here
I'm going to take the click event that
is generated and create a function that
I'm going to call
event.stoppropagation so that we do not
trigger the next JS link when we try to
click on this button okay then right
after that we can call our on joinery
community function and pass in our item
because that is up type Community as
well as the is joined Boolean parameter
because that is what that function
requires
perfect so now this should be clickable
and I should be able to leave and join
these communities right from inside of
this component so how cool is that okay
so one very subtle thing you'll notice
is that the logo and the text kind of
move over very slightly depending on the
size of this button because there's only
so much room in this container and so
when this button is a little bit larger
the text and the logo move over and we
don't want that to happen because it
looks kind of weird and we want it to be
in the exact same spot all the time so
the way we can fix this is on our box
component here we can add absolute
positioning so we can say position
is equal to Absolute and we can position
these buttons to be 10 pixels from the
right of the parent container so if I
save this it's going to look kind of
weird we just need to go up to this Flex
container that is the first child of our
next.js link and add a position of
relative now that absolute position
button knows it is positioned relative
to its parent which is this Flex
container here awesome so now when this
button grows it's not going to change
the position of that text because it's
using absolute positioning it is no
longer technically taking up any space
in that container even though it appears
that way and so the very last thing we
need to add to our recommendations
component is just the view all button at
the very bottom there so let's quickly
do that so below all of our list items
here in the communities.map function uh
just underneath there but inside of this
fragment here we want to add a box
component and this box is going to
contain that button that says View
so we save this then on this box we want
to give it some padding and the padding
is going to be 10 pixels top bottom 20
pixels left and right and then for our
button here we're going to give this a
height
of 30 pixels and a width of 100
percent and this button isn't going to
do anything it is for decoration only
but this would be a cool feature for you
to add to maybe take you to some
Community recommendation or Community
Discovery page where users could see a
more extensive list of communities that
they could potentially join awesome so
we are now completely done our top
communities component and we can just
add in those other two decorative
components on the right hand side here
so let's go and do that okay and I'm
just going to paste in the code for both
of these components because they're very
simple they're only about 20 lines each
and they don't really have any
functionality they're just for
decoration only so inside of our
community folder I'm going to create a
another file called premium
dot TSX and this is going to be this
component here that is recommending you
to try red premium okay and I'm just
going to paste in the code for this
component here it is here I will put the
links to these components in the
description so you do have immediate
access and you just throw them into your
project and then the other component I'm
going to create is going to be called
personal
home.tsx and that is going to be this
one here paste this one in it says
slightly longer but nothing super crazy
it's only 45 lines and again this uses
that uh Reddit personal home image from
the images folder so do make sure that
you do have this to make sure it works
on your end and that is it for these
decorative components so we can close
both of these and I can close my
directory here and inside of our index
page we can come back and bring both of
those in so just underneath
recommendations we can bring in our
premium component
and underneath that we can bring in the
personal home component so if I see this
and go back to the app so you can see
these showing up here but they are not
spaced out very good here so what I'm
going to do is actually change the
fragment to be a stack
and then we can add in some spacing here
and this spacing is going to be five
awesome so they're spaced out much
better now and this looks really really
good and actually a really good exercise
for you to do on this personal home
component here would be to actually make
those buttons do something functional
for example the create post button you
could trigger the opening of this
directory up here maybe scroll the user
to the top of the page and open that up
and then for the create Community button
you can open up the create Community
model so I will leave that up to you if
you decide to do that all right you guys
it is now time for deployment we are now
ready to actually get our application
into production and I've decided that
we're going to be using Purcell for our
deployment for those of you that don't
know versel is the company that created
an xjs and they making deploying next
apps extremely easy all you have to do
is just with a click of a button we can
connect the git repository that our
project is hosted on to a Purcell
project and every time we make changes
to the master or main branch of the
project it will automatically deploy
those changes and we can track the build
and everything on resell it's super easy
and we're going to see that in just a
few minutes all right so for deployment
if you have not done so yet you are
going to need to create a GitHub
repository for your project here and put
all of your code on GitHub because like
I mentioned we are going to connect this
repository to our newly created Versa
project that we're going to create right
now all right so before you move forward
with versel make sure you do have a
repository created on GitHub and all of
your code is on there and they actually
do have changes that I need to commit
here
um for our new index page that I need to
push to my main branch before we do this
as well okay so I'm just going to commit
this and I'm going to say complete index
page
I will push this to GitHub
perfect okay so now all of my latest
code should be on GitHub uh yeah so I'm
saying just right now it received that
commit so we should be good to go with
the deployment so this is what I'm going
to do I'm going to go to versel.com
okay and I already have some projects
created here this is the this is the
demo over here so what you're going to
want to do is create an account if you
do not have one and once you are logged
in you'll see some like sort of
dashboard where all of your projects are
and there will be some sort of button
where you can create a new project and
this is where we're actually going to
connect our repository with a single
click of a button you can connect any
one under GitHub repositories and get it
ready for deployment so versal makes it
extremely easy to deploy maxjs apps
okay so this is the project here Reddit
clone tutorial this was the repo we were
just looking at and uh so I'm going to
click on import
and it's going to ask you for a project
name I usually just leave it the same as
the repo name and then the framework
preset so we're using xjs and then I
usually and then the root directory we
can just leave as this index route here
and then there's some things in here
like the build and output settings we're
not going to touch this and then there
are environment variables which we are
going to need to add because if you
recall if you go to our DOT EnV local
file we have all of these environment
variables for our application to connect
to our Firebase project so in order for
our production application to connect to
our Firebase project we are going to
need to add all of these environment
variables into our production
environment and this is where we're
going to do that and these can of course
be modified and you can add more ones
and remove ones and edit ones after you
do deploy the project so don't worry if
you forget some of them or some of them
are wrong or anything you can always
change this after your initial
deployment and we may have to deploy it
a few times because it might fail the
first few times it usually happens the
build will fail and it'll you have to go
find something in your code refush to
GitHub to trigger a new build and then
usually after a few times
work so we're going to walk through that
process together okay so what we're
going to do is add all of these
environment variables to our next.js
project so what we're going to do is
copy all of these names here and place
them inside of the name part of the
environment variable and then place the
value inside of the value so let's do
the first one here so next public
Firebase API key I'm going to paste this
in here
and as the value
I'm going to grab the value
paste it in and just click add perfect
so once all six of these Firebase
environment variables have been added go
ahead and click on deploy and we can see
what is going to happen so what's going
to happen here is the deployment is
going to be queued and it's going to
start building the application to
attempt to take all of your code packed
it together into a production bundle and
then deploy that production bundle and
again as I mentioned this might fail the
first few times due to some sort of you
know any sort of typescript errors or
compiler errors really anything can
trigger a build error so we are going to
see that and we'll walk through any
debugging that might need to happen Okay
so we can go back to our like home page
here while it's building and we'll see
our new project here and we can just go
into this uh this is kind of the actual
dashboard of this project and we can
track everything there's there's we can
see the build logs in case something
does fail there's the deployments you
have in here and so we can see there
already was an error in the build so
let's go take a look at that so we can
go to view build logs so it says yeah
build failed so now we can take a look
at these logs here and see what errors
it came across okay so cannot find
module Firebase functions or
corresponding type decorations okay and
it tells you like what file this is in
and everything so it makes it super
convenient to debug so if we go to our
functions file in here it's saying that
it cannot find the module of Firebase
functions
or the corresponding type declarations
okay if you don't think I've come across
this one before when I deployed the
initial project I don't think I came
across this but let's see here
Firebase functions okay so for some
reason I do not have Firebase functions
installed I thought it would have
installed when I enabled Cloud functions
but I'm not sure exactly what happened I
don't remember having to manually
install it in our demo but that's okay
okay so I'm just going to
Firebase functions
maybe I did maybe I did have to manually
install this okay so I'm just going to
manually install this in our in our
project here npmi Firebase functions
foreign
so having failed deployments is super
common
um and it happens a lot so don't be
alarmed if your project fails to build
it is very very common and oftentimes
you have to try several times to get it
to work there's always stuff you miss
and things that just
um make it fail unexpectedly okay so
let's go back to versatile here and so
that was the first error that it came
across so basically how versell works is
every time you push changes to the main
branch or the master branch of your
project it automatically once you
trigger a rebuild and so all we have to
do here is push this new code that we
just have which is the installation of
Firebase function through our main
branch so let's Commit This you can say
install Firebase functions and if I
actually push this to my main branch
okay so now the code is on GitHub if I
go back to the MicroCell home here we
can see that it says just now via GitHub
and it's that commit is already there
and it will have triggered a new build
so the building is again in progress so
let's go view build logs and see what
happens this time okay so it failed
again so let's take a look at what
happened this time here
okay
um here's a few errors here
okay so the first one is
react hook use effect is called
conditionally react hooks must be called
okay so let's go to our index page for
our community
okay so the reason this is saying that
this use effect is called conditionally
uh it's talking about this one here and
that is because it is below this if
statement here so if this triggers
um this is actually not going to run and
that's not allowed in in react to Your
Hooks need to run the exact same amount
of times every single render it they
can't be conditionally called so to fix
this all we have to do is move this down
here below to the very bottom and then
if we save that that should solve this
one here
okay so the next one is saying that
um quotation single quote cannot be or
sorry can be escaped with
okay so instead of our reset password
it's saying online 33 it tells you the
line everything which is super nice
okay so I think it has to do with this
text here this um
this apostrophe inside of the wheel send
you a reset link so like all we have to
do to fix this is we could we could
change this to like we will or I think
we could wrap this in a template literal
string like this to make it JavaScript
and that should solve that we will see I
think that should work
um and then this one down here is it
saying do not pass children as props
instead Nest the children between okay
so go to our search input
um it's talking about line 16.
okay so I think that's this one here
okay so rather than I guess passing this
um search icon as a children prop to the
input left element uh what we can do to
do basically the exact same thing is
remove the self-closing tag on this
input left element here and create an
actual closing tag and then we can take
this search icon
component and place it inside of here
like this delete the child and this
should do exactly the same thing because
now this is acting as the child or
children of the input left element okay
so now if we go back to our app yeah it
does appear the exact same however now
it's more like it's proper for reaction
so I guess chakra has to update their
documentation to reflect that as well
because I think we just grab this off of
chakra but okay so let's go back to
versaille here and I think that was it
so here we have the Escape one children
as props and the use effect okay so I
think that's it so what I'm going to do
is commit these changes uh we can say
fix build errors
and push those to GitHub
some of you by the way might be using
your terminal to push these changes to
GitHub I'm just using the GitHub Source
control in the left here I just find it
super easy cool okay so this should
trigger a rebuild so let's go to so
let's refresh this this project here
um okay so fixed build errors it's there
and it is buildings so let's go ahead
and view the build logs see how far it
makes it this time okay so it looked
like my build succeeded we can see the
check mark here so it's pretty quick it
only took just over a minute uh one
minute and 22 seconds so now we can
actually visit this and this is the real
app here this is it in production it's
deployed at this uh versel domain sort
of given to you and you can connect a
custom domain to your project through
Versa there should be a domains section
inside of the project where is that
um I need to go to oh yeah view domains
so say you wanted to put like Reddit
projectproject.com or something any sort
of domain you would add that in here and
resell would connect that for you to
your production build so in our case I'm
just going to leave it as the assigned
one buy or sell but this is pretty cool
we have a securely deployed application
that is now officially on the internet
and it's connected to our Firebase
project so this is this is in production
so that's super cool it's officially
deployed and we can log in and
everything so I'm going to log in as my
Shad Mary user
and very cool we are now able to
actually use this application in
production this is actually on the
internet we are on the internet comment
very very cool
you can delete everything the app should
function exactly as it was in
development awesome
all right you guys so the very last
thing that we are going to cover here is
going to be Firebase security rules
because now that our application is in
production we want to add some security
rules to our database to only allow
certain types of users or authenticated
users to access certain resources in our
database such as posts comments so the
way we can Implement security rules is
we can go to our Firebase project here
and inside of the firestore database tab
we can navigate to the rules section
which we have briefly seen before and we
actually want to write out some rules
for our specific documents in our
database okay and security rules are
really important because even though our
front end if we go to our app okay so
only the owners of posts can like see
the front-end action icons here like
deleting the icon
Etc or only admins can change the
community image of the community but
technically you can still make a request
to the back end using the command line
like using making a curl request or
something and the request to your app
and to your database may not necess
necessarily be coming directly from your
actual front-end application and it
might be coming from some other source
like a curl command and so for that
reason it is important to protect your
database and all of the data inside of
your security rules against these types
of potentially malicious requests made
from outside of your application so now
your front end and your back end will
both be nice and secure okay so I'm just
going to expand this out a bit so we can
we can see this here so essentially this
is the default security rules that you
are given for a new Firebase project and
so right now there's only one rule that
exists it's basically allowing every
single type of action on our database
which is perfect for development because
we need to test out all of the features
so basically this thing here the
document equals and then the double star
thing is just a wild card that is the
path to every single document in our
database so it's the post the users and
everything in here every possible path
that is what this document thing
represents it's basically just saying
allow read and write in all cases that's
essentially what this means and so we
can write paths to our specific
resources like our posts and comments to
only allow read and write on updates and
deletions to each type of resource okay
awesome so let's remove this here and
let's write out our first security Rule
and once you write the first one the
rest should be pretty intuitive so you
can delete this here and the first one
is going to be our users collection so
to do that we can use the match keyword
here and we want to write the path to
the particular resource we are creating
the security rule for in this case is
going to be our users collection and the
second part of the path is going to be
our user ID so this curly bracket
notation here just indicates that this
is a dynamic path and that we are
referring to essentially any document
inside of the user's collection with any
particular ID and on any specific user
document we have those two sub
collections Community Snippets as well
as post votes and for both of those
they're going to have the same security
rules and so to indicate that we want to
refer to all of these sub-collections on
any particular user document we can use
the wildcard parameter rest of path and
set it equal to the double star and this
was similar to the double star we saw
before and this is basically just saying
that at any path inside of any
particular user documents or any
subcollection and any document inside of
any of those subcollections that is what
this is referring to here so we can
create specific rules for those and in
this case this is going to be the
community snippet sub collection as well
as the post vote subcollection and any
document inside of either of those okay
so then we can open up some curly
brackets here and this is where we're
actually going to write the permissions
okay so for these particular resources
we're going to say allow read and write
and then we can add a colon here and
then basically we just want to write
some sort of if statement I just want to
say allow this if some condition is true
so in our case we want to only allow
reading and writing to these particular
paths
if the request dot auth instance
is not null which means that the user is
logged in because we can access that
current user via this dot auth instance
because it's connected to our
authentication Service okay and we also
want to add the condition that the user
ID which is coming from this path here
so whatever we name this in the wildcard
path we can use as a variable inside of
this logic here so if I name this user
ID LOL down here this would be user ID
lull it's basically the same as a
dynamic type index.js whatever we name
the dynamic path we have access to that
variable name inside of the logic here
changes back to user ID
okay so we want to see that the user ID
is equal to the
requests.auth instance dot uid so we're
saying okay so the user must be logged
in so the request.auth instance is not
null and the user ID of the
authenticated user matches the user ID
of the actual user document that they're
trying to write to so only Chad Mary can
write to the Shad Mary user document
Chad mayor he cannot write to the Ben
document or whoever document awesome and
so that is it for our users collection
so we can come down here and start
working on the other ones to get so the
next one we're going to do is our posts
so we're going to say match slash posts
and we are going to again use our Wild
Card post ID variable here and for our
posts we are going to make them
completely public because all of our
communities are public on reddit.com
there are private communities and stuff
which would require more advanced
security rules but in our case we are
making all of our communities public so
all of the post data is available to me
to anyone for reading so we can just
simply say allow read and we do not need
to specify a rule which means that this
is going to be readable under all
circumstances but we want to add a
condition for writing a post so for
actually creating a post and storing one
in the database we want to add some
condition for that and in this case we
only want to allow the creation of posts
if the post Creator ID matches the ID of
the authenticated user because we don't
want Shady creating posts on behalf of
Ben or Ben creating post on behalf of
Chatty so we want to make sure that it
is shoddy creating a post for shoddy's
user so to do that we can say request
dot resource and request.resource is how
we can access the actual document object
that we are trying to write to the
database okay and then we can access the
data of that resource and our data if
you remember has a parameter called
Creator ID on it because if you go to
our new post form here this is going to
be the
request.resource.data object and so on
here we have access to the Creator ID so
we want to check that the resources
Creator ID is equal to the auth
instances user ID and the next rule that
we want to add for our posts is for the
deletion of posts because you only want
Shady to be able to delete Shady's post
we don't want Ben to be able to delete
Chinese posts so what we can do is we
can add a rule for deleting so we can
say allow delete and we only want to
allow the deletion of posts if the user
making the request so request dot auth
dot uid is equal to the Creator ID e of
the post resource that they're trying to
delete and the way we can access this
resource is we can say resource
dot data dot Creator ID so in the case
of creating a post when we are actually
like writing a document to the database
and we are passing data with a request
we access that data through
request.resource.data in this case we're
accessing a resource that is already
inside of our database so it's not
coming from a request so we can access
that just through that resource object
here I'm just going to change the order
of this first one here to match the
bottom one it doesn't really matter but
just a preference of mind so let's say
like that and the very last crud
operation we could add a rule for would
be for updating the post and in our case
our application is not built to allow
editing of posts but if you decide to
build that in this project or a future
project this is how you would write a
rule specific to updating this resource
so now we can work on our comments
so you can say match comments use our
comment ID wildcard variable
and the rules for this are going to be
the exact same as the posts they're
going to be publicly readable but only
the owners can create and delete these
resources and the very last type of
resource in our database are the
community documents so we can say slash
communities
and use our community ID wildcard cool
and so for communities all authenticated
users can create communities so we can
just say allow read they are publicly
readable but for writing we just want to
make sure that the user is authenticated
so we can say request.auth does not
equal no
just like that I'm just missing an if
statement here
awesome so now if I publish these rules
it will actually be published to the
Firebase servers where our application
is currently deployed and they might
take a minute to property to upload
servers but now if I go back to the
application these should be in effect
and depending on the functionality and
the types of features and security you
have built into your app you can add
more security rules and you can have
more advanced user-based authentication
but in our case this is exactly what we
need for our application perfect and
that is it for our security roles and
now our database is nice and secure and
only the appropriate users can access
the data that is available to them all
right you guys so believe it or not that
is the end of the entire Reddit build I
cannot believe we made it here it has
been a wild Journey congratulations if
you have made it to the end here I hope
you have learned an insane amount we
have covered so many things here and my
entire goal with this project was to
cover enough stuff in detail to give you
the tools necessary to create anything
you would want with these Technologies
so I hope you have gained that from this
and I really hope that you feel that
your skills have been upgraded in
following this tutorial and if you have
enjoyed this content please like And
subscribe it really does help out my
channel and I'm going to be creating
more and more tutorials in the future
this is just the beginning and also
please join our Discord it is a growing
community and it is not only for this
project just joining there uh to chat
really about anything it could be about
this project it could be about your own
projects and it could just be this
ongoing thing and chat about really any
future project all right so thank you
guys once again so much for watching I
really really appreciate it it has been
a crazy journey I hope you have learned
a lot so thank you guys so much once
again and I will see you next time